RENDON.
WE'RE WAITING UP ON.
WE'RE WAITING UPON ONE MORE
MEMBER TO ARRIVE BEFORE WE BEGIN
THE HEARING TODAY BUT I WOULD
LIKE TO ASK THE SERGEANTS TO BE
ABLE TO CALL THE MISSING
MEMBERS.
WHO AREN'T HERE RIGHT NOW BUT
FOR EVERYONE WHO'S HERE WERE
AWAITING ONE OTHER MEMBER BEFORE
WE BEGIN JUST WANTED TO NOTIFY
YOU OF THAT?
THANK
.
BUT IT HARDLY TODAY.
FIRE.
YEAH.
THIS WILL BEGIN TODAY'S SUB ONE
HEARING ITS ARE THIRD HEARING OF
THE YEAR. WE WILL START WITH
ISSUE ONE DEPARTMENT OF
REHABILITATION IF YOU CAN COME
FORWARD.
AND PERCENT
.
BEFORE WE BEGIN I'D LIKE TO
ESTABLISH QUORUM.
DOCTOR ARAMBULA.
HERE. HARPER.
NOT THIS HERE RUBIO.
WOULD.
QUORUM.
THANK YOU WITH THAT IF
COULD HAVE OUR FIRST PANEL
BEGINS.
SO.
THIS IS NOT OKAY THANK YOU.
SO GRADING SOME GOOD AFTERNOON.
I WANTED TO.
FIRST START BY.
JUST THINKING THE MEMBERS.
I AM I HAVE TODAY WITH ME KELLY
HIGH GRAYSON DIRECTOR OF JOBS
EVEN FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
REHABILITATION I HAVE WITH ME
TODAY.
KELLY HARGREAVES IS A CHIEF
DEPUTY DIRECTOR.
AND EVEN THOUGH OUR IN Y. LATE
WAS LISTED ON THE AGENDA SHE
ENFORCEMENT AS SALES NOT ABLE TO
BE WITH US TODAY.
WE CERTAINLY ALWAYS LOOK
FORWARD.
AN OPPORTUNITY TO SHOW ABOUT
OUR PROGRAMS AND CERTAINLY TO
ANSWERING YOUR QUESTIONS.
THAT YOU MAY HAVE.
THE AGENDA DOES A GOOD JOB OF
DESCRIBING THE TOPIC SO I JUST
WANTED TO HIGHLIGHT A COUPLE OF
THE. VIETNAM.
ISSUES ON THE AGENDA.
ONE IS THAT THE INDEPENDENT
LIVING SERVICES SECTION STAFF IS
SUPPORTED WHAT PROGRAM INCOME.
AND THAT WE HAVE BEEN USING A
PROGRAM INCOME TO SUPPORT THE
TRANSITION OF STUDENT SERVICES
FROM.
TO TO STUDENT SERVICES FROM THE
ADULT SERVICES SIDE IS A FIFTEEN
PERCENT SHIFT THAT WAS MANDATED
BY FEDERAL STATUTE.
AS A RESULT OF.
ARE THE CHANGES IN THE W. WHEN I
AND EIGHT WORKFORCE INVENTION
OPPORTUNITY I ACT.
WE WERE RESTRICTED TO GIVE
MINISTRATION OF UNIT PET LIVING
SERVICES SECTION STAFF DEFY
PERCENT SO ABOUT NINE HUNDRED
DOLLARS NINE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS SHIFTED.
TO BE AVAILABLE TO THE NETWORK
TO PROVIDE THE.
FUNDING FOR THE PRIORITIES OF
THE STATE PLAN FOR INDEPENDENT
LIVING.
AND THEN A COUPLE OF OTHER QUICK
TOPICS I'M FOR YOU WOULD BE THE
PROGRAM INCOME.
AND WE THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR
ME TO CONTINUE TO POINT OUT
ABOUT PROGRAM INCOME IS AT ITS
GENERATED. FROM INDIVIDUALS WHO
WERE ON SUPPLEMENTAL SECURITY
INCOME WHO DO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO GO BACK TO WORK.
WHO ARE ATTAINING EARNINGS ABOVE
SUBSTANTIAL GAINFUL ACTIVITY?
AND THOSE WHO OF COURSE ARE
STAYING AT WORK FOR AT LEAST.
NINETY DAYS.
WE DO ANTICIPATE THAT AS A
RESULT OF A SHIFT IN OUR CASE
LOAD TO A MUCH YOUNGER
POPULATION. THAT WHAT ABOUT THE
PROGRAM INCOME WOULD BE IMPACTED
IN YEARS TO COME.
THE PROGRAM INCOME IS OF COURSE
A MANDATED USE FOR THE
VOCATIONAL REHABILITATION
PROGRAM IT'S ALLOWED USE.
FOR THE INDEPENDENT LIVING
SERVICES PROGRAM THE OLDER
INDIVIDUALS WERE BLAMED PROGRAM.
ONE OF THE FINAL TOPIC WOULD BE
ORDER OF SELECTION.
OUT WE TODAY ARE IN ORDER OF
SELECTION IT AS A MECHANISM OF
THE FEDERAL LAW FOR COST
CONTAINMENT ONE WE DO NOT HAVE
SUFFICIENT FUNDS.
TO MEET ALL OF THAT NEED.
AND.
WHILE IN RECENT YEARS WE HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO CLEAR THE WAITING
LIST FOR THAT WE HAVE BEEN
IGNORED OF SELECTION SINCE THE
MID NINETIES.
AND THE LONG TERM.
USE OF ORDER OF SELECTION AS A
COST CONTAINMENT HAS CREATED
DETERRENT FOR PEOPLE WHO WOULD
OTHERWISE APPLY FOR OUR
SERVICES.
THANK YOU.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE LA WHEN IT
COMES.
ANY PUBLIC COMMENTS ON ISSUE ONE
AT THIS TIME.
TARGET AREA MARKET.
I AM WITH THE CALIFORNIA
FOUNDATION FOR INDEPENDENT
LIVING CENTERS.
AND WE REPRESENT TWENTY ONE OF.
CALIFORNIA'S TWENTY EIGHT
INDEPENDENT LIVING CENTERS.
.
WE STRONG SUPPORTER PROPOSAL TO
MOVE TOWARD AN EQUITABLE FUNDING
FORMULA THAT INCLUDES FACTORS
SUCH AS BASE FUNDING POPULATION
GEOGRAPHY.
AND THE COST OF LIVING INDEX.
THE PARTNER CREEP WITH PATIENTS
OF REPORT INDICATES THAT THERE'S
BEEN A POSITIVE IMPACT ON
SERVING PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES.
THROUGHOUT THE STATE'S.
THROUGH THE STATE'S REASON
INVESTMENT OF A MODEST SEVEN
HUNDRED FIVE THOUSAND.
DOLLAR INVESTMENT FOR THREE OF
OUR CENTERS.
UP WE BELIEVE THAT OUR NETWORK
OF CENTERS IS A COST EFFECTIVE
INVESTMENT.
THAT IMPROVES CALIFORNIA'S
HEALTH SILT TERMINATION AND
INDEPENDENCE OUTCOMES FOR PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES.
HOWEVER WE BELIEVE THAT AN
APPROPRIATELY FUNDED EVIDENCE
BASED
STUDY OF CALIFORNIA'S TWENTY
EIGHT. AND URBAN LIVING CENTERS
IN THE ROLE IN IMPACTING.
A SOCIAL DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH
IS OVERDUE.
WE BELIEVE THAT. OUTCOMES AND
METRICS DERIVED FROM SUCH A
STUDY.
TO CREATE CONDITIONS WHERE
CALIFORNIA'S HEALTH CARE SYSTEM
SEES VALUE.
AND INCREASES PARTNERSHIPS.
AND INVESTMENT THROUGH MODELS OF
CARE THAT INCLUDE INDEPENDENT
LIVING CENTERS.
SUCH A STUDY WOULD AMPLIFY THE
INDUSTRY LEVEL CASE FOR CROSS
SECTOR PARTNERSHIPS.
AS AFFECT A STRATEGY FOR HEALTH
SYSTEM IMPROVEMENT.
PROMOTE NEW WAYS OF THINKING
AND.
HAVE OF FOLKS ARMS SERVICE
DESIGN. IT POSITIONS THE
INDEPENDENT LIVING NETWORK TO BE
ACTIVE PARTNERS WHO ARE VALUED.
FOR OUR.
FOR I LIVED DIFFICULT
EXPERIENCES PROFESSIONAL
HIGH PERFORMING A QUALITY LIFE
OUTCOME.
ALSO WOULD CREATE CONDITIONS
WHERE CALIFORNIA'S HEALTH CARE
SYSTEM SEES VALUE AND INVESTMENT
MODELS OF CARE THAT INCLUDE IN
THE PEDDLING CENTERS.
AND OUR INTEGRATED PERSON
CENTERED AND COST EFFECTIVE.
IT WOULD FINALLY ALLOW INFINITE
LIVING SENATE CREATE A NEW
REVENUE STREAM.
OR REVENUE GENERATING CONTRACTS
WITH HEALTH CARE LONG TERM
SERVICES AND SUPPORT ENTITY.
WE ASK THAT THE LEGISLATURE AND
TO YOU OUR SUPPORT THE I'LL
NETWORK IN BUILDING SUCH A
STUDY.
WITH THE OVERALL INTENT OF
IMPROVING POPULATION HEALTH IN
QUALITY OF LIFE FOR OUR DISABLED
AGING COMMITTEE MEMBERS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SIR.
HI.
.
I'M SUSAN MILLER KNOWN AS TANK
MILLER EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
PLASTER INDEPENDENT RESOURCE
SERVICES IN AUBURN WE ARE ONE OF
THE THREE INDEPENDENT LIVING
CENTERS THAT HAVE BENEFITTED
FROM THE SPECIAL ALLOCATION THIS
YEAR OF FUNDING. US SINCE WE DO
NOT RECEIVE BASE FUNDS AND WHICH
IS INCLUDED AGAIN IN THE
GOVERNOR'S. PROPOSED BUDGET FOR
THE COMING YEAR ON AND I JUST
WANTED TO SHARE BECAUSE WERE
VERY SMALL CENTER WE SERVE
PLASTER ELDORADO AND HELPING
COUNTIES. WHICH IS FOUR THOUSAND
SQUARE MILES OF SIERRA
MOUNTAINS.
AND SO WE HAVE CHALLENGES OF
TRYING TO SERVE THE PEOPLE
ACROSS THAT TERRITORY FROM OUR
WHEN OFFICE IN AUBURN AND SO
THESE FUNDS AND I HAVE.
BEEN DIRECTED FOR US TO OPEN AN
OFFICE IN PLACERVILLE SO THAT WE
CAN SERVE THE RESIDENTS OF
ELDORADO COUNTY AND ALPINE
COUNTY. AND IT'S VERY
CHALLENGING WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
COST OF HAVING STAFF TRAVEL AND
MANY MILES ACROSS THE MOUNTAINS
REIMBURSING THEIR MILEAGE AS
WELL AS. THAT COST OF THEIR
TIME.
THE DIFFICULTIES OF TRAVEL WITH
WHEN A WEATHER AND SO WE CANNOT
EFFECTIVELY SERVE THEM FROM
AUBURN AT WHICH IS WHY WE HAVE
MADE IT A PRIORITY TO OPEN A
SATELLITE OFFICE IN PLACERVILLE.
SO I WANTED TO EXPLAIN WHAT WHAT
THE FUNDS ARE BEING USED FOR AND
AS WE GET THAT OFFICE A FULLY
STAFFED AND UP AND RUNNING.
THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE THAT WE
SERVE WILL INCREASE
SIGNIFICANTLY AND WE THINK IT
WILL BE EQUAL TO THE NUMBER THAT
WE CURRENTLY SERVE OUT OF OUR
OFFICE IN AUBURN. THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
WITH THAT I'LL BRING IT UP TO
THE DYESS FROM THE QUESTIONS WE
MAY HAVE.
HOPE.
WONDERFUL.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MY NAME IS ANA
ACTED WITH FREED CENTER FOR
INDEPENDENT LIVING ONE OF THE
TWENTY EIGHT IN THE PET LIVING
CENTERS AROUND ABOUT US HERE
YUBA SUTTER AND COLUSA COUNTIES.
I'M I JUST WANT TO SAY A FEW
WORDS.
.
WE SERVE OVER THIRTEEN HUNDRED
INDIVIDUALS WITH SIGNIFICANT
DISABILITIES AND OUR WORLD
COMMUNITY.
OR BILLION AND TICKLE PART OF
THE HEALTHCARE SYSTEM OF THE
SOCIAL SERVICE SYSTEM AND REALLY
HELP TO ADDRESS THIS REALLY
SPECIFIC SOCIAL DETERMINANTS OF
HEALTH FOR INDIVIDUALS.
WE WORK TO REDUCE EMERGENCY
ROOM VISITS AND HOSPITALIZATIONS
WE REDUCE INSTITUTIONAL
PLACEMENT BY GETTING PEOPLE OUT
OF A MORE COSTLY NURSING HOMES
OR PREVENTING THEM FROM GOING
INTO I'M. AND WE ALSO REALLY
WORK TO ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS.
BOTH A LOT OF THE WORK THAT WE
DO IS HELPING PEOPLE FIND
HOUSING AND HELPING KEEP THEM
FROM BEING A VICTIM ED AND
BECOMING HOMELESS.
AND THE OUTCOMES THAT WE
PRODUCES AN ORGANIZATION I THINK
ARE REALLY SIGNIFICANT WE HELP
TO IMPROVE ACTIVITIES.
OF DAILY LIVING FOR INDIVIDUALS
WE HELP PEOPLE CONNECT WITH THE
COMMUNITY AND WE HIT HELP PEOPLE
UNDERSTAND THAT THE VERY
NEBULOUS NETWORK OF LONG TERM
SERVICES AND SUPPORT THAT THEY
CAN BENEFIT FROM. AND LASTLY YOU
KNOW WE REALLY INDIVIDUALS WORK
WITH A REPORT THAT THEY HAVE
INCREASED QUALITY OF LIFE FROM
OUR SERVICES. SO I WANTED TO
MENTION THAT THE IDEA OF LOOKING
AT OUR DATA AND DOING A STUDY ON
HOW WE CAN REALLY BECOME AN
INTEGRAL PART. OF THE HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM AND OF THE NETWORK OF
SOCIAL SERVICES I THINK IS LONG
OVERDUE. WE WOULD APPRECIATE
YOUR SUPPORT NOT EFFORT. THANK
YOU MEANT.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
ALL MY NAME'S RON A LOG AND
pCOMMITTEE RESOURCES FOR
INDEPENDENT LIVING WE SERVE FOR
THE ALAMEDA COUNTY AREA. AND
ROUGHLY FOR US IT'S BEEN REALLY
TOUGH YES WE DO GET FUNDING. BUT
WHEN WE TAKE A LOOK AT THE CPI
THAT THE CONSUMER PRICE INDEX OF
THE BAY AREA ITSELF HAS GONE UP
FORTY FOUR PERCENT YET WE
HAVEN'T SEEN ANY INCREASES FOR
US. WE GET THESE POCKETS OF
INCREASES AND THE OTHER GREAT
BUT FOR CONSISTENT ONGOING
SUPPORTED FUNDING THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE LOOKING FOR.
WE YOU KNOW WE NOW WE HAVE A
YOUTH TRANSITION PROGRAM THAT
WERE WERE STARTING UP.
BUT THEN THE FUNDING FOR IT IT
NEEDS TO HAPPEN THEN IT'S WHAT
WE NEED TO HAVE IT.
COME WITH THE STUDENTS.
AND WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO
SUPPORT THEM AS THEY MOVE
FORWARD. OF FOR US WERE LOOKING
TO MAKE SURE THAT WHATEVER
FUNDING DOES COME IS SUSTAINABLE
IT'S NOT A ONE TIME POP. ON MY
OFTENTIMES I COMPARE TO FILLING
UP YOUR GAS TANK SO YOU WANT TO
GO TO WASHINGTON DC FROM HERE.
FILLING IT UP ONCE IS NOT GONNA
MAKE IT IT'S LIKE YOU HAVE TO
MAKE SURE THAT IT KEEPS YOU KEEP
OF FILLED UP. AND SO WE ARE
REALLY ASKING FOR THEIR SUPPORT
FOR ALL TWENTY EIGHT INDEPENDENT
THING CENTERS
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR.
COULD HAVE TEN.
MY NAME IS CHERYL BECAUSE FINE
AND I REPRESENT THE STATE
INDEPENDENT LIVING COUNCIL.
WHERE VERY SMALL STATE
DEPARTMENT AND WE SUPPORT AN
EIGHTEEN MEMBER BOARD THAT
REPRESENT DIVERSE DISABILITY?
AND ETHNIC CULTURE ACROSS
CALIFORNIA.
WHERE IN PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
DEAL ARE?
TO PROVIDE A HOME TO SUPPORT THE
TWENTY EIGHT IN THE PARA LIVING
CENTERS ACROSS CALIFORNIA. AND
THE VARIED SERVICES AND PROGRAMS
THAT THEY PROVIDE THAT ARE VITAL
TO PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES IN
THE STATE.
I'M SORRY DEPARTMENT
WHOLEHEARTEDLY SUPPORTS
OF FUNDING TO THE IMPAIR LIVING
CENTERS AS WELL AS OUR PARTNER.
.
PROGRAMS AND COMMUNITY SERVICES.
AND.
WE ENCOURAGE STATE LEGISLATOR
FLETCHER TO ON CONTINUE AND
MAINTAIN THIS VITAL FUNDING
WHICH HAS NOT SEEN INCREASES FOR
MANY MANY YEARS SO THANK YOU
BEGIN.
MY NAME IS CHAPTER DHEA. AND I
AM A CLIENT OF SACRAMENTO'S
RESOURCES FOR INDEPENDENT
LIVING.
STERN WOULD MISTER AGUILAR IS
YOU'VE HEARD ME BEFORE. HOME.
THE VIOLENCE OF THE SERVICE IS
KEEPING PEOPLE LIVING
INDEPENDENTLY.
AND THAT RESOURCE IS SERIOUSLY
NEEDING HELP.
BOTTOM
YEAH I'VE BEEN BEFORE YOU SOME
YEARS AGO WHEN DISABILITY
FUNDING ISSUES FOR EDUCATION.
WAS THE ISSUE THAT STARTED ME ON
THE ROW OF TESTIFYING WITH YOU
PEOPLE.
PLEASE
SUPPORTED
SI I UNDERSTAND IT AND GET TO
KNOW IT BETTER BECAUSE IT IS
FOUR DOLLARS SPENT YOU KNOW THE
IT IS MANY MANY DOLLARS THAT YOU
ARE SAVING. OTHERWISE AS RIGHT
NOW I JUST GOT A LETTER.
JANE HEY YOU KNOW WHAT WE HAVE A
METHOD WHERE YOU DON'T HAVE TO
HAVE A THREE DAY HOSPITAL STAY
TO GO TO A. SKILLED
SHOULD WE SAY NURSING CENTER YET
THE BUILDING I LIVE IN PROBABLY
HALF OF THEM NEED TO BE IN A
SKILLED. NURSING CENTER SO
TRYING TO LIVE INDEPENDENTLY.
THESE ARE TOOLS THAT HELP US
STAY IN THAT MATTER AND NOT GO
INTO A NURSING HOME.
YES SIR.
YOU OFFER MARTY EMOTO CALIFORNIA
DISBELIEF SENIOR COMMUNITY
ACTION NETWORK ALSO A FAMILY
MEMBER. FORMER BOARD MEMBER OF A
LOCAL INDEPENDENT LIVING CENTER
FOR OVER A DECADE YOU JUST WANT
TO BE A MENTION I'M STRONG
SUPPORT. FOR EQUALITY IN FUNDING
FOR ALL THE A INDEPENDENT LIVING
CENTERS ARE THERE DESPERATELY
NEEDED.
A COMMUNITY RESOURCE AND WE
SHOULD BE A SUPPORTING THEM YOU
WITH EVEN MORE.
A SUPPORT FROM THE STATE AND AND
FOR THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THANK
YOU.
I AGREE WITH EVERYTHING HE'S
JUST SAID I ALSO THINK THAT
CALIFORNIA'S DISABILITY RIGHTS
RAINY HICKS CALIFORNIA'S
DISABILITY RIGHTS WENT THINGS
ABOUT INDEPENDENT LIVING ON YOUR
OWN.
AND WHAT WE HAVE FOUND OUT IN
OUR STUDY IS AND FROM THE SENATE
OR MEDICAID AND MEDICARE IS
FOUND OUT THAT.
CHEAPER TO HAVE THEM FUND AYE
ELSIE'S.
SENATE IS TO HAPPEN PETE FUNDED
IN INSTITUTIONS.
HAVING THEM LIVE ON THEIR OWN TO
BE PROTECTIVE MEMBERS OF SOCIETY
THAT THEY WILL BELT TO.
EARN A LIVING.
AND AND BE MEN BE THEMSELVES AND
WE'RE ALL ABOUT THAT.
AND I'D RECOMMEND AND I TOTALLY
AGREE IF LIKE I SAID WE MUST
HAVE THIS AN ONGOING FUNDING
ISSUE WE SHOULDN'T HAVE TO COME.
YEAR AFTER YEAR AFTER YEAR TO
FIGHT FOR THIS SPECIAL WHEN IT
COMES.
JOE INDIVIDUALS AND THE CITIZENS
OF THE STATE.
IT'S A.
GOOD AFTERNOON CATHOLIC MORE
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIAN I
JUST WANT TO ADD OUR
ORGANIZATION SUPPORT TO THE
PROPOSAL WHICH INSURES ACCESS TO
SERVICES THAT HELP PEOPLE.
REMAIN IN THE COMMUNITY WHICH IS
GOOD POLICY AND MAKES PERFECT
FISCAL SENSE THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
JORDAN LINDSAY WITH THE ARK
CALIFORNIA UNITED SERVE OPPOSING
IN SUPPORT OF THE REQUEST THANK.
ANY FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENT AT
THIS TIME.
SEEING NONE.
WE WILL HOLD THIS BUDGET ITEM
OPEN PENDING THE MAY REVISION
BUT I'D LIKE TO PLEASE ASK FOR
THE DEPARTMENT OF
REHABILITATION.
TO UPDATE THE LEGISLATIVE STAFF
ON A REGULAR BASIS PERHAPS
QUARTERLY ON HOWARD DISCUSSIONS
ON I'LL SEE FUNDING ARE
CONTINUING.
CAN WE ASK FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
REHABILITATION TO PLEASE DO THIS
AT THE COMING MAY REVISION.
AS WELL AS TOWARDS THE END OF
SUMMER AND EVERY THREE TO FOUR
MONTHS AFTER THAT.
ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU.
I WITH THAT WE WILL MOVE ON TO
ISSUE TO.
THANK YOU
.
I THINK THERE FOR LIKE YOU KNOW
THE BETTER PART OF
WHEN YOU'RE READY DIRECTOR
PARCHMENT.
RIGHT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I'M NANCY
PARTS MEN.
DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES AND I'M
HERE WITH LANE THE FINE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR AND CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR ON JOHN DOYLE.
SO JUST GO TO PROVIDE.
.
A HIGH LEVEL BECAUSE THE AGENDA
DOES ADDRESS
I'M THE REALLY CRITICAL POINTS
THAT'S RE LATER TO THE
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER CLOSURES.
BUT TO PROVIDE SOME.
POOL UPDATED INFORMATION.
THAT YOU MIGHT FIND HELPFUL BUT
AS THE AGENDA DOES REFLECT.
WE.
ANNOUNCED
AND MAY HAVE TWENTY FIFTEEN THE
CLOSURE OF THREE DEVELOPMENTAL
CENTERS CINEMA.
PORTERVILLE. THOUGH GENTLE
TREATMENT AREA PORTERVILLE AND.
FAIRVIEW.
AS OF.
.
MAY TWENTY FIFTEEN OUR
POPULATION FORECLOSURE WAS EIGHT
HUNDRED EIGHTY SIX TODAY WE HAVE
A CURRENT POPULATION FOR
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE
TRANSITIONING TO THE COMMUNITY.
OF THREE HUNDRED FORTY SEVEN.
WE ARE PROTECTING AND GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET THAT WE ARE GONNA BE
REDUCING THAT POPULATION BY JUNE
THIRTIETH FOR CURRENT YEAR. TO
TWO HUNDRED AND SIXTY AND THEN
AT THE END OF JUNE THIRTIETH AND
TWENTY NINETEEN.
SEVENTY FOUR INDIVIDUALS.
THAT SEVENTY FOUR INDIVIDUALS
REFLECTS THAT FOR CINEMA
DEVELOPMENT ALSO NOTE THAT THE
LAST PERSON WOULD BE MOVING FROM
CINEMA I'M PRIOR TO DECEMBER OF.
THIS YEAR.
ADDITIONALLY LIKE TO JUST SHARE
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE.
.
THE SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT FOR
FEAR OF YOU IMPORT AVAIL SO WE
HAVE A REQUIREMENT TO OBTAIN THE
FEDERAL FUNDING TO MAINTAIN A
POPULATION THAT IS CONTINUING TO
DECLINE OF TRANSITIONING FOLKS
TO THE COMMUNITY. AS OF JUNE
THIRTIETH TWENTY EIGHTEEN THERE
AGREEMENT REFLECTS THAT WE
SHOULD HAVE A POPULATION OF
FIFTY SEVEN.
WE CURRENTLY HAVE A POPULATION
FOR THE INTERMEDIATE CARE
FACILITY WHICH IS.
FOR THE INDIVIDUALS THAT NEED A
TRANSITION UNDER THE SETTLEMENT
AGREEMENT.
.
THAT WE ARE WE ARE CURRENTLY AT
SIXTY SEVEN SO WE HAVE TEN MORE
THAT WE NEED TO TRANSITION BY
JUNE THIRTIETH.
AND THEN FOR PORTED FILTHY
AGREEMENT REFLECTS SIXTY ONE
INDIVIDUALS ON THAT WE NEED TO
BE BY JUNE THIRTIETH OF TWENTY
EIGHTEEN AND WE'RE CURRENTLY AT
FIFTY SEVEN SO WHERE. WE'VE
ALREADY MANDATE FOR THIS CURRENT
YEAR.
AND ONE OF THE OTHER AREAS
THAT'S OF PARTICULAR INTEREST
FOR.
SUPPORTING INDIVIDUALS
TRANSITIONING TO THE COMMUNITY
AS FOR MY YOUR STAFF. THE
COMMITTEE STATE STOP PROGRAM HAS
BEEN A VERY STE.
IMPORTANT PROCESS THAT THE
CLOSURE ON SO WE'RE CONTINUING
TO SUPPORT THAT MAKING SURE THAT
THE STAFF WERE FAMILIAR WITH
WHAT THE OPTIONS ARE AVAILABLE
TO THEM. WE'VE INCREASED THE
CONTRACTS AND WE'RE CONTINUING
TO DO THAT A INTERVIEWS TO. TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE AVAILABLE
TO THE SERVICE PROVIDERS TO
CHOOSE TO SELECT UP TO SUPPORT
THEM IN THE COMMUNITY.
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS WERE
HAPPY TO ANSWER THANK YOU.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE OLEO ANY
COMMENTS ON ISSUE ONE.
SEEING NONE WILL TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENTS ON.
WE HAVE A REPRESENTATIVE FROM
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA
YEAH I WOULD LOVE TO HEAR YOUR
TESTIMONY BEFORE PUBLIC COM.
GREAT THANK YOU SO MUCH SIR. UP
SO DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA
IS THE FEDERALLY MANDATED
PROTECTION AND ADVOCACY AGENCY
HERE CALIFORNIA WE ALSO HAVE THE
OFFICE OF CLIENTS RIGHTS
ADVOCACY WHICH IS THROUGH A
STATE CONTRACT WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES. AND I'M KATIE
HORNBERGER NAM THE DIRECTOR OF
THE OFFICE OF CLIENTS RIGHTS
ADVOCACY.
ALSO I'M WE REALLY ARE VERY
PLEASED WITH THE MOVEMENT THAT
WE'VE BEEN SEEING.
BY THE DEPARTMENT AND THE
REGIONAL CENTERS AND MOVING
PEOPLE OUT OF THE DEVELOPMENTAL
CENTERS. ON WE WERE ALSO A VERY
PLEASED WHEN THE DEPARTMENT
ISSUED ON THE SAFE TO SERVE
REGULATIONS ON REGARDING THOSE
INDIVIDUALS. ON THAT WOULD BE
INVEST SECURE TREATMENT AREA AT
PORTERVILLE DEVELOPMENTAL
CENTER.
ON LARGELY THOSE ARE PEOPLE WHO
ARE CURRENTLY INCARCERATED. OF
AND.
NEED TO BE MOVED TO ANOTHER
CITING FOR TREATMENT CLUB
UNFORTUNATELY IN THE REGULATIONS
ON WHICH INCLUDED A LOT OF ON
TRANSPARENCY WHICH WAS IS. IT IS
REALLY HELPFUL TO ALL OF US.
OF.
WHAT WE? ASCERTAIN THROUGH
BREEDING THOSE IS THAT IT REALLY
GUESTS THAT APARTMENT BETWEEN
FIVE AND SIX MONTHS
TO MAKE WHAT'S CONSIDERED A SAFE
TO SERVE DETERMINATION. WHICH
WOULD MEAN WHETHER OR NOT THE
PERSON WOULD LEAVE THEIR CURRENT
SETTING IN BE ADMITTED TO PORTER
VELL DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER. ON IN
AS A SAFE SAID MANY OF THOSE
PEOPLE ARE CURRENTLY
INCARCERATED. ON. WE BELIEVE
THAT THAT TIME PERIOD IS WAY TOO
LONG TO MAKE THAT DECISION AND
WE WOULD ASK THAT THE DEPARTMENT
MAKE THAT DETERMINATION. CALM
WITHIN THIRTY DAYS WHICH IS
CONSISTENT WITH A LOT OF OTHER
TIME LINES IN OUR SYSTEM AROUND
COMPREHENSIVE ASSESSMENTS AND
MAKING OTHER KINDS OF
DETERMINATIONS. ON WE WOULD ALSO
ASK THAT THE CLIENT'S RIGHTS
ADVOCATES ON OUR NOTICED OF ALL
OF THOSE DECISIONS. ON THE
RECENT TEST
TO SPEED UP THAT DETERMINATION
IS THAT UNFORTUNATELY IF SOMEONE
IS FOUND NOT SAFE TO SERVE. ON
THE NEXT STEPS TO DEVELOPING AN
APPROPRIATE PLACEMENT FOR THEM.
ALL OFTEN.
CAN BE VERY TIME CONSUMING AND
SO IF WE'VE ALREADY HAD SOMEONE
SITTING DOWN IN AN APPROPRIATE
SETTING FOR FIVE TO SIX MONTHS
WHEN WE BEGAN. TO INVESTIGATE
WHAT OUR NEXT STEPS ARE THAT.
DELAYS THE PROCESS
SIGNIFICANTLY SO THE SOONER THAT
ON THAT DETERMINATION CAN BE
MADE THE SOONER THAT IF THAT
PERSON IS DENIED ADMISSION WE
CAN BEGIN DEVELOPING OUT ANOTHER
PLAN FOR THEM.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I'M JUST ONE QUESTION BEFORE WE
TAKE PUBLIC COMMENTED SEEMED
LIKE YOU MENTIONED THIRTY DAYS
RIGHT HERE AND YET IN OUR.
AND THAT WE HAVE A TWENTY ONE
DAY LIMIT SO WANTED TO CLARIFY
WHICH WAS APPROPRIATE OR WHICH.
WAS RIGHT AND SO ON IT YOU KNOW
I'M I KNOW EARLY ON WE HAVE
THOUGHT ABOUT A TWENTY ONE DAY
TIME LIMIT. AND THEN ON IN
REVIEWING OTHER STATUTE
STATUTORY AND REGULATORY FORUMS
THIRTY SEEMED UPON.
BUT THE MOST OFTEN USED NUMBER
ON FOR A LOT OF THINGS THAT COME
IMPACT ON PEOPLE WHO MAY HAVE
CHALLENGING BEHAVIORS OUR OTHER
NEEDS THAT MAKE THEM MORE
CHALLENGING TO SERVE. ON AND SO
THOUGHT THAT NUMBER WAS MORE
APPROPRIATE.
WILL LAST FOR A RESPONSE BUT
AFTER PUBLIC COMMENT IF WE CAN
SO WE WILL NOW TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT ON ISSUE ONE.
SEEING NONE WE WILL BRING IT
BACK UP TO THE DYESS AND NOW I
WOULD HOPEFULLY HAVE THE
DEPARTMENT RESPONDS TO. A WHAT
WE COULD DO TO TRY TO MEET THE
EXPECTATION OF THIRTY DAYS.
SEEMS LIKE FIVE OR SIX MONTHS AS
A WHILE BUT.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS JOHN DOYLE
DTS ON WHAT WE APPRECIATE DRC'S
CONCERNS ABOUT REGARDING THE
LENGTH OF TIME IT COULD
POTENTIALLY TAKE IT AND JUST TO
BE CLEAR. FIVE OR SIX MONTHS IS
NOT A TIME PERIOD THAT'S A LATIN
STATUTE OR ANYTHING LIKE THAT.
CURRENTLY IT TAKES ABOUT SEVENTY
FOUR DAYS TO DO AN ASSESSMENT OF
AN INDIVIDUAL PROPOSED TO BE
COMMITTED TO PORTER BILL.
SO IN THAT SEVENTY FOUR DAYS
INCLUDES THE TIME THAT IT TAKES
TO GET A COURT ORDER. TO VISIT
THE INDIVIDUAL IN JAIL TO BEGIN
THE ASSESSMENT PROCESS.
AND RIGHT NOW WE'VE GOT.
TWO HUNDRED ELEVEN BED SUPPORTER
BILL CURRENTLY ABOUT TWO HUNDRED
OF FULL.
SO ON.
AND WE'VE GOT A REFERRAL LIST OF
NINE INDIVIDUAL SO. IT'S NOT AN
ISSUE THAT WE DON'T HAVE SPACE
TO PUT PEOPLE IT'S THE TIME THAT
IT TAKES TO DO A THOROUGH
ASSESSMENT. AND ONE OF THINGS I
THINK WE WOULD ALSO ONE NOTE IS
THAT FOR INDIVIDUALS. WHO
POTENTIALLY COULD BE UNSAFE TO
SERVE?
YOU'RE WE WITH THEIR OTHER RISK
FACTORS THAT WE LOOK AT SO WE
WANNA KNOW. ON YOU DON'T IT
DESERVES INDIVIDUALS BEHAVIORS.
POSE A RISK TO THAT RESIDENTS OR
THE STAFF AT PORTERVILLE. OWN
ARE THERE MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES
THAT ARE PREDOMINANT IS THE
INDIVIDUAL MORE APPROPRIATE
PLACED IN A STATE HOSPITAL.
ON.
IS THE INDIVIDUAL ACTION RISK OF
INJURY BECAUSE OF IT AT A PRE
EXISTING MEDICAL CONDITIONS SO.
.
AND THEN THERE ARE.
THE OTHER THING I THINK WE ALSO
NOTED SIT DOWN.
THE CASESARE VERY COMPLEX AND
THEY'RE USUALLY CONTRADICTORY
ASSESSMENTS.
ARM SO THAT THIRTY DAYS OFTEN
ISN'T ENOUGH TIME TO MAKE A
DETERMINATION WHETHER THE
INDIVIDUAL OF SAFE TO SERVE.
AND.
YOU KNOW WE THE DEPARTMENT USES
A PERSON CENTERED PLANNING
PROCESS TO ENSURE THAT PEOPLE
ARE GETTING THE APPROPRIATE
SERVICES AND SUPPORTS IT BUT ME.
AND YOU KNOW WHETHER OR NOT THAT
INDIVIDUAL IS ACTIVELY ENGAGE
WITH THE REGIONAL CENTER. ALSO
MAKES A DIFFERENCE AS FAR AS HOW
QUICKLY DID SUSSMAN CAN BE DONE.
AND I THINK FINALLY I WOULD NOTE
THAT YOU KNOW SINCE TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN. WE'VE HAD ONE
INDIVIDUAL WHERE WE HAD TO MAKE
A DETERMINATION ON AND NOT
SAFETY SERB ASSESSMENT SO. I
WOULD I WOULD JUST NOTE THAT THE
THERE'S NOT A SIGNIFICANT NUMBER
OF CASES THAT WE HAVE TO DEAL
WITH.
IS THERE ANYTHING ON THE STATE
SIDE WE CAN DO TO HELP WITH
WORKLOAD TO HELP LOWER SOME OF
THAT TIME FRAME AND.
WHAT WOULD THAT LOOK LIKE?
SO AT THIS FANCY APARTMENT YOU
KNOW AT THIS TIME I THINK THAT
THE BEST THING THAT THAT WE CAN
CERTAINLY DO IS JUST CONTINUE
WITH OUR COMMITMENT OF MAKING
SURE THIS AS.
AYE MISTER DOYLE HAD INDICATED
THAT WHILE THE FIVE AND SIX
MONTHS IS NOT SOMETHING THAT IS
IT'S NOT ROUTINE IT'S CERTAINLY
NOT THERE. THE.
STANDARD THAT WE WOULD LOOK TO
DO AND SO WITHIN THE STAFF THAT
WE HAVE IN OUR EXISTING
RESOURCES THAT WE CAN CONTINUE
TO.
MAKE SURE THAT IN EVERY
INSTANCE THAT WEEKEND.
MEET TIME LINES THAT ARE WITHIN
OUR ABILITY BASED ON WHAT THE
COURT DATES ARE BASED ON THE
OTHER FACTORS THAT WE MAY NOT
HAVE AS MUCH CONTROL LOVE. ON
THAT WE'RE COMMITTED TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE CAN GET FOLKS TO
AMEND ASSESSMENT SO WE CAN MAKE
SURE THAT THE.
NEEDS OF THE INDIVIDUAL IS
IDENTIFIED SO THE BEST SERVICES
CAN BE DONE. SO THAT THE FIVE TO
SIX MONTHS IS NOT IS IS NOT AN
AREA IN WHICH WE'VE EVEN
EXPERIENCED.
NOR DO I ACTUALLY ANTICIPATE IT
TAKING FIVE TO SIX MONTHS SO
WITH OUR EXISTING RESOURCES WILL
CONTINUE TO MAKE PRIORITIES TO
MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE ARE
ASSESSED. SO THEY CAN REALLY GET
TO THE BEST SERVICE OPTIONS THAT
ARE AVAILABLE TO THEM.
WITHOUT ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS
FOR MY COLLEAGUES.
SEEING NONE WE WILL HOLD ISSUE
ONE OPEN AND MOVE ON TO ISSUE
TO.
DOCTOR CHAIR MEMBERS AB AND SONY
PREDICT THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE.
YOU SHOULD ALL HAVE A HANDOUT
RELATED TO ISSUE TO.
ON SEQUESTERING SAVINGS
WONDERFUL THANK YOU.
AS NOTED IN THE AGENDA OUR
OFFICE WAS ASKED TO ASSESS
THROUGH SUPPLEMENTAL REPORT
LANGUAGE.
I THE PROPHETIC PROPOSAL TO TAKE
THE POTENTIAL SAVINGS THAT COULD
RESULT FROM THE CLOSURE OF
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS AND
APPLYING IT TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES COMMUNITY
SERVICES PROGRAM.
I WILL BRIEFLY WALK YOU THROUGH
THE FINDINGS FROM.
FROM OUR.
EXAMINATION OF THIS ISSUE.
IF YOU CAN TURN TO PAGE ONE OF
THE HAND OUT THERE REALLY TWO
POSSIBLE SOURCES OF SAVINGS AS
GUY WHEN IT COMES TO THE CLOSURE
OF DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS. ONE IS
NET OPERATIONAL SAVINGS AND ON
PAGE TWO WE'VE NOTED. REVENUES
GENERATED FROM THE SALE
REPURPOSE SING OF DEVELOPMENTAL
CENTER PROPERTIES.
I'M GOING TO IF YOU TURN TO PAGE
THREE GOING TO WALK YOU THROUGH
HOW WE CALCULATED NET
OPERATIONAL SAVINGS.
SENATE OPERATIONAL SAVINGS WILL
RESULT IF THE COST TO SERVE
INDIVIDUALS IN THE COMMUNITY IS
LESS THAN WHAT IT COSTS THE
STATE TO SERVE INDIVIDUALS IN
INSTITUTIONS.
SO THE FIRST THING WE HAD TO DO
WAS LOOK AT WILL WHAT DOES IT
COST THIS STATE TO SERVE
INDIVIDUALS IN INSTITUTIONS.
SO.
TO DO THIS WE NEED TO LOOK AT
THE GYM STATE GENERAL FUND
BECAUSE FIRST OF ALL WE CAN'T
LOOK AT TOTAL FUNDS AND WE ALSO
NEED TO LOOK AT THE COSTS OF THE
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS THAT ARE
CLOSING SINCE.
THERE ARE TWO FACILITIES THAT
WILL REMAIN OPEN.
SO WHEN WE A NARROW IT DOWN TO
THIS IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN THE STATE SPENDING
ABOUT TWO HUNDRED MILLION
GENERAL FUND TO SERVE.
INDIVIDUALS AT THE DC'S.
THE NEXT THING SO THIS IS WHAT
YOU CAN THINK OF IS THE AVOIDED
COST ONCE THE DISEASE ARE CLOSED
RELATIVE TO TODAY.
THE SECOND THING WE NEED TO LOOK
AT IS WHAT IS ACOSTA SERVE
INDIVIDUALS IN THE COMMUNITY.
WE ESTIMATE THAT ONCE THE FINAL
CLOSURES ARE CA ARE COMPLETE THE
COST TO SERVE THE REMAINING
ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED AND THIRTY
INDIVIDUALS WHO WILL HAVE MOVED
FROM TWENTY SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN
THROUGH FINAL CLOSURES. WILL BE
ABOUT SEVENTY FIVE MILLION
ANNUALLY FROM THE GENERAL FUND
THIS INCLUDES COST TO BOTH THE
DEPARTMENT OF DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES AS WELL AS COSTS IN
OTHER STATE PROGRAMS SUCH AS
MEDICARE OF.
FINALLY WE DO NEED TO LOOK AT
THE GENERAL FUND BECAUSE TO
PROVIDE SAFETY NET AND CRISIS
SERVICES IN THE COMMUNITY. THESE
OUR SERVICES THAT WERE FORMERLY
FORMERLY PROVIDED AT FAIRVIEW IN
CINEMA DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS
ONCE THEY'RE CLOSED. THE
DEPARTMENT IS WORKING TO BUILD
UP A SYSTEM IN THE COMMUNITY TO
PROVIDE THOSE SERVICES. WE PAID
BACK COST ABOUT TWENTY FIVE
MILLION GENERAL FUND ANNUALLY.
AND THAT'S LIKELY THE LEAST
THAT THE STATE WOULD SPEND.
SO IF YOU TURN TO PAGE FOUR WE
HAVE SORT OF A A BREAKDOWN.
OF THE THE REDUCE COSTS AS WELL
THERE ARE THE REDUCE SPENDING IT
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS AS WELL AS
THE ESTIMATED COMMUNITY COSTS.
WE ESTIMATE THAT THE MOST THE
STATE COULD SAVE IN ANNUAL
GENERAL FUND DOLLARS IS A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS AND THIS
IS AFTER FINAL CLOSURES ARE
COMPLETE. AND I WOULD MAKE.
TWO IMPORTANT POINTS ABOUT THIS
CALCULATION ONE IT DOESN'T
FACTOR IN THE SORT OF DYNAMIC
CHANGES BETWEEN NOW AND FINAL
CLOSURE SO WE'RE NOT LOOKING AT
THE REDUCED.
COSTS AT DC'S BETWEEN NOW AND
THEN BUT WE'RE ALSO NOT LOOKING
AT THE SIGNIFICANT COSTS TO THE
STATE TO DEVELOP NEW HOMES AND
RESOURCES OUT MY COMMUNITY.
WE'RE ALSO JUST NOTE.
THAT THIS ESTIMATE IS HIGHLY
VARIABLE.
A HUNDRED MILLION IS REALLY THE
MOST WE THINK THE STATE COULD
SPEND THAT SAFE.
NEXT IF YOU TURN TO PAGE FIVE
I'LL JUST BRIEFLY WALK THROUGH A
OPTIONS FOR RAISING REVENUES
FROM THE SALE RE PURPOSING OF
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER PROPERTIES.
WHEN IT COMES TO SELLING
INDIVIDUAL PARCELS OUR ENTIRE DC
PROPERTIES THERE ARE SOME
BENEFITS TO THIS OPTION ONE IT
WOULD REDUCE THE STATE'S
LIABILITY AT THESE PROPERTIES.
COULD ALSO GENERATE A ONE TIME
INFLUX OF REVENUES THIS REVENUE
CAN ALSO BE INVESTED TO GENERATE
INTEREST WHICH WILL BE AN
ONGOING SOURCE OF FUNDING.
AND THERE ARE SOME CHALLENGES
AND ISSUES TO CONSIDER WITH THIS
OPTION HOWEVER AT EACH OF THE
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER PROPERTIES
HAS UNIQUE CHARACTERISTICS THAT
COULD AFFECT THE SALE POTENTIAL
IN MARKET VALUE OF THE PROPERTY
SO FOR EXAMPLE. THERE'S AGING
INFRASTRUCTURE ITS NO MY.
THE PORTERVILLE LOCATION IS
FAIRLY REMOTE TO AN IS IN CLOSE
PROXIMITY TO THIS YEAR SECURE
TREATMENT PROGRAM.
THERE ARE ALSO LOCAL PREFERENCES
TO CONSIDER OTHER LOCAL ZONING
ORDINANCES AS WELL AS.
BOTH AT FAIRVIEW AT SORRY IN
THE CITY OF COSTA MESA AND THEN
ALSO. I WEAR CINEMA
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER IS LOCATED
THERE VOTER APPROVAL
REQUIREMENTS FOR DEVELOPMENT
PROJECTS.
WE ALSO DON'T KNOW THE CURRENT
VALUE OF THE PROPERTIES AND THEN
FINALLY I WOULD JUST NOTE THAT
THE STATE IF IT WANTS TO
GENERATE REVENUES FROM THE SALE
OF DC PROPERTY SPECIFICALLY FOR
THE DTS SYSTEM. AND IT WANTS TO
MAXIMIZE THE SALE POTENTIAL IT
MAY HAVE TO BYPASS THE TYPICAL
STATE SURPLUS OF PROPERTY
PROCESS THERE IS PRECEDENT FOR
DOING THIS IS JUST AN ISSUE TO
TO KEEP IN MIND.
ANOTHER OPTION OF WHEN IT COMES
TO DC PROPERTIES IS TO LEASE
INDIVIDUAL PARCELS OF THE
PROPERTY.
THE POTENTIAL BENEFITS INCLUDE
THIS COULD BE AN ONGOING SOURCE
OF REVENUE I'D ALSO KEEPS THE
PROPERTIES IN THE STATE'S HANDS
IF IT.
IF IT NEEDS NEEDS THOSE
PROPERTIES FOR PRETEND OF FUTURE
STATE USE.
AND THERE ARE SOME CHALLENGES
FOR ONE THE STATE IS NOT IN THE
BUSINESS OF BEING A LANDLORD IT
DOES NOT TYPICALLY LEASED
PROPERTIES AND ACT AS A LANDLORD
FOR THE SOLE PURPOSE OF RAISING
REVENUES.
AND AGAIN THE UNIQUE
CHARACTERISTICS OF EACH PROPERTY
COULD AFFECT THE LEASING
POTENTIAL.
AND I WANTED TO HIGHLIGHT ONE
ONE OPTION FOR LEASING HOWEVER
WHICH IS TO LEAST. INDIVIDUAL
PARCELS TO DEVELOP AFFORDABLE
HOUSING THERE'S PRECEDENT FOR
DOING THIS AT THE FAIRVIEW
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER PROPERTY
THERE'S CURRENTLY A HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT AND ANOTHER ONE IN
THE WORKS.
I THIS COULD INCREASE THE SUPPLY
OF HOUSING FOR BOTH DS CONSUMERS
AS WELL AS OTHER CALIFORNIANS.
THE SURPLUS RENTAL PROCEEDS
COULD BE USED TO SUBSIDIZE THE
WRENCH OF DC A DDS CONSUMERS.
.
AND I WOULD JUST NOTE THE THE
POTENTIAL CHALLENGES OF
ASSOCIATED WITH THIS OPTION ON
PAGE SEVEN. I'M AGAIN HAS TO DO
WITH SOME OF THE UNIQUE
CHARACTERISTICS OF EACH DC
PROPERTIES SO FOR EXAMPLE WOULD
VOTERS.
IN COSTA MESA APPROVE A THIRD
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT PROJECT
THAT'S
UNKNOWN. EYES NOMO WE WOULD NOTE
IS IN NOT CLOSE PER IS NOT IN
CLOSE PROXIMITY TO THE OTHER
TYPES OF SERVICES AND SUPPORTS
THAT DTS CONSUMERS WOULD NEED.
.
FINALLY ON PAGE EIGHT I WOULD
JUST NOTE A COUPLE OTHER ISSUES
FOR LEGISLATIVE CONSIDERATION.
I'M ONE WE WOULD JUST NOTE THAT
A LOT OF THE STATE BUDGET IS
ALREADY WALKED IN AND EARMARKED
FOR CERTAIN PURPOSES THIS WOULD
BE ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF DOING
THAT.
OF COURSE THE LEGISLATURE COULD
DECIDE TO SUSPEND THAT
REQUIREMENT IF IT NEEDED THE
FUNDS FOR ANOTHER PURPOSE.
BUT WE'RE ALSO NOT THE
LEGISLATURE ALWAYS HAS THE
OPTION TO INCREASE SPENDING ON
DDS BUT SERVICES.
AND FINALLY WE WOULD JUST NOTE
THAT THE LEGISLATURE SHOULD
THINK ABOUT HOW TO EFFECTIVELY
TARGET THE SAVINGS SO FOR
PROPOSAL IT MAY WANT TO THINK
ABOUT PARAMETERS FOR. THE
SPECIAL FUNDS OF AND THAT IT
WOULD LIKELY SET UP TO DEPOSIT
THE SAVINGS INTO. AND WE WOULD
ALSO RECOMMEND.
CONSIDERING A COMPREHENSIVE
ASSESSMENT OF SERVICE GAPS IN
THE DDS COMMUNITY SERVICES
PROGRAM.
AND JUST TO CONCLUDE IF THE
LEGISLATURE DECIDES TO PURSUE
THIS PROPOSAL THERE DEFINITELY
OPPORTUNITIES FOR. A GENERATING
SAVINGS FROM THE CLOSURE OF
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS AND
THERE'S JUST A FEW
IMPLEMENTATION ISSUES THAT MIGHT
WANT TO CONSIDER.
GREAT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
UP NEXT WE'LL HAVE SOME GLIMMER
MATHIS.
BUT HER.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND THE MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE.
I'M HERE TO EXPRESS MY SUPPORT
OF THE LAND LETTERMAN'S
COALITION BUDGET REQUEST.
THE NEED FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENTS FOR PEOPLE WITH
DEVELOP MENTAL DISABILITIES IS
BOTH VITAL AND URGENT.
IF YOU ARE AWARE THE THREE
REMAINING DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS
INCLUDING THE SECURE TREATMENT
PROGRAM. AT PORT A BILL AND THE
CANYON SPRINGS FACILITY WILL BE
CLOSED BY THE END OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE.
AS SUCH WE MUST DECIDE WHAT
HAPPENS TO THE MONIES SAVED FROM
THE CLOSURES OF THESE
FACILITIES.
MORE IMPORTANTLY WE MUST DECIDE
HOW TO ENSURE.
THAT THE REMAINING FIVE HUNDRED
AND THIRTY SEVEN INDIVIDUALS.
IN THE DE SEIZE ARE PROVIDED FOR
AS THEY TRANSITION INTO THE
COMMUNITY.
I BELIEVE THAT THIS CONVERSATION
MUST BEGIN WITH ENSURING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING
OPPORTUNITIES.
THE LATTER MEN COALITION HAS
PROPOSED THE CREATION OF THE.
INTEGRATED COMMUNITY LIVING.
FUND.
WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES.
THIS FUND WILL SERVE AS A.
REPOSITORY.
WHEN REVENUE IS GENERATED FROM
NEW USES OF THE DC PROPERTIES.
THE FUND WILL BE UTILIZED TO
FINANCE CAPITAL COSTS FOR THE
DEVELOPMENT OF NEW HOUSING UNITS
FOR REGIONAL CENTER. CLIENTS.
AS YOU ARE AWARE.
A PORTION OF THE SITE AT
FAIRVIEW DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER.
IS RUN AS HARBOR VILLAGE A MIXED
RESIDENT COMMUNITY WHICH SERVES
AS A MANDATED. PERCENTAGE OF
PEOPLE WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES.
THE REMAINDER OF THE UNITS ARE
LEAST TO THE PUBLIC AT MARKET
RATES.
THIS MODEL HAS GENERATED
REVENUES FOR HARBOR VILLAGE.
ULTIMATELY FUNNELS BACK INTO
DEPARTMENT OF DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES TO INCREASE SERVICES
FOR PEOPLE WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES.
THIS MODEL HAS PROVED EXTREMELY
EFFECTIVE.
I PROVIDING HOUSING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR INDIVIDUALS
TRANSFERRING. OUT OF THE STATE'S
REMAINING DC'S AS WELL AS
PROVIDING HOUSING OPTIONS FOR
INDIVIDUALS ALREADY IN THE
COMMUNITY.
IN NEED OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING
WHICH WE ARE TO HAVE AN ISSUE
WITH IN OUR STATE.
LAST FALL I VISITED THIS SITE
PERSONALLY.
I'VE SEEN HOW EFFECTIVE IT IS
AT SERVING PEOPLE WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES.
IS MY GOAL TO SEE THIS STYLE OF
INTEGRATED HOUSING
OPPORTUNITIES.
SPANNED THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
WITHIN A MY DISTRICT THE CITY'S
OF WHEN THE IMPORT OF BILL HAVE
ALREADY EXPRESSED A STRONG
DESIRE TO.
CREATE THIS INTEGRATED HOUSING
OPTION WITHIN THEIR COMMUNITIES.
WITHOUT ACTION FROM THIS
SUBCOMMITTEE ANY FUNDS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE CLOSURE OF
DC'S.
AND THE SALE OR LEASE OF THE
PROPERTY.
WILL BE LOST TO THE GENERAL
FUND.
WE CANNOT ALLOW THESE FUNDS TO
BE TAKEN AWAY FROM THIS
COMMUNITY.
AS A MEMBER OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE
I AM EXTREMELY PROUD TO BE.
IN SUPPORT OF THE LETTERMAN'S
COALITION BUDGET REQUEST ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT AS WELL.
WITH ME TODAY IS MISTER LINDSEY
FROM ARC IN ALIGNMENT COALITION
IS ALSO PROVIDES CONNECTS.
THANK YOU.
THANK MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE.
SOMEONE MATHIS FOR YOUR
COMMITMENT TO THIS ISSUE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR YOUR GREAT
ANALYSIS AND THE LA GO. ON THERE
A THROUGH REPORT OF THIS ISSUE.
A MISTER CHAIR I AM RIPPING THE
LAYMAN COALITION WHICH CONSISTS
OF MORE THAN TWENTY STATEWIDE
ORGANIZATIONS INVOLVED IN THE
ADVOCACY FOR THE DEVELOPER
DISABILITY COMMUNITY. AND WHEN
ALL OF THESE ORGANIZATIONS
CONVENE DURING THE SUMMER TO
DISCUSS WHAT WILL BE OUR
PRIORITY FOR THIS YEAR.
A WE COLLECTIVELY DECIDED THAT
THE CLOSURE OF THE DEVELOPMENTAL
CENTERS
PRESENTS AN IMPORTANT AND TIME
SENSITIVE WINDOW OF OPPORTUNITY.
TO PRY IMPROVE THE LIVES OF
PEOPLE.
INTELLECTUAL DEVELOP THE
DISABILITIES IN THE COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
AND WE DECIDED THAT OUR TOP
PARTY THIS YEAR IS TO MAKE SURE
THAT DOLLARS IN ASSETS THAT ARE
USED TO SERVE PEOPLE WITH ID DE
TODAY WILL CONTINUE TO SERVE
PEOPLE ID DE TOMORROW.
THERE ARE ESSENTIALLY TO
POTENTIAL POTS OF MONEY
AVAILABLE TODAY.
AND THE REQUEST KNOWS TO BE USED
TO CONTINUE TO BE STE TO SUPPORT
THE COMMUNITY.
FIRST PART OF MONEY OPERATING
DOLLARS AND DC'S AS WE HEARD
FROM ELIO.
OTHER PROPOSALS ON THE AGENDA
TODAY. AS WELL AS OTHER CRITICAL
NEEDS WITHIN THE COMMUNITY BACK
TO BE FUNDED THROUGH THE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR NET SAVINGS
ONGOING.
AND WE CAN.
.
AND WE CAN SCORE THOSE SAVINGS
TODAY TO FUND NEEDS AND THE
COMMUNITY NOW.
THE SECOND PART OF MONEY. IS
ANYBODY THAT STATE RECEIVED FROM
ASSETS THEMSELVES THE PROPERTIES
AS ASSEMBLYMAN MATHIS JUST
DESCRIBED.
FOR MORE THAN TWO HUNDRED YEARS
COMBINED THESE ASSETS BEEN PART
OF THAT YOU THE SYSTEM AND
CALIFORNIA'S NOT UNIQUE MANY
OTHER STATES AND HAD TO DEAL THE
EXACT SAME OPTION.
THEY HAVE THE SAME HISTORY AS
OURS OF LARGE SITES INSTITUTIONS
BEEN DEVELOPED AND WHAT DO THEY
DO NOW NOW WE'RE CLOSING THEM
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY. OTHER
STATES HAVE DONE EXACTLY WHAT
WE'RE PROPOSING TO DO TODAY.
TO RETAIN THOSE MONIES TO BE
USED FOR THE BENEFIT THE
COMMUNITY.
SO WHEN IS THE REQUEST THE
REQUEST IS TO USE REVENUES IF
WHEN THEY COME INTO THE STATE
FROM THESE ASSETS CONTINUE TO
BENEFIT CALIFORNIA'S WITH ID DE.
THE FIRST NEED IDENTIFIED BY THE
COALITION.
IS THE NEED FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING.
SO WE PROPOSE TO CREATE NEW
INTEGRATED COMMUNITY HOUSING
UNITS THROUGHOUT THE STATE BY
THE CREATION OF A FUND AT DTS
AND MANAGED BY THE DEPARTMENT.
OF HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT. EIGHT CITY WOULD
ADMINISTER THE FUN THE SAME WAY
IT DOES MANY OTHER FUNDS
BY SEEKING PROPOSALS FROM
DEVELOPERS.
OR NONPROFIT NONPROFIT HOUSING
ORGANIZATIONS
ETCETERA TO CREATE NEW UNITS SET
ASIDE SPECIFICALLY FOR REGIONAL
CENTER CLIENTS.
THEY NEED FOR HOUSING THE
COMMUNITY IS CRITICAL AND WE
KNOW THIS.
BECAUSE OF DISCRIMINATION
AFFORDABILITY AND ACCESSIBILITY
IT IS NEARLY IMPOSSIBLE
PER PERSON WITH ID DE WITH AN S.
SOCIETIES P. INCOME.
TO FIND HOUSING RIGHT NOW IN
CALIFORNIA THIS PROPOSAL WILL
HELP IT WON'T SORTS ALL POLL THE
PROBLEMS BUT WILL GET SOME
PEOPLE INTO A SAFE AN INTEGRATED
PLACE TO LIVE.
THE ADDED BENEFIT OF HOUSING
PROPOSALS LIKE THIS.
IS THAT IT CREATES ADDITIONAL
HOUSING SUPPLY THROUGHOUT THE
STATE.
ON AVERAGE THE STATE WOULD SPEND
AND HOW SPENT ON PROGRAMS LIKE
IT'S ABOUT SEVENTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR A NEW UNIT TO BE
BUILT.
WHEN ON AVERAGE ARE COSTING
THREE HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND ON THE
MARKET BUILT.
BUT IT IT IT ALSO LEVERAGES YOU
THINK LOW INCOME HOUSING TAX
CREDITS TO BUILD AN ADDITIONAL
FOUR OR FIVE FAIR MARKET PRICE
HOUSING UNITS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. AND OTHER
WORDS EVERY DOLLAR THE STATE
PUTS INTO DEVELOPING HOUSING
CREATES
FOUR DOLLARS AND TWENTY FIVE
CENTS.
ADDITIONAL HOUSING DOLLARS TO
CREATE UNION NEW UNITS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
ALSO REGARDING SONOMA
DEVELOPMENTS DEVELOPMENT CENTER
WE ARE WORKING WITH CENTER
REQUIRES OFFICE TO RESOLVE
CONCERNS ABOUT THE PROPOSAL BUT
WE ARE OPTIMISTIC THAT WE'LL BE
ABLE TO ADDRESS THOSE CUTS
CONCERNED SOON.
AND QUICKLY WHAT THIS PROPOSAL
IT IS NOT
IT IT'S NOT.
ASSEMBLY FOR PEOPLE COMING OUT
THE DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS ONE
MAKE THAT CLEAR THIS IS FOR ALL
REGIONAL CENTER CLIENTS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE THAT ARE
NEEDED FOR OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING.
ALSO WHILE WE.
AS HAS BEEN MENTIONED THERE ARE
MODELS ALREADY ABOUT BUILDING ON
SITES AGAIN PROPOSALS NOT.
DISCIPLINE NECESSARILY ONLY
ABOUT DEVELOPING ON SITES THEIR
NEEDS THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
THAT WE CAN ADDRESS WITH THIS.
S. OF THE LIMON COLLISION
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT THE
COMMITTEE SUPPORT THIS ONCE AND
THEN IT'S GONE OPPORTUNITY TO
TO FULFILL SOME OF THE NEEDS OF
CALIFORNIANS WITH INTELLECTUAL
DEVELOP DISABILITIES THINKING.
NEXT WE HAVE A REPRESENTATIVE
FROM SCO YOU.
WE MAKE THIS SPACE FOR HER IF
THAT'S POSSIBLE.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS AYE TIFFANY
WHITE WITH THE SERVICE EMPLOYEES
INTERNATIONAL UNION.
I REQUEST HERE TODAY
YOU HAVE A HIGHLY CONSIDER THAT
LEASING.
PORTIONS OF THE PROPERTIES FROM
THE DC CLOSURES OF OUR MEMBERS
FIND A VITAL THAT THERE ARE
THERE'S MULTIPLE SERVICES THAT
ARE.
A NEED WITHIN THE DD SYSTEM WE
WOULD AGREE WITH THE LATTER AT
COALITION THAT HOUSING IS THE
IMMEDIATE NEED OUT BUT THAT
SHOULDN'T LIMIT US FOR MAKING
SURE THAT THE ENTIRE SYSTEM IS
FUNDED ADEQUATELY. ARMS OUR
REQUEST IS THAT THERE BE A
SPECIAL FINE BECKONED ADDRESS
THE HOUSING NEED BUT IN THE OUT
YEARS BE ABLE TO HAVE SOME
SUSTAINABLE ONGOING FINDING.
TO ADDRESS OTHER CONCERNS
ANOTHER NEEDS WITHIN THE
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES.
SYSTEM WE THINK LEASING IS THE
BEST OPTION BECAUSE IT DOES
PROVIDE A SUSTAINABLE. ONGOING
I'M FUNDING SOURCE AS OPPOSED TO
SELLING WHICH YOU KIND OF JUST
GET A SINGLE BANG FOR YOUR BUCK.
OFTENTIMES UCF IN THIS
COMMITTEE WERE COMING BACK TO
ASK FOR DIFFERENT.
SOURCES OF FUNDING FOR
DIFFERENT SERVICES.
AND WE TAP INTO THE GENERAL
FUND QUITE OFTEN IF WERE ABLE TO
HAVE A SPECIAL FUND THAT'S
DEDICATED TO SERVICES THAT WE
CAN KIND OF GET INTO THEN WE
DON'T HAVE TO ALWAYS
CONTINUOUSLY. TAP INTO THE
GENERAL FUND I'M IN THE OUTGOING
YEAR SO. I REQUEST THAT IF THE
AYE YOU AGAIN WE'VE WE'VE HIGHLY
AGREE WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MATHIS AND WHAT THE LATIMER
COALITION THAT THE IMMEDIATE
NEED IS HOUSING BUT GIVEN THE
OPPORTUNITY AND I BELIEVE THE
DEPARTMENT AND.
THE STATE IS LOOKING INTO
LEASING AS THE OPTION WE WOULD
JUST ENCOURAGE YOU GUYS TO
CONTINUE TO LOOK AT THAT AS A
VIABLE OPTION AS IT DOES PROVIDE
I'M ONGOING FUNDING FOR THE
ENTIRE SYSTEM. AND WE ALL KNOW
THAT THE SYSTEM IS IN DIRE NEED.
OF
LITTLE INDETERMINATE THIS TIME
BECAUSE THE POPULATION THAT
REMAINS IN THE DEVELOPMENTAL
CENTERS TEND TO BE THE HIGHEST
NEED AND I SECURITY PATIENTS SO.
IT'S A DIFFICULT COST COMPARISON
WE CAN'T PASS TRANSITIONS I
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO NOTE THAT THE
POLICING OF THE REVENUE WOULD
REQUIRE STATUTORY CHANGES. AND
THAT BASED ON EXPERIENCE AT
HARBOR VILLAGE WE DIDN'T REALIZE
SIGNIFICANT GENERAL FUND.
REVENUES UNTIL DECADES AFTER
PROPOSAL WAS IMPLEMENTED SO
WOULD LIKE TO CAUTION AGAINST.
USING.
REVENUES FROM THOSE PROPOSALS
FOR ANY ONGOING FUNDING
REQUESTS.
THANK YOU SIR.
NEXT TIME I'D LIKE TO HEAR FROM
AT THE DEPARTMENT IF I CAN ABOUT
WHAT THE LA COMMENTED ON.
IF YOU'RE READY TO.
DISCUSS OTHERWISE WE CAN TAKE
PUBLIC COMMENT AND ASK QUESTIONS
LATER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR ARM.
YOU
EARNS ABOUT THE COST OF
SERVICES IN THE COMMUNITY AS
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE POINTED
OUT AS WELL. WE THINK THAT
RATHER THAN SIXTY MILLION A YEAR
TO SERVE PEOPLE IN THE COMMUNITY
BASED ON.
THE ESTIMATE PROCESS WE USE
WE'RE LOOKING AT NUMBERS MORE
LIKE EIGHTY FOUR MILLION.
THANK YOU SIR. WITH THAT WE WILL
NOW TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT ON ISSUE
TO.
EVELYN I'M HOUSING DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA WE UNDERSTAND
THAT THERE'S MULTIPLE PROPOSALS.
I'M OUT HERE ON THE ISSUE OF THE
DC PROCEEDS NO MATTER WHICH
PROPOSALS ARE ADOPTED WE BELIEVE
THAT THE DC PRESS IT SHOULD STAY
IN THE SYSTEM. FOR PEOPLE FOR
THE BENEFIT OF PEOPLE WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES WE
ALSO UNDERSTAND THAT THERE ARE
LOCAL COMPLEXITY THINGS TAKE
COMPLEXITIES INVOLVED WITH THE
WHOLE PROCESS OF WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH.
THE DEPARTMENT THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE AS THE PROCESS MOVES
FORWARD THINK YOU.
THANK YOU MA'AM.
CURRENT HOLDEN WITH EASTER SEAL
CALIFORNIA I REMEMBER THE
LETTERING COALITION AND AND IN
SUPPORT PRIMARILY BECAUSE WE
SERVE.
PEOPLE WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES ON A DAILY BASIS
AND THE MAJOR BARRIER TO GREATER
LEVELS OF INDEPENDENCE FOR THOSE
IN INDEPENDENT LIVING IN SUPPORT
OF LIVING IS CLEARLY ACOSTA
HOUSING. IS A MAJOR A.
HOWEVER CRISIS LEVEL ALMOST
BECAUSE IT'S THE PRIMARY BARRIER
THAT'S KEEPING PEOPLE FROM OUR
INDEPENDENT LIFE SO ANYTHING WE
CAN DO. TO BE ABLE TO HAVE SOME
DEDICATED FUNDING TO IT WOULD BE
A GREAT RELIEF THANK YOU.
ARGUMENT.
DR ARAMBULA MEMBERS OF THE%
COMMITTEE IT DISTINGUISHED STAFF
A RICK ROLLINS REPS IN ARKANSAS
SHE SHE REGIONAL CENTER AGENCIES
WERE HERE TO EXPRESS OUR.
SUPPORT FOR PRIORITIZING HOUSING
AS A.
THEM HUGE NEED IN OUR SYSTEM
AYE AND WITH THE CLOSURE THE
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS AND
MAINTAINING. THE BENEFIT OF THAT
TO IN OUR SYSTEM THANK YOU
BECAUSE.
SHERMAN MEMBERS CARLIN AND I'M
HALF THE ALLIANCE SPORTING.
INDIVIDUALS WITH INTELLECTUAL
DEVELOPMENT DISABILITIES ALSO IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE.
WHEN EMMA COALITION'S PROPOSAL
AND I DO WANT TO NOTE THAT.
THIS IS MISTER LINDSEY SAID
YOU'VE GOT TO POTS THERE'S THE.
PROPERTIES THEMSELVES THE ASSET
OF THE PROPERTIES THERE SECONDLY
THE OPERATIONS DOLLARS.
WE THINK HELIOS DONE A GREAT
JOB.
WE MIGHT ARGUE THAT THEY WERE
PERHAPS A BIT CONSERVATIVE EVEN
BUT HAVE DONE A GREAT JOB.
AT PULLING APART THE POSSIBILITY
OF SAVINGS AND.
WE'RE ASKING THAT THE
LEGISLATURE BE VERY CREATIVE I'M
LOOKING AT THIS BECAUSE IT IS AS
MR LENSES AT A ONE TIME.
OPPORTUNITY.
THERE'S NO REASON WE COULDN'T
FOR EXAMPLE EXTRAPOLATE IN THE
FUTURE LOOK AT FUTURE SAVINGS.
AND IN FACT SECURITIZED AGAIN SO
SAVINGS.
TO PROVIDE BENEFIT TODAY.
YOU KNOW FIFTEEN YEARS FROM NOW
WHEN THERE'S NO DEVELOPMENTAL
CENTER WILL BE STILL BE SAVING A
HUNDRED MILLION AND WHATEVER
PLUS. THAT WE OTHERWISE WOULD
HAVE SPENT HAD WE KEPT THE
CENTERS OPEN.
WHY NOT LEVERAGE AGAINST THAT
MONEY JUST LIKE WE HAVE BEEN
TOBACCO TAX SOLOMON'S ANOTHER
FINANCIAL SCHEMES STAYS LOOK AT?
TO EXPEDITE MONEY INTO THE
SYSTEM TODAY BECAUSE THERE IS NO
QUESTION.
THAT THE SYSTEM IS NOT HOLDING
TOGETHER UNDER THE RATE
STRUCTURE THAT WE HAVE TODAY. SO
IS A UNIQUE OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO PRIDE LEADERSHIP
NOT DO THINGS THE WAY WE'VE
ALWAYS DONE IT BEFORE. ONE WE'VE
CLOSED DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER
AFTER DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER
THERE'S BEEN ZERO BENEFIT TO THE
COMMUNITY AND ON THE ISSUE OF
ACUITY OF PERSONS WHO RESIDE
THERE. I WOULD JUST NOTE THAT
WHEN A FIRE GOES THROUGH A
FACILITY LIKE A DOZEN CINEMA WE
SUDDENLY EXPEDITE PEOPLE OUT OF
THEIR WITHIN FIVE MINUTES.
SO ACUITY OR NOT IF I WOULD LOOK
AT THIS MORE FOR THE SYSTEM AS A
FISCAL EMERGENCY.
AND IT'S TIME TO RE REACTIVE TO
THAT EMERGENCY TO TRY TO GET THE
SYSTEM HEALTHY AND WHOLE SO THE
PEOPLE THE COMMUTER GETTING HIGH
QUALITY SERVICES. AND THE STATE
IS USING ITS RESOURCES ADEQUATE
IN THIS REGARD THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THINK.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS ERIC RATHER
THE STATE COUNCIL ON
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES THE
STATE COUNCIL'S POSITION IS THAT
THESE DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS
EXIST TO FOR THE CARE AND THE
HOUSING. NAM OF INDIVIDUAL WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES AND
THEY'VE DONE THAT THE PAST IN
THE SAME DOLLARS SHOULD BE
COMMITTED GOING FORWARD BOTH
OPERATIONAL DOLLARS AND FROM THE
SALE OF THE ASSETS. AT THIS
POINT STATE COUNCIL RIPPER UP
SUPPORTS THE PROPOSAL FOR THE
INTEGRATED COMMITTEE HOUSING
FUND THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS JACKIE DELUDE
FOST WITH THE CALIFORNIA
SUPPORTER LIVING NETWORK.
OUR BOARD MET YESTERDAY THE
NUMBER ONE PRIORITY FOR THE
SUPPORTED LIVING NETWORK WHICH
IS IN SUPPORTED LIVING
INDEPENDENT LIVING ACROSS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA'S HOUSING.
WE CAN DO SUPPORT OF LIVING WE
CANNOT DO IT IF WE HAVE NOWHERE
SO FOR SOME OF THE LIVE AND WE
HAVE NO DIRECT SUPPORT
PROFESSIONALS. I'M AND I WANTED
A DEPARTMENT FINANCE I TALKED
ABOUT THE SEVERITY OF THE NEED
IN THE COMMUNITY IN COMPARISON
TO DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER. AGAIN
THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND PEOPLE
CONTINUE TO LIVE IN OUR
COMMUNITY FIVE AND SEVENTY THREE
MANY OF THOSE MY AGENCY
FORTUNATELY FORTY FIVE PEOPLE
HAVE TRANSITION OUT OF THE
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER. AND WHAT
THEY'RE STRUGGLING WITH TODAY.
IS HOUSING.
A TWO BEDROOM TWO BATH IN
SACRAMENTO IS FOURTEEN HUNDRED
DOLLARS A MONTH.
WE TALK ABOUT INDEPENDENT LIVING
THERE IS NO SAFETY NET FOR
SOMEONE WHO GETS FIFTEEN HOURS A
MONTH OF SUPPORT THEY DON'T HAVE
PLACES TO LIVE SOME OF THE
NEIGHBORHOOD YOU WOULD NOT WANT
YOUR FAMILY MEMBER TO LIVE UP.
THAT'S THE SAFETY NET RIGHT NOW
IS ON THE STREET WHERE DO THEY
GO I DON'T KNOW. I JUST THINK WE
HAVE TO RE LOOK AT OUR SYSTEM
THE DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS ARE
CLOSING I WAS READING THROUGH
THE LA REPORT EIGHTEEN NINETY
ONE.
EIGHTEEN NINETY ONE THIS HOUSE
PEOPLE WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES THEY LIVE THERE
THEY DIED THERE IT'S TIME TO
MAKE SURE THE PEOPLE IN THE
COMMUNITY CAN LIVE AND THRIVE.
SO WE NEED TO RE LOOK AT THAT WE
NEED TO LOOK AT THIS FUND WE
NEED TO DO WHATEVER IS IN OUR
POWER TO DO AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
IT'S NOT JUST A HOMELESS PROBLEM
IS NOT JUST OF THAT PROBLEM IT'S
A DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
PROBLEM EVERYDAY PICK.
JAMIE DAVIS EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
FOR MORE ADVENTURES AND SANDRA
FELT TODAY PROGRAM.
SERVING ABOUT A HUNDRED AND
FOURTEEN PEOPLE.
WE JUST INTEGRATED SIX PEOPLE
FROM THE DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER
ENTIRE DAY PROGRAM AND I CAN
ASSURE YOU WE'RE NOT GETTING ONE
PENNY MORE FOR THEM THAT WE GOT
FOR THE OTHER PEOPLE.
SO THEY'RE NOT COSTING MORE FOR
THEIR DAY PROGRAM SERVICES.
SO CONSIDERING THAT AN AVERAGE
OF A MILLION DOLLARS PER PERSON
IS GOING TO BE SPENT NEXT YEAR
ON DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER.
CLIENTS THAT LEAVES NINE HUNDRED
EIGHTY THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR EACH
OF THESE PEOPLE TO BE SUPPORTED
IN THE COMMUNITY. I THINK
THERE'S A DIFFERENCE.
AND I DON'T KNOW WHAT THEY'RE
HOUSING RATES ARE DON'T KNOW.
THEY ALL LIVE IN ONE GROUP HOME
DOWN THE STREET FROM OUR
PROGRAM.
BUT I CAN'T BELIEVE IT'S THEIR
SPENDING NINE HUNDRED EIGHTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER PERSON ON
pBECAUSE WE DON'T KNOW HOW MUCH
IT DOESN'T MEAN WE CAN'T AGREE
IN PRINCIPLE THAT IS A GOOD PLAN
THANK YOU.
I CAN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
IS THE COMMITTEE PERRY GETTING
WITH THE CALIFORNIA DISABILITY
SERVICES ASSOCIATION I WANNA SIT
REGISTER OUR SUPPORT FOR THE
WHEN WE COALITION PROPOSAL CDSA
IS A MEMBER OF THE LET ME
COALITION. AS WELL I WANT TO
SUPPORT THE THE IDEA THAT WE DO
NEED TO CAPTURE THESE OPERATIONS
DOLLARS I AGAIN I WANT TO
COMPLIMENT THE LA A ON THE
REPORT. I THINK SONNY DID A
GREAT JOB AND REALLY WE'VE BEEN
YIELDING SAVINGS FOR MANY YEARS
AS A DEVELOPMENT OF CENTERS OF
CLOSE DOWN THIS IS REALLY OUR
LAST SHOT TO TRY TO CAPTURE SOME
OF THESE DOLLARS WERE COMING AT
YOU. WITH A LAST GASP PROPOSAL
SAYING WE HAVE A BUNCH OF GAPS
WE'VE A BUNCH OF NEEDS OF THE
COMMUNITY. AND THIS IS OUR LAST
CHANCE TO REALLY COMMIT DOLLARS
HAVE ALREADY GOING TO THIS
POPULATION TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY STAY IN THE SYSTEM FUNDING
PEOPLE AND COMMUNITY. THANK YOU
PRODUCER.
I AM TEMAS MET WITH STRATEGIES
TO EMPOWER PEOPLE I'M I'M HERE
IN SUPPORT OF. HAVING THE MONEY
FOLLOW THE PEOPLE THAT IT SERVED
IT REALLY DOES IT SERVED SO MANY
PEOPLE THERE WHY SHOULD IT NOT
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT THEM AS THEY
MOVE OUT IN THE COMMUNITY AND
LEAVE. LIVE INDEPENDENT LIVES.
AND IT ALSO WILL BE SO MUCH
EXTRA LEFT OVER TO HELP
ADDITIONAL PEOPLE WHO ARE
ALREADY LIVING ON THE COMMUNITY
OR. AS I LIKE TO SAY I HAVE
TWENTY PEOPLE LIVING AND NOT
IDEAL SITUATIONS BECAUSE THERE
IS NO HOUSING.
THEY'RE LIVING WITH OTHER PEOPLE
THAT THEY REALLY WOULD PREFER
NOT TO BECAUSE THEY CAN'T FIND
HOUSING OR BECAUSE ANYBODY
LIVING OFF SSA SSI ONLY GETS
UNDER NINE HUNDRED DOLLARS A
MONTH.
NO RENT IN SACRAMENTO IS NINE
HUNDRED DOLLARS.
EVERYBODY JUST RAISE THE RENTS
AGAIN FOR PEOPLE THAT WERE ON
BUDGETS OR LOW INCOME HOUSING
AND THEIR LOW INCOME HOUSING IS
THAT.
WILL YOU BEING NINE HUNDRED
IT'S NINE HUNDRED NOW WE'RE
GONNA MAKE IT TWELVE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY DAYS.
NOBODY WANTS TO TAKE IT THEY
WANT THREE TIMES THE AMOUNT OF
RENT IT'S HORRIBLE LET ALONE
RDSP TURN OVER RATE BECAUSE OF
THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING THEY CAN
AFFORD TO WORK.
WITH THE PEOPLE THAT WE SUPPORT
AND THEY NEED QUALITY SUPPORT
STAFF.
IT'S ALL AROUND WE NEED MONEY TO
FOLLOW THEM. THANK YOU
I CAN.
UNABLE COMMITTEE I'M MARGARET
FIREMEN I'M THE CEO OF UCP OF
THE NORTH BAY.
THAT IS SO NO MY NAPA SOLANO
COUNTY AND I DO OF A BIT OF THAT
BECAUSE HE WORKED WITH THE UC P.
ARC A COLLABORATION AS WELL AS
LOCAL COMMITTEES DISABILITY
COMMITTEES. UNIVERSALLY THE
NUMBER ONE PROBLEM
IN OUR SYSTEM IS AFFORDABLE
HOUSING.
I DO NOT RUN HOUSING SERVICES I
BROWN AND EMPLOYMENT SERVICES
BUT I CAN'T GET STAFF THEY HAVE
NO PLACE TO LIVE AND THE FOLKS
THAT I HAVE TRADITIONALLY SERVED
ARE MOVING. INTO THE CENTRAL
VALLEY AND HOMES AND FAMILIES
ARE BEING BROKEN UP
BECAUSE OF THE PROBLEM IN THE
NORTH BAY THIS IT'S ONLY BEEN
EXACERBATED BY THE FIRES THIS
LAST YEAR. SO I REALLY WANT YOU
TO CONSIDER THIS PROPOSAL VERY
SERIOUSLY THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
OTHER ITEMS IN THE LANTERN AND
PROPOSAL NONE OF THEM ARE IS
CRUCIAL IS THE HOUSING. KEEPING
THE ASSETS OF THE DEVELOPMENTAL
CENTERS IN OUR SYSTEM IS
ABSOLUTELY CRUCIAL AT THIS TIME.
THINK
ACUMEN.
WHATEVER WITH USERS EXPLORE TO A
STAND AND SUPPORT OF THE POLICY
DECISION YOU'RE TRYING TO MAKE
IT WAS PREDICTED A GREAT JOB OF
TRYING TO DO ANALYSIS IS ON SOME
REALLY COMPLEX ISSUES. LITERALLY
POLICY.
ARE THOSE ASSETS THAT WERE
HOUSING FOR FOURTEEN THOUSAND
PEOPLE IN NINETEEN SEVENTY.
GONNA BE FOURTEEN THOUSAND UNITS
IN THE COMMUNITY WE HAVEN'T MADE
THAT MANY IS PEOPLE OF CONVERTED
OUT INTO THE COMMUNITY WE NEED
THAT ASSET. WHERE MY LEAD
ADVOCATES LOSS FOR SECTION EIGHT
HOUSING? WAS GIVEN TWELVE MONTHS
NOTICE IT TOOK US FIFTEEN MONTHS
TO FIND HER A PLACE IN A
NEIGHBORHOOD THAT NONE OF US
WOULD WANT TO LIVE. SHE'S HAD
MULTIPLE BREAK INS MULTIPLE
ISSUES IT'S NOT SAFE THAT'S
WHERE FOLKS ARE HAVING TO LIVE
IS A CRITICAL ISSUE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR.
HI MY NAME'S PATTY DIXON I'M
HERE AS AN EMPLOYEE FOR OVER
TWENTY FIVE YEARS WITH FOLKS
WITH DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES.
AS WELL AS A PARENT.
AND.
HOUSING IS A HUGE CRISIS IT'S
IT'S CRITICAL AGAIN THEY'RE
ASKING FOR THREE TIMES THE
INCOME IN ORDER TO RENT A PLACE.
WHICH ARE FOLKS DON'T HAVE.
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IS A HUGE
ISSUE AND NOT ONLY FOR.
THE FOLKS WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES BUT ALSO THEIR
STAFF.
BECAUSE OF COURSE THERE ISN'T
IN THE BUDGET MONEY TO PAY THEM
A LIVING.
GOOD WAGE SO I SUPPORT ALIGNMENT
COALITIONS PROPOSAL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MA'AM.
PHOENIX CALIFORNIA DISABILITY
RIGHTS WHERE WE'RE IN SUPPORT OF
LETTERMAN COALITION.
AND DOM PROPOSAL WANNA THINGS
THAT WE HAVE TO SEE IF THAT NANA
YES THE HOUSING. COSTS TO BE
AFFORDABLE BUT HAS TO BE
ACCESSIBLE.
A NEW DTS PROGRAM UNDERSTANDS
THIS THEY KNOW THAT WHEN THEY
BUILT THESE DOMINICAN HAVE UNITS
THESE HOUSES WILL BE ACCESSIBLE
PICKING USM. RIGHT NOW IF YOU
GET A HOUSE DON'T TWENTY SEVEN
PERCENT OF ALL HOUSING IT'S
ACCESSIBLE IN THIS STATE THAT'S
THE LAW.
BUT WITH THE DDS POPE BOZELL
HERE W. LOT MORE ACCESSIBLE
HOUSING AND A BILL TO MOVE RIGHT
IN RIGHT AWAY AND THAT IS WHAT
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT IN ORDER TO
LIVE INDEPENDENTLY THEY GOT TO
BE ABLE TO LIVE.
INDEPENDENTLY.
AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE IN SUPPORT
OF THIS PROPOSAL.
IF MILLER REPRESENTING THE LOS
ANGELES COALITION OF SERVICE
PROVIDERS.
VERY STRONGLY SUPPORT.
AT THAT THE POLICY
THAT THE TAX DOLLARS THAT WERE.
DEVOTED TO SERVICES FOR PEOPLE
WITH DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
REMAIN PURPOSED IN THAT
DIRECTION.
TRUTHFULLY BUT THE DEVELOPMENTAL
CENTERS HAVE BEING HAVE BEEN.
DEPOPULATED OVER THIRTY YEARS
MOST OF THE PEOPLE.
I WHO HAVE COME OUT OF THE
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS OVER THE
LAST THIRTY YEARS ARE BEING
SERVED BY COMMUNITY SERVICE
PROVIDERS.
I EVERY YEAR WHEN WE COME AND WE
ASK FOR A FEW A FEW CRUMBS FEW
EXTRA DOLLARS.
THE QUESTION THAT WE ALWAYS HEAR
IS WHAT WHERE WILL THOSE DOLLARS
COME FROM.
HERE WE'RE LOOKING AT THE
REALITY OF RESOURCES THAT
CALIFORNIA HAS DEVOTED TO THIS
POPULATION.
AND THAT IS WHERE THE RESOURCES
SHOULD COME FROM.
WE SHOULDN'T BE LOOKING AT.
ACTUALLY CAN
SCRIPTING.
CALIFORNIA'S
RESOURCES FOR THE
DEVELOPMENTALLY DISABLED.
BY.
LETTING THEM PERVERTED THE
GENERAL FUND WE SHOULD BE
LOOKING AT THAT AS THE POOL OF
RESOURCES. THAT THE THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND PLUS PEOPLE
NEED.
AND BY RE PURPOSING THOSE
DOLLARS.
SAVE THAT QUESTION OF WHERE WILL
THE MONEY COME FROM THIS IS A
SOURCE THAT CONSERVE THE
COMMUNITY FOR MANY YEARS. WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE LIMIT
COALITION.
THANK YOU SIR.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
MICHAEL LONG TO HELP OF MINOR
CASE OF SERENA PAULSON AND
ACCORDING TO IF THAT'S THE BILL
IN ITS.
AND HOUSING IS ONE IN THE MOST
IMPORTANT THINGS FOR HER HUTS.
AND THE REASON WHY IT'S
IMPORTANT BECAUSE IT GIVES US
OPPORTUNITY TO.
BEEN ABLE TO LIVE. IN THE
COMMUNITY.
YOU KNOW JACQUI WERE SAYING THAT
THE RAMP MUCH FOURTEEN HUNDRED
DOLLARS THERE'S ANOTHER PROBLEM.
I'M FACING PEOPLE WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
LIKE MARCEL.
AND THEIR IDEAS SHE GOT TO BE
ABLE TO MAKE THREE TIMES AS MUCH
AS THE INCOME. TO BE ABLE TO
QUALIFY IN THIS SITUATION.
OF BEING ABLE TO LIVE IN A
COMMUNITY.
SO I STRONGLY SUGGESTS TO BE
ABLE TO SUPPORT THE HOUSE SCENE.
ON PROPOSAL THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON LYNN DEPLORED
WITH THE VERY INK IN.
NAPA.
SOLANO CINEMA AND LAKE COUNTIES
AFFILIATED WITH THE ARK
CALIFORNIA AND ALSO WITH
CALIFORNIA SUPPORTED LIVING
NETWORK.
.
I AM VERY EXCITED TO HAVE THIS
CONVERSATION TODAY'S BEEN A
CONVERSATION THAT'S BEEN THE
REGIONAL CENTER SYSTEM IN IN THE
THIS FIELD OF SERVICES FOR MANY
MANY YEARS.
WAS REGIONAL CENTER EMPLOYEE
MANY YEARS AGO.
.
WE ALWAYS WANTED THE MONEY TO
FOLLOW THE PERSON WHEN THE
INDIVIDUAL LEFT THE
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER WHY WASN'T
THE MONEY FOLLOWING THE PERSON
THAT MADE NO SENSE. WE'RE
UNDERFUNDED IN THE COMMUNITY.
NOW IS A PROVIDER OF SERVICE I
SEE IT I SEE IT EVERY SINGLE DAY
THE STRUGGLE THAT WE FACE WITH
HOUSING.
IT'S INCREDIBLY CHALLENGING.
.
IT WILL HAVE THE RIGHT TO LIVE
IN THE HOME THAT THEY CHOOSE.
YET THERE ARE SO MANY
LIMITATIONS
LIKE THE GENTLEMAN BEFORE ME
SPOKE.
THREE TIMES THE RENT IS
REQUIRED IF THEY DON'T HAVE THE
FAMILY MEMBER WHO WANTS TO SIGN
ALONG WITH THEM. THEY DON'T GET
THE HOUSING.
.
THERE ARE LIMITATIONS WITH
REGIONAL CENTER ASSISTANCE OF
COURSE WITH YOU WITH THE
RENTING.
SO THEY'RE LEFT TO LIVE WITH TWO
OTHER PEOPLE THEY MAY NOT WANT
TO BE LIVING WITH.
I AM IN FULL SUPPORT OF THE
LETTERMAN PROPOSAL AND.
I AM HOPING THAT WE HAVE COME
TO THE REALIZATION THAT THE
MONEY NEEDS TO ACTUALLY FOLLOW
THE PERSON SO THAT THEY CAN
LIVE.
INDEPENDENTLY LIKE YOU OR I
WOULD WANT TO WITHIN THE
COMMUNITY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MA'AM.
I AM WHEN HYTNER AND I'M FROM
STRATEGIES TO EMPOWER PEOPLE
THAT'S A SUPPORTED LIVING IN AN
INDEPENDENT LIVING.
AGENCY HERE IN SACRAMENTO.
I LET'S BE FRANK YOU HAVE MY
FULL SUPPORT FOR THE WOMEN
COALITION PROPOSAL.
EVERY YEAR FOR DECADES I'VE
BEEN HERE AT THE CAPITOL.
TELLING YOU ABOUT WHY YOU NEED
TO CLOSE THE DC'S
AND THAT THE PEOPLE THAT LIVE IN
THE DISEASE CAN BE.
SAFELY AND WONDERFULLY
SUPPORTED. OUT IN THE COMMUNITY.
AND EVERY DAY AND I'M NOT
EXAGGERATING I GET A NEW
REFERRAL.
AT THE AGENCY AND I HAVE TO PUT
THEM ON A VERY LONG WAITING
LIST.
AND EVERY OTHER AGENCY IN TOWN
IS IT DOESN'T ISN'T TAKING
REFERRALS
AND THE BIG PROBLEM IS THERE'S
KNOW HOUSING FOR PEOPLE THAT
THEY CAN AFFORD. AND THERE'S NO
STAFF.
TO SUPPORT THEM.
THOSE TWO THINGS GO HAND IN HAND
THIS IS A SOLUTION THAT WILL
ADDRESS AT LEAST SOME OF IT.
PART OF IT A STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION.
THANK YOU HEGUMEN.
LIKE MANY MEMBERS MIGHT AGAIN MY
NAME IS RON HAY LONG AND
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR CREEL
COMMITTEE RESOURCES FOR
INDEPENDENT. LIVING AND ALSO A
MEMBER OF THE LATTER MIKKOLA XIN
WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF A LATIN
COALITION ON.
WE JUST TO LET YOU KNOW I HEARD
A TWO BEDROOM FOR FOURTEEN
HUNDRED AND STOCKTON AREA. IN
HAYWARD IT'S ONE BEDROOM AT
SIXTEEN HUNDRED.
AND SO IT'S NOT ONLY HAS TO BE
AFFORDABLE AND ACCESSIBLE BUT
ALSO SUBSIDIZE.
AND SO FOR PEOPLE TO LIVE IN OUR
AREA WE HAVE TO MAKE IT WE HAVE
TO MAKE IT WORK. AND AGAIN I
BELIEVE IN SUSTAINABILITY OF
THIS AND FULLY SUPPORT BOTTOM
COALITION.
EVERYONE GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS SARAH ONE.
I HAVE A HOUSE PAYMENT IS ONE
THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED HOURS A
MONTH EXPERT WITH MY ROOMMATE
AND CUT THE HOUSE AND HOW.
BUT IF I HAVE TO WE. OR I'M LEFT
WITH NOTHING.
SO I SAY IN IN THE SAFE HOUSE.
AND I PAY I'M PAY HALF AND HALF
IT'S OKAY I CAN AFFORD IT. BUT
IF YOU GUYS CUT THE HOUSING
WHERE AM I SUPPOSED TO GO.
YOU THOUGHT I WANT TO STAY IN MY
HOUSE FOREVER.
SO IF YOU CUT IT. AND THEN I
HAVE TO GO BACK TO THE HOSPITAL
OR.
DOES NOT HAVE TO DO IT THINK
YOU.
THANK YOU SIR.
ANY FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENT ON
ISSUE TO.
SEEING NONE I'LL BRING IT BACK
TO THE DYESS FRONT QUESTIONS WE
MAY HAVE GOT ONE MORE.
OKAY YEAH YES MA'AM.
MY NAME IS.
I THINK.
MY NAME IS RENEE FORWARD AND I
HAVE A DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITY
AND I'M BEING SUPPORTED IN THE
COMMUNITY.
BY THIS STEP AGENCY.
AND YOU REALLY DO NEED TO LOOK
AT HOUSING THE ONLY REASON I
HAVE A HOUSE I CAN AFFORD. IS
THAT THE OWNERS OF THE HOUSE
HAD.
DEVELOPMENTALLY DISABLED.
BROTHER AND SISTER WHO LIVED IN
THE HOUSE
SO THEY'RE KEEPING THE HOUSE
OPEN.
FOR PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES.
IF THEY WEREN'T.
I COULDN'T AFFORD THE RENT IN
THE AREA THAT I LIVE IN.
AND IT'S FUNNY WE'VE BEEN
GETTING PHONE CALLS FROM
MILITARES CONSTANTLY GOING WOULD
YOU LIKE TO PUT YOUR HOUSE ON
THE MARKET. SO I KNOW MY
LANDLORD THE OWNER IS MAKING
GREAT SACRIFICE.
BY.
LETTING US LIVE THERE AT A
LITTLE RANT.
IT IS TRUE THAT IF YOU'RE
DISABLED AND YOU WANT TO LIVE
INDEPENDENTLY.
YOU CAN'T FIND HOUSING.
THE SO ISUPPORT THE LANHAM ACT
AS FAR AS IT GOES THE OTHER
THING IS SHE SHOULD.
DEVELOP A POT OF MONEY FOR.
PAYING STOCK.
BECAUSE RIGHT NOW IF THEY LEFT
US
THEY COULD. MAKE MORE MONEY. AT
TARGET OR WALMART OR AND.
A LOT OF DIFFERENT PLACES.
SO.
SOMETIMES THEY LEAVE BECAUSE
THIS SACK CAN'T LIVE ON WHAT I'M
MAKING I LOVE YOU I LOVE THE
WORK BUT I CAN'T LIVE ON. WHAT
I'M MAKING AND SO THIS IS NOT
GOOD? THE OTHER THING IS
BECAUSE.
THE REST OF FOR ORDINARY PEOPLE.
YOU'VE ALL IS ACCEPTED THAT THIS
COST OF LIVING IN CALIFORNIA IS
REALLY HIGH. THE MINIMUM WAGE IS
GOING TO GO UP TO FIFTEEN
DOLLARS AN HOUR.
AND THAT WILL MEAN TO MY AGENCY
WHERE THEY'VE WORKERS ARE LUCKY
IF THEY GET UP TO FIFTEEN
DOLLARS AN HOUR THE AFTER WORK
THERE FOR YEARS TO DO THAT.
THEN THEY'LL BE PAID AT THE TOP
RATE FOR ALL THEIR EXPERIENCE
DEDICATION HARD WORK AND THE
FACT THAT THEY'VE MOVED UP.
IN THE CARE GIVING SKILLED.
AND THEN THE NEW PEOPLE JUST
OFF THE STREET WHO NEED TO BE
TRAINED FOR EVERYTHING.
STILL GET THE SAME WAGE.
THIS IS NOT A PRACTICAL OUTCOME.
PEOPLE WILL JUST DESSERT ALL THE
AGENCIES
AND I UNDERSTAND THAT A LOT OF
THE SMALLER AGENCIES IF I WANTED
TO MOVE OUT TO THE COUNTRY. MY
FAMILY SAYS I SHOULD.
BUT IF I MOVED OUT THERE I'M.
THE SMALLER AGENCIES HAVE GONE
OUT OF BUSINESS.
AND THERE COUNTIES.
DON'T HAVE THE SERVICES THAT
SACRAMENTO COUNTY HAS.
THEY ALL LIVE UP IN OUR BRING
CALIFORNIAN RIGHT NOW I CAN'T
THINK OF THE NAME OF THE COUNTY
THAT I'M SURE SOME OF YOU KNOW
IT.
AND THEY JUST DON'T HAVE THE
AVAILABILITY OF THE SERVICES.
BUT IF YOU CAN'T.
SHE'S RIGHT ABOUT ALL THE PEOPLE
WAITING FOR HOUSES.
IT'S PROBABLY NOT ALSO OUR
AGENCY BUT OTHER AGENCIES BUT
THEY'VE QUIT TAKING REFERRALS
BECAUSE THEY CAN'T HIRE STAFF.
AND I CAN'T FIND HOUSING.
SO. YEAH.  ALSO BROUGHT
WRITTEN COMMENTS FROM PRISTINE
GOAL.
JUDGES GREAT YOU GIVE IT TO THE
SERGEANTS WE CAN.
DISTRIBUTOR.
YEAH.
THANK YOU MAY. THINK YOU.
SO WITH THAT.
BRINGING HIM BACK TO THE DYESS
CAN I WANTED TO ALSO THANK SONYA
PREDICATE THE LA O. FOR.
COMPLETING THIS IMPORTANT
MEASURE IT WAS A QUESTION WE HAD
LAST YEAR.
IN ON PAGE FIFTEEN OF THE ELLIOT
REPORT THAT YOU HAD. SORRY
AGNESE CAME WITH A HANDOUT.
IT HAD TALKED ABOUT HOW. THE.
REGIONAL CENTER STRUGGLE TO
HELP CONSUMERS FIND CERTAIN
SERVICES SUCH AS AFFORDABLE
ACCESSIBLE AND SAFE HOUSING AS
WE'VE HEARD FROM MANY IN
TESTIMONY TODAY.
BUT ALSO REGULAR DENTAL CARE
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES AND
TRANSPORTATION ND SO I WANTED
TO GET A SENSE FROM THE
DEPARTMENT.
WHAT TYPE OF COMPREHENSIVE
ASSESSMENT OF SERVICE GAPS ARE
WE DOING RIGHT NOW?
TO RELATE THIS UNMET.
FUNDING REQUIREMENTS IN THE
COMMUNITY SERVICE SYSTEM.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR YOU KNOW
ONGOING ASSESSMENT AND
DISCUSSIONS AS FAR AS WHAT THE
NEEDS ARE IS IS SOMETHING THAT
WE NEED TO CONTINUE TO DO AND
THE CURRENT AVENUES THAT WE'RE
USING.
WE HAVE THE DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES TASK FORCE THAT WAS
ESTABLISHED BY SECRETARY DULY
WORKING WITH THE COMMUNITY TO
UNDERSTAND WHERE THOSE SERVICE
GAPS ARE.
NOT ONLY FOR INDIVIDUALS WITH
THAT ARE MOVING FROM
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS OR HAVING
THE NEEDS WITH VERY KIND OF
COMPLEX NEEDS BECAUSE CERTAINLY
A LOT OF FOCUS HAS BEEN THERE.
BUT UNDERSTANDING WHERE SOME OF
THE OTHER SERVICE GAPS ARE
HAVING SMALLER WORK GROUPS TO
WORK THROUGH SOME OF THE DETAIL
REGARDING SOME OF THE HOUSING
ISSUES. SO THAT SCENARIO IN
WHICH HAD HAS HELPED INFORM US
AS A DEPARTMENT ON SOME OF
SERVICE GAPS THE OTHER AREAS
THAT WE TAKE A LOOK AT IS THE
OPPORTUNITY THAT WE HAVE WITH A
COMMUNITY PLACEMENT PLAN. THIS
LAST YEAR WE'VE HAD AND.
APPROVAL THROUGH THE BUDGET
PROCESS TO BE ABLE TO USE A
COMMUNITY RESOURCE DEVELOPMENT
FUND.
AS A FOLLOW UP FROM COMMITTEE
PLACEMENT PLAN BECAUSE WHERE.
I'M DEVELOPED REALLY PRIMARILY
ALL THE RESOURCES FOR FOLKS WHO
ARE MOVING FROM THE
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER SO NOW
FOCUSING ON INDIVIDUALS ON AND
THE NEEDS WITHIN THE COMMUNITY.
AND I MENTION THAT BECAUSE PART
OF THE DEVELOPMENT OF THE
GUIDELINES ONE IS WE HAVE TO
REACH OUT TO. ON THE
STAKEHOLDERS FOR INPUT AND WANT
TO BE ABLE TO HAVE WELL WHAT ARE
THE PRIORITIES THAT WE NEED TO
LOOK AT.
TO PRIORITIZE THE USE OF THE
FUNDS.
TO DEVELOP THE COMMUNITY
RESOURCES IN DEVELOPING THE
GUIDELINES AND MEETING WITH
STAKEHOLDERS ONE OF THE AREAS
THAT WE'VE TALKED ABOUT IS HOW
DO WE REALLY GET A SENSE OF WHAT
THE NEEDS ARE. SO CERTAINLY WITH
CPP DOLLARS WE ARE ABLE TO LOOK
AT HOW MANY INDIVIDUALS WERE IN
A DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER WHAT. YOU
KNOW WHAT ARE THE NEEDS AND
BEING ABLE TO DEVELOPED BUT IT'S
NOT AS DEFINED WHEN WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT.
YOU KNOW JUST DISTRICT JUST
DISTRIBUTE DISTRIBUTING THAT.
THE RESOURCES UNDER THE
COMMUNITY RESOURCE DEVELOPMENT
FUNDS
SO IN THE GUIDELINES WERE GOING
TO ASK TO REGIONAL CENTERS TO
CEMENT TO US NOT ONLY THE DATA.
THAT WOULD SUPPORT THE PROPOSALS
THAT ARE WITHIN THAT.
THE SUBMISSIONS THAT WE'RE
GOING TO BE RECEIVING BUT ALSO
COMMUNITY INPUT TO START
IDENTIFYING WHERE THOSE GAPS OF
SERVICES SO WE CAN REALLY LINK
THOSE TWO.
ALSO A RESEARCH TEAM IS AN AREA
IN AND IDENTIFY MORE WHERE HE
TRENDS AS WE'RE LOOKING AT
TRENDS IN OUR CHANGES OF THE. A
COMMUNITY WHERE THOSE NEEDS
GOING TO BE EMERGING OVER TIME
HOW MANY INDIVIDUALS ARE
GRADUATING HIGH SCHOOL HOW MANY
INDIVIDUALS ARE GOING AND WE'RE
SEEING AN AGING POPULATION. SO'S
WE WE CAN'T LOOK AT ONE SIZE
FITS ALL AS FAR AS THE
INFORMATION THAT'S COMING TO US
WE REALLY DO HAVE TO TAKE A LOOK
AT. KIND OF THE UNIVERSE AND AND
GATHERING THAT INPUT TO HELP
INFORM THE SOME OF THOSE AREAS
OF GAPS OF SERVICES WELL AS THE
TASK FORCE IS COMING TO SOME
CONCLUSIONS I HOPE YOU WOULD
INCLUDE THE LEGISLATURE TO MAKE
SURE WE HAD. THE APPROPRIATE
INFORMATION IN FRONT OF US MAY
BE HAPPY TO PROVIDE UPDATES
THANK YOU.
WITH THAT WE WILL HOLD ISSUE TO
OPEN AT THIS TIME AND FOR
PROCEDURAL PURPOSES WE WILL MOVE
ON TO ISSUE FOR SINCE WE HAVE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER OLD.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
TRADE. EVEN ALLAH CHO ON HERE
.
UP IN JUST UP TO THAT YOU KNOW.
THE CHAIRPERSON HAD TO GO TO
ANOTHER MEETING SOMEBODY
STANDING IN FOR.
OKAY.
CLOSE GOING TO THINK THE THE
CHAIR AND I'LL THINK IT'S HERE.
THROUGH.
.
OUR ILLUSTRIOUS A COLLEAGUE. OF
FOUR IS A CONSIDERATION AND
ALLOWING US TO HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY PRESENT
ON THIS PARTICULAR ITEM.
.
MEMBERS SAID I'D LIKE TO THANK
YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT.
A TODAY MY REQUEST TO THIS
COMMITTEE.
THIS TO RECOGNIZE THAT WHILE IT
MAY BE DIFFICULT TO PROVIDE
ADEQUATE SERVICES ANYWHERE IN
OUR STATE. WITH THE CURRENT RATE
STRUCTURE.
IT IS VERIFIABLY IMPOSSIBLE
TO DO SO IN AREAS OF OUR STATE
THAT ARE AMONG THE MOST
EXPENSIVE PLACES TO LIVE. IN THE
ENTIRE COUNTRY.
I ENCOURAGE MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE TO RECOGNIZE THE VERY
SIMPLE TRUTH ACOSTA OPERATE ANY
BUSINESS ARE DIRECTLY RELATED TO
THE LABOR MARKET IN WHICH THEY
OPERATE.
WE SIMPLY CANNOT EXPECT A
SERVICE PROVIDER IN SAN DIEGO
SAN FRANCISCO OR PASADENA
FUNCTION WITH THE SAME
REIMBURSEMENTS THAT THE STATE
PAYS. AND LOWER COSTS AREAS OF
OUR STATE.
WE KNOW PROVIDERS ARE STRUGGLING
AND FAILING AND TO KEEP UP IN
HIGH COST REGION'S. AS THEY
STRUGGLE OR CLOSE IT IS THE
PEOPLE DEPENDING UPON THEM WHO
WILL SUFFER.
GRANTING THIS REQUEST FOR
TARGETED BRIDGE FUNDING WILL
PREVENT THESE.
ORGANIZATIONS TO CONTINUE
SERVING THE NEEDS OF
CALIFORNIANS WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES WHILE WE WAIT. FOR
THE COMPREHENSIVE RATE REFORM
EXPECTED IN THE COMING YEARS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE. AND
WILL TURN THE REST OF MY TIME
OVER TO GEORGE STEVENS AND MARC
KLAAS.
FIRST ONE EXPRESSED BY SINCERE
APPRECIATION TO THE MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMITTEE FOR GIVING ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY.
SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
HOLDINGS BUDGET REQUEST.
THE TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
IN ANNUAL BRIDGE FUNDING IS
DESPERATELY NEEDED BY SERVICE
PROVIDERS STATEWIDE ESPECIALLY
THOSE IN HIGH COST AREAS.
ULTIMATELY THESE DOLLARS TO
SUPPORT A THREE YEAR THOUSAND
CONSUMERS INDIVIDUALS WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DIABILITIES THAT
LIVE IN COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT
THE STATE.
MY NAME'S GEORGE STEVENS AND
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR THE NORTH
LOS ANGELES COUNTY REGIONAL
CENTER.
I'M ALSO THE CHAIRPERSON OF THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA CONFERENCE
REGIONAL CENTER DIRECTORS AND
THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY DIRECTORS
GROUP.
THE HOSTAGES COUNTY REGIONAL
CENTER SERVES TWENTY FOUR
THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED THIRTY NINE
CONSUMERS.
WHERE CURRENTLY PROVIDING INTAKE
ASSESSMENT SERVICES SEVEN
HUNDRED THIRTY ONE INFANTS
CHILDREN AND ADULTS?
THE SOONERS THE THIRD LARGEST
REGIONAL CENTER IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ONE OF THE FASTEST
GROWING RULING OVER ONE THOUSAND
NEW CONSUMERS EVERY YEAR. HAS
SEARCHED NEED FOR VIABLE IN
EXPANDING SERVICE DELIVERY
SYSTEM IS UNQUESTIONABLE AND
NECESSARY TO FILL THE STATE'S
OBLIGATION UNDER THE LANHAM ACT.
I'M ME HALF THE SENATE BORDER
DIRECTORS THE COMMUNITY THE
CENTER SERVES CENTER SERVICE
PROVIDERS I'M VOICE IN OUR
COLLECTIVE SUPPORT FOR ASSEMBLY
MEMBER HOLDS TWENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLAR BUDGET REQUEST.
THE IRAQIS WERE WE FIND THE
VALUES IN THE MISSION OF THE
STATE SET FORTH IN PROVIDING
COMMUNITY SERVICES FOR CONSUMERS
AND THEIR FAMILIES.
THE ACT STATES APART LEGISLATURE
FINDS THAT THE MERE EXISTENCE.
OR DELIVERY OF SERVICES AND
SUPPORT IS IN ITSELF
INSUFFICIENT EVIDENCE
A PROGRAM EFFECTIVENESS
TO ME PROGRAM MEANS THE
COMMUNITY SERVICE AS A WHOLE.
MOREOVER LETTERMAN ACT GOES ON
TO STATE THAT AND I'M
PARAPHRASING
THE SERVICES SHOULD BE AVAILABLE
STATEWIDE TO PROMOTE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR CONSUMERS. TO
BE INTEGRATED INTO THE
MAINSTREAM OF LIFE IN THEIR HOME
COMMUNITIES.
FOR VARIOUS FINANCIAL REASONS
BUSINESS COSTS AND RATES WERE
NOT ABLE TO ENSURE THAT THE
SERVICES AND SUPPORTS AUTHORIZED
AN INDIVIDUAL CONSUMERS AYE PPVS
ARE AVAILABLE STATEWIDE
EFFECTIVE OR EMPOWER CONSUMERS
AS ENVISIONED LAMBERT.
THIS IS DEMONSTRATED IN PART BY
THE TWO HUNDRED AND THIRTY NINE
PROGRAM CLOSE THE LOAN WITHIN
THE NORTH OF THINGS COMING
REGIONAL CENTER SERVICE HEARING
OVER THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS.
IN ADDITION NORTH LA HAS NOT
BEEN ABLE TO EXPAND NEEDED
SERVICES BECAUSE I REQUEST FOR
PROPOSALS TO DEVELOP NEW
SERVICES HAVE GONE UNANSWERED.
THE PRIMARY CAUSES TO THE
DISCONNECT BETWEEN ALLOWABLE
RATES AND COST TO CONDUCT
BUSINESS.
TING PLYWOOD FEDERAL STATE AND
LOCAL MANDATES PROVIDERS HAVE
INCURRED UNAVOIDABLE BUSINESS
BECAUSE THEY MAKE IT
INCREASINGLY POSSIBLE FOR THEM
TO EFFECTIVELY SERVE AND SUPPORT
CONSUMERS.
COST PRESSURES SUCH AS THE
MANDATE TO PROVIDE HEALTH
INSURANCE
PROTECT PERSONAL HEALTH
INFORMATION. AND COST OF HIGH
TECH PAIN ESCALATING WORKER'S
COMP INSURANCE
A SIMILAR FINANCIAL AUDITS AND
PAYING REQUIRED LOCAL WAGES.
OTHER COST DRIVERS OR RENT
TRANSPORTATION EMPLOYMENT COSTS
DUE TO HIGH TURNOVER.
REGIONAL CENTERS ARE NOT ALLOWED
TO INCREASE RATES DUE TO A
STATUTORY RATE FREEZE AND MEDIUM
RATES REQUIRING WORKS HOW SORRY
ABOUT THAT. AND MEDIA RATE
SETTING REQUIREMENTS WORKS WITH
THE PRESS.
PRESS
NEW EMPLOYER RATES AS COSTS IN
HAWKEYES HIGH COST AREAS.
I CAN NOT SOME KIND OF WAY.
WELL YOU GOT IT.
WITH UP TO THIRTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS MORE CONSUMERS WILL BE
NEGATIVELY IMPACTED BY PROGRAM
CLOSURES.
AND NORTH PHILLY OVER TWENTY ONE
HUNDRED CONSUMERS HAVE BEEN
DISPLACED.
BY PROVIDERS WHO HAVE CLOSER
DISCONTINUED SERVICES.
JUST THIS LAST WEEK TO MORE
PROVIDERS THAT GAVE NOTICE THAT
THEY PLANNED CLOSE CITING RATES
ARE TOO LOW TO SUSTAIN THEIR
BUSINESSES.
AS A CONSEQUENCE MORE
CONSEQUENCE WHERE CONSUMERS WILL
BE DISPLACED EMPLOYEES WILL LOSE
JOBS.
VACANCIES TURNOVER RATES ARE
ALSO SEVERE SO SEVERE THAT
CONSUMERS ARE TURNED AWAY ON
FROM THERE DON'T THEY SERVICES
DUE TO INSUFFICIENT STAFF TO
MEET REQUIRED. CONSUMER STAFF
RATIOS AS SUCH CONSUMERS ABSENT
FROM PAID EMPLOYMENT AND RISK
LOSING THEIR JOBS.
REALLY START PROVIDERS
I'M NOT ABLE TO HIRE THE RENT
AND RETAIN THE APPROPRIATE
CLINICAL STAFF TO SERVE INFANTS
AND TODDLERS CONSISTENT WITH
THEIR INDIVIDUAL FAMILY SERVICE
PLANS.
PROVIDE AN ALTERNATIVE SUPPORTS
THAT CONSUMERS.
WHO HAVE BEEN DISPLACED WERE
WHO'VE PROVIDERS OF CLOSE
BUSINESS ARE COSTLY AND ARE NOT
LIKELY TO MEET THEIR BY PP
OBJECTIVES AS ENVISIONED?
WE FIND OURSELVES IN MANY
REGIONAL CENTER SERVICE
COORDINATORS SPENDING DAYS
SEARCHING FOR ATTORNEYS AND
COBBLING TOGETHER A PATCHWORK OF
COSTLY SUPPORTS MEANT TO REPLCE
CAUGHT THE LOST OF THE MOST
APPROPRIATE SERVICES.
HUMAN COST IN THE SITUATIONS
CANNOT BE MEASURED ESPECIALLY
THE LOSS OF TRUSTING
RELATIONSHIP.
IN CLOSING.
WHAT IS TWENTY FIVE DOLLARS MEAN
TO THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
CONSUMERS WE SERVE? UNSUPPORTED
DAILY IN MEANS THE WORLD TO
THEM.
IT'S A NOMINAL COST THE PAVE TO
ENSURE EACH CONSUMER CONTINUES
TO HAVE A PRODUCTIVE AND
MEANINGFUL LIFE.
ASK ANOTHER WAY CAN CALIFORNIA
FOR TWENTY THREE CENTS A DAY PER
CONSUMER TO INSURE THEIR
WELLBEING AND THE CONTINUITY OF
THEIR SERVICES AND SUPPORTS.
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK FOR TODAY
AND IN SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER HOLDS TWENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLAR BUDGET REQUEST.
THANK YOU.
LIKE YOU COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS MARK CLAUS I'M THE
PRESIDENT AND CEO FOR HOME OF
GUIDING HANDS HOME GRADING HANDS
IS LOCATED IN SAN DIEGO.
WE HAVE BEEN PROVIDING SERVICES
TO INDIVIDUALS WITH INTELLECTUAL
AND DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
SINCE NINETEEN SIXTY SEVEN SO WE
WE'VE BEEN AROUND FOR A FEW
YEARS.
CELEBRATE OUR FIFTIETH
ANNIVERSARY.
LAST YEAR.
.
THE VAST MAJORITY OF. THE
SERVICES THAT WE PROVIDE ARE ARE
FUNDED THROUGH THE DEPARTMENT OF
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES OR MEDI
CAL WE HAVE SOME.
INTERMEDIATE CARE FACILITY
HOMES.
WHEN I SAY ALMOST ALL.
TO GIVE AN EXAMPLE LAST YEAR
WE'VE RAISED OVER TWO MILLION
DOLLARS A TO FUNDS SERVICES DUE
TO THE INADEQUATE RATES.
.
THIS YEAR WE HAVE RAISED FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS AND WE KNOW I
THINK WE'RE AT THAT FOR A KIND
OUR PERSPECTIVE.
UP TO KEEP GOING BACK TO OUR
COMMUNITY TO TRY THE FUND
SERVICES.
IT IT'S BECOMING MORE DIFFICULT
AND IT'S IT'S ACTUALLY A BAD
BUSINESS MODEL.
.
I AM ALSO A BOARD MEMBER THE SAN
DIEGO REGIONAL CENTER
REPRESENTING THE FENDERS AND SAN
DIEGO AND IMPERIAL COUNTIES AND
ANDMAYBE MOST IMPORTANTLY.
THE GRANDFATHER OF A YOUNG MAN
WHO IS RECEIVE SERVICES.
THROUGH THE EARLY START PROGRAM
IN THE REGIONAL CENTERS OF.
I'M HERE TODAY AS WELL ASKING IF
YOUR FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOLDEN'S TWENTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLAR REQUEST FOR
BRIDGE FUNDING. FROM THE PARDON
OF DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES.
TO BEGIN OF FISCAL YEAR TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHTEEN BEGINNING
JULY FIRST.
THE REQUESTED APPROPRIATIONS AS
GEORGE MENTIONED WOULD ALLOW FOR
THE POSSIBILITY OF SUMMARY RATE
RELIEF ON AT NUMEROUS COST
PRESSURES.
FACING PROVIDERS THEIR
STRUGGLING TO KEEP THE DOORS
OPEN.
AND CONTINUING OF THE SERVICES
TO PROVIDE GOOD QUALITY SERVICES
THESE FUNDS WILL HELP PRESERVE
ESSENTIAL SERVICES MAY TAKE OVER
LOVE RELATIONSHIPS.
THAT SERVICE PROVIDERS HAVE WITH
THE INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES
THEY SERVE. AND IN DOING SO
PREVENT THE STATE FROM HAVING TO
LOOK AT FUNDING ALTERNATIVE
SERVICES THAT TYPICALLY
REQUESTED REQUIRES SIGNIFICANTLY
MORE INVESTMENT.
.
IT IS GEORGE MENTIONED A
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOLDINGS OFFICE.
DID A SURVEY OF PROVIDERS WITH
OVER A HUNDRED PARTICIPANTS
FORTY SEVEN PERCENT OF THOSE
COMMUNITY AGENCIES THAT
RESPONDED. REPORTED DOWNSIZING
PROGRAM CAPACITY.
OR CLOSING.
LOOKING AT CLOSING PROGRAMS DUE
TO INADEQUATE FUNDING OF.
AS A RESULT OF INADEQUATE
FUNDING INDIVIDUALS ARE MOVING
LOSING SERVICES.
.
AND. THEN A WEEK WE CAN'T WAIT
FOR THE RATE STUDY I HEAR A LOT
OF YOU KNOW A LOT OF LEGISLATORS
LOT OF MY COLLEAGUES AND WILL
pGREAT STUDIES COMING OUT IN THE
ALL.
MARCH OF TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
SUCH A LITTLE BIT TOO LATE TO
GET INTO NEXT YEAR'S BUDGET.
AND WE ARE IN CRISIS TODAY.
THE BOTTOM LINE REALLY IS THAT
THIS ISN'T ABOUT MY ORGANIZATION
THIS ISN'T ABOUT HOME OF HEIGHT
GUIDING HANDS ARE THE MANY
PROVIDERS THAT ARE WOEFULLY
UNEXPECTED. WITH EXCEPTIONAL
DIRECT CARE STAFF THAT ARE
PLAYED.
INADEQUATE WAGES THIS IS ABOUT
THE PEOPLE THIS IS ABOUT PEOPLE
THAT WE SERVE.
THIS IS ABOUT YOUNG MAN.
.
NAME TERRY TERRY HAS LIVED WITH
US.
SINCE NINETEEN SINCE AUGUST
FIRST OF NINETEEN SIXTY SEVEN HE
SO HE'S RESIDE IN ONE OF OUR
HOMES.
FOR FIFTY YEARS HIS FATHER WAS
ONE OF THE FOUNDERS.
IT'S ABOUT RJ RJ SEE YOUNG MAN
HE SEVENTEEN.
HE'S ONE OF THE EIGHTEEN
CHILDREN THAT WE SUPPORT AND FOR
COMMUNITY CARE LICENSE HOMES A
FOR CHILDREN AND ADOLESCENTS
WITH SUMS SEVERE BEHAVIORAL
CHALLENGES.
THAT'S BEEN IDENTIFIED FROM MY
UNDERSTANDING IS WHAT HIGHEST
NEEDS OF OF THE REGIONAL CENTER
SYSTEM AND EDS.
BUT HONESTLY I DON'T KNOW HOW
LONG OUR ORGANIZATION CAN
CONTINUE TO OPERATE THESE HOMES.
THESE FOUR HOMES A EIGHT MONTHS
INTO THE YEAR. WERE LOSING THREE
HUNDRED AND NINETY THREE
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR THESE FOUR
HOMES SO LET'S OVER YOU KNOW
FIFTEEN HUNDRED DOLLARS A DAY.
JUSTIN OUT SOMEWHERE BETWEEN A
THOUSAND FIFTEEN HUNDRED DOLLARS
A DAY.
.
WITHOUT SOME IMMEDIATE RELIEF
THERE REALLY ARE NO OPTIONS
CURRENTLY AVAILABLE OTHER THAN
HIGHER COSTS OPTIONS FOR SOMEONE
LIKE TERRY FOR SOMEBODY LIKE
ARCHERY.
THIS IS WHAT KEEPS ME UP AT
NIGHT THIS IS WHAT KEEPS ME
GOING AT THE OFFICE AT FOUR AM
THIS IS WHAT GETS ME ON THE SIX
THAT TWENTY FLIGHT OUT OF
SACRAMENTO IN THE EIGHT TEND TO
GO BACK.
IT REALLY IS ABOUT THE PEOPLE
THAT WE SUPPORT IT'S NOT ABOUT
PROVIDERS IT'S NOT ABOUT THE
REGIONAL CENTERS.
IT'S ABOUT THE PEOPLE THAT COUNT
ON US EVERYDAY.
SO I'M ASKING FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
SUPPORT YOUR COLLEAGUES.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S ALL ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS AND SENATORS.
SUPPORT BRIDGE FUNDING REQUEST
THAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOLDEN HAS
PUT OUT THERE FOR TWENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I THINK YOU CAN THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
AND THINK YOU TO SOME WOMEN
HOLDEN FOR HIS INCREDIBLE. A
COMMITMENT TO THIS ISSUE IT AND
CHAMPION THIS CAUSE.
JORDAN LINDSAY EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE ARK IN UNITED
THROUGH PULLED THE CALIFORNIA
COLLABORATIVE
AND.
WATER AND THERE ARE MANY.
PROPOSALS IN HERE AND I'M JUST
GONNA SPEAK
BECAUSE MANY PARENTS BECAUSE
THEY'RE SPECIFICALLY TO A
MINIMUM WAGE.
AND THAT WE JUST HEARD FROM SO
MANY A COUPLE PEOPLE ABOUT THE
NEED FOR HOW HOW DIRECT SUPPORT
PATCH PROFESSIONALS
CAN GO GET A HIGHER PAYING JOB
TARGET OR DOING SOMETHING ELSE
OTHER THAN SUPPORTING. THEN
INDIVIDUALS AND WITH WHAT THEY
LOVE TO DO AND THEY'RE VERY GOOD
AT IT IS A SKILLED NEED.
SO IT'S INCREDIBLY PORTENT THAT
THEIR.
THAT THE WAGES REFLECT THAT.
IN THE OPEN MARKET IF COSTS GO
UP
OR MINIMUM WAGE GOES UP FOR A
TARGET THAN THEY CAN RAISE THEIR
PRICES TO COMPENSATE IF THEY
MUST.
FOR PROVIDERS IN THE COMMUNITY
IT IS A STATE RIGHT ACROSS THE
TABLE ACROSS THE STATE. AND AS
SOME WOMEN HOLDEN.
SO PERFECTLY OUTLINED ITS IT A
ONE SIZE FITS ALL FOR THE
STATE'S JUST DOESN'T MAKE SENSE.
AND.
.
WE HAVE HEARD THAT'S IS IN THE
CP I GOES UP AS MINIMUM WAGE
GOES UP AND I WANT IT THAT IN
THE RATES OF STAY THE SAME.
IT'S BECAUSE PROGRAMS TO CLOSE
INCREDIBLE PRESSURES AND I JUST
WANT SPEAK REAL SPECIFICALLY TO
ONE ISSUE WHICH WAS BOTTOM
OUTLINED VERY WELL ON THE AGENDA
BUT JUST TO ADD TO IT.
THAT THE DOUBLE WHAMMY THAT IS
HITTING PROVIDERS IN THE CERTAIN
REGIONS THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
IN THAT NOT ONLY ARE THERE COSTS
HIGHER BECAUSE THE MINIMUM WAGE.
BUT IT IN AND THE REIMBURSEMENT
RATES.
IS AT THIS.
IT'S LOWER THAN LET'S SAY
SOMEBODY IN BAKERSFIELD FOR SOME
AN ALLEY.
AS THE STATEMENT WAGE HAS JUST
INCREASE IN ON THE BOOKS WE HAVE
THE ABILITY. TO INCREASE.
PROVIDER RATES BASED ON THE
STATE MINIMUM WAGE.
THAT PROVIDER BAKERSFIELD OR
MODESTO AS IN THE AGENDA JUST
GOT THAT BOMB.
THE PROVIDER IN LA DID NOT GET
THAT BUMP THE PROVIDER IN
BAKERSFIELD JUST GOT SO IT'S A
DOUBLE WHAMMY FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS NOT ONLY TO HAVE
HIGHER COSTS ARE ALSO NOT EVEN
GETTING THE REIMBURSEMENT
INCREASE REIMBURSEMENT. THAT
THOSE IN OTHER PARTS THE STATE
HAVE RECEIVED.
IN AND SO WE ARE DEAFENING
SUPPORT OF US WOMEN HOLDINGS
REQUEST.
AND.
IT AND WHAT WE WHAT WE HAVE
SAID ABOUT THIS DEBATE AROUND
THE LOCAL MINIMUM WAGES THAT WE
HATE HATE HATE THAT WE ARE HERE.
ARGUING ABOUT MINIMUM WAGE.
WE WISH WE ARGUE ABOUT SOMETHING
SO MUCH MORE THAN THAT RIGHT NOW
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT MINIMUM WAGE
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS AMY
WESTLING I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
REGIONAL CENTER AGENCIES ALSO
KNOWN AS OUR CAB WE REPRESENT
ALL TWENTY ONE OF THE STATE'S
REGIONAL CENTERS. AND FIRST AND
FOREMOST I WANT TO THANK THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
HEARING THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE
TODAY THANK YOU CHAIR WONDERFUL
STAFFER AGENDA USING IT AND.
BRINGING UP BEFORE YOU THANK
YOU ALSO TO MISTER HOLDEN FOR
CONTINUING TO SUPPORT OUR
COMMUNITY AND CONTINUING TO PUSH
THIS ISSUE BECAUSE IT IS VITAL.
THE ASSOCIATION OF REGIONAL
CENTER AGENCIES IS GRATEFUL THAT
THROUGH A. B. X. TWO ONE THERE
WAS FUNDING SET ASIDE TO DO A
COMPREHENSIVE RATE STUDY IN OUR
SYSTEM.
OUR RATE SYSTEM IS BROKEN AND
THERE IS AN ACKNOWLEDGEMENT OF
THAT I OFTENTIMES SAY THAT IT
WANTS STARTED OFF LOOKING SORT
OF LIKE A THREE BEDROOM TWO BATH
HOUSE.
IT WAS CUTE AND FUNCTIONAL AND
NOW IT LOOKS MORE LIKE THE
WINCHESTER MYSTERY HOUSE AS
WE'VE ADDED ON OUT OF NECESSITY.
AND WE APPRECIATE THE THOROUGH
AND TRANSPARENT PROCESS THAT THE
DEPARTMENT AND THEIR CONTRACTOR
BURNT ASSOCIATES IS GOING
THROUGH TO UPDATE THE RATES.
BUT IN THE MEANTIME WE HAVE A
CRISIS TODAY AS MISTER CLAUS
NOTED. THE RATE STUDY IS DUE OUT
A.
BY MARCH OF TWENTY NINETEEN BUT
TODAY WE'RE CONTINUING TO SEE
PROVIDER STRUGGLE PARTICULARLY
IN HIGH COST AREAS OF THE STATE.
AND SO WE APPRECIATE MISTER
HOLDEN'S REQUEST FOR THIS BRIDGE
FUNDING WHICH REALLY IS A BRIDGE
BETWEEN NOW AND THE RELEASE OF
THE RATE STUDY AND RATE REFORM.
INTO A SYSTEM THAT MAKES MORE
SENSE AND IS BASED AGAIN ON REAL
COSTS FOR THIS PROVISION OF
SERVICES.
AS MR STEVENS AND MR KRAUSS
NOTED IT'S NOT ABOUT REGIONAL
CENTERS IT'S NOT ABOUT SERVICE
PROVIDERS IT'S ABOUT ENSURING.
THAT THE LETTERMAN ACT.
IS A REALITY FOR PEOPLE AND THE
WAY THAT WE NEED TO ENSURE THAT
IS BY ENSURING THAT THEY HAVE
ADEQUATE SERVICE PROVIDERS TO
MEET THEIR NEEDS.
AND THIS IS A BUSINESS WHERE.
IT IS ALL ABOUT RELATIONSHIPS IT
IS ALL ABOUT THAT PERFECT MATCH
BETWEEN THAT ONE INDIVIDUAL AND
THEIR SERVICE PROVIDER AND SO IS
SERVED SERVICE PROVIDERS
BEGINNING TO.
DECLINING ADMISSIONS OR NEED TO
CUT BACK ON SERVICES OR CLOSE
THEIR DOORS. THAT CAUSES
DISRUPTION IN REAL PEOPLE'S
LIVES
AND THESE PEOPLE ARE COUNTING ON
US TO ENSURE THAT THOSE PERFECT
MATCHES REMAIN AND THAT THEIR
SERVICES AREN'T SOMETHING THAT
WE JUST COBBLE TOGETHER. BUT
REALLY ARE HELPING THEM TO
ACHIEVE THEIR STATED GOALS AND
DREAMS.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MA'AM.
NEXT WE HAVE VERY GIARDINI WITH
CALIFORNIA DISABILITY SERVICE
ASSOCIATION FOLLOWED BY
CATHERINE BLAKE MARK.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN OF THE
COMMITTEE VERY JEDINI CALIFORNIA
DISABILITY SERVICES ASSOCIATION.
AND I THINK I'M A LOT OF A LOT
MY TESTIMONY ON OUR OUR FOUR
PERCENT RATE INCREASE IT COULD
BE STOLEN JUST FROM WHAT WE'VE
HEARD ON A ASSEMBLY MEMBER
HOLDING I WANNA. JUST FIRST
EXPRESS MY GRATITUDE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER HOLDEN FOR KEEPING THE
ISSUE I WANT STRONG SUPPORT HIS
TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLAR
BRIDGE FUNDING REQUEST FOR THOSE
HIGH COST AREAS.
BUT WE WE ALSO RECOGNIZE THAT WE
ARE IN A IN A REAL CRISIS AS A
AS A SYSTEM AS AS WE'VE HEARD.
AND SO WHAT WHAT CITIES IS
PROPOSING IS AND REQUESTING IS A
FOUR PERCENT INCREASE IN RATES
AGAIN UNTIL WE GET.
TO THE POINT WHERE THAT RATES
THAT WE'VE HEARD ABOUT IS
IMPLEMENTED.
AND THE REASON IS THAT YOU KNOW
YOU MIGHT WANT TO ASK HER WE GET
FOUR PERCENT WILL THAT TRACKS
YOU KNOW THE CPI INCREASE SINCE
WE GOT OUR LAST INCREASE WITH
THE VX TWO ONE FUNDING.
AND I WANT TO GO BACK JUST A
LITTLE BIT ON THE HISTORY OF
RATE INCREASES PRIOR TO A. B. X.
TWO ONE AND TWENTY SIXTEEN THE
SYSTEM HAD RECEIVED ANY INCREASE
AS A AS RATES SINCE TWO THOUSAND
SIX.
SO WE WERE LOOKING AT A TWENTY
PERCENT RAISE OUR INCREASE IN
CPI DURING TWO FROM TWO THOUSAND
SIX TO TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN WE
DID GET THE A B. X. TWO ONE
FUNDING.
AND THE X. TWO ONE FUNDING WAS
CERTAINLY IT AN ABSOLUTE
NECESSARY THING BUT
PREDOMINATELY IT WAS FOCUSED ON
A WAGE AND BENEFIT PASSED
THROUGH FOR DIRECT SERVICE
PROFESSIONALS. I THINK ALL THE
PROVIDERS IN THE ROOM WOULD
PROBABLY TELL YOU THAT'S THAT'S
REALLY WHERE A LOT OF THE MONEY
NEEDED TO GO BUT IT DID LEAVE A
LOT OF GAPS UNADDRESSED A A LOT
OF COSTA PROVIDERS JUST TO RUN
THE SERVICE DID NOT GET.
ACCURATE ARE YOU KNOW
COMMENSURATE INCREASES TO KEEP
THEM KEEP THE BUSINESSES FUND
FUNCTIONAL.
SO WE'RE AT A POINT WHERE WE'RE
SEEING PROVIDERS.
WHO WHO CANNOT DELIVER SERVICES
THAT THEY WANT TO DELIVER IN
THERE DEVELOPING INTERNAL
WEIGHTLESS REGARDING HEARD SOME
TESTIMONY ABOUT THAT?
AND SO WE'RE REALLY AT A POINT
WHERE WE DO NEED SOME SORT OF
TEMPORARY STABILIZATION UNTIL WE
CAN GET ACROSS THE FINISH LINE
WITH THE RATE STUDY. THAT'S
REALLY WHAT THE FOUR PERCENT
ABOUT IN THE OTHER THE OTHER
PIECE OF THE REQUEST IS REALLY
TO ELIMINATE THOSE MEDIAN RATE
CAPS WHICH WAS SUPPRESSING A
SERVICES KEEPING NEW PROVIDERS
OUT OF A SERVICES.
THAT THAT DON'T ALLOW REGIONAL
CENTERS TO NEGOTIATE WITH
PROVIDERS TO INCREASE RATES SO
ULTIMATELY THEY HAVE TO CLOSE
PROGRAMS. AND I I THINK WE HEARD
MISTER STEVENS VETOED AND WE
SPOKE A LITTLE BIT AS WELL AT
THAT MEETING RATE CAPS ARE
REALLY KILLERS ON KEEPING
SERVICES AVAILABLE TO THE
CONSUMERS WHO RELY ON THEM.
WE DID AT AN INFORMAL INTERNAL
SURVEY WITH CDSA MEMBERS WE HAVE
ROUGHLY OVER EIGHTY MEMBERS OF
THE CDSA TWENTY THREE OF OUR
MEMBER ORGANIZATIONS RESPONDED
TO THE SURVEY. AS ONE TO GIVE
YOU A LITTLE BIT OF AN IDEA IT'S
IT'S OBVIOUSLY NOT ASSEMBLY
REPRESENTATIVE BUT IT GIVES YOU
A FLAVOR OF WHAT WHAT WE'RE
DEALING WITH.
YOU KNOW THOSE TWENTY THREE
ORGANIZATIONS OPERATE HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY NINE PROGRAMS
FORTY TWO OF THOSE PROGRAMS HAVE
WAIT LISTS TODAY. WE ARE WE HAVE
THE LANHAM ACT WILL NOT POST
THAT WE LISTEN CALIFORNIA BUT IN
REALITY WE DO BECAUSE WE HAVE
SERVICES THE PEOPLE WANT. THAT
WE JUST CANNOT PROVIDE BECAUSE
WE DON'T HAVE ADEQUATE STAFFING
DUE TO THE LOW RATES.
AUTHOR OVER A THIRD OF THOSE
PROGRAMS HAVE REDUCE CLIENTS IN
THE LAST YEAR BECAUSE OF THE
STAFF SHORTAGE SO THEY'VE
REDUCED THE NUMBER SERVICES
AVAILABLE. FOR THOSE
ORGANIZATIONS HAVE CLOSE
PROGRAMS ENTIRELY DUE TO STAFF
SHORTAGE OR RATE INADEQUACY SO
WE'VE GOT WE'VE GOT SOME
VERIFIABLE PROBLEMS I THINK PART
OF THE PROBLEM WE DON'T HAVE A
REALLY GOOD DATA SYSTEM.
IN TERMS OF PROGRAM CLOSE AND
OVER THERE THAT ARC HAS DONE A
SURVEY THE REGIONAL CENTERS TO
DETERMINE HOW MANY PROGRAMS HAVE
CLOSE BUT I DO THINK IF IF YOU
REALLY TOOK A GOOD SNAPSHOT OF
THE COMMUNITY YOU WILL SEE A
COMMUNITY IN CRISIS AT THIS
POINT.
AND AGAIN.
.
WE YOU KNOW WE ARE AT A POINT
WHERE WE ARE LOOKING FOR
SOMETHING NOT NOT FOREVER BUT
THEIR POINT WHERE WE CAN JUST
KEEP OURSELVES AFLOAT. UNTIL THE
NEW RATES COME IN THROUGH THE
RATE STUDY WE THINK THE SAVINGS
FROM THE CLOSING THE DC THE MOST
PERFECT OUTLINED IN THE LA OVER
PORT COULD HELP BACKFILL SOME OF
THIS.
WE KNOW IT'S A SIGNIFICANT ASK
BUT WE ALSO THINK IT'S AN
UPSWING NECESSARY ACTS
SO THAT WE CAN DELIVER ON THE
PROMISE OF THAT LIMON ACT. SO WE
DON'T LEAVE PEOPLE SITTING AT
HOME WITHOUT SERVICES NOT
GETTING YOU KNOW NOT LIVING
FULFILLING LIVES THAT'S THAT'S
NOT WHO WE ARE AS CALIFORNIA
THAT'S NOT WHAT WE SHOULD ASPIRE
TO BE. AND WE WOULD LIKE YOUR
SUPPORT IN MAKING SURE THAT
THAT'S NOT WHO WE. THINK IS.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK ABOUT A SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT
ISSUE ARM AND FOR YOUR ONGOING
INTEREST AND COMMITMENT TO THE
ISSUES FACED IN THE SYSTEM BOTH
MISTER HOLDEN AND ALL OF THE
MEMBERS OF THE OF THE COMMITTEE.
I WANNA TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
INDIVIDUALS WHO LIVE IN VERY
RESTRICTIVE SETTINGS OR WHO ARE
LIKELY TO GO TO THOSE SETTINGS
AND THESE ARE THE INDIVIDUALS
WHO ARE MOST LIKE THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO PREVIOUSLY LIVED
IN STATE DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS
THEY HAVE. VERY INTENSIVE
BEHAVIORAL CHALLENGES.
AND BECAUSE IN TWO THOUSAND AND
EIGHT WE IMPOSED A MEDIAN RATE
FREEZE IT IS INCREASINGLY
DIFFICULT FOR INDIVIDUALS TO
MOVE FROM THESE VERY RESTRICTIVE
SETTINGS OR IF THEY NEED A
DIFFERENT KIND OF PLACEMENT
BECAUSE OF A BEHAVIORAL
CHALLENGE THEY'RE EXPERIENCING.
TO FIND AN APPROPRIATE PLACE FOR
THEM AND SO WHAT WE'RE
SUGGESTING IS BOTH WISE IN TERMS
OF POLICY AND FISCALLY SOUND.
AND BAD IS THAT FOR INDIVIDUALS
IN THESE VERY RESTRICTIVE
SETTINGS MOON MANY OF WHICH ARE
CALLED INSTITUTIONS FOR MENTAL
DISEASE THEIR LARGE WALK SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES THIRDS TO
THAT SERVE INDIVIDUALS ON IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA FOR EXAMPLE.
THOSE THOSE FACILITIES DON'T
GET ANY FEDERAL DOLLARS
IT'S A REQUIREMENT BY FEDERAL
LAW THAT IF YOU LIVE IN AND AM I
AM DE THAT YOU'RE NOT ELIGIBLE
FOR FEDERAL FINANCIAL
PARTICIPATION SO WE ARE PAYING
SLOW SOLELY WITH. STATE GENERAL
FUND MONEY OF THE COST OF THAT
INDIVIDUALS CARE WHICH IS VERY
EXPENSIVE FOR THAT INDIVIDUAL.
AND THAT'S BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE
BUT EFFECTIVE MECHANISM TO HELP
PEOPLE LEAVE THOSE SETTINGS OR
PREVENT THEIR
INSTITUTIONALIZATION THEIR AND
OUR SOLUTIONS ARE. FIRST THAT WE
RESTORE TO THE REGIONAL CENTERS
FOR THE SMALL GROUP OF PEOPLE
THE ABILITY TO NEGOTIATE RATES
BETTER BE ON THE MEDIAN RATE
BECAUSE THESE ARE INDIVIDUALS IN
CRISIS AND NEED A PLACE TO GO.
AND THEN WHEN THEY'RE CRISIS IS
RESOLVED A PLACE TO MOVE INTO.
AND SECOND THAT WE FIX THE FROM
OUR PERSPECTIVE BROKEN HEALTH
AND SAFETY WAIVER PROCESS WHICH
IS A VERY LONG PROCESS AND II
DON'T SAY THAT TO BE CRITICAL OF
THE DEPARTMENT I THINK THEY'RE
ACTUALLY SERVE TRYING TO WORK
THROUGH THE. BILL BACKLOG OF
REQUESTS FOR HEALTH AND SAFETY
WAIVERS FOR YOU AS BEST THEY CAN
BUT WHAT WE KNOW IS THAT IT
TAKES A HUNDRED AND FIFTY SIX
DAYS ON AVERAGE WHEN YOU TALK
ABOUT PENDING AS WELL AS THE NEW
REQUEST THAT ARE COMING IN. TO
PROCESS A HEALTH AND SAFETY
WAIVER. IF YOU'RE IN CRISIS AND
YOU NEED A PLACE TO GO THAT'S
THAT'S A BIT TOO LONG TO WAIT
BECAUSE YOU'RE NOT GETTING THE
SERVICES YOU NEED. SO.
FIRST OF ALL FOR INDIVIDUALS
CENTER IN THE MOST RESTRICTIVE
SETTINGS ARE IN DANGER OF GOING
THERE NICK LET THE DEPTH FLAT
THE REGIONAL CENTERS DO WHAT WE
THINK THEY'RE CAPABLE OF DOING
NEGOTIATED DIFFERENT RATE FOR
THAT INDIVIDUAL. AND FOR OTHER
INDIVIDUALS WHO NEEDS HELP
HEALTH AND SAFETY WAIVERS
PROVIDE A MORE TRANSPARENT AND
FAIR PROCESS WITH SPECIFIC TIME
LINES BY WHICH THE REGIONAL
CENTER WILL. WILL ACT ARM AND
RESOLVE.
BUT THE NEED FOR THAT SERVICE
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NEXT WE'LL HEAR FROM DIRECTOR
BARGMANN.
I THANK YOU.
.
SO HAS YOU CAN SEE OUR SYSTEM IS
EXTREMELY COMPLEX AND.
CERTAINLY OUR OUR COMMUNITY IS
STATES SUCH AN ELOQUENT JOB AND
OUT OUTLINING IMPORTANT ISSUES
AND AND THE THINGS THAT WE
CONTINUE TO HAVE DISCUSSIONS ON
ON A VERY FREQUENT BASIS SO. I'M
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ADDRESS A COUPLE OF THE ITEMS
THAT ARE OUTLINED IN ON THE
OBJECTIVE TODAY AND HAS
CERTAINLY BEEN DISCUSSED ON
THROUGH THE DISCUSSIONS THAT YOU
JUST HAD.
SO SPECIFICALLY REGARDING THE
THE RATE STUDY ON JUST
TO GIVE A LITTLE BIT OF
BACKGROUND INFORMATION ON IT.
THAT.
AB EX TWO ONE REQUIRE THE
DEPARTMENT TO SUBMIT A RATE
STUDY ON THAT WOULD BE AS IT WAS
STATED.
RELEASED IN MARCH OF TWENTY
NINETEEN.
WE DO HAVE A CONTRACT WITH
BURNS AND ASSOCIATE.
THEY'VE BEEN VERY ENGAGED IN
WORKING WITH THE STAKEHOLDER
COMMUNITY TO LISTEN TO THE
CONCERNS TO MAKE SURE THAT IT'S
ARE DEVELOPING. ON THE SURVEY
THAT THE SERVICE PROVIDERS NEED
TO COMPLETE THAT IT'S
CONSIDERING THE IMPORTANT
ELEMENTS THAT THAT IS GOING TO
HELPINFORM THAT TRAIT STUDY
PROCESS.
WE LIVE ESTABLISHED.
AS A SUB WORKGROUP FROM THE DS
TASK FORCE ON TO BE THE CENTRAL
POINT TO WORK DIRECTLY WITH
BURNS AND ASSOCIATE. IN ADDITION
TO THE NUMBER OF STAKEHOLDER
MEETINGS THAT HAVE BEEN THERE
AND CERTAINLY THE DISCUSSIONS
THAT. THAT HAVE BEEN.
IDENTIFIED PART TODAY AS WELL
AS MY DOES ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSIONS HAVE BEEN VERY
INFORMATIVE. TO OUR CONTRACTOR
IN THAT PROCESS.
ON THE OTHER AREA THAT IS LISTED
ON THE AGENDA THAT.
WANT TO SPEAK TO DO WHICH WAS
JUST SHARED AS FAR AS A QUICK
KIND OF THE COMPLEXITIES BUT
ALSO.
THE BARRIERS RELATED TO OUR
HEALTH AND SAFETY PROCESS SO
BACK AND.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT WHEN.
THERE'S A RESPONSE TO LOOKING
AT THE ECONOMIC CRISIS YOU KNOW
LOOKIG AT HOW WE CAN ADDRESS
SOME OF THOSE AREAS MANY OF THE
INITIATIVES. DIFFICULT DECISIONS
WERE MADE ONE OF THE AREAS WAS A
RATE FREEZE.
AS PART OF THAT PROCESS TO TAKE
A LOOK AT WITH THE.
RATE FREEZE COULD ABOUT
COINCIDING LOOK AT HOW TO IS
THERE GOING TO BE.
A SAFETY NET OR A RELIEF VALVE
IF IN THE EVENT OF CONSUMER
SAFETY IS IN QUESTION SO THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY PROCESS WAS
ESTABLISHED IN ALLOWED.
THE DEPARTMENT AUTHORITY TO BE
ABLE TO ADJUST THEIR RATES IN
RESPONSE TO HAVE ASSURANCE OF
MEETING THE HEALTH AND SAFETY
NEEDS OF INDIVIDUALS. SO
CERTAINLY OVER TIME THAT PROCESS
THAT WE'VE GONE THROUGH AS
YOU'VE YOU'VE HEARD AND THAT.
REQUIRED US THROUGH LAST YEAR
IS TO ESTABLISH A WORK GROUP. TO
IDENTIFY WITH THE STAKEHOLDERS
WHAT THE BARRIERS THAT THEY'RE
IDENTIFYING TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
STARTED DRESSING ON THE. THE
LIST OF THE HEALTH AND SAFETY
ITEMS THE REQUEST THAT HAVE COME
IN.
AND WE DO HAVE A BACKLOG AND IT
HAS TAKEN TIME FOR US TO KIND OF
WORK THROUGH THEM. THE WORKGROUP
WAS VERY HELPFUL IN IDENTIFYING
WAYS THAT WE CAN START
ADDRESSING AT SOME OF THE AREAS
A MUCH CERTAINLY THE CRITICAL
AREAS
AND WE DID WHAT THEY INDIVIDUALS
MOVING FROM DEVELOPMENTAL
CENTERS WE PRIORITIZED. ON LAST
YEAR AND WE HAD OPPORTUNITIES TO
BE ABLE TO DO PROVISIONAL
APPROVALS ON IN THE EVENT THAT
WE NEEDED ADDITIONAL INFORMATION
BUT THE SAME TIME NOT TO DELAY
THAT PROCESS WHERE EXTREMELY
OPEN TO BROADENING THAT.
OPPORTUNITY TO PRIORITIZE FOR
INDIVIDUALS IN.
RESTRICTIVE SETTINGS THAT ARE
AT RISK OF GOING TOO RESTRICTIVE
SETTINGS AND WORKING WITH THE
REGIONAL CENTERS TO EXPEDITE
THOSE REVIEWS.
ADDITIONALLY STREAMLINING THE
PROCESS OF MAKING SURE THAT WE
ARE WORKING WELL IN
COMMUNICATING WHAT IS THAT. AYE
AREAS THAT WE NEED TO HAVE TO
INFORM US FOR THOSE APPROVALS SO
WE CAN ALSO EXPEDITE.
THE OTHER AREA THAT WE DID AT
THE DEPARTMENT AS THAT WERE
REVIEWING WITH THE EXECUTIVE
TEAM EARLIER SO WE CAN BE ENGAGE
IN THE PROCESS TO SAY OKAY WE DO
NEED TO IDENTIFY THE VERY
SPECIFIC ITEMS SO WE CAN. MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE NOT GETTING
STUCK IN SOME OF THE. BACK AND
FORTH DISCUSSIONS SO WE CAN.
I CAN HELP.
JOHN DOYLE THE CHIEF DEPUTY CAN
HELP WE CAN HELP KIND OF MOVE
FORWARD WITH SOME OF THE THE
BACKLOG MOVE THINGS.
AND IT.
IN A WAY THAT IS A TURN AROUND
THAT IS GOING TO MEET THE NEEDS
OF THE INDIVIDUALS WHILE NOT
PERFECT IT CERTAINLY IS AN AREA
THAT IS A PRIORITY FOR US TO BE
ABLE TO CONTINUE TO FOCUS ON.
UNDERSTANDING THE THE URGENT
NEEDS WITH SOME OF THE
INDIVIDUALS THAT WERE SERVING.
NIKITA ACTOR NEXT DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE MALAYO INCOMES.
SONYA PARTICULARLY OWE A LOT OF
IMPORTANT ISSUES OBVIOUSLY WE'RE
JUST AB BROUGHT UP.
BUT WE WANT TO FOCUS ON JUST
ONE OF THE ISSUES WHICH MISTER.
WINS HE DID A GOOD JOB OF LAYING
OUT WHICH IS THEM THIS ISSUE
THAT AT THE WAY STATUE IS
CURRENTLY IMPLEMENTED DOES NOT
ALLOW VENDORS WHO ARE IN AREAS
WITH LOCAL MINIMUM WAGES THAT
CURRENTLY EXCEEDS THE STATE
MINIMUM WAGE. Q. ACCESS A RATE.
INCREASES.
THAT ARE PROVIDED.
WHEN THE STATE MINIMUM WAGE GOES
UP SO JUST TO TAKE AN EXAMPLE
THE VENDOR IN SAN FRANCISCO.
WHERE THERE'S BEEN A LOCAL
MINIMUM WAGE THAT'S HIGHER THAN
THE STATE MINIMUM WAGE SINCE
TWENTY FOURTEEN?
A VENDOR THERE MAY NOT HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO ACCESS ANY OF THE
RATE INCREASES ASSOCIATED WITH
THE STATE. MINIMUM WAGE
INCREASES WHICH OCCURRED FOUR
TIMES.
SINCE THEN. SO WE HAVE.
WE WOULD JUST RECOMMENDED THAT
IF.
THAT THE LEGISLATURE CLARIFY ITS
INTENT DID INTEND FOR ALL
VENDORS ACROSS THE STATE TO BE
ABLE TO ACCESS THOSE RATE
INCREASES AND IF THAT WAS THE
INTENT THEN TO.
A POTENTIALLY CLEAN UP THE
STATUTE TO.
MAKE IT SO THAT ALL VENDORS CAN
ACCESS.
THANK YOU.
JACOB WHEN DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
WE'RE GOING THE MINIMUM WAGE
ISSUES WERE HAPPY THIS WORK WITH
THEIR STAFF IN THE LA ODA KIND
OF GET OUR ARMS AROUND WHAT THE
PROPOSAL WOULD BE TO DEVELOP
THAT FISCAL ESTIMATE BECAUSE
DEPENDING ON THE WAY THAT THAT.
WOULD BE IMPLEMENTED COULD
REALLY IMPACT OF.
THE FISCAL IMPACT ON THE ROAD.
IF YOU.
NEXT WE'LL HAVE PUBLIC COMMENT
ON ISSUE FOR.
MY NAME IS DENNIS DEGREE.
I WORK FOR THE SANDRA FREEDOM OF
MOVEMENT. ALL THROUGHOUT.
BOARD MEMBER OF.
TASH.
EL I WOULD BE UNDER.
TO.
HELP A FILM HOLDER.
HOPE WOOD HUMAN.
MY NAME IS.
STICK ME I'M MY.
DANIEL'S MIGHT.
THE FACT MATTER IS THAT WITHIN
THE BAY AREA AND OTHER HIGH
LIVING CENTERS.
ONE CANNOT FIND AVENGERS TO TO
ASSIST.
A LANTERN MAX BEEN SET UP YET
THE FUNDING HAS NOT BEEN PUT IN
PLACE FOR REGIONAL CENTERS TO BE
SUCCESSFUL IN HELPING THE
POPULATION THAT THEY ARE
INTENDED TO SERVE.
WE CAN SPEAK FIRST HAND IN WHICH
WE HAD SET UP FOR AN APARTMENT
VENDORS AND THEN AND THEN THAT
THE PEOPLE THAT WERE ASSIGNED TO
US IN THE SIMPLEST WEEK WE
CANNOT WE CAN'T. AFFORD TO LIVE
HERE ON THAT AMOUNT.
THE TWENTY FIVE MILLION IS
ALLOWING FOR FOR THE WAGES TO BE
AT MINIMUM WAGE
YET. MANY PEOPLE WITHIN THE
CAPITAL WOULDN'T WORK FOR
MINIMUM WAGE NOR SHOULD DAY AND
I FEEL LIKE MANY WHO WORK IN THE
HEALTH CARE INDUSTRY ARE BEING
PENALIZED FOR THAT. AND I THINK
THAT THERE IS.
RESTRICTIONS BEING PLACED ON
THE REGIONAL CENTERS ON THE
MEDIAN CAP FOR EXAMPLE THE
ABILITY NOT TO NEGOTIATE WITH IN
DIFFERENT GEOGRAPHICAL AREAS
WHERE THERE'S A HIGHER COST OF
LIVING. IN ORDER FOR FOR THE
WAYNE SHERMAN ACT BE SUCCESSFUL
ADEQUATE FUNDING ON.
I THINK IT WAS THERE WAS A OR
OTHER CALIFORNIA DISABILITY
SERVICE SOCIALIZATION
RECOMMENDED A HUNDRED AND THIRTY
MILLION. AND AND THAT IS A SMALL
STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION IN
ORDER TO HAVE CARE GIVERS WHO
WHO CAN LIVE WITHIN THE BAY AREA
OR SAN DIEGO OR LA. A IN ORDER
TO TAKE CARE OF OF OF THE MOST
VULNERABLE POPULATION. WE WE
HAVE THE FUNDING AND WE
CERTAINLY ARE TAXED FOR IT ON
YET WE'RE NOT TAKING THAT
FUNDING AND HELPING THOSE THAT
NEED IT THE MOST.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
CONSIDERATION
THANK YOU.
STEVE MILLER REPRESENTING THE
LOS ANGELES COALITION OF SERVICE
PROVIDERS BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY
REPRESENTING.
MY SELF WHO WORKED.
FOR IN WITH PEOPLE WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES FOR
SINCE NINETEEN SEVENTY.
EARLY SEVENTY NINETEEN SEVENTY
EIGHT.
.
I THINK THERE ARE SOME QUESTIONS
THAT THAT NEED TO BE ARE
ADDRESSED TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IN THE DEPARTMENT
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES.
THAT HAVE TO DO WITH COMMON.
SENSE AND LOGIC.
IS IT.
IS THAT THEIR POSITION THAT AN
ORGANIZATION SERVING PEOPLE IN
SAN FRANCISCO. OR SERVING PEOPLE
AYE IN.
PASADENA.
CAN FUNCTION WITH THE SAME
REIMBURSEMENTS AS A PROGRAM
SERVING PEOPLE AND TO LAURIE.
OR A A A A MUCH MORE.
MODERATE COST OF LIVING AREA.
CAN THE SAME DOLLARS
DELIVER
THE SAME SERVICES.
IT'S AN INCONVENIENT TRUTH.
BUT IT IS STILL A TRUTH THAT IT
COSTS A LOT OF MONEY. TO LIVE IN
TO DELIVER SERVICES IN AIR IN
HIGH COST AREAS.
IS THERE ANY IS THERE ANY LOGIC
THAT CAN BE PRESENTED THAT SAYS
THAT IT DOESN'T COST MORE.
I'D LOVE TO KNOW THE ANSWER TO.
MOSTLY I AM HERE BECAUSE NOW
I'M.
I DID A LEADING ORGANIZATION
THAT SERVES A MANY PEOPLE
THROUGHOUT THE LOS ANGELES AND
PASADENA AREA FOR IT FOR MANY
MANY YEARS.
AND I STILL HAVE IN MY HEAD.
THE CONVERSATION WAS A
CONVERSATION.
THE PLAINTIVE CRIES
AND YELLING. AS I WAS TELLING
OFF ARE A FATHER WHO CALLED ME
WHEN I HAD TO LET HIM KNOW THAT
WE WERE CLOSING A PROGRAM. THAT
DID SERVE PEOPLE WITH VERY
SIGNIFICANT MENTAL HEALTH.
AND BEHAVIORAL ISSUES.
AND WE COULD NO LONGER HIRE
STAFF THAT HAD ANY
QUALIFICATIONS
TO SERVE PEOPLE WITH THOSE LEVEL
OF DISABILITIES.
SO I HAD TO CALL.
AND EXPLAINED THAT THE SERVICES
WERE ENDING IN TWO WEEKS.
AND I HEAR.
SOMEWHERE ELSE IN THE ROOM.
THE WIFE.
YELLING AT HER HUSBAND WHAT ARE
WE GONNA TO TELL HIM WHERE WE
GONNA DO.
AND HE'S ON THE PHONE
THREATENING TO.
SUMI.
DEMANDING.
THE ONLY THING THAT ANY OF THE
ORGANIZATIONS GET IN BUSINESS TO
DO IS TO SERVE.
WE JUST NEED THE RESOURCES TO
SERVE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER HOLDEN'S REQUEST
FOR TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
IS NOTHING MORE THAN A VERY VERY
SMALL TRANSFUSION.
KEEP PROVIDERS
ALIVE AND FUNCTIONING.
AND OUT LAST THING I'LL SAY IS
THIS WILL NOT BE THE FIRST BLACK
COST STUDY THIS WILL NOT BE THE
FIRST RATE STUDY.
THAT THE DEPARTMENTS UNDERTAKEN
IN THE LAST THIRTY YEARS.
AND I'M OLD ENOUGH TO HAVE BEEN
PART OF THE OTHER TWO.
THERE IS ABSOLUTELY NO
GUARANTEE.
FIRST OF ALL WHAT THE ECONOMIC
CONDITION OF CALIFORNIA'S GOING
TO BE IN TWO OR THREE YEARS.
OR WHAT THE DECISION WILL BE
ABOUT HOW MUCH OF WHATEVER THE
RATE STUDY PROVIDES.
WILL BE FUNDED.
BUT WE'LL SEE IF WE CAN GETS
KICKED DOWN THE ROAD AGAIN.
IN THE MEANWHILE.
PEOPLE EVERY DAY NEED SERVICES.
THIS IS A VERY MODEST AMOUNT OF
MONEY THAT IS GONNA MAKE A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF DIFFERENCE
IN THE LIVES OF THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE. AND I AND I STRONGLY
URGE YOU.
TO CONSIDER THE INCONVENIENT
TRUTH THAT WERE ASKING THIS
ADMINISTRATION FOR A LITTLE BIT
MORE MONEY THAT IS DESPERATELY
NEEDED.
THANK YOU
THANK YOU SIR.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON KELLY WHITE
WITH VILLAESPERANZA SERVICES
ARE SERVING ABOUT SIX HUNDRED
FIFTY INDIVIDUALS WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES AND
THAT BOTH LOS ANGELES COUNTY AND
VENTURA COUNTIES.
OF PRIMARILY OUR MAIN OFFICE IS
IN PASADENA WHICH IS.
BEING HIT WITH XCELERATED A
STATE LOCAL MINIMUM WAGE
ORDINANCE.
THAT IS COSTS IN OUR AGENCY ON
AFFECTED JULY FIRST ABOUT SEVEN
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS SOME
REALLY SERIOUS DECISIONS HAVE TO
BE MADE. WERE NOT THE ONLY
ORGANIZATION THAT'S NEED TO LOOK
AT THIS.
IT'S BEEN VERY DIFFICULT TO
RECRUIT A INDIVIDUALS IT'S BEEN
TO SAID BEFORE HERE THAT. ARE
INDIVIDUALS THAT WE SERVE WITH
THEM TO RATE REIMBURSEMENT WE
RECEIVE CAN GO WORK AT TARGET
THEY'RE NOT TAKING CARE SIX
INDIVIDUALS. MEDICATING HELPING
WITH THEIR DAILY LIVING SKILLS
FEE HELPING FEED THEM SIX PEOPLE
IN A GROUP HOME.
AND AND NOT AND MAKING. LESS
MONEY THAN SOMEBODY WORKING AT
TARGET YOU HAVE TO BE A VERY
VERY HUMBLE PERSON.
WHICH WE JUST CANNOT SUSTAIN AT
THE SYSTEM CANNOT SUSTAIN IT
SERVICE PROVIDERS ARE CLOSING
THEIR DOORS.
AND SO PLEASE PLEASE CONSIDER
NAM HOW IMPORTANT THIS BRIDGE A
GAP.
THAT FINN ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOME
HAS BEEN GRACIOUSLY. OF STEP
FORWARD AND POSING ABOUT WHAT'S
DISPLAY NEEDED WE NEED WE NEED
THE TWENTY FIVE NINE. TO GET TO
EVEN TO THE RATE STUDY AND AND
BEYOND THAT SO THE SYSTEM IS
THAT ON A BRINK
TOM THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MA'AM.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS KEVIN
RATHBUN FROM A MINUS WE SERVE
FOURTEEN HUNDRED UP WITHOUT
MENTAL DISABILITIES IN SAN
FRANCISCO EAST BAY. I'M ALSO
WITH THAT CALIFORNIA'S
DISSOCIATION AND WITH THE
CALIFORNIA'S PUT LIVING NETWORK.
AND AND DO ON.
TO HOLDEN'S.
GREAT EFFORTS.
WE'VE GOT TO HAVE THAT BUT I
WANT TO SPEAK ON THE RATE STUDY.
.
IN ORDER. TO ACHIEVE THE RATE
SETTING GOALS.
MANDATE IN AB EX TO DOESN'T.
OF CONSUMER CHOICE AND QUALITY
OUTCOMES.
STUDY MUCH USE MARKETPLACE COST
TO CALCULATE SERVICE PROVIDER
RATES.
BELOW THE LOCAL COSTS OF LABOR
AND BUSINESS RESOURCES
ARE THE ONLY VALID BENCHMARK FOR
CREATING RATES.
THE LOCAL MARKET CONDITIONS.
DICTATE HOW MUCH IT COSTS TO
DELIVER SERVICES.
WHEN RATES ARE SET USING LOCAL
MARKET COSTS AS THE BENCHMARK.
THERE WILL BE AN ADEQUATE NUMBER
OF SERVICE PROVIDERS BECAUSE
THEY WILL BE ABLE TO PAY FOR
THEIR EXPENSES.
SERVICE PROVIDERS.
COMPETE WILL COMPETE FOR
CLIENTS.
CREATING A QUALITY COMPETITION
IT DELIVERS QUALITY SERVICES.
WHEN AGENCIES COMPETE FOR
CLIENTS THESE CLIENTS HAVE
CHOICE.
I WILL CHOOSE THE VENDOR THAT
BEST SUITS THEIR NEEDS.
CALIFORNIA'S PUT LIVING NETWORK.
IT'S CREATED FIFTEEN PRINCIPLES
THAT CONSTITUTE A MARKET RATE
MODEL.
SETTING.
A HOME AND COMMUNITY BASED
SERVICE RATES.
THESE PRINCIPLES SHOW HOW TO
TAKE MARKET BECAUSE RATES IN
CONCERT AND CALCULATE VENDOR
RATES FOR DIFFERENT SERVICE
TYPES.
ESPECIALLY HOME BASED COMMUNITY
SERVICE.
WE WILL BE SHARING THESE
PRINCIPLES.
WITH YOUR COMMITTEE AND OTHER
STATE LEGISLATORS.
BUT THE MARKET LATE MODEL.
NEEDS MARKET DATA.
WE'RE DISAPPOINTED WITH BURNS
AND ASSOCIATES
THE VENDOR CONTRACTED TO PERFORM
THE RATE STUDY.
WHICH HAS PUBLICLY STATED THAT
THEY ARE NOT GOING TO COLLECT
MARKET DATA FOR THEIR STUDY.
WHILE WE.
ARE ENCOURAGED THAT BURNS AND
ASSOCIATES HAS AGREED TO ACCEPT
MARKET DATA FROM VENDORS.
WE DON'T KNOW WHY THEY ARE
PERFORMING THIS RICHARD RESEARCH
THEMSELVES.
UNLESS BURNS AND ASSOCIATES USES
LOCAL MARKET DATA THROUGHOUT THE
STATE.
WE ARE FORCED
TO CONCLUDE THAT THEIR WHICH
STUDY. WILL BE DIVORCED FROM THE
MARKETPLACE REALITIES
SERVICE PROVIDERS FACE EVERY DAY
AS THEY STRUGGLE TO SUPPORT
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES AT THE
CURRENT. BELOW MARKET PROVIDER
RATES.
WE ALSO MUST RELUCTANTLY
CONCLUDE.
THAT THE RATE STUDY.
IT'S CURRENTLY DESIGN.
WILL NOT MEET THE MANDATED
GOALS.
OF CONSUMER CHOICE.
AND QUALITY SERVICES OUTCOMES
THAT THE STATUTE DEMANDS THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU SIR.
CARLENE HOLDEN REPRESENTING
MISTER SEAL AFFILIATES IN
CALIFORNIA.
I'VE GOT IT GIVE CREDIT FOR
THIS WHOLE TOPIC IN THE WAY IT'S
BEEN HANDLED LITERALLY AS I
HEARD. EACH OF THE.
PRESENTATIONS I CAN IDENTIFY
THAT EVERY SINGLE ONE OF THEM
WAS RIGHT ON. AUG CLEARLY IN THE
LA MARKET WITH THE WITH
DIFFERENT CITIES AT DIFFERENT
LEVELS WE'VE GOT TO HAVE A
UNIFORM PLACE WHICH REGULARLY
PUTS US. ABOVE AND NOT ABLE TO
ACCESS WHAT THE STATE HAS BEEN
DOING THE REIMBURSEMENT ON AUG
BILL WILL FIX OUT PART.
AND.
OF THE FACT THAT IT'S GOING
IT'S BEEN A LONG TIME SINCE I'VE
BEEN RATE INCREASES THAT HELPED
A STABILIZER AT THE LABOR FORCE.
I THINK THE INTERMOUNTAIN BEING
REQUESTED ON THE FOUR PERCENT IS
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT ON THERE'S NO
QUESTION THAT MANY PLACES THERE
WAITING LISTS BECAUSE PEOPLE
WILL NOT APPLY FOR THE JOB.
SO CLEARLY IS AN ENTITLEMENT
PROGRAM WE ARE HAVING A RUBBER
MEETS THE ROAD ON THE FRONT
LINES IF WE CAN'T GET PEOPLE WHO
WILL COME AND APPLY FOR THE JOB
WE CAN'T. A START IN A
REASONABLE TIME SOMEBODY WHO
NEEDS TO SERVICE.
UP CLEARLY.
IT'S NOT UNUSUAL FOR ME TO HAVE
SOMEONE WHO'S BEEN THERE. AND
THEN I AM OUR FACILITY.
HEART WRENCHING STORIES SO ALL I
CAN DO IS VERIFIABLY TESTIMONY
THAT YOU'VE HEARD AND URGE YOUR
SUPPORT.
JAMIE DAVIS EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
MARIN VENTURES AND CENTER FILE.
A WE'RE ALSO MEMBER OF CDSA AND
ON WE DO SUPPORT THE FOUR
PERCENT INCREASE REQUEST.
ONE OF THE THINGS I LIKE A LOT
ABOUT LIVING IN CALIFORNIA
NATIVE HOOSIER HERE A.
IS THE COMPASSION SHOWN FOR THE
PEOPLE WHO LIVE HERE. AND THAT'S
EVIDENCED IN THE NEWS.
WITH THE NEW LAWS PROTECTING
IMMIGRANTS
WHO. MAY OR MAY NOT.
HAVE COME THROUGH THE
APPROPRIATE CHANNELS TO OUR
STATE.
OF ABOUT EIGHTY PERCENT OF MY
STAFFER IMMIGRANTS. I WAS JUST
ON A VERY EXPENSIVE PHONE CALL.
WITH GETTING LEGAL ADVICE ABOUT
HOW DO I PROTECT MY EMPLOYEES.
IN THE EVENT OF AN AYE NINE
AUDIT FOR EXAMPLE.
THESE THE KIND OF COSTS THAT WE
DIDN'T GET COVERED IN THE WAGE
AND BENEFIT PASSED THROUGH THAT
MY STAFF DID APPRECIATE.
BUT UP FOUR POINT FOUR TWO
PERCENT ADMIN WHICH WAS ELEVEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS.
AND I CHOSE TO GIVE RAISES TO MY
ADMIN STAFF.
THERE A LOT OF OTHER COST
PRESSURES.
VETERAN ACTED EVERY YEAR. THAT
WE CAN'T MEET.
OR WE MEET THEM HALFWAY.
OR.
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT WE DO IT
ALL THE WAY.
YOU KNOW WE'RE ALWAYS JUGGLING
THE PRIORITIES FOR. THE
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDED TO SUPPORT
OUR CLIENTS
THERE'S A BIG PUSH FOR COMMUNITY
INTEGRATION.
GUESS WHAT MOST OF OUR CLIENTS
ARE IMPOVERISHED IF COMPACT
COMPLEX NEEDS.
THEY'RE USE WHEELCHAIRS MOBILITY
DEVICES.
THEIR ELDERLY.
WHO PAYS FOR THEM TO GO TO THE
GYMIN MILL VALLEY SEVEN DOLLARS
A POP?
WHEN VENTURES.
THROUGH FUND RAISING.
WHO PAYS FOR THEM TO GO
SWIMMING?
MORE ADVENTURES.
THAT COST MONEY IT COST MONEY TO
FUND RAISER COST MONEY TO PAY
THE STAFF IT COST MONEY TO FIND
THE PLACES TO GO.
SO ALL OF THESE PRESSURES.
MAKE IT VERY HARD FOR PROGRAMS
HAVE QUALITY AND THAT'S WHAT
REALLY NEED FOR THESE PEOPLE
I'VE DONE THIS WORK THIRTY
YEARS.
I LOVE THE PEOPLE. AND THAT'S
WHY I'M HERE.
STARTED OUT FIVE BUCKS AN HOUR
IN AN ICF.
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY SEVEN.
SO I KNOW WHAT IT'S LIKE TO BE
AT A DIRECTOR STAFF.
I KNOW WHAT'S LIKE TO BE MIDDLE
MANAGER I KNOW WHAT IT'S LIKE TO
BE A LEADER.
AND. IT'S HARD ALL THE WAY
AROUND WHEN YOU DON'T GET ENOUGH
TO SUPPORT A PROGRAM.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY.
.
I'M CONFLICTED DO I SPEAK IS
APPARENT OR PROVIDER BECAUSE I
WEAR BOTH HATS SO I'M.
I LIKE TO SPEAK AS A PARENT
FIRST AND MY NAME'S MICHELLE HI
I HAVE A SEVENTEEN YEAR OLD WHO
WAS DIAGNOSED WITH AUTISM WHEN
HE WAS TWO IT BECAME A CLIENT
OF.
THE REGIONAL CENTER AT THAT TIME
I HAD NO IDEA WHAT THE REGIONAL
CENTER EVEN WISE THANK GOODNESS
FOR THE SERVICES. AND SUPPORTS
THAT HE RECEIVED AND THIS TWENTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS THAT I AM
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOLDEN HAS
REALLY CHAMPION FOR OUR
COMMUNITY IS JUST SEVERELY
NEEDED TO MAINTAIN THE QUALITY
OF THE SERVICES. THAT ARE
NECESSARY FOR PEOPLE TO LIVE
QUALITY LIVES IN THEIR COMMUNITY
ALONGSIDE THEIR PEERS WITH THEIR
FAMILY AND ENJOYING ALL THE SAME
BENEFITS THAT YOU AND I. I
RECEIVE AS A PROVIDER ONE OF THE
ON THINGS THAT I'D LIKE TO SPEAK
TO IS THE MEDIAN RATES. MEDIAN
RATES REALLY HAVE PREVENTED A
NEW PROVIDERS FROM ENTERING INTO
AND THE NETWORK OF PROVIDERS
BECAUSE IN SOME. AND SPACES THE
MEDIAN RATES ARE LOWER THAN WITH
THE TRADITIONAL RATES THAT WERE
NEGOTIATED AND THEN PROVIDERS
ARE NOT GOING TO BE ABLE TO OPEN
THEIR DOORS BECAUSE THEIR
COMPETITORS ARE MAKING. A LOT
MORE PER HOUR THAN WHAT THEY
WOULD BE MAKING UNDER THE MEDIAN
RATES AND I AM A MEDIAN RATE
PROVIDER AND THE STRUGGLES.
ARE REAL WEEK I HAVE TO LIMIT
THE AMOUNT OF REGIONAL CENTER
CLIENTS THAT I TAKE BECAUSE THAT
RATE IS SUBSTANTIALLY LOWER THAN
THE MARKET RATE FOR THE SERVICE.
AND THAT I PROVIDE SO I JUST
WANT TO THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER HOLDING THANK YOU FOR THE
TIME AND I AM I HOPE THAT WE CAN
WORK ON.
INCREASING THE RATES FOR
REGIONAL CENTER PROVIDERS THANK
YOU THANK YOU MA'AM.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS CARL LONDON I'M HAPPY
LAND SUPPORTING PEOPLE WITH THE
IT. INTELLECTUAL DEVELOPMENT
DISABILITIES.
TRY TO BE BRIEF I I WANNA START
JUST BY PRAISING THE STAFF
FORMATS THEY SOME IMAGE IN THE
EARLY IS. REALLY INTERESTING WAY
PERCENT THE FACTS FROM TODAY AND
LET PEOPLE TALK ON THIS REVENUE
HAVING JUST TRADITIONAL.
DEPARTMENT SAYS THE CENTER BY
RESPONSE TO THANK YOU FOR THAT A
PROCEED VIA THE WAY IT WAS
PRESENTED AND ALSO YOU GUYS FOR
HANGING IN HERE AND. LISTENING
TO THE STUFF IS IT'S A LOT OF
WORK ON YOUR BEHALF SO. IT'S
GREATLY APPRECIATED I DON'T
EXPRESS.
SUPPORT FOR MR HOLDS PROPOSAL
THANK HIM FOR PROVIDING.
LEADERSHIP HEHAS ON THIS FOR
REAL IN THE PAST COUPLE YEARS
THAT'S VERY. CRITICAL IMPORTANT
WHERE MEMBERS AND SECONDLY ONE
EXPRESS.
STRONG SUPPORT FOR THE PROPOSAL
THAT MR GIARDINI OUTLINED WE
HAVE TO HAVE SOME KIND OF BRIDGE
RATE INCREASE IN BETWEEN NOW AND
WHEN THE STREET STUDY COMES OUT.
ARE WITH THE RATES DAY'S GONNA
SAY. BUT IF IT'S HONEST
INTELLECTUALLY IT'S GOING TO SAY
THAT WE'RE NOT PAYING ENOUGH FOR
THE SERVICES THAT WE'RE TRYING
TO PROVIDE. OR IT'S GOING TO SAY
MAYBE WE SHOULD BE PROVIDING
CERTAIN THINGS ANYMORE AND
THEREFORE ONLY PAY FOR THESE
THINGS AND THIS IS HOW MUCH THE
COST. WHO KNOWS BUT UNTIL THEN
YOU HAVE A PROBLEM BECAUSE YOU
OF OVER THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
PEOPLE STATEWIDE?
MANY OF WHOM BY THE WAY AREN'T
EVEN ASKING FOR SERVICES WE
DON'T EVEN TALK ABOUT THE
SAVINGS. IN THIS SYSTEM FROM THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO SIMPLY
DON'T GET SERVICES.
SO EVERYBODY ELSE THAT IS
GETTING SERVICES
IS AFTER STRUGGLING TO FIND
ANYTHING. OF SOME KIND OF
QUALITY.
GETTING MORE AND MORE DIFFICULT
EVERYDAY THE RATES DON'T MATCH
UP TO THAT THE STAFF THAT WERE
PEEING OUR LOWER LOWER PAID
RELATIVE TO THE COST LIVING
THERE'S NO QUESTION ABOUT THAT.
THAT COST OF LIVING GOES UP
EVERY SINGLE YEAR. IN WITH IT
ANY CHART IN AMERICA IT'LL SHOW
COLA THE COST OF LIVING GOING
UP.
AND THE RATES HERE ARE FROZEN
OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
YOU'RE NOW TALKING ABOUT THE
PROVIDERS THAT ARE ON THE ROPES
OF THE ONES WHO HAVE BEEN AROUND
FOR FIFTY SIXTY FORTY YEARS.
THE BIG ONES THE ONES WHO HAVE
BEEN IN THE COMMUNITY AND EVERY
PERSON WAS GETTING SERVICES. IS
GETTING SERVICES DIRECTED BY AN
IPP PROCESS THROUGH THE SYSTEM
MEAN THAT THE. LEGISLATURE IN
THE PAST TO SET UP TO THE WOMEN.
.
ACT
YOU HAVE BEEN AYE PP IN PLACES
IS EXACTLY WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO
GET. OUT OF THE SERVICE MODEL
AND WE CAN'T PROVIDE THE
SERVICES ANYMORE.
I ALSO JUST WHAT IT'S WORSE THAN
ON OF A BOARD.
OF A LOCAL NONPROFIT YEAR'S
SACRAMENTO I TRY TO PUT MY MONEY
FROM A MOUTH IS BUT BEING
INVOLVED IN THE SYSTEM. IN THAT
MANNER WE JUST SAP TO A BUDGET
PRESENTATION BUYER CFO RECENTLY
AND I CAN TELL YOU IN LOOKING AT
YEAR OVER YEAR OF LAST YEAR TO
THIS YEAR. I WAS STUNNED BECAUSE
I'VE BEEN SITTING ON THIS POOR
FOR NUMBER YEARS. BUT TO WATCH
THE FLIP THE NUMBER OF
CATEGORIES OF SERVICES THAT WE
GET RATES FOR. THAT SUDDENLY YOU
ARE IN THE RED THAT USED TO BE
IN THE BLACK NEARLY EVERY
PROGRAM TYPE THAT WE PROVIDE. IS
IN THE RED BASED ON THE ROAD ON
THE RATES NOW.
THERE'S A COUPLE OF AREAS THAT
ARE FLOATING ARREST ANYONE TO
SEE WITH THE ARE BECAUSE YOU
GUYS MIGHT GRAB. AND DECIDE
WE'RE BEING OVERPAID THOSE AREAS
BUT THAT'S LITERALLY. WHAT'S
HOLDING THE SYSTEM TOGETHER
RIGHT NOW
AND THIS IS AN AGENCY THAT'S
BEEN AROUND FOR SIXTY YEARS LONG
BEFORE I WAS. HERE SIXTY FIVE
YEARS ACTUALLY CREATED BY
PARENTS AND CONCERNED PEOPLE IN
THE COMMUNITY FOR THEIR
CHILDREN.
IT'S BEEN AROUND THAT LONG IN
THAT TWENTY MILLION DOLLAR
AGENCIES STARTING TO LOOK EVEN
ON THE ROPES AND TEETERING AND
AND HAVING TO REFUSE. TO PROVIDE
SERVICES BECAUSE WE CAN'T DO IT
WE CAN'T OF THE STAFF TO
COMMAND.
SO WE WILL NOT BE OFFICIAL
WAITING LIST
BUT WE ARE LITERALLY TELLING THE
REGIONAL CENTER. NO MORE UNTIL
WE GET SOMEBODY TO LEAVE THAT
WILL TAKE SOMEBODY NEW AND
THAT'S THE ONLY WAY WE CAN DO IT
NOW. THAT'S NOT WHAT YOU WANT IN
THE SYSTEM
SO DO THIS RATE INCREASE SHOW
SOME LEADERSHIP DO THIS AS AN
INTERIM STEP SUNSET IT I DON'T
CARE. BUT A SUNSET ON IT.
IN RECOGNITION OF THE FACT THAT
WE'RE GOING EVER RATES STEADY
ACOSTA IT'LL BE DONE BY THEN.
AND WILL LOOK AT IT AGAIN BUT DO
SOME KIND OF INCREASED A WHOLE
THIS THING TOGETHER UNTIL THEN
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HELLO MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
AIRING CARRUTHERS EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE STATE COUNCIL ON
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
RISING IN SUPPORT OF TWO
ADVOCACY PROPOSAL ITEMS THAT ARE
IN THE AGENDA ON THIS ITEM. THE
FIRST IS THE HEALTH AND SAFETY
WAIVER PROCESS THROUGH THE
DEPARTMENT OF THE PROPOSAL IN
THE AGENDA IS TO LIMIT THAT TO
THIRTY DAYS. A SIDE EFFECT OF
THE MINIMUM WAGE QUESTION IS
THAT THIS PROCESS WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT IS THE ONE THAT
BECOMES THE VEHICLE. TO ADDRESS
DIFFERENCES IN LOCAL MINIMUM
WAGE UP BETWEEN THE STATE WHAT
THE STATE PAYS AND WHAT THE
LOCAL ORDINANCES. AT THIS
PROCESS NOT SET UP FOR THIS
PURPOSE BUT IT'S SERVING IT'S
PURPOSE NOW SO AS THE NUMBERS OF
THOSE REQUESTED SKYROCKETED FROM
ZERO FIVE YEARS AGO TO NINETY
EIGHT.
JUST LAST YEAR THE WAIT TIME
FOR PEOPLE HAS INCREASED WERE AT
A FIVE YEAR HIGH IN WAIT TIMES
OF MODERN FIFTY SIX DAYS OF THE
PROPOSALS TO BRING DOWN THE
THIRTY DAYS WE REPRESENT AND
PEOPLE WITH DEVELOP DISABILITIES
THEIR FAMILIES. WHO HAVE FROM
THEIR POINT OF VIEW A TRUE
HEALTH AND SAFETY?
CRISIS THEY NEED A WAIVER FOR IN
THEIR MINDS A MINIMUM WAGE LOCAL
STATE DIFFERENTIAL. IS NOT
WHAT'S ON THEIR MIND AS AS A
CRISIS.
SO PLEASE WE CAN DO TO ADDRESS
THAT.
TIME DIFFERENCE IN THE TIME
DIFFERENCE IS THERE REALLY NO
FAULT THE DEPARTMENTS IT'S JUST
AM WHERE THAT CRUNCH HAS LANDED.
AND THE SECOND ISSUE IS A
DIFFERENT WAIVER IT'S THE SELF
DETERMINATION WAY FROM WHICH IS
THE PROPOSAL FROM. THE STATES TO
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO GET
FLEXIBILITY IN THE SERVICES WE
PROVIDE SO THAT INDIVIDUALS WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES HAVE
CONTROL AND CHOICE OVER THEIR
OWN SERVICES. AND THE BUDGETS
THEY CREATE OF THE STATE COUNCIL
DEVELOPMENT IS ABILITIES AND I
INVITED THE DEPARTMENT TO ONE OF
ITS RECENT STATEWIDE SELF
DETERMINATION VISOR COMMITTEE.
MEETINGS WHERE THEY WERE REALLY
PRETTY FRUSTRATED WITH THE
DEPARTMENT FOR THE LACK OF
PROGRESS AND AND THE DEPARTMENT
RESPONDED NANCY.
DIRECTOR BARGE MEN FOCUSED WITH
HER MANY MANY PRIORITIES ASHY
PULL THIS ONE OUT AND SAID THIS
IS GONNA BE A PRIORITY IN HAS
MADE GREAT PROGRESS IN ADVANCING
THIS TOWARD THE FINISH LINE. IF
GETTING ITS ADMITTED SO THE
COUNCIL APPLAUDS OF THE
DIRECTORS LEADERSHIP I'M IN THIS
IT'S IMMINENTLY BEING ARE GOING
TO THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
KEEP CHECKING MY EMAILS.
HOURLY TO SEEING WHEN THAT WILL
HAPPEN AT ONCE IT DOES THERE
WERE ATTENTIONTURNS TO
IMPLEMENTATION THERE MANY
QUESTIONS A TO BE ANSWERED ARE
NURSING THE DEPARTMENTS WORKING
ON A PLAN. OUR STATE WEITZEL
DETERMINATION VISOR COMMITTEE
MEETS AGAIN NEXT WEEK AND WE ARE
READY TO BE PARTNERS WITH THE
DEPARTMENT IN FIGURE OUT THE
IMPLEMENTATION SALUTE SMITH
ROBERT STEPHENS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SIR.
HI MICHAEL COCKY EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF ALL IN CALIFORNIA.
WE PROVIDE RESIDENTIAL MONDAY
SERVICES AND THE SAN FRANCISCO
BAY AREA LOS ANGELES COUNTY SO
WE HAVE MAYBE A HEIGHTENED
EXPERIENCE OF THE CHALLENGES OF
WORKING WITH. A FIXED MEDIAN
RATES.
THE PEOPLE WE SERVE HAVE VERY
COMPLEX.
SKILLED NURSING NEEDS AND SOME
OF OUR HOMES AND VERY COMPLEX
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH NEEDS AND SOME
OF OUR HOMES.
AND IT KILLS ME THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT ADVOCATING FOR
MINIMUM WAGE FOR PEOPLE WHO AS
HAS BEEN MENTIONED BY OTHERS.
HAVE REALLY SIGNIFICANCE
SKILL SETS TO IT AND
SOPHISTICATION IS TO WORK WITH
OUR RESIDENTS
SIR WE SUPPORT THE TWENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR. ON GAP FUN BUT I
THINK WE CAN DO BETTER.
I THINK YOU KNOW AS SOMEBODY
WHO SPEAKS ON A DAILY BASIS WITH
OUR DIRECTOR STAFF A FOUR
PERCENT INCREASE WOULD BE
MEANINGFUL.
BUT WOULD STILL LEAVE PEOPLE
WITH CHALLENGES.
LIVING AND THE AREAS WHERE WE
PROVIDE SERVICE AND SO I'M HERE
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT AND AND TO
HOPE THAT WE CAN LOOK FORWARD
AND YOU BETTER THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SIR.
HELLO MY NAME IS SANDY JONES ON
THE HUMAN RESOURCES DIRECTOR FOR
STRATEGIES TO EMPOWER PEOPLE
SUPPORTED LIVING AGENCY HERE IN
SACRAMENTO AREA.
I JUST WANNA GIVE YOU A FEW.
THINGS TO THINK ABOUT AS YOU
CONSIDER ALL THE INFORMATION A
VAT.
ALL TO SAY THIS A MONTH IN
WHICH OUR TURNOVER RATE IS ONLY
FORTY FIVE PERCENT IS A GOOD
MONTH.
THE IT'S CRAZY A GOES UPWARDS
OVER FIFTY PERCENT
CAN YOU IMAGINE TRYING TO WORK
ON ANY OF YOUR PROJECTS ARE YOUR
GOALS. AND HALF YOUR STAFF
LEAVE.
AND NOW RATHER THAN BEING ABLE
TO WORK ON YOUR PROJECTS AND
GOALS OR EVEN YOUR DAILY WORK
YOU HAVE TO SPEND YOUR TIME.
FINDING NEW STAFF TRAINING NEW
STAFF GETTING THAT STAFF
EXPERIENCE THAT'S WHAT WE DEAL
WITH ALL THE TIME.
EVERY DAY ALL DAY LONG.
THE OTHER PROBLEM THAT WE HAVE
IS WE CAN'T JUST SAY WELL
MINIMUM WAGES ENOUGH TO HIRE
PEOPLE WE ALSO HAVE TO TRAIN
THEM. WITH THEIR TRAINING AND
THEIR LENGTH OF SERVICE THERE
SHOULD BE REWARD AN INCENTIVE.
THAT WE STRUGGLE TO PROVIDE.
WE ALSO HAVE TO DEAL WITH THE
COMPACTION ISSUE OF THE PEOPLE
THAT DO DECIDE THE STATE FOR
LOWER THAN THEY SHOULD.
THAT THEY MAKE THIS AND NEW
PEOPLE GET THE COMING RIGHT HERE
SO WHERE DO WE GO WITH THAT.
THERE IS NO FUNDING TO GO UP
HIGHER FOR EXPERIENCE LONG TERM
STAFF
WE HAVE TO THINK ABOUT THESE
THINGS AND ALL THE OTHER THINGS
THAT AS EMPLOYERS IN THIS STATE
WE HAVE TO PROVIDE.
SO PLEASE CONSIDER THOSE THINGS
AS YOU HEAR ALL THE INFORMATION
THAT YOU'RE YOU'RE CONSIDERING
THINK YOU.
HE CAME.
TIFFANY RIGHT WITH THE SERVICE
EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL UNION
AND WE JUST WANT TO SPEAK
SPECIFICALLY TO THE MINIMUM WAGE
ISSUE FOR THOSE I'M CITIES I
HAVE A HIGH.
MINIMUM WAGE AND THEY'RE UNABLE
TO ACCESS THE RATE INCREASE WE
FEEL AS THOUGH THEY SHOULD BE
ABLE TO ACCESS THAT RATE
INCREASE SO AT ECHO THE COMMENTS
MADE BY MY COLLEAGUE FROM THE
ARCTIC IN WHICH IS.
ECHO THE COMMENTS ALSO MADE BY
THE LA O. AND ENCOURAGE
EVERYBODY TO KIND OF LOOK AT
WHAT THE INTENT OF THAT IS.
TO MAKE SURE AND ENSURE THAT
THOSE CITIES ARE ABLE TO ACCESS
THAT RATE INCREASE ALTHOUGH THEY
HAVE A PARTY ESTABLISH HIGHER A
MINIMUM WAGE THANK YOU.
BUT YOU.
GUY HOUSTON MISSION HOPE DAY
PROGRAM.
IN THE EAST BAY WE SIR FOUR
HUNDRED AND FIFTY INDIVIDUALS
EVERY SINGLE DAY.
.
IT'S TOUGH BEING THE LAST IN
THESE KIND OF THINGS BECAUSE
EVERYTHING'S BEEN SAID OVER AND
OVER SO.
MUCH MORE ELOQUENTLY THAN THAT
I CAN DO IT.
BUT I JUST WANT TO GIVE YOU A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT OUR PROGRAM.
WE'VE BEEN IN EXISTENCE FOR
OVER EIGHTEEN YEARS AND THIS IS
JUST OUR EXPERIENCE THAT WE'VE
HAD WITH WITH RATES.
SINCE TWO THOUSAND AND TWO.
OUR NET INCREASE IN RATES IS
SEVEN PERCENT.
I AND THAT IS ATTRIBUTABLE TO
THE INCREASE IN TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN.
OF THOSE DOLLARS OF THAT SEVEN
PERCENT SIX AND A HALF PERCENT
FOR OUR PROGRAM. WAS OFF PASSED
THROUGH TO OUR EMPLOYEES
SO ARE SO US AS AN ORGANIZATION.
WHICH AGAIN SEARCH FORM FIFTY
PEOPLE ARE AND.
IN SIX DIFFERENT LOCATIONS
YEAH WE HAVE A HALF A PERCENT
INCREASE FOR RUNNING THE
BUSINESS.
I AT THE SAME TIME YOU HAVE
THINGS NOT ONLY COSTS GO UP NOT
ONLY IN THE BAY AREA BUT
EVERYWHERE.
YOU HAVE THINGS THAT.
THAT GOVERNMENT OF YOU KNOW
FORCES UPON US
A WE HAD THE TAX INCREASE OF FOR
GASOLINE.
ARE WE A MAJOR COMPONENT OF OUR
PROGRAM IS TRANSPORTATION.
AND SO THE GAS TAX INCREASE
INCREASED OUR COST TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED DOLLARS A MONTH.
EVERY MONTH SINCE THAT'S BEEN
INSTITUTED. ARE IF THAT COULD BE
REBATED OUR PASTOR BACK TO IS
THAT BE FOR OUTSTANDING BUT
THAT'S A COST.
ANOTHER ITEM YOU'RE GONNA TALK
ABOUT LATER IS IS EXTRA TWO DAYS
OF OF THE EXTRA VACATION DAYS
WILL THOSE OUR VACATION DAYS US
WAS OUR PENALTY DAYS.
BECAUSE ARE INDIVIDUALS ARE
GETTING SERVICES.
WE'RE NOT GETTING PAID FOR
THOSE DAYS.
SO IT'S A PENALTY AYE ITS
ATTACKS ON US.
BUT I I PASSED OUT YOU KNOW OUR
HISTORY FROM OUR ORGANIZATION.
AND AGAIN.
LA ZEROES IN MOST OF THE YEARS.
AND THAT THE SAME TIME ALL I
HAVE TO COMPARE IS IS THE BAY
AREA.
THE BAY AREA.
CP I.
AND OVER THE COURSE OF THAT.
FIFTEEN YEARS SINCE TWO THOUSAND
TO THE COST OF LIVING HAS GONE
UP FORTY FOUR AND A HALF
PERCENT.
AND AGAIN WE GOT OUR SEVEN
PERCENT BUT THAT WAS PASSED TO
EXCLUSIVELY ALMOST TWO
EMPLOYEES.
SO I'M HERE TO SUPPORT THE
OTHER PROPOSAL CDSA OF THAT YOU
KNOW WE NEED TO HAVE THAT FOUR
PERCENT INCREASE.
IT NEEDS TO BE OUT THERE
IMMEDIATELY AND LOOK AT THAT AS
A DOWN PAYMENT BECAUSE.
AS BEEN SAID EARLIER IF THERE'S
ANY INTELLECTUAL HONESTY IN THIS
REPORT AYE IF WE REALLY HAVEN'T
GOT INCREASE IN SIXTEEN YEARS
THAT OBVIOUSLY WE'RE NOT GETTING
ENOUGH MONEY TO PROVIDE THE
SERVICES FOR OUR. INDIVIDUALS
I AND SO LOOK AT THAT AS A AS A
DOWN PAYMENT A VERY GOOD ONE AND
MUCH APPRECIATED.
BUTTA GOING FORWARD BEYOND IN
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY ONE OF MOST OF YOUR GOING
TO BE HERE.
LOOK AT THAT IS AS.
HOW WE CAN MAKE THE SYSTEM
SUSTAINABLE ARE GOING FORWARD
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
CERN WELCOME BACK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER THANK YOU?
WELL CENTRIFUGES EXPLORED.
IT'S ABOUT PEOPLE.
WE'RE ADDING OVER TEN THOUSAND
PEOPLE TO THE SYSTEM.
WE'RE NOT ADDING.
THE THREE THOUSAND DIRECT
SERVICE PROFESSIONALS BECAUSE WE
CAN'T FIND HIM WE CAN'T HIRAM WE
NEED THOSE DOLLARS REALLY MAKE
THAT WORK.
I HAVE A KEY ADVOCATE I'VE
ALREADY MENTIONED ONCE ALL MAKE
SURE AGAIN CRUCIAL BIT HER
LATER.
WHO LOST A LONG TERM STAFF?
TO GAS STATION.
BECAUSE SHE GOT A HIGHER WAGE.
THAT'S WHAT SOME A LOT SOMEONE
WHO NEEDS TWENTY FOUR SEVEN
SUPPORT GREAT COMMUNICATION
WANTS BE HERE AS A ADVOCATE
LOBBYIST AS A PROFESSIONAL.
SHE NEEDS A LEVEL SUPPORT TO BE
SUCCESSFUL IT'S ABOUT PEOPLE.
SO THOSE PROPOSALS THEY'RE
THEY'RE BOTH THE MEDIAN RATE
RELIEF IS A KEY ISSUE FOR THINGS
THAT ARE AT THAT WE NEED TO GET
SOME WAY TO GET AROUND THAT. AND
WE NEED SOMETHING THAT GETS US
TO THE RATE STUDY BECAUSE COULD
TAKE ANOTHER YEAR FOR THE
LEGISLATURE DECIDE. HOW TO
ACTUALLY FUND THAT
SO WE'RE TALKING AT LEAST TWO
YEARS OUT EVEN IF WE GOT IT ON
MARCH NINETEENTH?
THANK YOU SIR.
MARTY MOTOR CALIFORNIA
DISPLACINGYOUR CREE ACTION
NETWORK AND ALSO A FAMILY MEMBER
JUST WANNA SAY FIRST OF ALL
THANK YOU FOR LISTENING TO ALL
OF US.
I KNOW YOU'VE CONDUCTED A LOT
HEARINGS ON UNIVERSAL HEALTH
COVERAGE AND OTHER ISSUES SUCH A
FACING CALIFORNIA AND YOU'VE
BEEN REALLY GOOD THE COMMITTEE.
YOU AND THE STAFF HAVE BEEN
REALLY GOOD ABOUT LISTENING.
JUMP TO THE VOICES THAT NORMALLY
ON HER I JUST WANNA SAY IS A
FAMILY MEMBER THOUGH WHEN MY
SISTER WAS STILL LIVE HERE
DEVELOPMENT DISABILITIES OF WAS
MORE ABOUT THE SERVICES SHE
COULD NOT GET.
IN THE SERVICES THAT SHE HAD.
AND WAS A CONSTANT STRUGGLE AND
SHE DIED IN TWO THOUSAND THREE.
AND SAD TO HEAR AND I RAN INTO
FAMILIES NOW WHEN THAT SITUATION
STILL EXISTS. ONE ALSO SAY THAT
DECEIT YOU'VE HEARD.
PROVIDERS AND FAMILIES AND
OTHERS TALK ABOUT.
PEOPLE CLOSING BECAUSE OF OF
LACK OF RESOURCES FROM THE
STATEMENT YOU'VE HEARD IT FOR
THE PAST TEN FIFTEEN TWENTY
YEARS WHAT'S DIFFERENT NOW. IS
THAT NEVER BEFORE IN HISTORY OF
CALIFORNIA OR ACTUALLY IN THE
NATION. HAVE MINIMUM WAGE GONE
UP IN CONSECUTIVE YEARS
FIRST ONE CONSECUTIVE YEARS BUT
ALSO BY THE AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT
IT THAT HAS BEEN INCREASED THOSE
ARE GOOD THINGS FOR CALIFORNIA.
NEVER BEFORE HAVE THERE BEEN
INCREASES IN LOCAL MINIMUM
WAGES.
AS THERE HAVE BEEN IN SO AND
ALSO THERE'S HEALTHCARE COSTS
ALTERED CIRCUMSTANCES THAT
DIDN'T EXIST.
TEN YEARS AGO AND AGAIN THESE
ARE GOOD THINGS ARE HAPPENING
FOR CALIFORNIA WORKERS.
BUT IF WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A
DIFFERENT ENVIRONMENT THAT NEEDS
TO BE ADDRESSED.
SO I JUST WANTED TO POINT THAT
OUT SO
SECOND.
TOWARD THAT END I DO WANT AN
URGE THAT THE SUBCOMMITTEE IN
THE LEGISLATURE.
AND THE SUBCOMMITTEE IN THE
OTHER HOUSE.
SERIOUSLY CONSIDER THE PROPOSALS
REGARDING.
RELIEF AND I WOULD STE I WOULD A
URGE YOU THAT I KNOW THAT JUST
CONCERNED BUT ONGOING COSTS
WHILE THERE'S GONNA WITHOUT
KNOWING HOW THE RATE CITY'S
GONNA LAND. IN MAY BE. TAKING UP
THE SUGGESTION THAT SOME OTHERS
HAVE MADE AND I WOULD ARE
CHEAPER TO SUPPORT MAKE IT A ONE
TIME.
APPROPRIATION OF ONE YEAR OR TWO
YEARS OR SOMETHING. UNTIL A RATE
STUDY IS OF OR RATE
RESTRUCTURING IS IS IS IS WELL
FALLING ADOPTED BY THE
LEGISLATURE.
ALSO I WOULD OF ONENESS SUPPORT
THE.
ISSUES RAISED BY TO.
ASSEMBLY RIGHT CALIFORNIA I
THINK THERE IS ON THE RIGHT
TRACK OF LOOKING AT PERSON
CENTERED. ADVOCACY IN TERMS OF
PEOPLE WHO WERE PLACED IN
RESTRICTIVE SETTINGS THAT THEY
SHOULD NOT BE PLACED IN.
AND I DON'T APPLY DRC FOR ALWAYS
STANDING UP FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WE SHOULD BE PUTTING
OUR RESOURCES TO GET THOSE
PEOPLE OUT OF THOSE SETTINGS.
I'M LAST WEEK ON THE RATE STUDY
I'M ON THE DEVELOPMENT OF
SERVICES TASK FORCE.
AND I SERVE ON THE RATE STUDY
WORKGROUP. AND I WON APPLAUD THE
DEPARTMENT FOR THE WORK OF THAT
YOU'VE DONE I'M LOOKING AT
SHOULD.
NANCY PARCHMENT.
BUT I WANT TO SAY THAT ONE THING
THAT'S MISSING AND IT NEEDS TO
BE INCLUDED THAT WOULD URGE THE
LEGISLATURE. TO REALLY INSIST
THAT IT'S A DONE THE INCLUSION.
OF FAMILIES AND PEOPLE WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES IN
TERMS OF BEING SURVEYED.
AND HAVING THEIR VIEWS PART OF
THE DISCUSSION.
IN A IN A FORMAL WAY SECONDLY.
I THINK THEY'RE THEY'RE TRYING
TO DO A PROVIDER RATE STUDY AND
I THINK THAT NEEDS TO BE RE
LOOKED AT.
LOOKING AT A RATE STUDY AMINO
RATE PROVIDER SURVEY THAT LOOKS
AT HOW THE SYSTEM SHOULD BE.
RATHER THAN THE RETRO LOOK AT
HOW THE SYSTEM WORKS THAT'S
BASED ON COSTS.
AND DOES NOT TIE INTO OUTCOMES.
WHICH IS A FAMILY MEMBER IT WAS
ALL ABOUT OUT COMES FOR MY
SISTER AND FOR EVERYBODY ELSE.
SO THANK YOU.
I AM JACKIE DELUDE VOSS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA'S PART OF THE NETWORK
AND ALSO THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF STEP FIRST WE WANT TO
RECOGNIZE ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOLDEN
ABOUT THE BRIDGE FUNDING. I WAS
LOOKING AT.
THE THIRD CUP MANY THE THIRD
ITEM ON THE AGENDA AS THE SAFETY
NET. AND OF OUR DIRECT SUPPORT
PROFESSIONALS ART OUR CURRENT
SAFETY NET THAT WERE COMPLETELY
LOST AND IF THIS BRIDGE FUNDING
GETS US TO A RATE STUDY THAT'S
ACTUALLY GOING TO GET US TO A
RATE INCREASE. WHICH
UNFORTUNATELY I'VE BEEN AROUND
LONG ENOUGH TO BE SKEPTICAL I'M
HOPEFUL.
I'M ALWAYS HOPEFUL I WOULDN'T BE
HERE EVERY YEAR AFTER YEAR BUT
IF WE CAN'T SAY TO THESE
PROVIDERS HAS TWENTY THREE
COUNTIES TWENTY THREE COUNTIES
AND THEIR BAKER TO SAY HEY
DISCOVERY THE FUNDING. SO I CAN
A POLICE PAY MY STAFF THE LOCAL
MINIMUM WAGE IT'S NOT LIKE
THEY'RE DOING A PIE IN THE SKY
ASK THERE IS SAYING. GIVE ME
ENOUGH MONEY TO PAY LOCAL
MINIMUM WAGE SO AS WE TALK ABOUT
THE MILLIONS OF DOLLARS BEING
SERVED IN THE SAFETY NET PROGRAM
AND EVERYTHING THAT WE ARE
DOING.
THERE ARE EXISTING PROVIDERS MY
AGENCIES BEEN AROUND SINCE
NINETEEN NINETY FOUR I USE TO
THINK I WAS A YOUNG ONE AND I'M
NOT.
WE HAVE TO THINKWHAT ARE WE
DOING TO THESE PROVIDERS THAT
ARE EXISTING RIGHT NOW THAT ARE
STRUGGLING RIGHT NOW AND LA AND
IN SAN DIEGO AND IN EMERYVILLE
WHO KNEW THE HIGHEST. HIGHEST
MINIMUM LOCAL MINIMUM WAS
EMERYVILLE I DID NOT.
I'M IN SACRAMENTO COUNTY IVA
COMPACTION ISSUE I HAVE A
MINIMUM WAGE PROBLEM HERE HER
FROM MY AGE ARE DIRECTOR OF A
FORTY FIVE PERCENT TURNOVER RATE
WERE DESPERATE THE FOUR PERCENT
THE CDSA TALKS TO.
HE HELLO LOOK I HEARD ENOUGH
AMONG AB IF STUDENTS WANT ABOUT
THE GOVERNOR HATES ACROSS THE
BOARD I DON'T HAVE TO HEAR IT
AGAIN I KNOW I'M GONNA HEAR IT.
WHAT I HATE IS TURNOVER RATE THE
LOSS OF QUALITY AND THE LOSS OF
RESPECT UBER PROVIDER COMMUNITY
SAY WE'RE JUST TRY TO DO THE
BEST WE CAN?
AND IF WE CANNOT RECOGNIZE THIS
COMMUNITY TO DAY THAT'S BEEN IN
THE SYSTEM SINCE NINETEEN SIXTY
NINE AS OUR SAFETY NET BUT WE
WILL BE LOST SO LET'S DO THE
RIGHT THING AND BRED FUND THE
SYSTEMS. THAT NEED TO SUSTAIN
THEMSELVES BECAUSE IN THE
DEVELOPMENT OF CLOSING TWENTY
TWENTY ONE HERE WE ARE.
HERE WE ARE SO THANK YOU.
NANCY CHANCE CHOICES PERSON
CENTERED SERVICES I'M I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR. I AM.
ONE ECHO PRETTY MUCH WHAT
YOU'VE HEARD IN ADVANCE AND I
WILL REPEAT THAT I JUST HAVE TWO
THINGS I WANTED TO BRING UP
WEARING A STAFFING CRISIS.
I MEAN THERE IT YOU'VE HEARD
THAT BUT IT'S TRUE AWARENESS
STAFFING CRISIS WE CAN'T HIRE
PEOPLE FOR WHAT WE'RE ABLE TO
PAY AND SO QUALITY.
.
IS IS THAT.
AFFECTED. AND IF EURO.
AN AGENCY LIKE OURS LIKE
JACKIE'S LIKE THE PEOPLE THAT
YOU'VE HEARD FROM YOUR GONNA TRY
TO PAY MORE. AND GET THOSE
QUALITY PEOPLE AND BUT IT
THAT OUT THE.
RISK OF GOING IN THE HOLE EVERY
SINGLE MONTH WE ALSO HAVE A
PROGRAM IN TRUCKING THAT'S THE
SECOND THING I'M GONNA SAY
TREKKIE IS EXTREMELY EXPENSIVE
TO LIVE MEN.
WE HAVE HAD A RATE INCREASE TO
THAT PROGRAM IN YEARS AND WE'RE
TRAVELING TO PAY FOURTEEN TO
FIFTEEN DOLLARS AN HOUR JUST FOR
OUR DAY SERVICE PROGRAM. AND
WE'RE THE ONLY PROGRAM THERE NOW
THERE ISN'T ANY OTHER PROGRAM
FOR THOSE PEOPLE THAT LIVE THERE
IF WE CLOSE. THEY DON'T HAVE
SERVICES AND THERE'S NOT A
MECHANISM TO HELP US SO I
SUPPORT THE BRIDGE FUNDING I
SUPPORT BUT THINGS THAT HAVE
BEEN DISCUSSED HERE BUT WE HAVE
TO. WE HAVE TO REALIZE WHERE THE
STAFFING CRISIS AND WE OUT THE
FIND A WAY TO FUND OUR STAFF
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MA'AM.
HELLO MY NAME'S CHATS FOR DOOR
GOING ON THE.
NEW VICE PRESIDENT FOR AL WHEN
AND.
SO I THINK I'VE BEEN ON THE JOB
NOW ABOUT FOUR WEEKS AND.
I'M GOING BACK AND FORTH FROM
PENNSYLVANIA A COUSIN HAVING A
TOUGH TIME MYSELF FINDING.
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
SO.
SO. YOU KNOW THE ISSUES HERE.
ARE REAL AND.
SO I DON'T WANT TO KIND OF
REITERATE ON ON ON WHAT
EVERYBODY ELSE SAID BUT. YOU
KNOW WHEN WE TALK ABOUT LOSING
PEOPLE TO A GAS STATION YOU KNOW
WE'RE NOT JUST TALKING ABOUT.
YOU KNOW SOMEONE GOING SOMEWHERE
FOR A BETTER WAGE OKAY BUT. YOU
KNOW. THE PEOPLE THAT I'VE MET
ONE OF MY FIRST OBJECTIVES WAS
TO GO IN AND TO GO TO ALL OF OUR
HOMES AND MEET WITH OUR STAFF.
AND THIS WAS AN ISSUE FOR
EVERYONE OF THEM OKAY SO NOT
ONLY.
OUR PEOPLE CAN LEAVING OR
CONSIDERING LEAVING.
FOR BETTER WAYS TO TAKE CARE OF
THEIR FAMILIES OKAY BUT WE'RE
ALSO TAKING AWAY THEIR DREAM.
THE PASSION IN THE DREAMS OF THE
PEOPLE WHO WORK.
WITH WITH YOU KNOW OUR RESIDENTS
IT'S THEIR PASSION IT'S THEIR
DREAM.
SO WE HAVE TO FIGURE THIS OUT.
THE THE OTHER THING I LIKE TO
COMMENT ON IN THE LAST COUPLE
WEEKS.
.
YOU KNOW WHAT WE HAD A
DELEGATION FROM NEW JERSEY.
WHO CAME HERE BECAUSE?
CALIFORNIA IS RECOGNIZED AS THE
MODEL.
WERE THE MODEL WHEN IT COMES TO
PROGRAMS AND SERVICES
BUT CLEARLY.
WERE NOT THE MODEL WHEN IT COMES
TO THE FINANCE PART OF IT.
SO NOT ONLY DO WE HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY FOR PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA.
BUT THE STATE OF NEW JERSEY.
AND THE REST OF THE COUNTRY IS
LOOKING UPON OUR LEADERSHIP. TO
FIGURE THIS OUT.
BECAUSE WHEN WE FIGURE THE SAL.
OTHER PEOPLE WILL FIGURE OUT
TILL AND IF WE CAN'T FIGURE IT
OUT.
THEN IT'S MOST LIKELY THEY'RE
NOT GONNA BE ABLE TO FIGURE OUT.
A FEW DAYS AGO I TALKED TO
SOMEONE FROM ISRAEL.
WHO WANTS TO COME DOWN AND SEE
THE CALIFORNIA MODEL SO THEY
GONNA BE DOWN HERE IN JULY?
SO NOT ONLY.
WE HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE
PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA. BUT WE
HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY TOWARD
COUNTRY.
AND WE HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY TO
THE WORLD.
BECAUSE WHEN WE FIGURE THIS OUT.
WALL FIGURED OUT FOR THE COUNTRY
AND WILL FORGET OUT FOR THE
WORLD.
SO YOU KNOW. LET'S MAKE THIS
HAPPENED BECAUSE IT'S NOT JUST
ABOUT.
YOU NO PROVIDING PEOPLE THE
MONEY OR NOT PAYING ENOUGH
MONEY.
WE'RE LITERALLY RIPPING THE
DREAMS AND THE PASSION.
AWAY FROM PEOPLE WHO DO THIS
WORK.
BECAUSE THEIR STOCK.
DO WE TAKE CARE OF THE
RESIDENTS.
OR DO WE HAVE TO LEAVE OUR DREAM
AND OUR PASSION.
TO TAKE CARE OF OUR FAMILY.
THAT'S A TOUGH SPOT.
AND IT'S NOT A SPOT THAT I'VE.
YOU KNOW.
REALLY HAD TO STRUGGLE WITH AS
MUCH.
UNTIL NOW.
OKAY SO LET'S FIGURE THIS OUT
AND TAKE CARE OF THE PEOPLE WHO
ARE TAKING CARE THE PEOPLE.
OKAY THANK YOU SIR.
YOU HAD I OUR DOG PASCO WERE
FROM IMAGINE SUPPORTED LIVING
SERVICE IN SANTA CRUZ COUNTY AND
I'M. HERE TO SPEAK AS A FORMER
GAS STATION ATTENDANT WHO CAME
TO WORK IN THIS SYSTEM.
BOTH WAYS AND I JUST WANT ARE
ENCOURAGE THE LEGISLATURE AND
THANK THE DEPARTMENT TO OF
FOLLOW UP ON WHAT.
MARTY SAID THAT.
IT WOULD TO REDO THE RATES ARE
NOT TAKE INTO ACCOUNT OUTCOMES
AT.
FEELS LIKE A WAY OF PERPETUATING
WANTS CALMNESS HERE SO I HOPE
THAT'LL BE ON PEOPLE'S MINDS.
THANK YOU SIR.
I RUN A LOT WITH CREEL I AM I
JUST WANT TO SAY WE SUPPORT.
ASSEMBLY HOLDINGS BRIDGE TO A
FUNDING IT'S LIKE WE DEFINITELY
NEED THAT BUT I HEARD THAT
THERE'S A LOT ABOUT MINIMUM
WAGE.
YOU NO I WENT INTO THIS FIELD
BECAUSE IT WAS A PROFESSION NOT
A MINIMUM WAGE JOB. AND FOR A
LOT OF THE PEOPLE THAT WORK HERE
THINK THAT THIS IS A PROFESSION
WHEN WE SHOULD BE ACTUALLY
PAYING THEM FROM IT.
I ALSO THINK TWO FOUR PERCENT
PER YEAR. AND HAVE A SUNSET ON
THAT I WOULD LIKE TO SEE A FOUR
PERCENT A YEAR EVERY YEAR UNTIL
WE DO GET A WAGE RATE ADJUSTMENT
ON THIS.
WE NEED IT IT'S LIKE WHICH CAN
DO THIS ONE TIME SAY OKAY WE
DONE IT AND WE'RE GONNA DO A
STUDY ON IT. BUT WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT THIS DOES GET DONE.
THANK YOU.
YES SIR ANY OTHER PUBLIC
COMMENT.
WE'LL BRING IT BACK UP TO THE
DYESS I FIRST WANTED TO START BY
THANKING ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOLDEN
FOR.
DOING THE HARD WORK THAT'S
NECESSARY.
NICKEL VASQUEZ OUR STAFFER FOR
HUMAN SERVICES HAS SAID THAT
WE'VE NEVER GOTTEN A LETTER
PRIOR TO THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
COMING OUT.
BUT YOUR EFFORTS AND YOUR HARD
WORK.
HAVE BEEN REFLECTED BY THE
QUANTITY AND QUALITY OF.
INFORMATION THAT WE'VE GOT
INSIDE JUST WANTED TO THANK YOU
FOR THAT.
I'D LIKE TO OPEN IT UP FOR ANY
QUESTIONS THAT WE MAY HAVE HERE
ON THE DICE.
I I KNOW MISTER HOLDEN IS THE
GIG GONE SO I DON'T WANT YOU TO
BE LATE SO KEEP IT SHORT.
.
FIRST THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON THE LAST FOR THE
HARD WORK FOR WORKING WITH
EVERYBODY STAFF.
.
I'M HONORED TO BE A CO AUTHOR ON
IT WITH YOU.
.
YEAH AND I THINK PART OF THE
THING THAT WAS A MISSION WITH
THE BRIDGE FUNDING IS WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT TWENTY FIVE
MILLION FROM THE GENERAL FUND.
BUT THERE'S ALSO MATCHING
FUNDING FROM.
THE FEDS
THAT ARE ACTUALLY BRING THIS UP
TO I BELIEVE THE NUMBERS FORTY
FOUR MILLION.
SO I THINK THAT'S WORTH
MENTIONING.
THE ENDOWMENT THEY OFFER THE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND SPEAK AS A
DAD.
I'VE LITERALLY BEEN THROUGH THIS
WITH MY SON.
WHERE WE LOST THE PROVIDER?
BECAUSE OF FUNDING ISSUES
AND THAT PROVIDER GOT SHUT DOWN
SO I THINK.
IT WE WE GET INTO THIS PROVIDER
CLIENT CONVERSATION WHEN WE'RE
UP HERE.
BOUGHT IT. YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
PEOPLE THAT ARE WORKING TRYING
TO GET BY AND PROVIDE FOR THEIR
FAMILIES WHO WAS REFERRED TODAY
HAVE YOU KNOW SOME PEOPLE LOVE
TO BE GAS STATION ATTENDANTS.
SOME OF LEFT FROM GAS STATION
ATTENDANTS COME HERE. BUT.
WE HAVE PEOPLE THAT ARE THAT
PICKED A PROFESSION
SERVE IN AND TO HELP.
PEOPLE WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES.
WHO'VE MADE IT THEIR LIFE.
THE SAME TIME THAT.
BUT AS A DAD.
WITH THE SUN THAT THAT'S BEEN
DOWN THIS ROAD.
WE HAVE FAMILY MEMBERS
WHO ARE EXTREMELY. DEPENDENT ON
THE SERVICES.
I SURELY THINK FOR THEM THAT MY
SON DID WELL IN IN THESE
MAINSTREAM AT SCHOOL NOW.
WITHOUT THAT HE MAY NOT HAVE
BEEN.
AND I THINK IT'S EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT THAT AS WE'RE DOING
THE STUDIES.
AND AND WE'RE DOING ALL OF THIS
WE HAVE TO CONSIDER WHY. IT
LOOKS LIKE.
WHEN A CHILD OR PERSON REVERTS.
BECAUSE THAT IS AN EXTREME
DIFFICULTY.
FOR THAT FAMILY FOR THAT
INDIVIDUAL. AND THEY HAVE TO
FIND ANOTHER PROVIDER TO COMMIT
ME HAVE TO START ALL OVER.
AGAIN.
AND THAT'S AN ADDED COST.
THAT WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
PERSONALLY THOSE OF US ON THE
DYESS.
DEPARTMENT A FINE LA OF THE THAT
WE LOOK INTO.
BECAUSE THAT NEEDS TO BE
ACCOUNTED FOR AS WELL.
SHELDON.
AGAIN.
THERE IS A MEMBER I'M EXTREMELY
HONORED TO BE WORKING.
WAIT WITH YOU.
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOLDEN ON
THIS.
AND I HOPE MY COLLEAGUES ON THE
DICE
PHIL IS IDEAL BECAUSE I KNOW
I'LL BE ADVOCATING BE ON THE
SCENE FOR THIS IS WHAT.
SO I HAVE A COUPLE REQUESTS IF I
MAY AS WE CONTINUE TO LOOK AT
THE PROPOSAL'S RAISED UNDER THIS
ISSUE.
FIRST CAN THE DEPARTMENT AND
FINANCE PLEASE PROVIDE A FISCAL
AFFECT ASSESSMENT OF THE
STATUTORY CLEAN UP PURSUANT TO
THE LA O. RECOMMENDATION.
REGARDING THE MINIMUM WAGE.
AND SECONDS CAN THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE PLEASE CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THOSE MAKING PROPOSALS
IN THIS AREA. EVEN IF IT IS TO
PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO
SEE HOW THESE IDEAS COULD BE
WORKABLE IF THEY WERE ADOPTED BY
THE ASSEMBLY.
WITH THAT WE WILL HOLD THIS ITEM
OPEN AND RETURNED TO. ITEM ISSUE
THREE.
I THINK.
SO.
FACILITY.
DIRECTOR GAINER YOU YES. TO
CONFINE MY SPOT DIDN'T WHERE WE
ARE TODAY. SO I'M AGAIN I IN IN
RESPECT OF EVERYBODY'S TIME I I
DO WANT TO MAKE NOTE THAT THE
AGENDA. HAS PROVIDED AN UPDATE
ON OUR SAFETY NET.
PROPOSALS AND IT'S ON PAGE
TWENTY TWO PROVIDES A GRID.
THAT HAS SOME AREAS.
BUT JUST A LITTLE BIT OF
BACKGROUND ON THAT I'D LIKE TO
JUST SHARE.
IN IN HEARING.
OVERTIME CONCERNS ABOUT THE
DEVELOPMENT OF RESOURCES IN THE
COMMUNITY.
WE HAVE.
FOR MANY MANY YEARS IDENTIFIED
OPPORTUNITIES FOR DEVELOPING
RESOURCES AND WHILE THERE
CONTINUES TO BE GROWTH IN OUR
SYSTEM AND CHANGES AS FAR AS THE
NEEDS OF INDIVIDUALS. YOU KNOW
WE HAVE TO CONTINUE TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE.
THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE SOMEWHAT
FLEXIBLE AND AND MAKING SURE
THAT WE'RE TAKING A LOOK AT WHAT
THOSE NEEDS ARE.
CERTAINLY IN TWO THOUSAND
TWELVE WHEN THERE'S A MORATORIUM
REPLACEMENTS AND DEVELOPMENTAL
CENTERS I'M NOT ONLY DID THAT
TIME IDENTIFIED THE NEED TO
DEVELOP RESOURCES BECAUSE
INDIVIDUALS THAT WERE IN THAT
COMMUNITY.
THAT EITHER MAY HAVE BEEN
REFERRED TO OR NEEDING.
SUPPORT SERVICES SIMILAR TO
THOSE AT AT THE DEVELOPMENTAL
CENTER WE HAD TO START
DEVELOPING RESOURCES.
SO OVER TIME WE'VE REALLY
IDENTIFIED HOW CAN WE START
LOOKING AT DEVELOPING THE
COMMUNITY RESOURCES TO SUPPORT
INDIVIDUALS.
WITH COMPLEX NEEDS.
WITH THE SECRETARY'S
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER TASK FORCE
AND THEN THE THE.
FOLLOWING THE DC TASK FORCE THE
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES TASK
FORCE.
REALLY CAME FROM A DISCUSSION
WITH ADVOCATES CONSUMERS FAMILY
MEMBERS.
AND AND THE MANY MEMBERS THAT
ARE PART OF IT TO HELP INFORM US
WHAT THE PRIORITIES ARE.
MANY OF THOSE PRIORITIES FOR
DEVELOPING NEW MODELS OF
SERVICE.
BUT ALSO RECOGNIZING THAT THEIR
SERVICES ARE NOT ONLY FOR
INDIVIDUALS MOVING FROM
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS BUT
RECOGNIZING THAT THERE IS A NEED
IN THE COMMUNITY AS WELL.
SO AGAIN WITH THE SERVICES THAT
ARE OUTLINED IN THE SAFETY NET
PLAN THAT WAS INTRODUCED LAST
YEAR.
A A A DO WANT TO JUST MAKE
NOTES THAT A PLAN IS NOT JUST A
ONE TIME EVENT.
IT'S IT'S A COMMITMENT THAT
THAT WERE MAKING TO HAVE THE
CONTINUE DISCUSSION.
WITH THE INDIVIDUALS IN THE
COMMUNITY AND OUR AND
MAINTAINING THAT COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT.
WE HAVE A SUB WORKGROUP OF THE
DS TASK FORCE ON THAT IS A VERY
IMPORTANT ON VOICE TO US AS WE
TAKE A LOOK AT CONTINUED NEEDS
AS WELL.
SO.
AND IF THERE'S ANY SPECIFIC
QUESTIONS REGARDING THE STATUS
OF WHAT IS ON OUTLINED OR ON THE
SAFETY NETWORK HAPPY TO ANSWER
THOSE QUESTIONS I JUST WANT TO
SHARE WITH YOU I HAVE DOCTOR
BRAD. BACKSTROM HERE WHO IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR ON THE OVERSIGHT
OF THE STAR SERVICES IN THE
ACUTE CRISIS SERVICES IN HAS
BEEN. INTIMATELY INVOLVED IN
DEVELOPING AND IMPLEMENTING.
THE DEVELOPMENT FOR THE ITEMS
THAT ARE OUTLINED IN THE SAFETY
NET PLAN.
NEXT WE WILL HAVE KATHERINE
BLAKEMORE FROM THE DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA FOLLOWED BY.
AYE DIANA CARSEN FROM DISABILITY
VOICES UNITED THANK YOU SO MUCH
AND I WILL BE BRIEF BECAUSE I
KNOW IT'S GETTING ON LATE.
I JUST WANNA START BY SAYING
YOU KNOW I AM THE DIRECTOR OF
THE AGENCY THAT TWICE SUED THE
STATE TO CLOSE STATE
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS.
AND I'M REALLY PLEASED WHERE WE
ARE BUT IT ALSO MEANS I FEEL
THIS UNIQUE RESPONSIBILITY TO
ENSURE THAT WITH THE CLOSURE OF
THE DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS. THAT
WE HAVE IN PLACE A SYSTEM THAT
WILL ENSURE THAT PEOPLE
PARTICULARLY THOSE IN CRISIS GET
WHAT THEY NEED. SO WITHOUT I
WANNA JUST ARM GIVE YOU MY
THINKING AND MY AGENCIES
THINKING ABOUT SOME
RECOMMENDATIONS OF THINGS THAT
WE ARM THAT WE NEED TO DO.
BUT FIRST JUST MAKE SURE THAT
WE HAVE LOCAL CAPACITY FOR
CRISIS SERVICES
AND YOU KNOW WHAT THE THE
DEPARTMENT'S CORRECT WE ARE
DEVELOPING THIS I JUST WORRY
THAT THERE'S GOING TO BE THIS
THESE GAPS AND PEOPLE ARE NOT
GOING TO. GET WHAT THEY NEED AND
SO I THINK THE PLACE TO START IS
TO ASSESS WHAT IS THE CURRENT.
CAPACITY IN LOCAL COMMUNITIES
WHERE ARE THE GAPS SO THAT WE
KNOW IN ALL CORNERS OF THE STATE
IN ALL REGIONAL CENTERS THAT
THERE IS SUFFICIENT LOCAL CRISIS
ARM CAPACITY BECAUSE THAT'S WE
SHOULD START KEY PEOPLE WHERE
THEY ARE. GIVE THEM WHAT THEY
NEED TO AMELIORATE THE CRISIS
AND LET THEM CONTINUE TO LIVE IN
THE CURRENT LIVING ARRANGEMENT.
WE ARE JUST ABOUT TO HAVE
COMMUNITY CRISIS HOMES WHICH IS
REALLY A TERRIFIC MODEL AND I
APPLAUD THE DEPARTMENT FOR THEIR
DEVELOPMENT OF THE COMMITTEE
CRISIS HOMES.
PART OF WHAT WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE IS THAT WE HAVE AFTER
SOMEONE'S CRISIS IS AMELIORATED
THAT THEY HAVE A PLACE TO GO
BECAUSE IF THEY DON'T THE
COMMUNITY CRISIS HOME WILL
BECOME THEIR NEW HOME. WHILE
WE'RE LOOKING FOR ALTERNATIVE
ARRANGEMENTS AND I DON'T YET
KNOW THAT WE HAVE THE NUMBER AN
ARRAY OF SERVICES THAT ARM THAT
WE NEED.
THE NEXT IS TO REDUCE ARM OUR
RELIANCE ON INSTITUTIONS FOR
MENTAL DISEASE THAT I TALKED
ABOUT OF A FEW MINUTES AGO.
WE KNOW WE HAVE A GOOD MODEL IN
THE STATE ACUTE CRISIS SERVICES
THOSE WORK REALLY WELL.
KUDOS TO THE DEPARTMENT FOR
DEVELOPING A MODEL THAT ACTUALLY
COMPLIES WITH THE STATUTE DOES
COMPREHENSIVE ASSESSMENTS WORKS
HARD TO GET PEOPLE BACK INTO THE
COMMUNITY WITH THE WITHIN THE
TIME LINES.
BUT BECAUSE THAT CAPACITY HAS
YET NOT YET BEEN SUFFICIENT WHAT
WE END UP DOING IS PLACING
INDIVIDUALS INSTEAD IN
INSTITUTIONS FOR MENTAL DISEASE.
AND THEY STAY THERE AND THEY ARE
PLACES WHERE WE NOW GET DATA
THAT SHOW VERY HIGH USES OF
CHEMICAL AND PHYSICAL RESTRAINTS
OF INDIVIDUALS. WE SHOULD WE WE
KNOW THAT PEOPLE HAVE A
DIFFICULT TIME GETTING OUT OF
THERE BECAUSE THERE ISN'T A
MECHANISM TO DO VERY EFFECTIVE.
ON TRANSITION PLANNING.
SO WHAT WE.
WHAT WE WANNA DO IS CHANGE ON
HOW PEOPLE GO INTO THESE?
INSTITUTIONS FOR MENTAL DISEASE
AND AND ENSURE THAT PEOPLE CAN
COME OUT MORE QUICKLY SO THE
FIRST IS PEOPLE BUT GOING TO THE
STATE UNITS AND PEOPLE WERE
GOING TO I AM THESE ARE EXACTLY
THE SAME PEOPLE BUT WE HAVE
DIFFERENT ADMISSION CRITERIA. WE
SHOULD HAVE A SINGLE CRITERIA BY
WHICH PEOPLE GET ADMITTED TO
EITHER ONE OF THOSE PLACES WITH
I THINK THE STATE PROVIDING SOME
OVERSIGHT ABOUT HOW PEOPLE END
UP WHERE THEY AND WHERE THEY END
UP.
I'M SURE THAT DURING THAT TIME
THAT
INDIVIDUALS ARE IN I AM DES THAT
WE TIMELY TO THE ASSESSMENT
CENTER COMPREHENSIVE. AND THAT
IS PART OF THAT PROCESS WE TAKE
CARE TO ENSURE THAT WE ARE
FIGURING OUT FROM THE BEGINNING
WHAT SERVICES THE PERSON NEEDS
ON TO LEAVE. I SAY THIS BECAUSE
OF INDIVIDUALS WE REPRESENT ON
GIVE YOU ONE VERY QUICK EXAMPLE
WOULD REPRESENT A YOUNG WOMAN.
ON WHO HAS BEEN IN AND I AM DE
FOR THREE AND A HALF YEARS AT
FIRST SHE WAS TOLD SORRY THERE
JUST AREN'T ANY PLACES FOR YOU.
AND SHE'S TOLD YOU'RE ON A
WAITING LIST TO GET INTO PLACE
AND THEN.
SOMEBODY ELSE GOT THAT
PLACEMENT WE'VE WE NOW
INTERVENED AND HAD.
* FOR A COMPREHENSIVE
ASSESSMENT IMPORT PEOPLE TOLD
HER IS SHE'S NOT READY TO MOVE
TO THE COMMUNITY SHE'S BEEN IN
AN I. M. D. FOR THREE AND A HALF
YEARS OF YOU'RE NOT READY TO
MOVE TO THE COMMUNITY AFTER
THREE AND A HALF YEARS. WHAT
HAVE WE BEEN DOING AND WHAT
MONEY HAVE WE BEEN SPENDING SO?
TAKING SERIOUSLY AND HONORING
THAT PROCESS SO THAT PEOPLE CAN
LEAVE AND MOVE TO OTHER LIVING
ARRANGEMENTS IS REALLY JUST NOT
ONLY GOOD POLICY BETTER USE OF.
THE STATE'S ARM THE STATE'S
MONEY AND I THINK ONE WAY TO
ENSURE THAT THAT HAPPENS WITH A
LITTLE MORE FIDELITY IS RIGHT
NOW THE DEPARTMENT HAS TO
APPROVE. ANY EXTENSION ARM AT A
NINETY DAY MARK WHICH IS HALF
WAY THROUGH THE INDIVIDUALS ARM
COMMITMENT THERE. INVOLVE THE
DEPARTMENT EARLIER AND MORE
FREQUENTLY AND REQUIRE THAT THE
ARM. REVIEW THIS AT A THIRTY DAY
MARK AND EVERY ONGOING THIRTY
DAY MARK SO INDIVIDUALS ARE NOT
STUCK THERE FOR THREE AND A HALF
YEARS ONLY TO LEARN THAT THEY'RE
NOT READY TO HAVE. TO MOVE ON
OUT THE LAST ONE I'LL TALK ABOUT
ON IN THE REST IS JUST IN OUR
TESTIMONY IS WE HAVE CLIENTS
RIGHTS ADVOCATES ARM. WHO HAVE?
CONTINUE TO REPRESENT PEOPLE WHO
ARE IN THESE RESTRICTIVE LIVING
ARRANGEMENTS WITH A FAIR AMOUNT
OF SUCCESS OF SOME OTHER
EXAMPLES OF THAT COULD WORK AT
THE END. ONE OF THE WAYS THEY
CAN BE MOST EFFECTIVE AND
HOPEFUL IN THAT PROCESS IS BY
HAVING ACCESS TO THE SAME
INFORMATION THAT OTHER MEMBERS
OF THE TEAM HAVE. WHO ARE
PARTICIPATING IN THAT TRANSITION
PLANNING WE'VE DONE THAT IN SOME
CIRCUMSTANCES WHEN THEY GET
NOTICED BUT NOT CONSISTENTLY
STATUTORILY SO WE WANT TO WORK
WITH THE DEPARTMENT TO CLEAN UP
THAT LANGUAGE IN AND THE MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE AND ENSURE
THAT?
OUR STAFF CAN BE THE MOST
HELPFUL AND HELPED DESIGN THE
KIND OF.
AFFECTED TRANSITION PLANS THAT
WILL KEEP PEOPLE MOVING TO THE
OTHER TYPES OF PLACES IN IN THE
COMMUNITY THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS THE ANNA PASTERNAK
CARSON IM WITH DISABILITY VOICES
UNITED I'M A KINDERGARTEN
TEACHER. AYE IN SAN DIEGO I ALSO
TEACH AT SAN DIEGO STATE
UNIVERSITY IN THE FIELD OF
DISABILITY STUDIES.
BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY I AM A
SISTER AND AN ADVOCATE FOR MY
BROTHER PLUCKING CARSON. AND IF
I MAY SAY YOU HAVE A WONDERFUL
NAME MY FAMILY WOULD AGREE
INCLUDING MY GRANDFATHER* MY
UNCLE PLUCKING MY THREE COUSINS
JOAQUIN AND MY. AUNT JOAQUIN.
TRUE STORY.
.
MY BROTHER JOAQUIN WASTED A
TOTAL OF FIFTEEN YEARS ON TWO
SEPARATE OCCASIONS.
ONCE FOR EIGHT YEARS AND ONCE
FOR SEVEN YEARS IN FAIRVIEW
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER.
WHICH WAS TWO HOURS AWAY FROM.
OUR HOME OUR FAMILY TRAVELED TWO
TO THREE HOURS EACH WAY IN
TRAFFIC EVERY WEEKEND.
TO SPEND TIME WITH HIM AND
ASSURE HIM THAT WE STILL LOVED
HIM.
BOTH TIMES IN THE DC WERE THE
RESULT OF BEHAVIORAL CRISES WITH
NO COMMUNITY SUPPORTS OR
RESOURCES TO SERVICE NEEDS AND
MEET OUR FAMILY'S NEEDS. WE HAD
NO ALTERNATIVE.
WE VOWED THAT WE WOULD GET HIM
OUT AND NEVER LET THIS HAPPEN
AGAIN.
WE ENTERED A THREE YEAR LEGAL
BATTLE WITH THE HELP OF.
DRC.
AGAINST THE SAN DIEGO REGIONAL
CENTER TO BRING WALKING BACK
HOME INTO THE COMMUNITY WITH
SUPPORTIVE LIVING SERVICES.
HE'S BEEN HOME FOR SIX YEARS.
OUR FAMILY HAS BEEN ABLE TO
PROVIDE WALKING WITH THE HOME OF
HIS OWN THAT IS WALKING A FIGHT
AS WE CALL IT. ON OUR PROPERTY.
AND CREATIVE SUPPORT THAT ARE
PERSONALIZED BASED ON HIS NEEDS.
HE'S HAD CRISES SINCE HE'S BEEN
HOME.
BUT HE AND WE HAVE GOTTEN
THROUGH THEM SAFELY BECAUSE OF
THE PERSON SENATE CENTER
PLANNING. I NEEDED RESOURCES
THAT ARE IN PLACE.
ALTHOUGH OUR FAMILY HAS FUNDED
JOAQUIN'S HOUSING.
BECAUSE JOAQUIN WAS A DC
RESIDENT HE HAS EXTRA FUNDING
AND RESOURCES TO HELP ENSURE HIS
SUCCESS IN THE COMMUNITY AND FOR
THAT OUR FAMILY IS ETERNALLY
GRATEFUL.
BUT JOAQUIN WOULD NOT HAVE ENDED
UP.
IN THE DC TWICE.
HAD SAFETY NET SERVICES BEEN IN
PLACE TO BEGIN WITH.
WHEN HE WAS A CHILD.
AND THAT IS WHAT WE WANT TO
SPEAK TO TODAY.
CRISES HAPPEN NOT ONLY TO ADULTS
EXITING DC'S BUT THEY ARE VERY
REAL FOR MANY FAMILIES MANY
CHILDREN WERE LEFT FLOUNDERING
WITHOUT HELP WITHOUT HOPE.
CRISES HAPPEN.
FOR CHILDREN AND ADULTS AND
FAMILIES
DVD YOU ONCE THE LEGISLATURE TO
UNDERSTAND THIS REALITY AND BE
COGNIZANT OF THE IMPACT OF YOUR
DECISIONS RELATED TO FUNDING AND
OVERSIGHT OF DTS.
ONE OF OUR CONCERNS IS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE AND DTS THE SAFETY
NET PLAN HAVE.
FOCUSED ON DEVELOPING SERVICE
SERVICES FOURTH FIVE HUNDRED
THIRTY FOUR DC MOVERS AND NOT
ENOUGH ATTENTION HAS BEEN PAID.
TWO THE FAR GREATER NUMBER OF
INDIVIDUALS WHO RESIDE WITH
THEIR FAMILIES ARE IN COMMUNITY
SETTINGS WHO HAVE EQUALLY
CHALLENGING SUPPORT NEEDS.
ANOTHER CONCERN IS THAT DTS IS
PLAN IS MOVING SLOWLY.
THE CRISES THAT FAMILIES
EXPERIENCE ARE VERY REAL AND DC
CLOSURES ALTHOUGH A GOOD THING
MEAN THAT PEOPLE WILL END UP IN
EMERGENCY ROOMS. AND IN JAILS
WITHOUT THERAPEUTIC SERVICES FOR
EXTENDED PERIODS OF TIME IF WE
DO NOT ENSURE THAT APPROPRIATE
SUPPORTS IN PLACE WITHIN EACH
REGIONAL CENTER AREA.
ALTHOUGH WE THINK DDS FOR
INCLUDING STAKEHOLDERS IN THE
PLANNING PROCESS AND WE ARE
ENCOURAGED THAT DTS HAS
PROMISED.
THAT SERVICES WILL BE DEVELOPED
THROUGH PERSON CENTERED
PLANNING.
WITH A FOCUS ON CULTURAL
COMPETENCE POSITIVE BEHAVIOR
SUPPORTS AND TRAUMA INFORMED
CARE.
WE ARE CONCERNED THAT THERE IS
NOT ADEQUATE OVERSIGHT TO ENSURE
THAT THESE GOALS ARE MET. WITH
EACH INDIVIDUAL MEETING SAFETY
NET SERVICES.
WE'VE LAID OUT A SET OF
RECOMMENDATIONS IN THE REALITY
CHECK PAPER. THAT YOU HAVE. WITH
THE ULTIMATE GOAL OF KEEPING
INDIVIDUALS IN CRISIS IN THEIR
HOMES IN THE COMMUNITY BUT THAT
IF THAT IS NOT POSSIBLE WE
ADVOCATE FOR THE DEVELOPMENT OF
SERVICES AND SUPPORTS THAT CAN'T
SAY NO.
MEANING THEY CANNOT DENY OR
REMOVE THE INDIVIDUAL BECAUSE OF
THEIR BEHAVIORS.
THE SPECIFIC RECOMMENDED EAT
DACIANS ARE IN THE PACKET BUT
I'M GOING TO SUMMARIZE A FEW.
WE NEED TO ENSURE THAT PARENTS
ARE INFORMED ABOUT AVAILABILITY
OF A CONTINUING.
CONTINUUM OF CRISIS SERVICES
THAT SUPPORT PEOPLE STAYING IN
THEIR HOMES AND COMMUNITIES.
WE NEED TO MAKE IT EASIER AND
FASTER FOR INDIVIDUALS AND
FAMILIES IN CRISIS TO RECEIVE A
HEALTH AND SAFETY WAIVER FROM
DTS SO THAT THEY CAN PAY THEIR
WORKERS. HIGHER RATE IN ORDER TO
SUPPORT SOMEONE WITH EXTREME
BEHAVIORS.
WE NEED TO CREATE DEADLINES NOW
BECAUSE PEOPLE IN CRISIS CANNOT
WAIT WE NEED TO BE SURE THAT
SERVICES AND HOUSING ARE
AVAILABLE TO ALL INDIVIDUALS IN
CRISIS INCLUDING CHILDREN. AND
NOT FOCUS PRIMARILY ON THOSE
LIVING OUT OF DC'S WE NEED TO BE
SURE THAT PEOPLE. NEEDS HAVE
BEEN MET WHEN THEY ARE IN CRISIS
AND THAT THEY BECOME STABILIZED
IN ORDER TO TAKE THEM BACK HOME
OR INTO THE COMMUNITY AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE.
WE NEED TO HOLD REGIONAL CENTERS
ACCOUNTABLE FOR PROVIDING
CHOICES THAT FIT WITH THE
FAMILIES CULTURAL PREFERENCES.
AND BASED ON PERSON CENTERED
PLANNING.
THERE NEEDS TO BE CHOICES
OFFERED.
WE NEED TO ENSURE THAT CRISIS
TEAMS AND COMMUNITY AGENCY STAFF
ARE TRAINED. TO RECOGNIZE.
AND TREAT THE ROOT OF THE CRISES
IN A DIGNIFIED AND RESPECTFUL
MANNER.
IN ORDER TO DO ALL THESE THINGS.
WE NEED TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
FUNDING TO DEVELOP MORE OPTIONS
FOR INDIVIDUALS.
INCLUDING RESTORING FUNDS FROM
THE FISCAL YEAR TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN TO TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN.
WELL STAKEHOLDERS HAVE BEEN AN
INTEGRAL PART OF THE DTS
PLANNING PROCESS AND WE THINK
THEM FOR THAT.
ALL OF THE FAMILY MEMBERS WHO
SERVE ON THE DISABILITY SERVICE
TASK FORCE REPRESENT OLDER
ADULTS MOST OF WHOM HAVE LIVED
OR CURRENTLY LIVE IN A DC.
HE NET SHOULD BE WIDENED
INCLUDE FAMILY MEMBERS.
CHILDREN AND YOUNG ADULTS WHO
ARE IN CRISIS AS WELL.
THE BOARD OF DIRECTORS OF
DISABILITY VOICES UNITED ALL OF
US OF WHOM ARE VOLUNTEERS URGE
YOU TO STUDY OUR REPORT AND
RECOMMENDATIONS AND RELY ON THEM
TO MAKE THE MOST INCLUSIVE AND
MOST RESPONSIBLE.
DECISIONS FOR CALIFORNIANS WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES WHO
ARE IN CRISIS.
THE FEEL FREE TO CONTACT US IF
YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR NEED
OUR ASSISTANCE IN ANYWAY THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU DIANA AND TELL MY THE CRYO
YOUR BROTHER.
THE CHIEF PARLIAMENTARIAN HAS
TOLD ME IN. OUR STATE'S HISTORY
ON THE FIRST JOAQUIN WE WERE
ELECTED TO THIS NEW LEGISLATURE.
BUT BUT BUT BUT. I WILL HE MIGHT
BE FOLLOWING YOU.
HAPPY TO GRADUALLY SOME FUN.
NEXT I'D LIKE TO HEAR FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE KNOW
THEY'LL PLEASE.
SONYA PADDICK ILIO. M. AS HAS
BEEN ALLUDED TO BY THE PREVIOUS
SPEAKERS.
.
THE STATE MAY VERY WELL HAVE TO
CONSIDER WHAT FUTURE WHAT WHAT
SERVICES ARE NEEDED IN THE
FUTURE BEYOND WHAT'S ALREADY
BEEN APPROVED AND.
.
FIVE FUNDS HAVE BEEN
APPROPRIATED FOR.
SO TO THIS AND WE NOTE THAT IN
LAST YEAR'S TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE.
SHEET THAT THE DEPARTMENT IS
REQUIRED TO PROVIDE QUARTERLY
UPDATES TO LEGISLATIVE STAFF.
ON THE DEVELOPMENT OF THE
COMMUNITY BASED.
SAFETY NET AND CRISIS SERVICES.
WE SUGGESTED THAT THE
LEGISLATURE MAY WANT REQUEST
SOME ADDITIONAL SUBVERT MEAN
SPECIFIC INFORMATION TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND WHETHER THE. CURRENT
SERVICES THAT ARE PLANNED ARE
GOING TO BE ADEQUATE WHETHER
THEY'RE REALLY FEELING THE NEED
AND WHAT.
AND AND GIVE THE LEGISLATURE
SORT OF INSIGHT INTO WHAT MIGHT
BE NEEDED IN THE FUTURE.
WE PROVIDED SOME EXAMPLES THAT
ARE IN THE AGENDA SUCH AS HOW
OFTEN THE MOBILE CRISIS UNITS
ARE ENGAGED ARM HOW OFTEN THE
SAFETY NETS TO HOMES REACH
CAPACITY. HOW DDS IS
COORDINATING WITH REGIONAL
CENTERS?
AND.
MORE INFORMATION ABOUT HOW MANY
INDIVIDUALS GET PLACED IN MORE
RESTRICTIVE SETTINGS AS MS
BLACKMAR. SPOKE ABOUT.
AND WE DO WANT TO NOTE HOWEVER
THAT.
THE DEPARTMENT IN THE IN THE
LAST MEETING OF THE COMMUNITY
SUPPORTS AND SAFETY NETWORK
GROUP THAT'S PART OF THE DS TASK
FORCE THE DEPARTMENT DID
PROVIDE.
A LOT OF A FAIRLY DETAILED
INFORMATION ABOUT SOME OF THESE
ISSUES AND WERE WILLING TO WORK
WITH STAKEHOLDERS ON SPECIFIC
REQUESTS FOR INFORMATION.
NEVERTHELESS THE LEGISLATURE
MAY WANT TO FORMALIZE.
SOME OF THESE INFORMATION
REQUESTS THE DEPARTMENT.
DEPARTMENT FUNDS.
JACOB I'M DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
WE'RE HAPPY TO WORK WITH YOUR
STAFF GO LOOK AT WHAT ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION CAN PROVIDE DURING
THE QUARTERLY BRIEFINGS TO MAKE
THAT BENEFICIAL FOR ALL
PARTICIPANTS  WE PREFER TO
STAY AWAY FROM SOLANO. PORTING
LANGUAGE BUT AGAIN WE'RE HAPPY
TO WORK WITH YOUR STAFF TO SEE
WHAT WE CAN PROVIDE DURING THE
CORD BRIEFINGS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT WILL TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT ON ISSUE THREE.
AARON CARRUTHERS EXECUTRIX OF
THE STATE COUNCIL ON
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
RISING IN SUPPORT OF THE
TESTIMONY FROM THE DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA RELATED TO
ASSESSING THE SAFETY NET ARMED
SERVICES. AND CAPACITY AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY THE GAPS OF THE COW
THE STATE COUNCIL THINKS IN A
VERY EFFECTIVE STRATEGY ARE THE
MOBILE CRISIS UNITS.
AND WANTS TO BE SURE THAT AS THE
STATE'S DEPARTMENT OF
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES HAS
SOME OF THESE AND REGIONAL
CENTERS HAVE SOME OF THESE. THAT
WE INCORPORATE THOSE INTO
UNDERSTANDING THE COMPLETE
PICTURE OF SERVICES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
ANY FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENT ON
ISSUE THREE.
YEAH HI MY NAME IS PHILBIN A AND
I'M THE DIRECTOR OF THE LOCAL
REGIONAL CENTER HERE IN
SACRAMENTO WE SERVE.
ABOUT TWENTY THREE THOUSAND
FOLKS AND.
.
HAVE BEEN REALLY BIG PARTNERS I
THINK WITH THAT WITH OTHER
REGIONAL CENTERS IN WITH THE
DEPARTMENT IN THAT.
HELPING PEOPLE LEAVE THE
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS WHICH HAS
REALLY BEEN ONE OF THE THE
GREAT.
GREAT PROJECTS THAT I'VE BEEN
ABLE TO WORK ON IN MY LIFE. BUT
BIRD WE'RE NEARING THE END AT
OUR REGIONAL CENTER WERE DOWN TO
TEN PEOPLE AT HOME A
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER I MEAN THAT
IS.
THAT IS AN AMAZING DAY TO BE AT.
BUT THAT DOESN'T MEAN THAT WE
DON'T STILL HAVE A LOT OF FOLKS
WITH.
THE I MEAN THE SAME NEEDS AS THE
PEOPLE WHO WERE COMING OUT OF
THEIR WHO ARE BEING INCREDIBLY
WELL TAKEN CARE OF FROM WHAT I
CAN SEE.
BUT THE EXCITING THING IS WHAT
WE'VE LEARNED.
FROM THE DEVELOPMENT OF OF
SERVICES INCLUDING MOBILE CRISIS
SERVICES AND OTHER TYPES OF
SERVICES FROM OUR DEVELOPMENTAL
CENTER EXPERIENCE I THINK WE GET
TO FINALLY. NOT HAVE TO ALWAYS
WORRY ABOUT TAKING PEOPLE OUT OF
THE DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS AND
WE'RE GOING TO BE ABLE TO SPEND
THAT MONEY IN THE COMMUNITY AND
THERE ARE NEW FUNDS AS WE'VE
HEARD. THAT ARE BECOMING COMING
FORWARD FOR THE DEVELOPMENT OF
COMMUNITY RESOURCES AND.
I KNOW THAT MANY OF US ARE GOING
TO BE.
FIGHTING HARD ON BEHALF OF THE
FOLKS WHO FIND THEMSELVES
OCCASIONALLY AND REALLY SERIOUS
CRISIS SITUATIONS SANTA.
WE'VE LEARNED HOW HOW TO HELP
PEOPLE WE REALLY HAVE AN
ENHANCED BEHAVIORAL. SUPPORT
HOMES ARE ONE WAY THAT PEOPLE
DON'T GET KICKED OUT ZERO.
ZERO REJECTION OPTIONS ARE CLOSE
TO ZERO REJECTION OPTIONS I
THINK ARE REALLY IMPORTANT TO
OUR FOLKS SO. I WANT TO THANK
THE DEPARTMENT FOR THEIR THEIR
LEADERSHIP HERE AND ADD MORE
CERTAINLY HAPPY TO BE PART OF
THE TEAM THAT'S GONNA.
BRING THIS AROUND TEN AND HELP
FOLKS IN CRISIS.
THANK YOU SIR OKAY.
SEEING NO FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENT
ON BRING IT UP TO THE DYESS MANY
QUESTIONS WE MAY HAVE.
SEEING NONE. REGARDING THE ONLY
OWES SUGGESTION ON OVERSIGHT I'M
INTERESTED IN FORMALIZING THE
INFORMATION REQUESTED ON SAFETY
NET THAT THE LA O. HAS
SUGGESTED.
CAN I ASK FOR THE ELIOT TO
ASSIST IN THE DEVELOPMENT OF
DRAFT SUPPLEMENTAL REPORTING
LANGUAGE. THAT THE SUBCOMMITTEE
COMMITTEE MAY CONSIDER WHEN WE
TAKE UP THE MAY REVISION. FOR
THE DEPARTMENT OF DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES.
AND THEN SECONDLY I WANT TO
THANK THE DEPARTMENT FOR
PROVIDING SOME INITIAL FEEDBACK
ON WHAT ADVOCATES HAVE RAISED.
AND SPECIFIC SUGGESTIONS FROM DR
SEE I'D LIKE TO ASK THE
DEPARTMENTS TO PLEASE WORK WITH
THE SUBCOMMITTEE STAFF.
TO FOLLOW UP ON THESE IN MORE
DEPTH IN PREPARATION FOR OUR
WORK IN MAY AND JUNE.
WITH THAT WE WILL HOLD ISSUE
THREE OPEN AND MOVE ON TO ISSUE
FIVE.
EXCUSE ME I NOW SEE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LACKEY HERE WERE ACTUALLY
GOING TO TAKE ISSUE TWELVE UP.
AT THIS MOMENT
.
WHEN YOU'RE READY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER.
OKAY WELL THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS REALLY APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ACTUALLY. BE HERE
TODAY TO PRESENT IDEAS THAT
COULD HELP THE OF THE DEPARTMENT
OF DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES.
IDENTIFYING REPORT SERVICE GAPS
FOR INDIVIDUALS WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES.
EVER SINCE I BEGAN MY CAREER AS
A SPECIAL ED TEACHER.
I'VE BEEN PASSION ABOUT HOW WE
CAN BETTER SERVE THE NEEDS OF
INDIVIDUALS PUT.
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES.
CURRENTLY DDS COLLECTION REPORTS
A GREAT DEAL OF INFORMATION
ABOUT CONSUMERS SUCH AS CASELOAD
AGE.
QUALIFYING DIAGNOSIS.
RAGE I'M SORRY RACE ETHNICITY.
LANGUAGE METAPHYSICAL HEALTH
STATUS
AND REGION AND MANGA AMONG OTHER
THINGS.
DDS ALSO HAS INFORMATION ABOUT
VENDORS SUCH AS THE NUMBER
PROVIDERS WITH EACH SERVICE
CATEGORY.
AMOUNT OF EXPENDITURES BY VENDOR
AND THEIR LOCATION.
WHAT SEEMS TO BE MISSING IS A
CLEAR AND EASILY REPORT OF A
LINK BETWEEN THE TWO?
WHICH IS NEEDED TO IDENTIFY
SERVICE GAPS
FOR EXAMPLE.
WE DO NOT KNOW WHAT SERVICE
CATEGORIES HAVE PROBLEMS WITH
DTS CLIENTS OBTAINING ACCESS TO
SERVICES. NOR DO WE HAVE DATA TO
KNOW WHICH REGIONS HAVE PROBLEMS
WITH ACCESS.
IN MY AREA ACCESS TO APPROPRIATE
TRANSPORTATION IS SHE IS A
SIGNIFICANT ISSUE.
WITHOUT DOUBT WE CANNOT IDENTIFY
THE ROOT CAUSE OF SERVICE CAPS.
A GOOD FIRST STEP IN BETTER
UNDERSTANDING THE MISSING LINK
BETWEEN DOUBT ABOUT CONSUMERS
AND VENDORS. WOULD BE FOR
STATUTES.
TO DIRECT THE CONVENING OF A
WORKGROUP COMPROMISED OF DDS
STAFF LEGISLATIVE STAFF.
REGIONAL CENTER STAFF AND
STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING SERVICE
PROVIDERS CONSUMERS AND
FAMILIES.
THE WORKGROUP WOULD DEVELOP A
PLAN FOR IMPROVING DDS DATA
COLLECTION.
PROCESSES IN AN EFFORT TO BETTER
IDENTIFY QUANTIFY SERVICE GAPS
AT THE ROOT CAUSES.
THE OVERALL OBJECTIVE WOULD BE
TO MORE EFFECTIVELY USE DATA TO
INFORM THE ADMINISTRATION A
SISTER LEGISLATIVE DECISION
MAKING ABOUT FUNDING.
THIS GROUP COULD WORK IN CONCERT
WITH THE A DS TASK FORCE.
HOWEVER THE SCOPE OF THIS NEW
WORKGROUP WOULD BE BROADER
NATURE.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
PRESENTED DAY AND I HOPE THE
COMMITTEE WILL CONSIDER THIS
REQUEST GO FORWARD THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER NEXT WE'LL HEAR
FROM THE DIRECTOR IF YOU HAVE
ANY COMMENTS OR. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE ANOTHER.
THOUGHT I'D JUST LIKE TO SAY
THAT.
WITH THE THE WORK OF THE DS
TASK FORCE AND AND CERTAINLY
THE.
THINGS THAT WE'VE HEARD TODAY
AS FAR AS ASSESSING THE GAPS IN
SERVICES IT'S AN AREA THAT WE
CONTINUE TO.
WELCOME INPUT AND.
WELCOME DISCUSSION THANK YOU.
YOU.
SONYA PARTICULARLY.
THIS IS AN ISSUE ON WHICH WE
AGREE WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LACKEY.
IT'S.
ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE TO LINK
WHAT WE KNOW ABOUT CONSUMERS.
WITH WHAT WE KNOW ABOUT SERVICE
PROVIDERS TO MORE SYSTEMATICALLY
AND OBJECTIVELY IDENTIFY GAPS IN
RELATED UNMET FUNDING
REQUIREMENTS.
A LOT OF THE CURRENT EFFORTS
WHILE THEY HAVE A LOT OF MERIT
AND REMAIN VERY IMPORTANT. THEIR
MORE.
ANECDOTAL AND DEPENDED ON WHO
SPEAKS UP.
IT WE THINK IT WOULD BE REALLY
IMPORTANT TO HAVE A WAY TO
ADDRESS THESE SERVICE GAPS ON
I'M.
IN A MORE SYSTEMATIC WAY THERE
MAY BE.
THE OPPORTUNITY TO LOOK AT SOME
IN OF ABOUT. WAYS TO.
UMKC TO GATHER AND COMPILE THEM
DATA FOR THIS EFFORT THIS WOULD
REALLY I THINK AID BOTH STRIPPED
THE DEPARTMENT AND THE
LEGISLATURE IN.
MAKING SPENDING DECISIONS.
COULD YOU.
THE PUBLIC COMMENT ON THE ISSUE
TWELFTH.
AS CHAIR MEMBERS SAID RECALLING
TRIPS AND ARC ASSOCIATION
REGIONAL CENTER AGENCIES WHO
WANT THANK MISTER LACKEY AGAIN
FOR SINCERE ATTEMPT TO TRY TO
HELP. IN GATHERING IMPORTANT
DATA FOR US TO FILL A FIGURE OUT
OUR AND UNMET NEEDS AND SERVICE
GAPS IN THE SYSTEM AND LOOK FOR
TO WORK WITH THE DEPARTMENT MIST
MISTER LACKEY THIS. COMMITTEE IN
THE LEGISLATURE AND NOT PURSUING
THIS INITIATIVE THANK YOU THANK
YOU SIR.
HI MICHELLE HEIGHT OF A BOARD
CERTIFIED BEHAVIOR ANALYSTS
PROVIDER AND A PARENT AND I
WOULD JUST LIKE TO THANK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LACKEY FOR
BRINGING THIS. I'M TO THE
COMMITTEE'S ATTENTION AND BEING
SUCH A VOCAL ADVOCATE FOR THE
DISABILITY COMMUNITY HAS REALLY
APPRECIATE IT AND I HOPE THAT
YOU CONSIDER THE REQUEST THANK
YOU. BECAME.
PHONE THIS CHAIR MEMBERS JORDAN
TO THE OUR CAN YOU SEE P.. AGAIN
JUST WANNA.
ACKNOWLEDGED SINCERITY AND THE
PASSION THAT ASSUMING LIKE T'S
HAD FOR THIS COMMITTEE FOR A
LONG TIME AND APPRECIATE HIS
PROPOSAL AND HOW OPPRESSION IT
IS CONSIDERING MANY OF THE
DISCUSSIONS WE'VE HAD TODAY
ABOUT IT ADDRESS THE NEEDS WHAT
ARE THE NEEDS AND LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH. THE DEPARTMENT
AND THE LEGISLATURE IN DOING SO
THANK THANK YOU.
HELLO KEVIN WRATH MANOS CRA IT'S
YES A LAN.
WE'VE ADVOCATED FOR SOMETHING
LIKE THIS FOR A SEVERAL YEARS AT
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER LACKEY
FOR YOUR CONCERN A WE BELIEVE
THAT CREATING. A DATABASE OF
VENDORS.
IS THE WAY TO GO WE HOPE THAT.
THE DEPARTMENT
WILL A LOOK AT THIS AD THAT
WOULD AT THAT WOULD ADDRESS THE
ISSUES BUT IT WOULD ALSO
ADDRESS.
.
WHAT WHAT SERVICES AND NEED TO
BE DEVELOPED IN WHICH AREAS
BECAUSE YOU COULD JUST SAY FOR
EACH FOR EACH EACH VENDOR COULD
HAVE A SMALL HOME PAGES SAY?
THIS IS THE SERVICES WE PROVIDE
THESE ARE THE. THESE ARE THE
CERTAINTIES OF THE SERVICE
BECAUSE THAT WERE ACCEPTING NEW
CLIENTS ON. THESE OF THE
CULTURAL COMPETENCIES THAT WE
HAVE THESE OF THE LANGUAGES THAT
WE SPEAK FOR THE SERVICES WE
COULD WE COULD ADDRESS THAT POS
DISPARITY ISSUE. AND A LOT OF
OTHER ISSUES TO A VENDOR
DATABASE AND ENHANCE CONSUMER
CHOICES I'VE BEEN A PARENT
CONFERENCES WHERE THEY'VE ASKED
FOR THESE KIND OF THINGS. I'M
ASSUME AND THIS THIS THAT THIS
TECHNOLOGY IS A DECADE OLD SO I
THINK WE CAN DO IT NOW THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU SIR.
PAGE EIGHTEEN CALIFORNIA
DISABILITY SERVICES ASSOCIATION
TO TWENTY THINK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LACKEY FOR BRING THIS ITEM TO
THE TABLE WERE CERTAINLY IN
SUPPORT OF ANY ANY EFFORTS TO
BRING MORE DATA INTO THE SYSTEM
AND WE SPOKE EARLIER ABOUT SOME
THE REACH CHALLENGES WERE FACING
SOME. THANKS MUCH.
SEEING NO FURTHER COMMENT I'LL
BRING IT BACK UP TO THE DYESS
AND SEEING THAT WE HAVE NO
QUESTIONS I WANT TO THANK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LACKEY FOR THIS
PROPOSAL WILL. HOLD THIS ITEM
OPEN TICKET SAYING THAT WE HAVE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER HERE I'D
LIKE TO BRING THEM UP FOR ISSUE
ELEVEN.
NO.
EVEN.
WHEN YOUR INTEREST. MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT FOR YOU TODAY.
IN MY SIX YEARS IS AN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER THIS IS THE FIRST TIME I
PRESENTED BEFORE BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE SO YOU KNOW IT
MEANS SOMETHING TO ME.
THE TOPIC I'M HERE TO DISCUSS IS
ONE THAT REQUIRES THE
COMMITTEE'S CONSIDERATION IN THE
LEGISLATURE'S ACTION.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST A
REASONABLE APPROPRIATION OF FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS TO EXPAND
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES FOR
DEVELOPMENTALLY DISABLED
INDIVIDUALS.
WE MUST NOT LEAVE ANYONE BEHIND.
THIS MODEST INVESTMENT WILL HELP
DESERVING INDIVIDUALS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA.
CIVIC COOLEY IT WILL GO TOWARD
IMPLEMENTING COMMUNITY
VOCATIONAL DEVELOPMENT SERVICES.
THAT WILL EMPOWER THOSE WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES TO
ATTAIN BETTER UP EMPLOYMENT.
WE KNOW THAT STEADY EMPLOYMENT
GREATLY ENRICHES ALL OF OUR
LIVES.
INDIVIDUALS IN COMMUNITY WORK
SETTINGS CAN CONFIDENCE AND HAVE
A HIGHER QUALITY OF LIFE.
THEY CONTRIBUTE TO THEIR LOCAL
ECONOMY PAY TAXES AND REYES
RELIED LESS ON. PUBLIC MONEY.
CURRENTLY INDIVIDUALS WITH DD
ARE RESTRICTED IN THEIR
OPPORTUNITIES.
FOUR YEARS AGO THE LEGISLATURE
RECOGNIZED THE MERIT OF
EXTENDING UP IMPLEMENT
OPPORTUNITIES TO INDIVIDUALS
WITH DD ONE AMP APPROVED S. B.
FIVE SEVENTY SEVEN.
UNFORTUNATELY S. B. FIVE SEVENTY
SEVEN WAS NOT IMPLEMENTED DUE TO
PURE BUREAUCRATIC RESTRICTIONS.
EXPERTS WHO FOLLOW ME WILL
EXPLAIN THIS IN DETAIL.
MY COLLEAGUES IN TWENTY THIRTEEN
THE LEGISLATURE CLEARLY STATED
THAT COMPETITIVE EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES
SHALL AND I WILL REPEAT SHALL BE
REGALED IN THE HIGHEST PRIORITY.
FOR INDIVIDUALS WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
REGARDLESS OF THE SEVERITY OF
THEIR DISABILITIES AND THROUGH
THE EMPLOYMENT FIRST POLICY.
WE AND GOVERNOR BROWN NEED TO BE
HELD ACCOUNTABLE TO THE PROMISES
WE MADE THE DD POPULATION.
I'VE ALWAYS SAID PROMISES MADE
SHOULD BE PROMISES KEPT.
WE NEED TO INVEST IN THIS
UNDERSERVED POPULATION.
LET ME TODAY'S WILL SANFORD
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF FUTURES
EXPLORED AND BARRY JORDANIAN
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS DIRECTOR FOR
THE CALIFORNIA'S DISABILITY
SERVICE ASSOCIATION TO ELABORATE
FURTHER ON THIS PROGRAM AND ITS
BENEFITS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION THANK YOU AND
WELCOME TO A BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE.
I'LL BE BACK WITH.
GREAT THAT THAT YOU MISTER CHAIR
BAY JUTTING CDSA THINK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER FOR YOUR
CONSTANT TENSION ON THIS YOU
KNOW AND I'M JUST GONNA TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE BACKSTORY
OF THESE COMMUNITIES VOCATIONAL
DEVELOPMENT SERVICES AS THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TOUCHED ON THIS
WITH A PILOT PROGRAM. THAT WAS
CHAPTER DONE SIGNED BACK IN TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN THAT ONE TENER
PAVLEY WAS HERE UNFORTUNATELY
WAS NEVER IMPLEMENTED.
BECAUSE AS A PILOT PROGRAM IT
WASN'T ELIGIBLE FOR EACH CBS
WEAVER FUNDING.
I BECAUSE IT WASNT AVAILABLE
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
UP AT WHEN WE WHEN WE DISCOVER
THAT LAST YEAR WE APPROACH THEM
WITH MEMBER FRAZIER GRACIOUSLY
OFFER OFFER TO AUTHOR AB SIXTY
NO SEVEN WHICH GOT THROUGH THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS WITH
ABSOLUTE AL UNIBODY NO NO VOTES
GOT TO THE GOVERNOR'S DESK.
BEFORE HE VETOED IT SAYING WELL
IT HAS MERIT THIS BELONGS IN THE
BUDGET DISCUSSION SO HERE WE ARE
FOR COMPLETE WE'RE BACK AND AT
AT THIS POINT WHERE WE'RE
REALLY.
.
LOOKING TO
EXPAND AS AS THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SAID EXPLAINABLE EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES IN SOME OF THE PRE
EMPLOYMENT. OF VOCATIONAL
SERVICES THAT PEOPLE NEED IN
ORDER TO GET INTO COMPETITIVE
INTEGRATE EMPLOYMENT.
I LEAVE IT TO WILL TO DESCRIBE
SOME OF THE PARTICULARS BUT
ULTIMATELY IT'S ABOUT GIVING
PEOPLE THE OPPORTUNITY. TO
ACHIEVE COMPETITIVE INNOVATIVE
EQUIPMENT AND FOR THOSE IN
CERTAIN SETTINGS TO START
TRANSITION INTO MORE COMPETITIVE
IMMIGRANT EMPLOYMENT.
GOTTA GET THE EASY PART OF IT
WILL SAN FOR WHAT FEATURES
EXPLORED.
THE GOAL OF THIS RELEASE OF
FIGURE OUT A WAY THAT WE CAN DO
ACT WITH THE LEGISLATURE
OFFERED.
THREE B. X. TWO ONE WHAT'S PAID
INTERNSHIP PROGRAM WHICH AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR FOLKS TO BE PAID
WALLY DO INTERNSHIPS IN THE
COMMUNITY. MANY DAYS SERVICES
WANT TO DO THAT BUT THIRD OF ONE
TO THREE ONE TO FOUR ONE SIX
RATIO. THEY HAVE NO WAY TO STAFF
ITS SUPPORT BESTTHIS OPTION
WOULD PROVIDE SOMEONE WANTS
SERVICES THAT COULD BE USED TO
HELP SUPPORT PEOPLE. GET OUT IN
THE COMMUNITY DO THE PAGAN
WORSHIP GAIN THAT VOCATIONAL
EXPERIENCE SO THAT WAS A BIG
PART OF WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO.
BETTER AS WE KNOW THAT THE HOME
AND COMMUNITY BASED SETTINGS
RULES COMING.
WE NEED TO FIND MORE WAYS
INTEGRATOR FOLKS INTO THE
COMMUNITY THIS TO BE ANOTHER WAY
TO HELP PROGRAM SORT OF FIND
DIFFERENT WAYS TO GET PEOPLE
INVOLVED AND ACTIVE IN THE
COMMUNITY IDEAL INDEPENDENT
IMPLEMENT. THAT MAYBE OTHER
OPPORTUNITIES ALSO THE OTHER
PIECE WE PUT INTO THIS IS WE
KNOW THAT WORK ACTIVITYPROGRAMS
IS A SERVICE. ARE CLEARLY IN THE
CROSSHAIRS OF SEGREGATED
SERVICES THAT WILL PROBABLY GO
AWAY.
THESE ARE FOLKS WHO WANT TO WORK
WHO HAVE BEEN WORKING MANY FOR
THIRTY FORTY YEARS. BUT WE NEED
A WAY TO HELP THEM GET ACROSS
THE BARRIER.
AND WHAT OUR OPTIONS ARE THERE'S
WE ACTUALLY PROPOSED AT TAYLOR
DAYS SERVICE AS NOT IN LIEU OF
SERVICES BUT IT'S CONJUNCTION ON
A SMALL SCALE TO HELP THEM MOVE
TO COMPETITIVE NB IMPLEMENTS A
LEADING TO MORE SEGREGATED
SHELTERED EMPLOYMENT. TO MORE
COMMUNITY BASED EMPLOYMENT SO IS
REALLY THE FOCUS IS HOW CAN WE
MOVE PEOPLE TO TO HAVE THOSE
OPPORTUNITIES CROSS THE REALLY
LARGE GAP FROM A. SEGREGATED
SETTING TO A MUCH MORE COMMUNITY
BASED SETTING.
WITHOUT A LOT OF SUPPORT OPTION
SO THAT WAS REALLY THE FOCUS OF
THE EFFORT AND WE AGAIN THANK
SOMEONE ARE FRAZIER BOTH AUTHOR
BILL LAST AND THEN BRING IT
BACK.
THE BUDGET PROCESS.
THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL HEAR FROM
THE CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR YOU
HAVE A COMMENT FOLLOWED BY LEN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. ON WE
APPRECIATE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRASIER'S UP PROPOSAL AND AS WAS
NOTED.
THE ADMINISTRATION. DOES
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THESE SERVICES
HAVE MERIT.
HOWEVER WE DO HAVE SOME CONCERNS
WITH THE PROPOSED DOLLAR AMOUNT.
AND WHEN THE DEPARTMENT DID ITS
ANALYSIS OF AB SIXTY NO SEVEN NO
QUESTION HARD NUMBERS WERE
PROBABLY ON THE HIGH SIDE
THERE'S NO QUESTION ABOUT THAT.
BUT I THINK WE HAVE SOME
CONCERNS THAT THIS FIVE MILLION
DOLLAR ESTIMATE MAYBE ON THE LOW
SIDE.
ON WE ITS IT FOCUSES ON TAYLOR
DAY SERVICES AS.
BUT MR SANFORD MENTIONED AND.
.
ONLY EIGHT REGIONAL CENTERS USE
THOSE SERVICES SO WE DO HAVE
SOME CONCERNS THAT THIS NUMBER
MAY BE LOW. AND THAT. THE
PROBLEM THAT IT COULD CREATE IS
THAT BECAUSE.
OUR SERVICES ARE PART OF AN
ENTITLEMENT PROGRAM.
IF MORE IF A IF A NUMBER IS LOW
IT COULD CREATE PROBLEMS DOWN
THE ROAD.
IS THERE A MORE ACCURATE NUMBER
THAT YOU WOULD RECOMMEND THAT.
WOULD BE. AND WE DON'T HAVE A
REVISED ESTIMATE AT THIS POINT
NOW.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE HELLO.
NOW WILL TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT ON
ISSUE ELEVEN.
MISTER CHAIRMAN BURSERA CRAWLING
TRIPS AND ARC ASSOCIATION
REGIONAL CENTER AGENCIES SO
WE'RE HERE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
PROPOSAL WE SUPPORTED S. B. FIVE
SEVENTY SEVEN BY. SENATOR
PAPILLAE IN AB SIXTY NO SEVEN BY
MISTER FRAZIER HAND OF SUPPORT
THIS.
EFFORT ALSO WANNA CONGRATULATE
MISTER FRAZIER OF BECOMING THE
CHAIR OF THE SENATE SUES ME
SIMPLY SELECT COMMITTEE ON.
INTELLECTUAL AND DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES WHAT FOR TO WORK
WITH YOU SIR THEN MOVE INTO OUR
SYSTEM FORWARD.
AARON CARRUTHERS EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE STATE COUNCIL ON
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES ALSO
GONNA CONGRATULATE THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FOR BEING CHAIR OF THE
SENATE'S THE ASSEMBLY SELECT
COMMITTEE A INTELLECTUAL
DEVELOPMENT DISABILITIES. WE
KEEP TRYING YOUR PROMOTION IT
IS.
THAT THE CROWDS WRITTEN FOR YOU
HERE.
I'M NOT HERE TO PROMOTION IS NOT
OF EMOTION OKAY IT'S NOW.
A RISING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS PROPOSAL THERE TO BE REALLY
CLEAR ABOUT WHAT'S BEING ASKED.
IS THAT IT'S ABOUT DISCOVERY
WHAT'S DISCOVERY DISCOVERY IS
THE PROCESS OF SAYING IT LIKE A
JOB WOULD YOU LIKE TO DO.
THAT PROCESS ACTUALLY ISN'T
REIMBURSABLE RIGHT NOW WHICH IS
SHOCKING.
SO IF THE DEPARTMENT BELIEVES
MORE MONEY SHOULD GO FOR THIS
THAN THIS COUNCIL SUPPORT THAT
TOO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR.
NOT TALL.
EVELYN I WILL HAVE SOME
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA I'M
WE SUPPORT THE PROPOSAL IN
CONCEPT WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE PROPONENTS TO
FULLY UNDERSTAND. NOT ONLY THE
METHODOLOGY BUT. THE WHOLE
CONCEPT OF KERR EXPLORATION WITH
THE FOCUS REALLY ON COMPETITIVE
INTEGRATED EMPLOYMENT SO WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU JUST
TO FIGURE OUT WHAT THE THE
METHODOLOGY OF THE PROPOSAL. AND
THE SPECIFICS THANK YOU THANK
YOU MA'AM.
CARLENE HOLDEN ONCE AGAIN WITH
EASTER SEALS.
WE LOVE.
CUSTOMIZED TAILORED GAY WE LOVE
THE EXPLORATION AND DISCOVERY IT
SO THE RIGHT THING TO DO WE
CELEBRATED WITH FRAN PAVLEY AS
WE WERE GETTING THAT MOVING
THROUGH WE YEAH BEHIND AGAIN THE
FULL LAST YEAR. WE REALLY LOOK
FORWARD BEING ABLE TO CELEBRATE
THIS BEING A REALITY SO WE LOOK
FORWARD TO THE SUPPORT YOU GET
TO THE BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU.
JOINT LINDSAY WITH THE ARE CAN
YOU SEE P. IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SIR.
SEEING NO FURTHER COMMENT PUBLIC
COMMENT ON BRING IT UP TO THE
DYESS FOR ANY COMMENTS.
SEEING NON.
I WOULD LIKE FOR THE DEPARTMENT
TO PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
TO ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER ABOUT
WHAT A CORRECT NUMBER WOULD BE
PRIOR TO THAT MAY REVISION. SO
THAT WE MAY MAKE SURE WE HAVE
THE APPROPRIATE INFORMATION IN
FRONT OF US.
WITH THAT WE WILL HOLD ISSUE
ELEVEN OPEN AND THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER FOR
BRINGING THANK FOR CONSIDERATION
PATRICIA THINK.
WITH THAT WE WILL MOVE ON TO
ISSUE FIVE
JUST CONFIRMING RUN ISSUE FIVE.
CORRECT.
WE WILL NOW GO SEQUENTIALLY.
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR LIKE TO INTRODUCE
BRIAN WHEN FILLED.
THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF A
COMMUNITY SERVICES DIVISION THAT
WILL PROVIDE A BRIEF OVERVIEW
FOR YOU. THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING I'LL PROVIDE YOU
WITH AN OVERVIEW OF THE
DEPARTMENTS OVERSIGHT OF
DISPARITY FUNDING SO THAT AB EX
TWO ONE PROVIDES THE DEPARTMENT
WITH THE METHOD ELEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS.
CHIU.
AWARD CHIU A REGIONAL CENTERS
AND THIS YEAR THAT WAS EXPANDED
TO ALSO INCLUDE CANADA BASED
ORGANIZATIONS.
FOR I PROPOSALS THAT THEY SUBMIT
TO THE DEPARTMENT THAT THEY
IMPLEMENT AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
WITHIN EACH REGIONAL CENTER
CATCHMENT AREA. TO ADDRESS
DISPARITIES THAT STATE THAT ARE
IN EACH OF THEIR AREAS.
SO LAST YOU WE APPROVE NINETY
SIX PROPOSALS FROM REGIONAL
CENTERS. AND AS I MENTIONED
BEFORE THIS YEAR IT WAS THAT
EXPANDED TO INCLUDE COMMITTEE
BASED ORGANIZATIONS. THAT
APARTMENT RECEIVED.
HUNDRED AND FORTY PROPOSALS
TOTALING OVER TWENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS AND WE WERE ABLE
TO APPROVE SIXTY SIX OF THOSE
PROPOSALS THIRTY FIVE OF THOSE
WENT TO JUNIOR. COMMITTEE BASED
ORGANIZATIONS AND THIRTY ONE OF
AWARDS WERE FOR REGIONAL CENTERS
TWENTY FOUR OF THOSE BEING FOR
CONTINUING PROJECTS FROM FISCAL
YEAR SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN.
THE DEPARTMENT HAS SCORED THE
PROPOSAL'S WITH THAT TEAM OF
HAVE INDIVIDUALS WHO USE THAT
THAT APART AND. DEPARTMENT OF
REHABILITATION WAS REPRESENTED
AND DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA
WAS ALSO REPRESENTED AND SCORING
THE PROPOSALS. AND FOR THE
DEPARTMENT.
I'D ALSO LIKE TO POINT OUT THAT
WE ARE CURRENTLY IN THE PROCESS
OF WORKING WITH EACH OF THE
ENTITIES UPON THE MEASURES THAT
WILL BE USED TO. TO.
LOOK AT THE PROGRESS AT EACH OF
THESE PROPOSALS MAKES AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL SENSE AT SOME OF THE
PROS PROPOSALS ARE THINGS LIKE
OUTREACH THE LOCAL COMMUNITY.
TRAINING AND PROMO TORAS MODELS
WE'RE WORKING WITH THOSE
ORGANIZATIONS TO DETERMINE HOW
THEY WILL.
LOOK AT SUCCESS OF THESE
PROJECTS.
I'D ALSO LIKE TO POINT OUT THAT
THE SENATE HUMAN SERVICES
COMMITTEE LAST YEAR REQUESTED
THAT THE DEPARTMENT PREPARE A
PLAN ON HOW IT WOULD ADDRESS
DISPARITIES. AND TO THE
DEPARTMENT HAS BEEN WORKING WITH
STAKEHOLDERS CAN'T ON THE
OUTCOMES THAT DEPARTMENT WILL
USE TO DETERMINE THE PROGRESS IS
BEING MADE. AND KEY AREAS WITHIN
THE PURCHASE OF REGIONAL CENTER
SERVICES.
SO WITH THAT.
.
HOW STOP WITH DISPARITIES?
THANK YOU. TIME THAT RESPITE.
PLEASE.
SO I IN TWO THOUSAND AND NINE
DURING THE BUDGET CRISIS
ONE OF THE COST SAVING MEASURES
WAS A CAP ON THE AMOUNT OF REST
BUT THE REGION CENTER COULD
PURCHASE AT NINETY HOURS OF IN
HOME RESPITE PER QUARTER. AND
TWENTY ONE DAYS OF OUT OF HOME
RESPITE PER YEAR.
DOT CAP IN STATUTE ALSO HAD AN
EXCEPTIONS PROCESS OR A.
KEY SO THAT IF AN INDIVIDUAL
NEEDED ADDITIONAL RESPITE THE
REGIONAL CENTER COULD APPROVE
IT.
LAST YEAR TRAILER THE LANGUAGE
LIFTED THE CAP ON RESPITE AND
SO.
I HAD FACT IN JANUARY FIRST OF
THIS YEAR THAT CAPITAL EXISTS IN
STATUTE.
IN AUGUST OF TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN THE DEPARTMENT ISSUED
A DIRECTIVE TO REGIONAL CENTERS
TO.
ASKED THEM TO CONDUCT OUTREACH
TO THEIR LOCAL COMMUNITIES TO
INFORM THEIR COMMUNITIES ABOUT
THIS LEFT OF THE RESPITE CAP AND
TO PAY PARTICULAR ATTENTION TO
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO. MIGHT NOT
TYPICALLY AVAIL THEMSELVES OF
REGIONAL CENTER SERVICES
WE ALSO REQUESTED THE REGIONAL
CENTERS REVISED THE PURCHASE OF
SERVICE POLICIES.
TO REFLECT THIS CHANGE IN
STATUTE REGIONAL CENTERS USED
THEIR POLICIES TO PROVIDE SOME
PRIDE PARAMETERS AROUND THE
SERVICES THAT THEY PROVIDE.
SAID DEPARTMENT IS CURRENTLY
REVIEWING REGIONAL CENTERS
PURCHASE OF SERVICE POLICIES AND
THE LAW REQUIRES THE DEPARTMENT
TO APPROVE THOSE POLICIES PRIOR
TO IMPLEMENTATION.
THAT POLICIES MUST INCLUDE AND
EXCEPTIONS PROCESS SO THAT IF
THERE ARE ARE EXCEPTIONAL
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT HOW FALL
OUTSIDE OF THOSE PARAMETERS THAT
THE REGIONAL CENTER HAS
ESTABLISHED. THAT THROUGH THE
PLANNING TEAM PROCESS THE
REGIONAL CENTER WILL WILL
CONSIDER THOSE EXCEPTIONAL
CIRCUMSTANCES AND CAN GRANT.
EXCEPTIONS TO ADD THE AMOUNT OF
HOUSE AND HOME OR OUT OF A
RESTAURANT THAT THEY PROVIDE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR.
NEXT WE WILL HEAR FROM.
.
THAT KATIE HORNBERGER.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND AND AS I
RECOGNIZE THE TIME I WILL TALK
FAST WHICH I'M GOOD AT. UP
ASSUME WE REALLY APPRECIATE THE
DEPARTMENT'S EFFORTS
ON IN BOTH ON ENSURING THAT
MEASURABLE OUTCOMES.
OR ACHIEVED ON I'M AND THINK
THAT THEY'RE VERY MUCH ON THE
RIGHT TRACK IN THAT REGARD I
WOULD ALSO SAY THAT WE WOULD
LIKE TO SEE. THOSE ON MEASURES
PUBLICLY ON STATED IN A PUBLIC
FORUM DOWN IN A WAY THAT WE CAN
BOTH FOUND REPLICATE THINGS THAT
WORK AND STOP DOING AND STOP
SPENDING MONEY ON THINGS THAT
DON'T. ANSWER PROVIDING THAT IN
A PUBLIC FORUM I THINK IS AN
IMPORTANT STEP TOWARD THAT.
IN TERMS OF SPENT ON ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT.
WE HAVE DISCOVERED IN THE
COURSE OF ARE ADVOCACY IS THAT
IN ADDITION TO PURCHASE OF
SERVICE POLICIES. REGIONAL
CENTERS ALSO HAVE INTERNAL
PROTOCOLS ARE GUIDELINES THAT
THEIR SERVICE COORDINATORS USED
TO MAKE DECISIONS PARTICULARLY
AROUND RESPITE. FROM WE HAVE
SEEN A FEW OF THOSE PROTOCOLS
HOWEVER IT SOME REGIONAL CENTERS
WHEN WE'VE ASK FOR THEM THEY
HAVE REFUSED TO GIVE THEM TO US
ON. STATING THAT THEY ARE NOT
REQUIRED TO UNDER ANY LAW.
AND.
I WOULD ENCOURAGE ON THE
DEPARTMENT ON AND THE
LEGISLATURE TO LOOK ALSO AT
THOSE POLICY IT VIA PROTOCOLS
AND GUIDELINES NOT JUST THE
PURCHASE OF SERVICE POLICIES. ON
MANY OF THEM.
STILL CONTAIN A A CAP AND ON
THE.
CONTAIN AN ASSESSMENT TOOL THAT
DON IS NOT NECESSARILY MADE ON
PUBLIC SO FAMILIES CANNOT AVAIL
THEMSELVES OF THAT TOOL TO
BETTER PREPARE FOR THAT PLANNING
PROCESS.
BOB LIKE. REALLY ON ENCOURAGE
EVERYONE TO HAVE THOSE ON
PROCEDURES MADE PUBLIC ON IN AN
EFFORT TOWARD TRANSPARENCY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. BERMAN A
FINANCE ELLIOTT.
ANY PUBLIC COMMENTS ON THE ISSUE
FIVE.
HELLO IT'S ME AGAIN AND I HAVE
ON OF WEARING MY CALIFORNIA REST
ASSOCIATION HAT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK
YOU FOR MOVING THE CAP. THAT WAS
DEVASTATING.
.
AND.
WE USE TO I MEAN FOR THE CAP WE
GOT.
PROBABLY USED TO GET ABOUT SIXTY
HOURS SEVENTY HOURS.
A MONTH.
FOR CLIENTS HOME IN SO. SO IT'S
IT'S GREAT TO SEE THAT THE
OPPORTUNITIES THERE TO INCREASE
RESPITE SINCE WEST IS SO
EFFECTIVE AND SAVES THE STATE SO
MUCH MONEY IN PROVIDES. SO MUCH
SUPPORT FOR FAMILIES.
A AND THAT AND OF COURSE THE
CLIENTS
THAT WE SERVE.
.
COUPLE THINGS ARE.
WE'D ARM.
WE LIKE WILL CLEAR POLICIES
WOULD LIKE THEM PUBLISHED.
CALIFORNIA REST ASSOCIATION
WOULD LIKE A COPY.
WE LIKE THEM PUBLISHED AS WE
HEAR FROM OUR BY ASSOCIATION
MEMBERS THAT. THAT FAMILIESARE
CONFUSED.
THEY DON'T KNOW ABOUT IT.
AND THIS ISN'T LIKE US THEY'RE
NOT NOBODY'S TRYING TO KEEP A
SECRET RIGHT IT'S JUST WE GOT TO
GET OUR ACT TOGETHER ON THE
STUFF I'M.
AND THEN I'M ONE OF THE WHERE
THE MOST.
.
CONFUSING THINGS
THAT WE'D LIKE CLARIFIED IN WHEN
AS AS THE DEPARTMENT WITH VIEWS
POLICIES IS. IS THERE SOME KIND
OF TRADE OFF YOU KNOW IF YOU
GET.
A BUNCH MORE.
RESPITE YOU CAN'T GET OUT OF
HOME RESPITE.
WE'VE SEEN.
FAMILIES.
WE'VE HEARD JUST ANSWER TOTAL
STUFF THERE'S NOT ENOUGH DATA OF
COURSE BUT I'M WE'VE HEARD
PEOPLE SAY GOSH YOU KNOW NOW WE
CAN'T HAVE ANY OUT OF HOME
RESPITE BECAUSE WE GOT A BUNCH
OF IN HOUSE IN HOME RESPITE.
SO SO JUST TO CLARIFY THAT AND
SO THE PARENTS AND CASE MANAGERS
KNOW THAT TOO.
THAT AND WE WE WE HOPE THAT
INCREASING RESPITE DOESN'T MEAN
IN HOME RESPITE DOESN'T MEAN
DECREASING OUT OF HOME RESPITE.
AND THAT THERE SOME CAP SOME
TOTAL CAP BETWEEN IN HOME IN OUT
OF HOME RESPITE FOR EACH CLIENT.
WE WE DON'T UNDERSTAND THAT TO
BE THE CASE AND WE WOULD
REQUEST.
THAT.
.
BE ON.
THERE BE.
GUIDELINES PUBLISHED GUIDELINES
AND THAT WOULD BE THE GUIDELINES
FOR THE CASE MANAGERS AND THAT
THERE NOT BE.
PUBLIC GUIDELINES AND THEN
SECRET IN HOUSE GUIDELINES
RIGHT.
WHERE WE'RE AT THAT CONTRADICT
OR SOMEHOW SUBVERT THE PUBLIC
GUIDELINES
SO WE LIKE THERE TO BE? NO
PROTOCOLS INSIDE REGIONAL CENTER
FOR CASE MANAGERS EXCEPT THE
PUBLIC GUIDELINES THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU SIR.
JORDAN INTO THE OUR COMMUNITY
PEEING A THREE QUICK THINGS OR
ONE REGARDING THE RESPITE THE
COMMUNITIES INCREDIBLY GRATEFUL
THAT THAT WAS A RESTORED AND WE
pRECORDS LET'S THAT LEGISLATURE.
IN THE NEXT YEAR INTO IN THE
DEPARTMENT TO MAKE SURE THAT
ACTUALLY PEOPLE ARE NOW
UTILIZING IT MORE.
AS IT IS A CRITICAL SERVICE IN
THE COMMUNITY A NUMBER TWO
REGARDING THE RACIAL DISPARITIES
WE HAVE TO CONTINUE AS I KNOW
OTHER CHAIR IN THIS COMMITTEE
WILL TO CONTINUE TO KEEP A CLOSE
EYE ON THAT AND MAKE THAT A TOP
PRIORITY.
WE THE LEGISLATURE HAS APPROVED
A A GOOD CHUNK OF CHANGE FOR
GRANTS TO BOTH THE LAST OF THE
REGIONAL CENTER. AND THIS YEAR
REAL CENTER INCOMING PROVIDERS
TO MAKE A DIFFERENCE TO MAKE AND
IN IN IN MAKING A DENT IN THIS
DISPARITY WE ENCOURAGE
LEGISLATURE TO.
WATCH THAT CLOSELY IS IT
WORKING WHAT ARE THOSE DOLLARS
GOING FOR IT IS ACTUALLY MOVING
THE NEEDLE AND.
THE IT IF NOT THEN LET'S JUST.
FINALLY.
.
REGIONAL CENTERS AND THANKS TO
YOUR REQUIREMENTS REPORT
DISBANDED AT THE RACIAL
PURCHASER PURCHASERS IS BASED
ON.
.
MANY FACTORS INCLUDE RACE AND
ETHNICITY.
HOWEVER IT'S NOT UNIFORM
BETWEEN RITUAL CENTERS AND JUST
IN TERMS OF EVALUATED AND TRYING
TO COMPARE APPLES TO APPLES
MAKES IT DIFFICULT IT WOULD BE
REALLY.
A IT WOULD BE APPRECIATE IF
THERE'S SOME WAY THAT WE CAN
MAKE THAT MORE UNIFORM BETWEEN
ALL THE UNIFORM. ALL REGIONAL
CENTERS REPORTING UP SPECIFIC TO
THAT THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON EVENING.
MY NAME IS AMY WESTLING I'M FROM
ARQUEBUSES SHIZHEN OF REGIONAL
CENTER AGENCIES FIRST AND
FOREMOST I WANT TO. ACKNOWLEDGE
THE LEGISLATURE FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP AND.
HELPING US TO RESTORE THE
RESPITE HAD LAST YEAR. IT WAS
SOMETHING THAT OUR COMMUNITY
SORELY NEEDED AND WE WERE PROUD
TO PARTNER WITH DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA IN OUR
ADVOCACY EFFORTS ON THAT.
CRITICAL RESTORATION.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER THAT
REGIONAL CENTERS PROVIDE NEED
SPACE SERVICES. AND SO OF COURSE
THERE HAS TO BE A WAY TO
DETERMINE NEED.
THAT ONE OF THE MOST
CHALLENGING THINGS THAT SERVICE
COORDINATORS MUST DO IS HELP TO
DIFFERENTIATE NEED PURSES WANT.
AND THE THINGS THAT REGIONAL
CENTERS CONSIDER WHEN THEY LOOK
AT A FAMILY'S RESPITE NEEDS
ARE THE INDIVIDUAL SELF CARE
SKILLS THEIR MEDICAL NEEDS THEIR
BEHAVIORAL SUPPORT NEEDS. THE
FAMILY DYNAMICS AND COMPOSITION
THE INDIVIDUALS DAILY SCHEDULE
ALL OF THESE THINGS PLAY INTO
HOW MANY HOURS THERE ARE IN A
DAY AND HOW WHAT'S THE TRUE NEED
FOR RESPITE.
ADDITIONALLY ONE OF THE JOBS OF
A REGIONAL CENTER SERVICE
COORDINATOR. IS TO.
TEASE OUT WHAT EXACTLY A FAMILY
IS ASKING FOR.
IF FOR INSTANCE SOMEONE ASKS FOR
TWO HUNDRED OF HOURS A MONTH OF
RESPITE AND THE SERVICE
COORDINATOR DRILLS DOWN A LITTLE
DEEPER AND FIND OUT IT'S SO MOM
AND DAD CAN GO TO WORK. THAT'S
NOT RESPITE THAT'S DAYCARE BUT
WE KNOW THAT OFTEN TIMES PEOPLE
WILL ASK FOR SERVICES THAT THEY
KNOW THE NAME OF.
AND IT'S INCUMBENT UPON SERVICE
COORDINATORS.
AND THEY DO A FANTASTIC JOB WITH
THIS TO DRILL DOWN AND FIGURE
OUT EXACTLY WHAT IS THAT NEED
AND WHAT IS THAT.
WHERE IS THAT COMING FROM?
AND SO WHILE THE RESTORATION OF
RESPITE WAS A GREAT THING.
WE NEED TO REMEMBER. THAT AT THE
END OF THE DAY THE SERVICE IS
ABOUT ENSURING THAT INDIVIDUALS
AND THEIR FAMILIES HAVE THE
SUPPORTS TO STAY TOGETHER.
AND THAT THEIR NEEDS ARE MET
THANK YOU.
ACUMEN.
SEEING NO.
FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENT I WILL
BRING IT BACK UP TO THE DYESS
FOR ANY COMMENTS YOU MAY HAVE.
SEEING NONE.
I'D LIKE TO MAKE A REQUEST
A RESPONSE FROM THE DEPARTMENT
OF DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES IN
WRITING TO THE ISSUES. AND
QUESTIONS RAISED BY DRC FOR BOTH
THE DISPARITIES FUNDING. AND THE
RESPITE RESTORATION BY THE END
OF THIS MONTH FRIDAY MARCH
THIRTIETH PLEASE.
WITH THAT WE WILL HOLD ISSUE
FIVE OPEN AND MOVE ON TO ISSUE
SIX.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR HIS NEXT
ISSUE ARE IS THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PUT
PROPOSAL. TO RESTORE THE UNIFORM
HOLIDAY SCHEDULE.
IN TWO THOUSAND NINE TEN THE
STATE WAS FACING A TWENTY SEVEN
BILLION DOLLAR GENERAL FUND
SHORTFALL. AND AND NUMBER OF
GENERAL FUND SAVINGS PROPOSALS
WERE PUT IN PLACE.
TO REMEDIATE THAT SHORTFALL THIS
IS ONE OF THOSE PROPOSALS.
ON.
WHAT THE PROPOSAL DID WAS IT
AMENDED THE EXISTING STATUTE
THAT CALLED FOR TEN?
HOLIDAYS DURING THE YEAR THAT
WERE TIED TO BASICALLY THE
FEDERAL HOLIDAY SCHEDULE. IT
ADDED FOR HOLIDAYS THE FOUR DAYS
BETWEEN CHRISTMAS AND NEW YEARS.
AT THAT TIME IT RESULTED IN THE
GENERAL FUND SAVINGS OF SIXTEEN
POINT THREE MILLION DOLLARS.
UPDATING THAT NUMBER TO.
THOUGHT BASED ON OUR CURRENT
CASELOAD EXPENDITURE NUMBERS WE
WE THINK THAT THE SAVINGS.
BY REINSTITUTING HIS PROPOSAL IS
CLOSER TO NINETEEN POINT FIVE
MILLION.
AS NOTED IN THE AGENDA SERVICE
PROVIDER ORGANIZATIONS BROUGHT A
LAWSUIT AGAINST THE DEPARTMENT
AND IT RESULTED A IN QUITE A BIT
OF BACK AND FORTH BUT AT ONE
POINT THERE WAS AN INJUNCTION
PLACED ON THE DEPARTMENT FOR
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE SCHEDULE.
THE US DISTRICT COURT. VACATED
THAT INJUNCTION IN ON AUGUST OF
TWENTY SIXTEEN.
UGH THERE WAS AN APPEAL FILED
BUT THE YEAH FEDERAL APPELLATE
COURT UPHELD THE DISTRICT COURT
DECISION IN MAY OF TWENTY
SEVENTEEN.
SO.
.
WHAT THE DEPARTMENT IS NOW
PROPOSING CONSISTENT WITH THE
COURT'S RULING IS TO RE
IMPLEMENT?
STATUTE EFFECTIVE JULY FIRST OF
TWENTY EIGHT TEN.
THANK YOU.
COME NEXT I'D LIKE TO HEAR FROM.
JORDAN THEN AMY FOLLOWED BY
KATIE AND IF WE COULD MAKE ROOM
FOR A MINUTE SOMEWHERE THAT BE
GREAT. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
RESULT BE AS QUICK AS POSSIBLE.
.
YEAH I I WANNA MAKE IT START BY
SAYING HOW BLESSED WE ARE THAT
WE'RE AT A COMMITTEE HEARING.
AND WHAT'S NOT TWO THOUSAND AND
I WORK EVERY SINGLE THING ON THE
AGENDA AS A CUT.
AND WE ARE AT A PLACE WHERE
EVERY SINGLE THING ON THE AGENDA
IS HOW WE CAN IMPROVE PEOPLE'S
LIVES.
EXCEPT THIS.
WHY IS THIS HERE?
?
THIS IS THE LEGACY CUT
FROM THE RECESSION.
AND ONE WHICH THE ARK CALIFORNIA
ALONG WITH UCP SAN DIEGO ENTERED
INTO LAWSUIT AGAINST THE CITY
CALIFORNIA THE FEDERAL COURT.
RULED IT AS A DIRECT CUT.
SYSTEM THAT'S WHAT THEY SAID THE
ONLY REASON WHY WE DIDN'T WIN IN
COURT IS BECAUSE IN THE US
SUPREME COURT SAID THE THIRD
PARTIES NOW LONG NO LONGER HAVE
STANDING.
TWEEN.
MEDICAID IN IN MEDICAID CASES
THAT'S THE ONLY REASON WHY.
SO ONE
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A PROPOSAL
WHICH IS A CUT SO THAT FAMILIES
AND INDIVIDUALS DRUM
DISABILITIES FOR DAYS.
ADDITIONAL FOUR DAYS ARE LEFT TO
FEND FOR THEMSELVES FOR CERTAIN
SUPPORTS AND SERVICES.
AND THAT WON'T BE PROVIDED.
IT WILL CAUSE PEOPLE AND
FAMILIES.
TO HAVE TO MAY BE APPARENT TAKE
DAYS OFF WORK OR AN INDIVIDUAL.
HAVE TO SIT AT HOME THE WHOLE
DAY AND ALSO IS A RATE CUT TO
PROVIDERS WHO PROVIDING
SUPPORTIVE LIVING SERVICES
INDEPENDENT SERVICES BECAUSE
THEY STILL HAVE TO PROVIDE.
THE SERVICE IN THE HOME.
.
SO THAT ADDITIONALLY THIS IS
COSTING THE STATE IN THIS
LAWSUIT IT'S IT'S SOMETHING
WHICH IS NOT NEEDED IT'S A
RECESSION ERICA.
IN IT'S HARMING FAMILIES.
IT. AN ADDITIONAL WERE ABOUT TO
HEAR PROPOSAL ABOUT INCREASE TO.
A HEADQUARTERS
AT A TIME WHERE THERE'S ALSO
PROPOSAL TO.
CUT SERVICES AND SUPPORTS THE
PEOPLE IN THE COMMUNITY I THINK
THAT.
FLAT OUT REJECTING THIS PROPOSAL
IS WHAT WE'RE ASKING FOR THE LA
DID A GREAT JOB IN IN THEIR
THREE.
.
SUGGESTED OPTIONS HERE THEY ARE
CAN YOU SEE PIECE.
WOULD LIKE TO REQUEST THAT THE
COMMITTEE ADOPT THE SECOND
PROPOSAL THERE TO JUST FLAT OUT
REJECT THIS THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING.
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR ALL OF YOUR
TIME AND YOUR PATIENCE AS WE
WORK THROUGH THESE CRITICAL
ISSUES IN OUR SYSTEM.
AS JORDAN NOTED THIS IS.
ONE OF THOSE THINGS THAT WAS
AROUND DURING THE RECESSION THAT
CAME BECAUSE EVERYONE.
STATEWIDE IN LOTS OF STATE
FUNDED SERVICES WERE BEING ASKED
TO TAKE FURLOUGHS.
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT A HOLIDAY WE
NEED TO REMEMBER THESE ARE NOT
PAID HOLIDAYS FOR SERVICE
PROVIDERS. IT'S NOT PAID
HOLIDAYS FOR DIRECT SERVICE.
PROVIDERS OR THEIR STAFF.
IT IS TIME OFF WORK WITHOUT PAY.
BUT AGAIN LIKE WE BEEN CIRCLING
BACK TO ALL DAY THIS IS ABOUT
PROVIDING SERVICES THAT PEOPLE
CRITICALLY NEED TO BE INTEGRATED
INTO THEIR COMMUNITIES.
WE KNOW THAT.
DAYS SERVICES OFTENTIMES HELP
PEOPLE TO BECOME EMPLOYED AND
HELP PEOPLE TO MAINTAIN THE
UNEMPLOYMENT. AND OFTENTIMES
NGUYEN INDIVIDUALS WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES ARE
WORKING THE SAD TRUTH IS THAT
THEY'RE WORKING IN LOW WAGE JOBS
AND THEY CAN'T DICTATE THEIR OWN
DAYS OFF.
SO IF THERE SERVICE PROVIDERS
CAN'T.
BE PAID FOR THE DAYS THEY
SUPPORT THEM FOR SERVICE
PROVIDERS ARE FACED WITH EITHER.
NOT SUPPORTING THEM AND THE
PERSON LOSES THEIR EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITY. OR SUPPORTING THEM
IN THE SERVICE PROVIDER GOES
WITHOUT PAY.
WE DID A SURVEY OF THE REGIONAL
CENTERS TO FIND OUT WHAT'S THE
CURRENT STATE OUT THERE BECAUSE
WE KEEP HEARING A LOT ABOUT. TEN
DAYS IS THE NORM. WHAT WE FOUND
IS THAT CURRENTLY
SEVEN REGIONAL CENTERS ARE
OPERATING UNDER A HOLIDAY
SCHEDULE?
WITH FIVE OF THOSE
TAKING TEN DAYS A YEAR ONE
TAKING NINE ONE TAKING TWELVE.
BUT THE OTHER FOURTEEN CENTERS
ARE ALL LETTING THEIR SERVICE
PROVIDERS TELL THEM WHEN IT
MAKES SENSE FOR THEM TO BE OFF.
IF A SERVICE PROVIDER IS
PROVIDING SERVICES.
AND NOT IN AN EMPLOYMENT SETTING
IT LIKELY WON'T MAKE SENSE FOR
THAT PERSON FOR THAT PROVIDER TO
BE OPEN ON CHRISTMAS DAY.
BUT IF A SERVICE PROVIDER IS
SUPPORTING SOMEONE WHO WORKS IN
RETAIL.
IT MAY MEAN THAT THEY REALLY DO
NEED TO PROVIDE CRITICAL
SUPPORTS ON THANKSGIVING.
SO OUR CODE IS.
JOINING WITH THE ARE CAN YOU SEE
P. AND MANY MANY OTHER GROUPS IN
ASKING FOR REJECTION OF THIS
PROPOSAL.
THANK YOU
IF YOU.
FOLLOW ALONG WITH WHAT AMY WAS
SAYING ON THE CURRENT LAW
EXEMPTS INDIVIDUALS WHO RECEIVE
SUPPORTED WORK SERVICES HOWEVER
HAS NOT BEEN UPDATED. TO INCLUDE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WORK IN THE PAID
INTERNSHIP PROGRAM OR THOSE THAT
ARE ENGAGED IN COMPETITIVE
INTEGRATIVE EMPLOYMENT WITH
SUPPORTS. AND SO WE WANT TO
ENSURE THAT OUR CONSUMERS WHO
ARE IN INTERNSHIPS AND IN IN
COMPETITIVE JOBS WHICH IS OUR
ULTIMATE GOAL FOR PEOPLE. ON ARE
NOT NEGATIVELY IMPACTED ON IN
ANY WAY BY A HOLIDAY SCHEDULE
ON.
WE SORT OF ASSUME IT WAS NEVER
THE DEPARTMENT'S INTENTION THAT
THOSE ON ADDITIONAL SERVICES BE
COVERED BY IT BUT BELIEVE THAT
CLARIFICATION OF THE STATUTE
WOULD ON ENSURE THAT THERE ARE
NO UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES.
THANK YOU. NEXT DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE NOEL.
SONYA PADDICK ILIO.
AND.
WE KNOW THAT THE LEGISLATURE HAS
THREE OPTIONS ON THIS ISSUE IT
CAN IMPROVE THE PURPOSE THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL CAN
REJECTED OUTRIGHT OR IT COULD DO
SOME KIND OF COMPROMISE WHERE IT
APPROVES.
AND A UNIFORM HOLIDAY POLICY
BUT REDUCES THE NUMBER OF DAYS
TO SAY TEN.
AT THIS TIME WE'D LIKE TO JUST
PROVIDE A BIT MORE CLARITY ON
THE FISCAL IMPACT OF THESE
VARIOUS OPTIONS SO.
ONE THING TO KNOW IS THAT WHEN.
IN TWENTY FIFTEEN THE
DEPARTMENT QUIT IN FORCING THE
YOU THE FOURTEEN DAY UNIFORM
HOLIDAY POLICY SO IT'S NOT BEEN
ENFORCED SINCE THAT TIME. WHAT
THIS MEANS IS AS MS WAS LAYING?
NOTED A LOT OF THE REGIONAL
CENTERS HAVE EITHER GONE BACK
TO.
HOLIDAY POLICY OF TEN DAYS NINE
DAYS OR TWELVE DAYS OR THEY
DON'T HAVE A SPECIFIC AND SET
HOLIDAY POLICY. WHAT THIS MEANS
IS THAT EVEN THOUGH THE
ADMINISTRATION DIDN'T PUT?
URGENT REQUEST FUNDING TO PUT
BACK IN THE BUDGET WHEN THEY
QUIT ENFORCING THE POLICY IT
MEANS THAT.
.
SERVICE PROVIDERS ARE LIKELY
BILLING FOR THESE SERVICES ON
THOSE ADDITIONAL DAYS ON THE
NATURAL. SO IF THE LEGISLATURE
WERE TO.
PROVE THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL WE AGREE WITH THE
DEPARTMENT THAT THIS COULD
RESULT IN SAVINGS NEXT YEAR OF
CLOSE TO TWENTY MILLION GENERAL
FUND.
HOWEVER IF THE LEGISLATURE CHOSE
TO REJECT THE POLICY WE THINK
THAT THE ADDITIONAL COST
A TWO TWO I'M. GO BACK TO TEN
DAYS OR WHATEVER THE REGIONAL
CENTERS WANTED TO DO WOULD ONLY
COST ME ABOUT THREE MILLION.
GENERAL FUND BECAUSE SERVICE
PROVIDERS HAVE ALREADY BEEN
DOING FOR THOSE DAYS
THAT MAKES IT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
JAKE Y. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
OF.
PUSHING BACK A LITTLE BIT ON THE
LA US POSITION ON THIS I THINK
WE ACKNOWLEDGE THAT MANY OF THE
REGIONAL CENTERS OF RETURN TO OF
THEIR OWN.
HOLIDAY SCHEDULE THERE REALLY
ISN'T A UNIFORM ON A SCHEDULE IN
PLACE CURRENTLY. BUT BECAUSE
EACH OF THE REGIONAL CENTERS HAS
BEEN BUILDING ON DIFFERENT DAYS
AND THERE IS NO UNIFORMITY WE
WOULD RECOMMEND THAT ANY CHANGE
THIS PROPOSAL. WOULD BE RESTORED
AS CUT SO BUILDING IN THE.
FULL TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS IN
THE BUDGET YEAR TO ENSURE THAT.
THE DEPARTMENT IS IN SHORT ON
RESOURCES IN THE BUDGET HERE AND
HAVE TO COME BACK AND MAKE AND.
CORNER BUDGET REQUEST.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. WILL NOT TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT ON ISSUE SIX.
RICK ROLLINS ON BEHALF OF
ARKANSAS SHE SHOULD REVEAL
CENTER AGENCIES AND IDEA. BAKER
INDULGENCE OF MY BOSS AB DID A
GREAT JOB IN HER PRESENTATION
BUT THERE'S ONE THING I DID WANT
TO ADD. AND THAT IS SO HIGH HIGH
AS MANY OF YOU KNOW I AM A
PARENT OF A SON WITH AUTISM.
WHO RECEIVES REGIONAL CENTER
SERVICES?
IF THIS PROGRAM DOES GOING TO A.
POLICY GOES INTO EFFECT OF HIM
HIS DAY PROGRAM IS IMPACTED AND
I'M TOLD I HAVE TO TAKE CARE MY
SON WHILE I'M SUPPOSED TO BE AT
A BUDGETS HAVE ONE HEARING. AT
THE CAPITOL I'M GONNA CALL MY
REGIONAL CENTER QUITE FRANKLY
AND SAY HEY I NEED HELP. YOU
NEED TO SEND PERSONAL ASSISTANTS
WHICH BY THE WAY IT'S GOING TO
COST YOU MORE THAN KEEPING MY
DAY PROGRAM OPEN FOR THAT DAY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR.
NANCY CHANCE CHOICES PERSON
CENTERED SERVICES ON HERE IN
OPPOSITION OF.
THE REINSTATEMENT OF HOLIDAY
SCHEDULE WILL. I MEAN WE NEED TO
JUST SAY IT LIKE IT IS THIS IS A
CUT TO A SYSTEM THAT YOU'VE JUST
HEARD.
THROUGHOUT THIS TESTIMONY TODAY
IS ALREADY SUFFERING IS ALREADY
STRUGGLING WITH ON PAYING THEIR
FOLKS AND GETTING PEOPLE AND
HOLDING ON TO.
EMPLOYEES AND NOW WE'RE GONNA
FURLOUGH THEM FOR FOUR MORE DAYS
WITH NO PAY ON AND WE'RE GONNA
SEND OUR GUYS THAT WERE
SUPPORTING. HOME. TED FOR
SOMEBODY TO FIGURE OUT WHAT TO
DO WITH THEM AND I JUST THINK
THAT'S.
IT'S IT'S NOT NECESSARY RIGHT
NOW.
YOU KNOW WHERE ARE THE
STRUGGLING LIKE WE SAID WITH THE
MINIMUM WAGE.
FROZEN FROZEN.
RATES AND WITH RISING
HEALTHCARE COSTS.
AND IN ADDITION THIS PROPOSAL.
AND THE
QUITE FRANKLY ANY HOLIDAY
SCHEDULE TO ME ISN'T IT ISN'T
IT.
COMP ON CONTRADICTION TO THE NEW
HOME AND COMMUNITY BASED
SERVICES ROLE. BUT SAYS WE NEED
TO BE PERSON CENTER WE NEED TO
REACH SHOULDN'T BE DOING
ANYTHING UNIFORMLY WE SHOULD BE
OUT THERE DOING WHAT THE PERSON
NEEDS.
SO TO ME THIS IS IN
CONTRADICTION TO WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH HERE
THROUGH THE THE TWO THROUGH H.
CBS. AND FINALLY. IF WE CAN'T
GET YOU TO FLATLY REJECT
MAYBE WE COULD PUT IT OFF FOR A
COUPLE OF YEARS TILL WE HAVE A
RATE.
STUDY BACK
AND YOU KNOW DELAY IT DON'T
INSTITUTE RIGHT NOW DELAY IT FOR
A COUPLE YEARS TO WE HAVE THE
RATE STUDY TO WE KINDA KNOW
WHERE THAT WHERE WE'RE GOING TO
BE GOING WITH RATES. AND THEN
LOOK AT IT AGAIN BUT IF WE CAN
FLATLY DENIED THAT BE GREAT.
THE HUMAN.
PARDEE EMOTO CALIFORNIA
DISABILITY SENIOR COMMITTEE
ACTION NETWORK ALSO A FAMILY
MEMBER. I SUPPORT THE PREVIOUS
COMMENTS ESPECIALLY FROM NANCY
CHANCE AND ALSO THE THE PANEL UP
UNDERSCORING ONE THING. GIVEN
ALL THE ISSUES REGARDING.
CUTS OVER THE PAST OF SEVERAL
YEARS AND HOW PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
HARMED.
IMPOSING THIS REDUCTION NOW.
IT IS SIMPLY UNFAIR AND THAT'S
HOW IT NEEDS TO BE VIEWED IT AS
THE SUN FAIR. AND IF YOU LOOK AT
THE FACT HOW THE STATE VIEWS
REQUEST FROM ADVOCATES OF.
FOR ACROSS THE BOARD RATE
INCREASES OR MORE RESOURCES NOT
JUST FROM DEVELOPMENT SERVICES
IN OTHER AREAS I JUST SAYS MEDI
CAL.
IN THE STATE'S RESPONSE IS A
CAN'T.
DO THESE THINGS ESPECIALLY IN
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES.
ONE OF THE REASONS IS BECAUSE OF
THE RATE STUDY.
IT.
GOING ON THAT LOGIC THOUGH IF
YOU'RE NOT BEEN IMPOSED ACROSS
THE BOARD RATE INCREASES OR
FUNDING RESOURCES BECAUSE THERE
IS A RATE STUDY. IN THE STATE
OUT OF FAIRNESS SHOULD NOT BE
IMPOSING AN ACROSS THE BOARD
CUT.
AND A ONE OF THE THINGS OUT WITH
THE LA O. SHOOT THE THREE
OPTIONS YOU CAME UP WITH THERE'S
UP FOR ADOPTION THAT NANCY
CHANCE JUST MENTIONED. WHICH IS
RATHER IN THE REJECT IT
COMPLETELY BECAUSE I KNOW
LEGISLATURE DOESN'T LIKE TO DO
CERTAIN THINGS ARE SO IF YOU
KNOW DID.
DEFINITIVE SOMETIMES SOMETIMES.
MAYBE DELAY IT. A REINSTATEMENT
FOR YEAR UNTIL THE RATE STUDY IS
COMPLETED AND SEE IF SEE IF THIS
EVEN MAKES SENSE IN THE SCHEME
OF THINGS AND ALSO DOES IT MAKE
SENSE OF THIS IS HOW WHAT THE
STATE WANTS TO DO IN TERMS OF
COMPLIANCE.
OF HOME AND COMMUNITY BASED
SERVICES RULES THANK YOU.
IF YOU WANNA GET CLOSER.
THANK YOU.
REMOVED.
WHO? I NEED HELP.
GOOD AFTERNOON I AM THEY CALLED
US LAW FROM ANTIOCH IF THE FOR
FORCED CLOSURE DAYS ARE
IMPLEMENTED I WILL BE FORCED TO
STAY HOME I WILL BE ISOLATED
UNHAPPY AND WILL ONLY HAVE MY
HOME CARE STAFF. TO SOCIALIZE
WITH DR I AM NOT OUT IN THE
COMMUNITY WITH MY PEERS AND
CANNOT INTEGRATE WITH OTHERS I
AM ALSO DENIED DISAPPOINTS TO
WORK AND HELP OTHERS IN THE
COMMUNITY THE CLOSURE DAYS WILL
ALSO AFFECT. THE SUPPORT STAFF
BY HAVING THEM TO WORK LAWYER
DOCTOR STATE WILL HAVE TO PAY
MORE IN THE LONG RUN BECAUSE OF
THE EXTRA STAFFING NEEDED FOR
THE HOME CARE GIVERS ALSO THAT
PEOPLE WHO ARE WORKING. AT THE
DAY AT WORK PROGRAMS WILL LOSE
MONEY TO THEY CANNOT PAY THEIR
BILLS SO THEY GO FIND MORE
CONSISTENT EMPLOYMENT THIS LEADS
TO A VERY HIGH TURNOVER RATE AND
MAKES IT HARD. TO FIND GOOD
QUALITY PEOPLE I HOPE YOU WILL
CONSIDER THE PERSONAL IMPACT OF
THESE FOR FORCED CLOSURES ON THE
PEOPLE THAT USE AND NEED THE
SERVICES TO LEAD A NORMAL AND
SUCCESSFUL LIFE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MA'AM AND THANK YOU
FOR BEING AN ADVOCATE.
CARLENE HOLD WITH EASTER SEAL
DITTO I CAN'T FOLLOW THAT SHE
WAS SO ARTICULATE A GREAT JOB OF
HER ARTICULATING THE ISSUES
THANK YOU.
JAMIE DAVIS MORE ADVENTURES.
I PAID ATTENTION ON THE
GOVERNOR RELEASED THE BUDGET AND
LISTEN IN TO.
A PHONE CALL I THINK WAS DIANA
DO WAY GOING OVER IT.
PERHAPS NANCY.
AND THAT ARE VERY FIRST I SAW
THIS ARTICLE.
CALIFORNIA'S COLLECTING SO MUCH
OF YOUR MONEY IT CAN'T SAVE AT
ALL.
SO I HEAR THAT WE HAVE TO HAVE
FOR ADDITIONAL DAYS IN WHICH OUR
AGENCY WILL LOSE FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS.
AND MY STAFF WILL HAVE TO STAY
HOME WITH NO PAY. AND I KNOW
THIS ARTICLE IS ABOUT THE
COMPLEXITY OF THE RAINY DAY
FUND.
BUT IMAGINE IF YOU WORK FOR A
SMALL BUSINESS AND YOU FIND OUT.
YOU'RE GETTING A PAY CUT.
AND THEN YOUR OWNER SAYS WE'VE
HAD THE BEST YEAR EVER.
YOU KNOW IT'S NOT FAIR TO OUR
STAFF IT'S NOT FAIR TO OUR
CLIENTS IS NOT FAIR.
HUMAN.
SHALL I'D AGAIN I'M A PROVIDER
AND A PARENT AND I JUST WANT TO
ECHO WHAT NICOLE SAID THAT THIS
IS NOT A HOLIDAY SCHEDULE IT'S
JUST A FORCED CLOSURE SCHEDULE
WHERE PEOPLE. DO NOT GET THE
SUPPORTS AND SERVICES THAT THEY
NEED TO BE MEANINGFUL I HAVE ARE
MEANINGFUL LIVES IN THE
COMMUNITY SO I WOULD HOPE THAT
YOU WOULD OPPOSE THIS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
VERY JUTTING CDSA.
WERE STRONGLY OPPOSING THIS
MEASURE IN THIS PROPOSAL.
CLEARLY A RELIC OF A DIFFERENT
TIME IN THE AT THE ECONOMY
CALIFORNIA DOESN'T REALLY SEEM
APPROPRIATE AT THIS POINT. ALSO
JUST TO POINT OUT WE'VE TALKED
ABOUT A. B. X. TWO ONE AND HOUSE
WAYS MEN TO PASS THROUGH THIS
COMPLETELY CUTS BACK ON WHAT THE
STATE JUST DID TWO YEARS AGO TO
HELP DIRECTORS PROFESSIONALS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS A LINE THE
SENTENCE AB HARM MY ADVENTURES.
I'M A STAFF OVER THERE OVER
TWENTY FIVE YEARS.
AND I'M ID GO THROUGH THAT LAST
TIME THAT WE HAD THIS.
FOR HOLIDAYS IT IS REALLY
REALLY.
SAT THERE WE MAJORITY OF AS WE
HAD TO WORK TWO JOBS BECAUSE.
ON ONE OF THOSE DAYS WE HAD TO
STAY HOME OR. YOU KNOW UP
WITHOUT PAY AND THEN ON THE
THOSE DAYS WE HAD TO.
TRY TO SAVE ED SAYING SO WE HAD
TO TAKE SOME TIME OFF ON ANOTHER
DAYS SO WE DON'T HAVE A TIME THE
DEAL FOR THAT.
SO I AND I HAD IT CONVERSATION
WITH THE ONE OF MY COWORKERS THE
OTHER DAY AND SAID IT'S.
FOLLOW THAT'S GREAT LAND AND
HAVE AFFORDABLE HOLIDAYS AND I
SAID.
ON I DON'T I'M NOT HAPPY ABOUT
THAT BECAUSE YOU DON'T KNOW YET
YOU'RE NOT GONNA GET PAID THAT'S
NOT A HOLIDAY. HE GOES WHAT DO
YOU MEAN IS NOT A HOLIDAY IT
SETS A HOLIDAY SO NOW. YOU GONNA
STAY HOME WITHOUT PAY ON THIS
YOU HAVE A BIG DEAL IF YOU DON'T
HAVE A PAID TIME OFF YOU CAN'T
GET PAY. THANK YOU.
I CAN.
WELL SEVERAL FEATURES EXPLORED I
WAS HERE IN THOSE DARK DAYS I
WAS IN THOSE DISCUSSIONS AND TWO
THOUSAND NINE WHERE WE HAD
TRYING CUT SEVEN HUNDRED AND
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS WE DIDN'T
QUITE IN THAT HAVEN'T GOT THAT
MUCH BECAUSE I'M JUST UNDER FIVE
HUNDRED.
AND WE AGREED TO THE STATE
EMPLOYEES WERE TAKING FOUR DAYS
OFF.
EVERYBODY ELSE WAS TAKEN FOR LOW
SAID OKAY WE WILL OUR FOLKS ARE
WILLING TO GIVE.
ALL THOSE THINGS HAVE BEEN
RESTORED.
EXCEPT FOR US
SO WHAT IS IT ABOUT THE NICOLES
THE WORLD THAT SAYS THEY DON'T
DESERVE TO HAVE A FULL LIFE LIKE
EVERYBODY ELSE.
SEEING NO FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENT
I BRING IT UP TO THE DYESS FOR
ANY COMMENTS WE MAY HAVE. IT
WOULD.
S. REMOVED TWO I MOVED TO REJECT
THIS ITEM.
THE SECOND.
I AM BEING NOTIFIED THAT.
FOR US TO TAKE SPECIFIC ACTIONS
WE HAVE TO.
HAVE CERTAIN PROCEDURES IN
PLACE.
RON I WOULD LIKE TO SAY FOR THE
SAKE OF A FULLER PICTURE OF THE
OPTIONS ONLY.
CAN FINANCE PLEASE PROVIDE THE
SUBCOMMITTEE STAFF WITH WHAT
WOULD BE THE COST IF ANY. OF
ADOPTING A COMPROMISE OF A TEN
DAY UNIFORM HOLIDAY SCHEDULE VIS
A VIS WHAT THE GOVERNOR HAS
PROPOSED IN HIS BUDGET.
WORK TO GET THAT TO YOUR STAFF
GREAT.
WITH THAT WE WILL HOLD THIS ITEM
OPEN AND I SEE SENATOR WILK HERE
AND WE WILL MOVE ON TO ISSUE
NOT.
THEN ONE WOULD GET MAD IF I
DIDN'T KNOW FEDERAL.
THEN WE'VE GOT.
TO HAVE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS IN AND THANK YOU FOR ALL
YOUR HARD WORK ON THIS COMMITTEE
IS A VERY IMPORTANT COMMITTEE
AND I REALLY. APPRECIATE THE WAY
THAT YOU DO IN SUCH A THOUGHTFUL
THOUGHTFUL MANNER.
I'M HERE TO TALK ABOUT I WANNA
THANK YOU FIRST FOR JAN DIES IN
THIS REQUEST WHICH CHANGES THE
AGE OF ONSET DEFINITION OF
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITY. FROM A
DISABILITY THAT ORIGINATES
BEFORE AGE EIGHTEEN TO ONE WHICH
ORIGINATES BEFORE AGE TWENTY
TWO.
THIS CHANGE WILL CONFORM TO THE
FEDERAL AGE OF ONSET DEFINITION
WHICH WAS CHANGED ALMOST FORTY
YEARS AGO.
THIRTY STATES HAVE ALSO UPDATED
THEIR AGE OF ONSET.
A TO THE DEFINITION OF TWENTY
TWO WHY.
OUR BECAUSE MODERN SCIENCE AND
UNANIMOUS MEDICAL CONSENSUS LONG
AGO CONCLUDED THAT THE BRAINS
DEVELOPMENT. DEVELOPMENT
DEVELOPMENTAL PHASE IS NOT
COMPLETED AGED EIGHTEEN BUT
CONTINUES TO AT LEAST AGE TWENTY
TWO.
INDIVIDUALS MADE NEW NEWLY
ELIGIBLE FOR DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITY SERVICES AT BY THIS
AGE OF ONSET WOULD BE ALMOST
ENTIRELY WITHIN THE LANHAM ACT
CATEGORY FIVE.
QUOTE OTHER HANDICAPPING
CONDITIONS FOUND TO BE CLOSELY
RELATED TO INTELLECTUAL
DISABILITY OR TO REQUIRE
TREATMENT SIMILAR TO THAT
REQUIRED FOR INDIVIDUALS WITH
INTELLECTUAL DISABILITY IN
QUOTE.
THIS CATEGORY CONTAINS BRAIN
INJURIES WHICH ARE EXPECTED BE
THE PRIMARY GROUP OF NEWLY
ELIGIBLE INDIVIDUALS BRAIN
INJURIES ARE DIVIDED INTO TWO
SUBCATEGORIES ACQUIRED BRAIN
INJURY AB AYE. INFORMATIK BRAIN
INJURY.
TB I.
OUR SOURCE RESEARCH CONCLUDES
THAT AN ESTIMATED THREE HUNDRED
NINETY FOUR NEW ELIGIBLE
INDIVIDUALS BETWEEN AGES
EIGHTEEN AND UP TO TWENTY TWO
WOULD BECOME ELIGIBLE FOR
REGIONAL CENTER SERVICES UNDER
THIS BUDGET REQUEST. IN THE
FIRST YEAR THIS SOURCE RESEARCH
WAS PROVIDED TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES THE
ALEJO AND THIS COMMITTEE.
THE DEPARTMENT DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES SUPPLEMENTAL BUDGET
REPORT FROM FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN THIS THE
AVERAGE AND REGIONAL CENTER
PROCLAIM EXPENDITURE AT FIFTEEN
THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED SEVENTY
FIVE.
ACCORDING TO THE TWENTY ONE
INDIVIDUAL REGIONAL CENTERS
EXPENDITURE REPORTS FOR THE SAME
FISCAL YEAR.
THE AVERAGE ANNUAL EXPENDITURE
FOR FIFTH CATEGORY CLIENTS IS
THIRTEEN THOUSAND OATH FORTY
ABOUT SEVENTEEN PERCENT LESS
THAN THE AVERAGE FOR ALL
CATEGORIES.
WELL THIS AVERAGE ANNUAL PER
CAPITA EXPENDITURE ROUNDED UP TO
THIRTEEN THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED
IN THE NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS MAY
NEWLY ELIGIBLE BY THIS BUDGET
REQUEST ROUND AFTER FOUR
HUNDRED.
THE TOTAL ANNUAL FUNDING
INCREASES ESTIMATED AT FIVE
POINT FOUR MILLION DOLLARS.
THIS WOULD INCLUDE A FORTY ONE
PERCENT UP FROM FEDERAL FUNDS
AND FIFTY NINE PERCENT STATE
GENERAL FUNDS OF THREE POINT ONE
MILLION DOLLARS.
THIS AMOUNT IS LESS THAN ONE
TENTH OF ONE PERCENT OF THE
REGIONAL CENTER SPY POINT FIVE
BILLION DOLLAR ANNUAL BUDGET.
WOULD RECTIFY DECADES LONG IN
EQUITY IN THE LA FOR SOME OF OUR
STRUGGLING YOUNG DEVELOPMENTALLY
DISABLED CALIFORNIANS. AND HELP
ALLEVIATE SOME OF THEIR
SUFFERING.
SOME OLDER CASES OF TRAUMATIC OR
ACQUIRED BRAIN INJURY FROM PRIOR
USED WHAT ALSO BECOME ELIGIBLE
IN THIS NUMBER IS LESS CLEAR.
YET IT WOULD BE A LOGICAL TO
ASSUME THAT PRIOR YEARS WOULD
HAVE HIGHER NUMBERS. THE MORE
LIKELY BE LOWER MOST OF THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WILL HAVE ALREADY
FOUND AN ALTERNATIVE SOURCE OF
SUPPORT.
OTHERS AND PARTIALLY WILL NOT OF
SURVIVED.
ALSO SOME INDIVIDUALS WHO WERE
DENIED SERVICES DUE TO THEIR AGE
OF ONSET WILL HAVE FALLEN INTO.
LEVELS HAD A DISABILITY THAT
THEY WOULD HAVE HAD IT BEEN
GIVEN TIMELY SUPPORT SERVICES.
AND MAY NOW HAVE GREATER STATE
EXPENDITURES BEING SPENT ON THEM
AND LONG TERM FACILITIES
SOMETHING THIS BUDGET REQUEST
WOULD PREVENT GOING FORWARD.
OUR REGIONAL CENTER SPECIALIZED
PROVIDING COMMUNITY BASED
SERVICES WHICH ENABLE
INDIVIDUALS WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
THE CIVIL ADD DISABILITIES.
SUCH AS A PARTY DRAMATIC BRAIN
INJURY TO CHIEF THEIR FULL
POTENTIAL. AND HIGHEST LEVEL
SELF SUFFICIENCY.
THE EVIDENCE IS CLEAR THAT IF WE
GIVE THESE INDIVIDUALS THE
MEDICAL. NECESSARY TREATMENT
THEY NEED THEIR LIKELIHOOD OF
REHABILITATION THAT LISA HIGHER
LEVELS OF SELF SUFFICIENCY WILL
BE GREATER AND THEY WILL
ULTIMATELY BE MUCH LESS OF A
FINANCIAL BURDEN TO THE STATE.
ALSO IT'S WORTH NOTING THAT TB
AYE IN INCIDENCES ARE DECLINING
GRADUALLY AND HAVE BEEN FOR
YEARS LIKELY DUE TO GREATER
AWARENESS AND PREVENTION.
CHANGING AGE OF ONSET DEFINITION
WILL MAKE IT POSSIBLE TO
ACTIVELY SERVE ALL OF THE
DEVELOPED DEVELOPMENTALLY
DISABLED CALIFORNIANS NOT JUST
SOME OF THEM.
WITH PERMISSION THE CHAIR I HAVE
TWO WITNESSES OUGHT TO PROVIDE
TESTIMONY. AYE WITH ME I HAVE
FIVE. CARLENE HOLDEN WITH EASTER
SEALS A SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND
KATHERINE KITTY GRAHAM A MOTHER
OF A SON WITH TBI.
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING US TO BE
A PART OF THE DISCUSSION AND I
INFORMED THE DEBATE.
I'D LIKE TO OFFER.
EXPERIENCE.
RELATED IN A AND A VARIETY OF
FASHIONS.
ONE OF WATCH IS FROM A PUBLIC
POLICY PERSPECTIVE.
A AND THE OTHER IS FROM KIND OF
THE MANAGEMENT OF THE EASTER
SEAL UP BOTH MY MY ONE
EXPERIENCE AS WELL AS OUR
AFFILIATE HERE IN SACRAMENTO.
AND THEN THIRD I'D LIKE TO SHARE
PERSONAL EXPERIENCES CONSIDERING
I HAVE A GRANDSON AND WE WENT
THROUGH THE PROCESS IF YOU HAD
AN INVALID.
TOP.
SO IN A VARIETY OF REASONS I'M
VERY INTERESTED THE TOPIC AND
I'VE GOT TO BE A PART OF THE
DEBATE. FROM THE A PUBLIC POLICY
PERSPECTIVE. OFF FOR ME IT'S A
PARODY ISSUE.
AW WHEN YOU END UP WITH A
SCIENTIFIC RESEARCH THAT'S
BACKED UP OF THE FACT THAT THE
BRAIN DOES CONTINUE TO DEVELOP
TELL AT THE STATE'S TWENTY TWO
OF NOT TWENTY FIVE OR TWENTY
SIX.
YOU KNOW IT GOT THE SCIENTIFIC
BACKING BUT WE'VE ALSO HAD THE
MEDICAL COMMUNITY BEHIND IT.
WE'VE HAD THE THE NATIONAL.
RULES CHANGED OUR WE'VE HAD THE
HEALTH CARE RULES CHANGE EIGHT
PST TO GOES UP TO AGE TWENTY
TWO.
FOSTER CARE GOES UP TO AGE
TWENTY TWO SPECIAL EDUCATION
EVEN GOES UP TO AGE TWENTY TWO
SO WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE PUBLIC
FUNDED DOLLARS. IT'S LIKE
EVERYONE ELSE IN THE SYSTEMS ARE
KIND OF ACKNOWLEDGING THAT THE
AGE
ARE WHERE YOU ARE STILL
DEVELOPING IT'S UP TO AGE TWENTY
TWO. OF FROM OF IN A FUNDING
PERSPECTIVE OUR REGIONAL CENTER
SERVICES A MUCH SMALLER SUBSET
OF ALL OF HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES. AND YET WE HAVE A CARD
UP WITHIN THE STATE OR WITHIN
THE IN THE COUNTRY ON THE.
ON THE ISSUE OF OF WHAT
CONSEQUENCES TO TO DEVELOPMENT
DISABILITY AND MORE THAT AGES SO
PROPULSIVE PERSPECTIVE WE
ENCOURAGE.
IT TO COME TO TWENTY TWO. NOW
IF.
A FROM A MANAGEMENT PERSPECTIVE.
I VISITED OUR EASTER SEAL
AFFILIATE AND.
SACRAMENTO A NUMBER OF TIMES OF
THEY HAVE A TWO TIER BAD BRAIN
INJURY PROGRAM I'VE ALWAYS BEEN
VERY PROUD OF THE WORK THAT
WE'RE DOING AND I BELIEVE OUR
OTHER WITNESS HERE IS GONNA BE
ABLE TO GIVE A PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE OF. OF HOW VARIOUS.
.
I TALKED WITH THEIR EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR JUST THIS WEEK BECAUSE
I WAS ASKING FOR THE TBI PROGRAM
WATER THE NUMBERS GOING TO BE
AND ARE WE LOOKING AT KIND OF
WHAT WHAT'S THE UPTAKE. IS
EVERYBODY WHO'S GOING TO BE
ELIGIBLE AUTOMATICALLY GOING TO
BE FLOODING THE SYSTEM. AND WHAT
THEY WERE SAYING IS THEY THEY
DON'T THINK THAT'S GOING TO BE
THE CASE AT ALL.
AND KEEP IN MIND THAT EVEN WHEN
YOU'RE RUNNING A TBI SOONER YOUR
NUMBERS ARE VERY LARGE SO I
THINK THEY NORMALLY RUN.
AB TWENTY FOUR PEOPLE
PARTICIPATING IN THE GET PEOPLE
FROM ALL OVER CALIFORNIA.
ON.
REPRESENTING MANAGEMENT STAFF
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AYE AND
UP WITH PEOPLE WHO FIND OUR
SERVICES BECAUSE THEY'RE SO
ALIGNED WITH INDEPENDENT LIVING
IN SUPPORT OF LIVING. THAT
THEY'LL MAKE THE REQUEST
ARE ONLY TO FIND OUT LATER THAT
THEY MISSED THE CUT OFF AGE.
SO YOU KNOW I LOOK AT THE
SERVICES AND SUPPORTS THAT THEY
WOULD NEED I WOULD GO THEY WOULD
FIT FROM OUR. LONG TERM SERVICE
AND SUPPORT PERSPECTIVE BUT THEY
MISSED THE CUT OFF AGE SO I
THAT'S ALWAYS BEEN VERY HEART
WRENCHING. BECAUSE IT JULIA.
WEEK EARLIER A YEAR EARLIER THEY
CERTAINLY WOULD HAVE HAD A MUCH
BETTER FUTURE IN FRONT OF THEM.
.
ON A PERSONAL LEVEL WHICH OF
COURSE IS ALWAYS MUCH HARDER TO
TALK ABOUT.
.
AND IT WENT THROUGH WE WIN
THROUGH TIME AT.
.
PALO ALTO.
OH WELL MY GRANDSON WAS GETTING
SURGERIES THERE WENT THROUGH
SURGERIES FOR ABOUT IT AYE A
YEAR MAYBE A YEAR PLUS.
ANTI WE STAYED UP ON AND OFF AT
THE FAMILY UNIT THAT WAS THERE
SO I GOT TO KNOW NOT ONLY HIS
CARE BUT ALL OF THE OTHER PEOPLE
WHO WERE THERE. FROM ACROSS THE
COUNTRY SO IF WE'RE PREPARING
NUMBERS AND PROJECTIONS BASED ON
HOW MANY PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA
GET THE SURGERY JUST REMEMBER
THAT SOME OF THOSE HOSPITALS.
ARE LITERALLY ACTING AS A
TRAUMATIC BRAIN INJURY FOR
ACROSS THE COUNTRY AND YET THEY
ARE STILL SMALL.
SO WHEN YOU'RE LOOKING AT
NUMBERS I DON'T THINK WE'RE
LOOKING AT LARGE NUMBERS IN YOU
LOOKING CLEARLY THAT THAT. THE
MEDICAL GETS TAKEN CARE OF SO
FAR IN ADVANCE OF WHEN THE LONG
TERM CARE LONG TERM SERVICES A
SUPPORT KICK HIM.
SO MY GRANDSON WAS.
GETTING.
.
MULTIPLE SURGERIES.
THEN HE TRANSFERRED TO.
A REHAB FACILITY AND THEN HE
TRANSFERRED TO CAST THE COLINA.
SO ON THE REVIEW HAVE FACILITY
THEY'RE STILL LOOKING AT VERY
MUCH MEDICAL. AND ABOUT THE.
TRANSITIONAL LIVING CENTER THEY
SERVE FORTY TWO PEOPLE AND THEY
ARE PRIMARILY FROM CALIFORNIA I
THINK PROBABLY SOME FROM OUT OF
STATE.
AND.
THEY'LL HAVE A GRADUATED.
LEVELS OF INDEPENDENT
FUNCTIONING I GOT TO KNOW THAT
PARTICULAR PROGRAM WELL WELL I
WATCHED MY GRANDSON AND THE
PEOPLE THAT HE WAS GOING TO THE
PROGRAM WITH.
AND.
.
I DON'T THINK THE UPTAKE IN
THERE IT IS. EITHER IT IS ALSO
NOT GOING TO BE A HUNDRED
PERCENT OF AYE. ION.
I THINK THAT AS OUR GRADUATING
TO GREATER LEVELS OF
INDEPENDENCE.
AND GIMMICK THAT WAS COVERED BY
MEDICAL SO HE WOULDN'T SEE
HE.
THE PEOPLE WHO WILL CHOOSE IT
WOULD TRANSITION TO A REGIONAL
CENTER FUNDED SERVICE WITH A
WARM HAND OFF.
WHICH IS EXACTLY HOW WE WOULD.
ALWAYS WATER SYSTEM IN
CALIFORNIA TO BE.
SO ARE WE THINK THAT.
IT MAKES A LOT OF THINGS AYE
AYE TOPPED A MODEL THE WAY THEY
HAD SET UP THE MODEL WAS VERY
SIMILAR TO THE WAY WE WOULD SET
UP.
A THE STEPS OF GREATER LEVEL OF
INDEPENDENCE WITHIN OUR REGIONAL
CENTER FUNDED SERVICES.
.
SO FOR A VARIETY OF REASONS.
I THINK THAT BECAUSE OF THE
PARODY ARGUMENT I ALSO THINK
BECAUSE OF THE LONG TERM
SERVICES AND SUPPORTS NEEDED.
AND THE FACT THAT LITERALLY AS A
PROVIDER WE ARE SERVING THE
PEOPLE WITH THE EXACT SAME.
LEVELS OF NEED.
IT JUST HAPPENED A YEAR OR TWO
BEFORETHE PRIOR CUT OFF SO I
THINK OUR SYSTEM IS SET UP FOR
BEING ABLE TO HANDLE IT AND OR
CAN MAKE THE ADJUSTMENTS
ESPECIALLY UNDER PERSON CENTERED
PLANNING. AND I THINK OUR
SERVICES WERE VERY ALIGNED
ACTUALLY WITH KATHLEEN A MODEL.
SO FOR A VARIETY OF REASONS I I
WOULD LIKE TO ENCOURAGE YOUR
SUPPORT AND I JUST WANT ONE LAST
PLEA BEFORE I TURN IT OVER TO
OUR PARENTS.
.
PERHAPS IT'S ALWAYS THE PARENTS
THE PARENTS WERE THERE AT EVERY
STEP BUT PALO ALTO. WE WERE ALL
THERE WE.
.
YOU KNOW WE FOUGHT FOR THE
HEALTH OF OF ARE CERTAIN SIN
DOCTORS AND THEIR SONS AND
DAUGHTERS.
AND.
THE PARENTS ARE ALWAYS GONNA BE
THERE SO THE PARENTS ARE ASKING
FOR.
THE SAME LEVEL OF SUPPORT OF
OTHER PEOPLE WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES. AND LET ME TURN IT
OVER TO HER PARENTS IF YOU.
DIDN'T I MY NAME IS KATHERINE
I'M FROM UKIAH AND I WAS.
REALLY GRATEFUL TO BE ABLE TO
COME HERE AND TALK WITH
ASSEMBLYMAN WOULD AND I'M WITH
THE SUBCOMMITTEE ABOUT.
MY SON AND HOW IMPORTANT THIS
ISSUE IS FOR FAMILIES AS WELL AS
FOR THE YOUNG PEOPLE.
OF OUR COMMUNITIES.
I WAS SO GRATEFUL TO DR
BLOOMBERG WHO IS EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF MY LOCAL REGIONAL
CENTER WHO ENCOURAGED ME AND
KNEW OF SENATOR WILKES.
EFFORTS AND ENCOURAGE ME TO
INVESTIGATE AND DO WHAT I COULD.
SO I'M VERY HAPPY TO BE HERE.
MY SON IS NOW THIRTY SEVEN AND
WHEN HE WAS TWENTY ONE HE
SEPARATE A DRAMATIC BRAIN
INJURY.
HE WAS IN.
A REHAB FACILITY FOR NINE
MONTHS AND.
IT MADE PHENOMENAL PROGRESS.
WENT FROM WHAT THEY SAID WOULD
BE A VEGETABLE NEVER WALK NEVER
TALK NEVER DO ANYTHING TO BEING
RELATIVELY HIGH FUNCTIONING
RIGHT NOW.
I THINK THAT ATTESTS TO THE
PLASTICITY OF THE BRAIN IN THE
ABILITY OF THE YOUNG PEOPLE. TO
IN FACT MAKE PROGRESS.
IT WAS A NEW THEORY AT THE TIME
AND I LATCHED ONTO IT YOU CAN
BET THAT BLESSED IS THE OF THE
BRAIN. BUT ANYWAY HE.
AFTER NINE MONTHS HE CAME BACK
INTO THE COMMUNITY AND WE WANTED
TO CONTINUE THE PROGRESS THAT HE
HAD MADE. AND.
WE REACHED OUT FOR SERVICES AND
THE SERVICES.
IN THE BEGINNING OF COURSE TO
INTEGRATE THEM INTO THE
COMMUNITY AND AND BECOME SELF
SUFFICIENT WE LOOK FOR THE DAY
CARE PROGRAMS. AND THE DAYCARE
PROGRAMS WOULD OF BEEN ABLE TO.
HELP HIM SET GOALS HELPING HAVE
FRIENDS BECAUSE ALL OF HIS OLD
FRIENDS WERE OF COURSE GONE AT
THIS POINT BUT.
IT TO SET GOALS AND TO.
TO DO BEHAVIOR MODIFICATION AND
TO LEARN TO SOCIALLY INTERACT
APPROPRIATELY AND ALL OF THOSE
ARE THE KINDS OF SKILLS WITH
TRAINED PEOPLE WHO COULD SUPPORT
HIM IN THIS JOURNEY AND WOOD
TALK ABOUT IMAGE. AND HELP HIM
OF THIS WHOLE STAFF BUT.
ALL OF THE DAY PROGRAMS WERE
REGIONAL CENTER FUNDED AND WE
WERE NOT ALLOWED TO ENTER INTO
ANY OF THEM.
SO MY SON ENDED UP AT A SENIOR
CENTER PLAYING BINGO SO THAT HE
HAD SOMETHING TO DO WHILE I HAD
TO RETURN TO WORK.
SO THEN THE NEXT ONE WAS
WORKING JOE WANTED TO WORK HE
HAD A HIGH WORK AT THE KEY.
WAS.
VERY MOTIVATED TO WORK IT WAS.
HIS IDENTITY WAS TO WORK AND SO
WE WENT TO DEPARTMENT WE HAVE
BEEN DEPARTMENT OF THREE HAVE.
DID SOME ASSESSMENTS AND YOU
KNOW FOUND SOME JOB POSITIONS
FOR HIM AND.
HE WAS WORKING AS A JANITOR YOU
KNOW CLEANING TOILETS FOR
SWEEPING FLOORS AT SUCH A WHICH
HE WAS HAPPY TO DO WITH THE
POINT.
BUT.
DEPARTMENT WE HAVE ONLY HAS A
JOB COACH FOR SIX WEEKS
AND SICK JOE WAS JUST NEWLY
COMING YEAR IS JUST REALLY NEWLY
OUT FOR DRAMATIC BRAIN INJURY
AND SO. SIX WEEKS WAS MOSTLY
LIKE GETTING HIS ATTENTION IT
YOU KNOW AND HE NEEDED SOMEBODY
TO COME IN AND SAY AND TO.
INTERACT WITH THE BOSS AND SAY
WELL YOU KNOW WE HAVE TO ADJUST
THIS OR TO HELP JOE UNDERSTAND
YOU CAN'T DO THAT OR TO HELP YOU
KNOW IMPULSIVITY OR. JOE THOUGHT
HE COULD DO IT BETTER THAN THE
BOSS COULD DO IT YOU KNOW I MEAN
THESE KINDS OF THINGS CAN'T DO
AND SO. YOU KNOW TO HELP
NEGOTIATE THESE KINDS OF THINGS
AND.
REGIONAL CENTER YOU KNOW COULD
COME IN EVEN ONCE A MONTH TO SAY
OKAY HOW'S IT GOING YOU KNOW OF
AND THEY HAVE JOB GO TO SIT WILL
GO A LIFETIME IF YOU NEED IT BUT
JOE WOULDN'T NEEDED IT FOR A
LIFETIME JUST NEEDED. TO GET
OVER THOSE BECOMES YOU KNOW AND.
SO WE.
WE LOST THAT OPPORTUNITY AND SO
WE DISCOVERED EASTER SEALS IN
SACRAMENTO AND SO WE CAME OVER
HERE AND A PARTICIPATED IN THE
EASTER SEALS PROGRAM WHICH WAS
FABULOUS. AND.
YOU KNOW WHEN I THINK ABOUT THE
COST IT WAS THERE WERE SO MANY
OTHER PEOPLE IN THERE WERE SO
MANY SERVICES THAT WERE BEING
OFFERED AT THE CITY. SAMETIME
SPEECH IN PHYSICAL THERAPY AND
AND ALL THIS COMMUNITY
INTEGRATION AND STUFF AND IT IT
WAS A FABULOUS PROGRAM AND SO
THEN WE HAD TO THE WORK
COMPONENT AND WE FOUND ANOTHER.
ALTA REGIONAL CENTER PROGRAM WHO
WAS WILLING TO JUST SOAK JOE
INTO THEIR PROGRAM AND THEY PUT
HIM ON A A WORK CREW WHERE HE
WAS A TAKING FROM BOX TO FLORIDA
A. DINING ROOM CHAIR IN
REBUILDING IT AND PUTTING IT
TOGETHER AND HE WAS SO PROUD OF
DOING THAT HE WASN'T UP THE
INDUSTRY STANDARDS BUT. HE WAS
ON A WORK CREW IT DIDN'T COST
THEM REALLY ANYTHING TO TAKE ON.
ONE MORE PERSON TO WORK WITH
THEM AND HE WAS IN HEAVEN.
IN BEING ABLE TO WORK BUT THEN
THE OTHER COMPONENT OF LIVING IN
SACRAMENTO SINCE I'M IN UKIAH IS
THE LIVING SITUATION AND I FOUND
OF. A RESIDENTIAL CARE THAT
WOULD HAVE TAUGHT HIM TO COOK
AND TELL HIM TO SHOP AND TAUGHT
HIM TO BE INDEPENDENT AND
SOCIALLY INTERACT WITH PEOPLE
AND STUFF. AND THEY WERE IT WAS
A REGIONAL CENTER.
THAT RESIDENTIAL AND THEY SAID
BUT WE HAVE THIS OTHER EXTRA
ROOM THAT WAS LIKE LIKE A CLOSET
YOU KNOW BUT WE WERE WILLING TO
LIVE IN IT BUT THE REGIONAL
CENTER SAID. NO IF YOU PUT
SOMEBODY IN THERE THAT IS NOT A
REGIONAL CENTER CLIENT WE WILL
CANCEL YOUR VENDOR SHIP.
SO JOE LOST OUT ON THAT
RESIDENTS AND THE GATE PUT HIM
INTO ANOTHER RESIDENTIAL CARE
THAT.
DIDN'T HAVE THE SUPPORT THAT
DIDN'T HAVE THE INTEREST THAT
DIDN'T HAVE ANY OF GOALS OUR
DIRECTION AND JOE ENDED UP.
SMOKING TOO MUCH IN GETTING
SOME CIGARETTES AND HAVING A
SEIZURE AND HAD ANOTHER HEAD
INJURY AND SO I HAD TO BRING HIM
HOME.
SO WE STARTED OVER AGAIN IN
UKIAH HE WANTED TO.
TO LIVE INDEPENDENTLY I MEAN
EVERYTHING WAS TO FOR HIS OWN
SELF ESTEEM AND TO BUILD
INDEPENDENCE WHAT WE WANTED WAS
INDEPENDENCE FOR HIM AND.
THE ONLY WAY I COULD REALLY DO
IT WAS I BECAME THE CASE MANAGER
I MANAGE THE STAFF I MANAGED
EVERYTHING AND YOU TELL ME ANY
TWENTY ONE TO THIRTY SIX YEAR
OLD THAT WANTS THEIR MOTHER
AROUND ALL THE TIME. IS NOT
HAPPENING YOU KNOW SO IT WAS IT
WAS HARD FOR JOE BECAUSE HE WAS
RESISTANT AND. AND I IT JUST
BECAME A CHALLENGING BANG AND
THE LAST ONE IS GETTING A JOB
WITH BY MYSELF FOUND SOMEBODY IN
SANTA ROSA WHICH IS AN HOUR'S
DRIVE TO AND FROM. THAT WAS
WILLING I THOUGHT TO GIVE HIM A
JOB BUT I JUST GOT AN EMAIL THIS
MORNING SAYING.
SORRY WE CAN'T DO A JOB COACH
BECAUSE HE'S NOT A REGIONAL
CENTER CLIENT.
SO I NOW HAVE A SON SIXTEEN
YEARS OUT WHO WAS HIGHLY
MOTIVATED HIGH WORK ETHIC VERY
POSITIVE APPROACH WHICH WERE
HEAD INJURIES IS NOT ALWAYS THE
CASE THAT CAN BE VERY NEGATIVE
AN ANGRY. BUT HE WAS POSITIVE HE
WOULD MAKE PEOPLE LAUGH JUST
WALKING INTO THE ROOM. AND HE'S
NOW DISCOURAGED
DEPRESSED
AT HOME AS WE SPEAK PUBLICLY ON
THE COMPUTER PLAYING CANDY CRUSH
AND WATCHING MOVIES
AND DISCOURAGED AND NOT. ABLE TO
BE A PRODUCTIVE MEMBER OF OUR
SOCIETY WHICH IS WHAT HE WANTED
TO BE HE WANTED TO BE
INDEPENDENT AND CERTAINLY.
.
ABLE TO BE PRODUCTIVE WE
ENVISION FOR AWHILE HIM BEING
ABLE TO GO TO THE HIGH SCHOOL
AND TALK TO HIGH SCHOOL SENIORS
ABOUT DRINKING AND DRIVING BUT.
THAT'S LIKE NOT EVEN VAGUELY ON
THE AGENDA AT THIS POINT YOU
KNOW BECAUSE HE DOESN'T HAVE THE
SKILLS HE DOESN'T HAVE THE
ABILITY. AND MY CONTENTION IS
THAT IF HE WAS ON SUCH A ROLL
FROM THE REHAB IT THAT IN THE
COMMUNITY WE COULD HAVE HAD
THOSE EARLY INTERVENTIONS THAT
REGIONAL CENTER PROVIDES. WHICH
REALLY WOULDN'T COST ALL THAT
MUCH BUT IT WOULD HAVE BEEN
PHENOMENAL FOR HIM HE COULD BE A
PRODUCTIVE MEMBER OF OUR SOCIETY
NOW HE COULD BE DOING.
CONTRIBUTING POSITIVE THINGS AND
IT REQUIRES THAT EARLY
INTERVENTION AND THAT EARLY
SUPPORT AND IF WE DON'T HAVE
THAT THEN WE CAN'T HAVE THE
PRODUCTIVE MEMBERS OF OUR
SOCIETY AS THEY WOULD LIKE TO BE
SO I WOULD. ENCOURAGE YOU TO
THINK THAT MAYBE IT'S A LITTLE
EXPENSIVE ON THE EARLY
INTERVENTION SIDE BUT SO MUCH OF
IT COULD BE INCORPORATED TO
THINGS THAT ARE ALREADY
HAPPENING TO ONE OR TWO MORE
PEOPLE DON'T MAKE ANY
DIFFERENCE.
AND WHAT IS THE COST AT THE
OTHER END BECAUSE NOW JOE IS NOT
INDEPENDENT HE NEEDS TWENTY FOUR
HOUR SUPERVISION I AM NOT GOING
TO BE ALIVE FOR EVER SO I'M
GOING TO REQUEST A STATE
CONSERVATIVE SHIP TO MANAGE HIM.
HE'S GOING TO BE PULLED FROM HIS
COMMUNITY THAT IS THE ONLY THING
HE HAS LEFT PROBABLY PUT DOWN IN
SOME HOME SOMEWHERE IN LA OR
WHATEVER HAVE NOTHING GOING ON
FOR AND THE COST OF SOCIAL
SERVICES THE COST OF. LUCKILY
FOR JOE NOT JUDICIAL BUT MANY
HEAD INJURIES ENTERED THE
JUDICIAL SYSTEM THE MENTAL
HEALTH SYSTEM THE STATE
CONSERVATORSHIP YOU TELL ME THE
COST AT THE OTHER END. PURSES
BILL EXPENSE OF INCORPORATING
THEM INTO A REGIONAL CENTER
WHICH IS ALREADY. FUNCTIONING
AND PRODUCING POSITIVE WONDERFUL
THINGS.
SO THANK YOU FOR CONSIDERING
INCORPORATE  IN THE AGE
EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY ONE THEY ARE
DEFINITELY YOUNG THE PLASTICITY
OF THE BRAIN IT WAS SO OBVIOUS
THOUGH.
THANK YOU FOR CONSIDERING THE
OPTION.
AND I JUST WANTED TO SAY JOE'S A
LUCKY MAN TO HAVE A MOM LIKE YOU
FIND
HOME FAN.
AND WITH THAT I IF WE COULD MAKE
A SPACE FOR THE DEPARTMENT AND
THEN I'D ALSO LIKE TO HEAR FROM.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AS WELL
AS FULLY.
DO YOU THINK OF.
TO COME.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR ARM.
AS SENATOR WILK NOTED THE
PRIMARY CONCERN WE HAVE A COUPLE
CONCERNS WITH HIS PROPOSED BUT
THE PRIMARY ONE.
IS THAT WELL YOU CAN ESTIMATED
NUMBER FOR WHAT ANNUAL COSTS
MIGHT BE IT'S SUBJECTIVE BECAUSE
YOU COULD ESTIMATED A LOT OF
DIFFERENT WAYS.
THE CONCERN IS WHAT THE IMPACT
WOULD BE FOR OLDER CASES.
AS WAS NOTED IN THEIR ESTIMATE
THEY REALLY DON'T HAVE ALL THE
WAY TO PROJECT WHAT THOSE
NUMBERS MIGHT BE. IT'S AN
UNKNOWN.
THE CONCERN WE HAVE IS THAT.
THE SERVICE IS WHETHER SOME
THERE'S AN INTERSECTION OF
BETWEEN THE TYPES OF SERVICES
THAT WE PROVIDE IN THE TYPES OF
SERVICES.
THAT INDIVIDUALS.
WITH ACQUIRED DRAMATIC BRAIN
INJURY MAY NEED.
I'M NOT ALL SERVICES
IT WE DON'T PROVIDE ALL THE
TYPES SO THIS COULD RESULT IN
THE
DEPARTMENT HAVING TO DEVELOP
NEW.
MODELS OF SERVICE TARA FIND NEW
PROVIDERS TO PROVIDE THOSE
SERVICES AND.
WE THINK THAT YOU KNOW THAT THE
COST OF DEVELOPING THOSE
SERVICES COULD BE SIGNIFICANTLY
HIGHER THAN WHAT'S PROJECTED
HERE.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ELLIOTT.
AS SONYA PARTICULARLY HEALTH. I
AM I WOULD JUST NOTE THAT.
THE LA O. HAS BEEN WORKING WITH
THE SENATOR'S OFFICE ON REFINING
THE ESTIMATE WERE ALSO HAPPY TO.
RESPOND TO ANY SPECIFIC
REQUESTS FROM THE SUBCOMMITTEE.
OF THEIR WE THINK THERE ARE A
COUPLE AREAS WHERE THAT WE CAN
REFINE THAT ESTIMATE INCLUDING.
.
LOOKING AT THE AVERAGE COST FOR
ADULTS ARE CURRENTLY THAT
ESTIMATE IS SORT OF BASED ON ALL
AGES AND WE THINK THAT MIGHT
INCREASE THE ESTIMATE A BIT. HOW
WE ALSO NEED TO INCLUDE THE COST
OF REGIONAL CENTER OPERATIONS
INTO THE PER PERSON COST? AND
THEN THERE'S THIS ISSUE OF
LOOKING AT.
THE OLDER ADULTS WHO MAY NOW BE
ELIGIBLE FOR SERVICES BECAUSE
THEY HAD AN INJURY IN AGES
EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY ONE. WE DO
THINK THAT THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT WE CAN YOU KNOW POTENTIALLY
COME UP WITH A A RANGE OF OF
ESTIMATES FOR THIS AND WERE. WE
PLAN TO CONTINUE WORKING WITH
THE SENATOR'S OFFICE OVERTHE
NEXT COUPLE MONTHS.
TO COME UP WITH A BETTER
ESTIMATE.
WE WOULD ALSO JUST NOTE THAT ALL
THAT WE DO AGREE WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF THAT.
.
CERTAIN SERVICES MAY NEED TO BE
EXPANDED OR DEVELOPED.
BUT WE WOULD NOT THAT THE
DEPARTMENT CURRENTLY.
BUT DOES SERVE PEOPLE WHO HAVE
SUFFERED FROM TRAUMATIC BRAIN
INJURIES IF THEY ACQUIRED THE
INJURY WHEN THEY WERE SEVENTEEN
FOR EXAMPLE.
SO IT MAY BE THE CASE THAT
EXPERTISE WOULD WOULD NEED TO BE
EXPANDED AND SERVICES EXPANDED
BUT. IT'S IT'S NOT A TOTALLY
UNHEARD OF.
.
ROLL.
JAIL AND PART OF FINANCE JUST
ECHOING THE FISCAL CONCERNS IN
THE DEPARTMENT AND SOME OF.
CHALLENGES AND PUTTING A
FISCALLY OUT OF THAT WAS
MENTIONED BY THE LA WE ALSO JUST
LIKE TO NOTE THE. INCREASING
ONGOING CAUSES MORE FOLKS BECOME
ELIGIBLE FOR THE SERVICES AND
ARE IN THE SYSTEM. AND WOULD
NOTE THAT IS AN ONGOING CONCERN
THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
WILL NOT TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT ON
ISSUE NINE.
PATRICK ROLLINS ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION REGIONAL CENTER
AGENCIES THAT WE'VE BEEN WORKING
OUR SENATOR WELL CAN HAS SAW
STAFF SINCE THE INCEPTION OF THE
BILL FROM LAST YEAR WHICH WAS
PROOF BY THE POLICY COMMITTEE
BED. FAILED TO GET OFF THE
SUSPENSE FILE LAST YEAR SO
THEREFORE. OF THE EFFORTS BEEN
THE MOVE TO THE BUDGET PROCESS
SO YOU'RE SERVING SERVICE A
POLICY AND FISCAL SIDE OF THIS
ISSUE AND CLEARLY. YOU KNOW ALL
OF US IN AM A PARENT AND MY
HEART GOES OUT TO YOU I KNOW
WHAT YOU'RE GOING THROUGH.
THIS SYSTEM UNFORTUNATELY IS A.
FINITE SYSTEM IS A CLOSED SYSTEM
IF YOU HAVE A CHILD IN
CALIFORNIA FOR INSTANCE WHO HAS
TRIPPED SYNDROME YOU'RE NOT
QUALIFIED.
BASED ON THE DIAGNOSIS OF
TOURETTE'S TO BE AND IN OUR
SYSTEM. ARE OUR SYSTEMS GROWING
WITH THE CURRENT POPULATION OF
ACCORDING TO THE DDS AND THE
ADMINISTRATION WERE GONNA BE
ADDING FIFTEEN THOUSAND. NEW
CLIENTS IN THIS COME UP COMING
FISCAL YEAR WITH WHAT WE HAVE
TODAY.
AND OF THOSE FIFTEEN THOUSAND
SEVENTY PERCENT ARE GOING TO BE
KIDS WITH AUTISM SO THAT'S ONE
NEW CHILD WITH AUTISM EVERY
FORTY EIGHT MINUTES COMING INTO
THE REGIONAL CENTER SYSTEM.
YOU'VE HEARD HOURS OF TESTIMONY
HERE AND WILL CONTINUE ABOUT THE
UNDER FUNDED NATURE OF THIS
SYSTEM AND IT REALLY COMES DOWN
TO THE DOLLARS.
I DON'T THINK THERE'S ANYONE
THAT WOULD ARGUE THAT FOLKS WITH
BRAIN INJURY ARE DESERVING OF
SERVICES.
OUR SYSTEM OF WAS SET UP.
TO SERVE PEOPLE DEVELOPMENT
DISABILITIES WE HAVE SOME GREAT
SERVICE PROVIDERS LIKE EASTER
SEALS AND OTHERS WHO DO PROVIDE.
SERVICES THAT THIS POPULATION
BUT WE AGREE THAT THERE WOULD BE
A NEED TO DEVELOP NEW SERVICES
AND OUR IN OUR SYSTEM TO NOT
CARE FOR FOLKS. WITHOUT WITH
BRAIN INJURY SO OUR POSITION
ESSENTIALLY AS WE CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH SENATOR WELCOME. WE
UNDERSTAND THE NEED FOR
PROVIDING SERVICES TO PEOPLE IN
NEED THAT'S WHAT WE'RE ALL
ABOUT.
WE'D LIKE TO BRING TO THE
COMMITTEE'S ATTENTION THAT BY
RAISING THE. ELIGIBILITY AGE
FROM EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY TWO IT
NOT ONLY IMPACTS FOLKS WITH
BRAIN INJURY BUT ALL ANYONE ELSE
IN OUR SYSTEM AS WELL SO THE
OPIATE OF FISCAL TIED TO THAT.
I'M SURE ARE AS THINGS MOVE ON
SO I DON'T HAVE ANY.
GREAT WORDS OF WISDOM OUR
GUIDANCE FOR YOU ON WHAT TO DO
ON THIS BUT CLEARLY.
THAT IT'S IT THERE'S A LOT OF
MONEY INVOLVED WE NEED TO HAVE A
DEAL WITH THE FISCAL SIDE OF
THIS ONE FUND THESE PROGRAMS.
OR UNDERFUNDED ALREADY AND ALSO
WE WOULD REALLY THINK THAT. WE
CAN'T MOVE FORWARD ON THIS
PROPOSAL.
FROM THE REGIONAL CENTERS
PERSPECTIVE UNLESS THE MEDIAN
RATE UP HIS ARM IS REMOVED ARE
THESE. ARE TYPES OF SERVICES FOR
PEOPLE WITH BRAIN INJURY TEND TO
BE EXPENSIVE THERE SOME OF ARM
AND REDUCE OUR PEOPLE BRAIN
INJURY ALREADY. IN OUR SYSTEM
UNDER THE AGE OF EIGHTEEN THEY
TEND TO BE EXPENSIVE SERVICES.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR.
CARING CARRUTHERS OF THE STATE
COUNCIL ON DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES ESTATE COUNCIL
EXIST IN FEDERAL AND STATE LAW
THERE'S A COUNCIL LIKE OURS IN
EVERY STATE AND TERRITORY
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY WE LOOK
AT AND FOLLOW BOTH FEDERAL DD
ACT AND THE STATE LANCEMENT ACT.
RISING TO CONFIRM THAT THIS
PROPOSAL WOULD CONFORM STATE
DEFINITION OF DEVELOPED A
DISABILITY TO THE FEDERAL
DEFINITION WHICH IS OUR AGE
TWENTY TWO THANK YOU.
MICHELLE HIDE.
AS A PROVIDER IN APPARENT I
WOULD JUST LIKE TO THANK SENATOR
WILK FOR HIS ADVOCACY IN THIS.
AREA AND ALSO SUPPORT THE
EXPANSION OF ELIGIBILITY TO
MATCH WITH THE FEDERAL
DEFINITION SO THANK YOU BECAME.
MEANING CHAIRMEN AND COMMITTING
MY NAME'S ASTRA ZENECA I'M THE
VICE PRESIDENT OF UNITED
DOMESTIC WORKERS HOUSE MEDICAL
THIRTY NINE THIRTY. ON I WANT TO
SAY THANK YOU TO SENATOR WILK
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD AND I
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO THE
MOTHER FOR HER TESTIMONY.
AS A PARENT MYSELF EXIT WITH A
TOAD WITH INTELLECTUAL
DISABILITY.
THEY GO THROUGH A LOT AND THEY
DEPEND ON THE SERVICES AND THANK
YOU TO THE TO DTS AND THE
REGIONAL CENTERS FOR THE
SERVICES THAT ARE PROVIDED TO
US.
ON WE ARE FAR BEHIND TIMES IF WE
DON'T DO THIS.
AND I WON'T PUT A PRICE TAG ON
MY SON'S LIFE.
SO.
I WOULD URGE YOUR SUPPORT OUR
UNION URGES YOUR SUPPORT FOR
THIS.
AND WE THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
BRINGING US FOR.
EVELYN I WILL HASN'T WITH
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA WE
DO THINK THAT PEOPLE WITH ON TV
I WOULD BENEFIT FROM THE
REGIONAL CENTER SERVICES THEY
HAVE A LOT OF THE SAME ISSUES
THE PEOPLE WITH INTELLECTUAL AND
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES TO.
AMEND WHILE WE DO SUPPORT THE
PROPOSAL WE WOULD. REQUEST THAT
THE FISCAL RESOURCES FOLLOW THE
PROPOSAL SO THAT CURRENT UP
SERVICES ARE NOT IMPACTED. WITH
THE ONSLAUGHT OF NEW PEOPLE.
MARTY MOTO CALIFORNIA DISPLACING
YOU COMMITTEE ACTION NETWORK
ALSO A FAMILY MEMBER JUST WANNA
SAY.
AS A FAMILY MEMBER APPRECIATE IN
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF YOUR
PROPOSAL SENATOR WILK A.
S. FAMILY MY I'VE RUN ACROSS
FAMILIES ACROSS THE STATE.
IN MY TWENTY YEARS AND
STATEWIDE ADVOCACY FAMILIES TO
JUST LIKE YOU.
OF WHO ARE IN DESPERATE BECAUSE
OF JUST BECAUSE OF THE CALENDAR
WHERE THEIR SON OR DAUGHTER.
ACQUIRED YOUR TRAUMATIC BRAIN
INJURY.
TWO THOUSAND THREE WE ORGANIZE
MASSIVE RALLIES TO FIGHT.
.
THAT THEN ADMINISTRATION BY
GOVERNOR WORK SCHWARZENEGGER TO.
OF SUSPEND THE LANHAM ACT AND WE
HAD FIVE THOUSAND PEOPLE ON THE
CAPITOL LAWN. ONE OF THE FAMILY
IS DEBATE TO FAMILIES WHO ASKED
ME IF THEY COULD SPEAK. AND
THERE WERE FAMILIES OF PEOPLE
WHO HAD DRAMATIC BRAIN INJURIES
WHO DID NOT QUALIFY FOR REGIONAL
CENTER SERVICES.
WE WERE THERE TO SPEAK FOR
JUSTICE JUST LIKE THE PARENTS
WERE. FIFTY YEARS AGO.
AND THE THING FOR THE.
FAMILIES LIKE YOU.
AND THE FAMILIES THAT I'VE
TALKED TO IN THE PAST AND
FAMILIES WHO SPOKE TO THAT
AUDIENCE OF FIVE THOUSAND.
IS THAT INJUSTICE THAT THEIR
CHILDREN.
WERE NOT COVERED.
AND WERE NOT GIVEN SERVICES AND
SO SOMETHING NEEDS TO CHANGE AND
TOTALLY UNDERSTAND. THAT THE THE
CHALLENGE BEFORE ALL OF US
POLICY MAKERS OF THE LIMITED
RESOURCES THAT THE STATE HAS.
AND I THINK THAT'S ALWAYS GOING
TO BE A CHALLENGE FOR US IT
NEVER GOES AWAY BUT SOMETIMES
DOING THE RIGHT THING AND. I
THINK THAT'S SOMETHING MISTER
ROUNDLY YOU SAID MISTER WOULD
YOU SAID ON THE ISSUE OF
UNIVERSAL HEALTH COVERAGE DOING
THE RIGHT THING IS SO IMPORTANT.
IN THE CHALLENGES HOW DO WE GET
THERE AND SO I HOPE THIS
SUBCOMMITTEE DOESN'T SAY NO.
TO SENATOR WILK PROPOSAL BUT
OTHER THAN THAT.
IF WE CAN'T FUNDED THROUGH THE
REGIONAL CENTERS AND LET'S FIND
A WAY.
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA DID THE
RIGHT THING AND HELP PEOPLE WITH
TB I AND THE OTHER.
BRAIN INJURIES THERE'S GOTTA BE
A WAY TO ACTUALLY.
GIVE THE JUSTICE TO THESE
FAMILIES THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING VERY GETTING
CALIFORNIA DISABILITY SERVICES
ASSOCIATION ONE I THINK YOU
CENTER WILL FOR BRING THIS
PROPOSAL.
WE SUPPORT YOUR BILL LAST YEAR
AND WE'RE CERTAINLY IN SUPPORT
OF PROPOSAL THIS TIME IT'S
MATTER FAIRNESS AND WE THINK
IT'S A GOOD IDEA THANK YOU.
YOU.
JORDAN'S OF THE RTC PIECE
SOMEBODY ARE SEE.
IN SUPPORT.
BUT WE WANT THE FUNDS TO BE
THERE AS WELL THANK YOU.
SEEING NO FURTHER PUBLIC
COMMENT.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
MATHIS.
FIRST.
CATHERINE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR SHARING
THE STORY ABOUT YOUR SON JOE.
I AM GONNA DIVE INTO MY PERSONAL
COMBAT VETERAN STORY HERE FOR A
MINUTE.
.
I WAS HIT WITH A ROADSIDE BOMB
THE FIRST TIME WHEN I WAS TWENTY
THREE YEARS OLD.
AND THEN THE SECOND TIME WHEN I
WAS TWENTY FOUR.
AND I SUFFERED A TRAUMATIC BRAIN
INJURY EARNING ME A PURPLE
HEART.
THANK GOD AND I NEVER THOUGHT
I'D SAY THAT THAT THE VA HAD
COGNITIVE RETRAINING THERAPY OR
I PROBABLY WOULDN'T BE SITTING
BEFORE YOU TODAY ON THE SIDES.
WE DO NOT HAVE A CIVILIAN.
EQUIVALENT.
THAT OUR SYSTEM TO TO DO THAT.
WERE LACKING THAT.
THE FACT THAT.
CALIFORNIA TO.
MANY TIMES LIKES TO BRAG ABOUT
HOW AS GOOD AS CALIFORNIA GOES
THE NATION. QUITE FRANKLY IS
BEHIND THE CURVE ON THIS ONE.
IN WE DESPERATELY NEED TO GET UP
TO THE FEDERAL STANDARD.
CHAU CATHERINE I.
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR FROM.
CHAMPION THIS ISSUE FORWARD.
SEVERAL YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD.
.
AS TO MY REQUEST FOR THE
DEPARTMENT.
AND FOR THE ALEJO.
PLEASE WORK WITH THE SENATOR
GIVE THEM COUNCIL ON HOW TO
FIGURE THIS OUT.
BECAUSE QUITE FRANKLY THE
THOUGHT THAT.
SOMEBODY PLAYING FOOTBALL RIDING
A BIKE OR GETTING IN A CAR
WRECK.
COULD NOT RECOVER THE WAY THAT
I'D BEEN BLESSED TO BE ABLE TO
RECOVER.
IS NOT ACCEPTABLE.
SO WE HAVE TO FIGURE THIS OUT WE
HAVE TO FIGURE OUT THE FUNDING
MECHANISM.
TO MAKE THIS.
WHERE?
WE ARE ABLE TO HAVE THIS WORK.
BECAUSE PEOPLE DESERVE AT THAT
THE FACT THAT SOMEBODY GETS OVER
AGE BRACKET. AND WE'RE SCUTTLED
FOLLOWING THE CRACKS.
IS A JOKE AND I'M NOT OKAY WITH
THAT.
SHOW THAT IS MY REQUEST OF THE
DEPARTMENT AND AND RT WORKING
WITH THEM.
BUT YOU ALSO DOWN TO FIGURE THIS
OUT.
THANK YOU
IT WOULD.
OR THANK YOU SENATOR WELL FOR
YOUR PERSISTENCE ON THIS ISSUE I
DON'T THINK CAPTION FOR MAKING
THE TRIP TO YOU ARE FROM UKIAH
TODAY AND. I WOULD JUST LIKE TO
SAY THAT YOU KNOW.
.
AT WITH IT WITH OUR MEMBER
MISTER MATHIS ARE TALKING ABOUT
HIM CALIFORNIA WE LIKE TO PRIDE
OURSELVES IN LEADING IN SO MANY
WAYS BUT TO FIND OUT THAT. WERE
WHAT FORTY YEARS BEHIND THE
FEDERAL STANDARD.
IS IS REALLY HAS REALLY
EXTREMELY DISAPPOINTING QUITE
FRANKLY.
.
WE ACTUALLY KNOW THAT IN SOME
PORTIONS OF THE BRAIN THEY'RE
STILL DEVELOPING TO AGE TWENTY
SIX. AND WE KNOW THAT FROM
ADDICTION WE KNOW THAT BECAUSE
OF SMOKING.
AND AND AND HOW ADDICTIVE THOSE
THINGS CAN BECOME AND SO.
SO THE FACT THAT WE'RE NOT
TAKING THE SINGS IN THE
CONSIDERATION HERE.
AND WE'RE LOOKING AT THIS IS A
LINE ITEM YESTERDAY GOING TO BE
A COST TO IT BUT LOOK AT THAT
LOOK AT THE OUT YEARS.
IF YOU COULD INTERVENE AT THIS
AT THESE AGES UP TO TWENTY TWO
AND AFFECT THE ABILITY OF
SOMEONE TO INTEGRATE BACK INTO
SOCIETY TO BE ABLE TO WORK. WHAT
IS THAT GOING TO SAVE US IN THE
LONG RUN?
GETS A LINE ITEM NOW BUT IT
COULD BE IT COULD BE SO MUCH
MORE COSTLY ON THE OTHER END.
AND I JUST IMPLORE YOU TO FIND A
WAY TO FIGURE THIS OUT.
PLEASE. THIS IS YOU NO I AYE
MOFFETT FRUSTRATED IN GENERAL ON
ON HEALTHCARE ISSUES THAT WE
DON'T THINK STRATEGICALLY ABOUT
THINGS WE THINK OF THINGS PEOPLE
AS A LINE ITEM AND IT HAPPENS
OVER AND OVER AND OVER AGAIN AND
SO. I ASK YOU TO LOOK LOOK LOOK
AT THE BIG PICTURE LOOK AT THE
POTENTIAL SAVINGS AND LOOK AT
THE POTENTIAL QUALITY OF LIFE
FOR SOMEBODY OUT THERE AND THE
FAMILIES AND I'M AND. AND TRY TO
FIND A WAY TO HELP THIS HAPPEN
AND MAYBE WE CAN START A TREND
AND. AND AND LOOKING AT THESE
THINGS MORE STRATEGIC
CLAY.
AND I I HOPE I HOPE WE CAN MOVE
FORWARD THAT WAY THANK YOU THANK
YOU SOME.
I'M GONNA HAVE TO REQUEST IF I
MAY FIRST I'D LIKE TO GET WHAT
THE ADMINISTRATION'S ASSESSMENT
OF THE FISCAL.
AFFECT OF THIS PROPOSAL WOULD
BE. AND SECOND I WOULD LIKE TO
ASK IF THE ADMINISTRATION
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND LA
JOH.
CAN CONSIDER THE CROSS OVER
EFFECT WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
REHABILITATION SERVICES
AND IF THAT MIGHT MITIGATE THE
FISCAL OF FACT TO MAKING THIS
TICKET.
WITH THAT WE WILL HOLD THIS
ISSUE BERMAN AND MOVE BACK TO
ISSUE SEVEN.
A HIP HOP
.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR OF THE
DEPARTMENT HIS INCLUDED A THREE
BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSALS IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. OF THE FIRST
REQUEST TWO MILLION DOLLARS ONE
POINT FOUR MILLION DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND IN NINE POSITIONS.
IN HEADQUARTERS TO INCREASE OUR
CLINICAL STAFF OVERSIGHT INTO AN
ONGOING MONITORING OF OUR
COMMUNITY A. BETTER RESIDENTIAL
HOMES THE ARE PUSHING HOMES THE
MEDICAL MODEL HOMES OF THEM
BEHAVIORAL HOMES.
AT THESE RESOURCES ARE JUST
ANOTHER COMPONENT IN THE
DEPARTMENT SAFETY NET PROPOSAL.
THE SECOND PROPOSAL SHIFTS TWO
POINT ONE MILLION. DOLLARS SIX
BY ONE POINT SIX MILLION DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND AND FIFTEEN AND A
HALF POSITIONS.
UP FROM THE DEVELOPMENTAL
CENTERS BUDGET TO HEADQUARTERS
THIS IS MORE OF A TECHNICAL
CLEAN UP. IT UP IMPROVES
TRANSPARENCY IN THE BUDGET
BECAUSE THESE POSITIONS PROVIDE
SUPPORT STATEWIDE AND WE JUST
WANT TO BRING THEM TO
HEADQUARTERS. BECAUSE THEY WILL
BE PROVIDING ONGOING ACTIVITIES
AFTER THE DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS
CLOSE.
THE FINAL PROPOSAL.
REQUEST TWO HUNDRED NINETY FIVE
THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
EIGHT THOUSAND GENERAL FUND.
INTO POSITIONS
TO A BEGIN STARTUP IN PLANNING
ACTIVITIES FOR.
AN INTERNAL AUDIT UNIT OUR
DEPARTMENT DOESN'T HAVE A UNIT
AT THIS TIME. TO DO INTERNAL
AUDITS WE HAVE TO.
WE HAVE AUDITOR'S TO.
DO AUDITS OF THE REGIONAL
CENTERS AND OF OUR PROVIDERS.
AND WE HAVE TO REDIRECT THOSE
RESOURCES IN ORDER TO WIN WE
HAVE TO. LOOK AT INTERNAL ISSUES
OR WHEN WEHAVE TO RESPOND TO
AUDITS BY THE BUREAU OF STATE
AUDITS THE STATE COMPTROLLER'S
OFFICE THINGS LIKE THAT. SO
THAT'S THE ANYA INTENT OF THESE
NEW POSITIONS.
HELLO DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
WHY NOT TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT ON
ISSUE SEVEN?
THANK MISTER CHAIRMAN FOR THE
ARC.
JORDAN'S WITH YOUR CAN CP.
WHAT WE HAVE NO COMMENT ON
WHETHER OR NOT THE FUND SHOULD
HAPPEN THAT IS YOUR DECISION WE
JUST WANT TO MAKE A PUBLIC
COMMENT THAT THE ARE CAN USE P.
I AM HAS? GREATLY APPRECIATED
THE CURRENT LEADERSHIP OF THE
DEPARTMENT AND THE WAY THAT THEY
HAVE REACHED OUT TO THE
COMMUNITY AND TO THE FAMILIES TO
THE PROVIDERS TO WORK WITH US.
AND WE JUST WANT TO SAY THAT
THANK YOU.
WITH THAT CAN SING NO COMMENTS
FROM THE DYESS WE WILL HOLD
ISSUE SEVEN OPEN AT THIS TIME
AND MOVE ON TO ISSUE A.
THANK YOU SO.
BY THE SOCIAL WRECKING CAMP
SERVICES.
I THINK THAT THE AGENDA IS WELL
OUTLINES ON IT PRESENTS THE
ISSUE THAT WAS.
BEFORE. THE.
.
THE SERVICE SYSTEM WHEN THERE
WAS FOR.
CUT SINCE THE SPENDING CAP
SERVICES ANSEL SAREK SERVICES
AND IT ALSO ADDRESSES THE
ESTIMATE FROM THE DEPARTMENT.
THINK YOU WERE ALSO GOING TO
HAVE ON ISSUE EIGHT AMY JORDAN
AND.
AND EVELYN.
IN THAT ORDER IF WE MAY.
DAVID.
GOOD EVENING.
IT SEEMS LIKE WE'RE TALKING A
LOT ABOUT TWO THOUSAND NINE
TONIGHT. AND THIS IS ANOTHER
OPPORTUNITY TO REVISIT SOME OF
THOSE PAINFUL CHOICES WE HAD TO
MAKE DURING THE RECESSION.
AT THAT TIME. THE DEPARTMENT OF
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES WAS FACED
WITH MAKING SIGNIFICANT CUT
THERE WAS A ROBUST STAKEHOLDER
PROCESS ABOUT HOW BEST TO
ACHIEVE THOSE CUTS WHILE
KEEPING.
SERVICES IN PLACE FOR
INDIVIDUALS THAT THE REGIONAL
CENTERS WERE SUPPORTING. AND A
PAINFUL CHOICE WAS MADE THE CUT
FAMILY SUPPORT SERVICES.
BUT THAT WAS A PROMISE THAT THE
SERVICES WOULD BE RESTORED WHEN
THE INDIVIDUAL TWICE BUDGET.
WAS IT ACTED AND THAT'S OUR
PROGRAM THE STATE IS NO LONGER
PURSUING SO NOW THERE'S REALLY
NO PATH FORWARD.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO KNOW THAT THE
MISSION OF REGIONAL CENTERS IS
TO HELP PEOPLE TO BECOME PARTS
OF THEIR COMMUNITIES.
AND IF WE REALLY WANT PEOPLE TO
BE INCLUDED. AND IN A MEANINGFUL
WAY IN THEIR COMMUNITIES WE HAVE
TO PROVIDE THEM WITH THE ABILITY
TO DO THAT.
SOCIAL RECREATION IN CAMP
SERVICES PROVIDE THAT MISSING
PIECE WHICH ALLOWS REGIONAL
CENTERS TO COMPLETE THEIR
HOLISTIC APPROACH TO THIS
PROCESS.
IT'S ABOUT INCLUSION.
WE THROW AROUND THINGS LIKE
PERSON CENTERED PLANNING A LOT
BUT WE DON'T TAKE THE TIME TO
ASK REALLY WHAT IS THAT.
THE FEDERAL DON'T GOVERNMENT
GIVES US A FANTASTIC DEFINITION
AND IT TELLS US THAT WE NEED TO
BALANCE.
WHAT'S IMPORTANT FOR PEOPLE.
TO IT AGAINST WHAT'S IMPORTANT
TO PEOPLE.
WHAT'S IMPORTANT FOR PEOPLE OR
THOSE THINGS THAT ARE NEEDED FOR
HEALTH AND SAFETY.
SUPERVISION MEDICAL CARE.
WHAT'S IMPORTANT TO PEOPLE ARE
THOSE THINGS THAT MAKE LIFE
WORTH LIVING.
THINGS THAT. MAKE IT SO THAT WE
WANT TO GET UP AND WE WANT TO
ENJOY YOUR DAY AND WE WANT TO
PARTICIPATE IN OUR COMMUNITY.
SOCIAL RECKON CAN'T REALLY
PROVIDE THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
PEOPLE TO TAKE SKILLS THAT
THEY'RE LEARNING. AND TO APPLY
THEM IN A WAY THAT MAKES LIFE
MEANINGFUL AND SUCCESSFUL FOR
THEM.
IT BRINGS IMMEASURABLE VALUE TO
THEIR LIVES.
AND IT AFFORDS THEM THE SAME
OPPORTUNITIES THAT PEOPLE
WITHOUT DISABILITIES ENJOY.
AND REALLY AT THE END OF THE DAY
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE ALL HERE FOR.
IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT TO NOTE
THAT AS THE SELF DETERMINATION
PROGRAM IS ROLLED OUT.
PEOPLE WHO WERE ENROLLED IN THE
SELF DETERMINATION PROGRAM WILL
HAVE THE OPTION TO PURCHASE THE
SERVICES WORDS PEOPLE IN THE
TRADITIONAL SERVICE SYSTEM WILL
NOT.
SORT OF A SENSE OF EQUITY IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE PROVIDE PEOPLE
IN BOTH SYSTEMS THE ABILITY TO
ACCESS THESE CRITICAL SUPPORTS.
ADDITIONALLY WE KNOW THAT THESE
ARE SERVICES THAT INDIVIDUALS
AND FAMILIES FROM DIVERSE
COMMUNITIES VALUE. AND WE NEED
TO GIVE THEM THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ACCESS THEM AGAIN.
AND FINALLY.
WE KNOW THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAS AN EXPECTATION
THAT PEOPLE WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES.
WELL ACCESS THEIR COMMUNITIES
AND WILL BE INTEGRATED IN THOSE
COMMUNITIES.
AND THIS SET OF SERVICES ALLOWS
PEOPLE TO DO THAT SO IT ALLOWS
US TO MEET FEDERAL EXPECTATIONS.
THEY ALLOW US TO MEET THE
EXPECTATIONS AND DESIRES OF
INDIVIDUALS AND THEIR FAMILIES.
AND THEY ALLOW US TO DO THE
RIGHT THING FOR NOT THAT MUCH
MONEY THANK YOU.
THE NOVEL AND I'M HUSON DISOBEY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA JUST ECHO. ON
A LOT OF THE COMMENTS THE AMY
HAVE AS MADE YOU KNOW SOCIAL
RECKON CAMPING MAY PROMOTE
COMMUNITY INTEGRATION AND
SOCIALIZATION AFTER REGIONAL
CENTERS CAN CONSUMERS. WE KNOW
THAT THIS PARTICULAR CUT
IMPACTED.
.
GROUPS FROM UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES AND IMPACT THE
DISPARITY ISSUES THAT WE ARE
FACING TODAY ARM AND WE KNOW
FROM TALKING TO FAMILIES AND
THAT THAT THIS IS A SERVICE THAT
THEY WOULD.
ASK FOR IF IT WAS AVAILABLE AND
FOR THOSE FOR REASONS WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT. THE
REINSTATEMENT OF THE SERVICES
AND HAVE ADVOCATED FOR THAT OVER
THE LAST FEW YEARS.
I CAN GIVE.
I THINK YOU JORDAN ENDS WITH THE
ARE CAN YOU SEEKING A QUICKLY
ARE THE ONLY COMMENTS I WILL AND
IF YOU. TALK WITH INDIVIDUALS
WHO WHO DID RECEIVE THE SERVICES
IN THE PAST.
AND WHEN THEY TALK ABOUT THE
SERVICE THAT'S WHEN THEIR EYES
LIGHT UP AND THEY SAY OH MY
GOSH.
THAT.
WEEK WHERE I WAS AWAY FROM MY
PARENTS AND WAS ACTUALLY LIVING
IN PHILLY THAT CHANGED MY LIFE.
AND IT SIMILAR TO THAT ITSELF A
WRECK ACTIVITIES OUT AT IT IT'S
A LIFE CHANGING. AND OFTEN TIMES
THOSE INDIVIDUALS AREN'T HIGH
UTILIZES OF OTHER SERVICES THESE
ARE THE ONES WHICH A LIFE
CHANGING FOR THEM. AND WE THINK
YOUR EFFORTS LAST YEAR UPON THIS
AS WELL SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WE'RE VERY HOPEFUL THAT THIS
WILL CONTINUE FORWARD AND WILL
GIVE GOLD WITH HIM THANK YOU.
I LEN DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
ANY PUBLIC COMMENTS ON ISSUE
EIGHT.
I GUESS.
I'M I'M RUNNING A STAMPER
SICKENING I'M I'M GENERAL'S
PRIMARY CAREGIVER.
ONE OF THINGS THAT DANIEL LOVES
IN THE SUMMERS CAN'T CRAM.
ANY GUESS TO HEALTH FRIENDS AND
SOCIALISING AWAY FROM ME. AND I
AM AND SERIOUSNESS KID HAVING
THE INDEPENDENCE AND WITH
ABILITY TO GARDEN PURSUE
DIFFERENT A DESIRES IN ENJOY
DIFFERENT PURSUITS.
AND HAVING THE OPPORTUNITY TO
HAVE CAMPS FOR DENTAL HAVE THAT
OPTION AND WE LISTED OUT WE GO
WHICH CAMP YOU WANNA GO WHICH
PROGRAM. AND IN THIS THE SUMMER
HOPEFULLY A DINO INTENDS TO BE
GONE FOR THE MONTH OF JUNE.
I HAS BACK TO BACK THAT'S WE
WANT TO DO I WOULD RESPECT THAT.
AND IF IF WE CAN MAINTAIN
PROGRAM SENTINEL HASN'T AUTONOMY
DO THAT JUST EVERYONE ELSE WOULD
LIKE TO DO I THINK THAT'S ONLY
APPROPRIATE THINK IT'S JUST.
THANK YOU SIR.
HEARING CARRILLO STATE COUNCIL
ON DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
RISING IN SUPPORT OF THIS
PROPOSAL.
FIT BUDGET COMMITTEE OFTEN
HEARS REQUEST FROM THE DD
COMMUNITY RELATED TO DIFFERENT
RATES PROVIDER RATES MINIMUM
WAGE RATES.
.
WE REPRESENT THE THE PERSPECTIVE
A FAMILIES AND OF PEOPLE WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
INTELLECTUAL DISABILITIES AND WE
ASK THEM WHAT'S IMPORTANT OF
THEM THIS IS THE ANSWER THAT
COMES FORWARD. AND IT'S REALLY
KIND OF NEAT ABOUT ALL OF US
FROM THE TABLE HERE IS THAT WE.
WORKING ON OUR PRIORITIES ON OUR
OWN IN OUR OWN CAN ARMED GROUPS
SAID WHAT'S THE MOST IMPORTANT
ONE EACH OF US INDIVIDUALLY SAID
RESTORATION OF SESSION AND
RECONCILING CAYMANS COMPARED
NOTES AS TO WHAT WAS IMPORTANT.
AND WE ALL HAD THE SAME THE SAME
TOP PRIORITY SO PLEASE CONSIDER
SUPPORTING AT RESTORING IT THANK
YOU THANK YOU SIR.
WELL SEVERED YEARS EXPLORATORIUM
OVER THE LAST NUMBER YEARS WE'VE
HAD LEGISLATIVE TOWN HALL
MEETING THAT ARE SELF ADVOCATES
PUT UP WITH THE KEY ISSUES WHERE
THERE WERE THREE. LIVE WORK
PLAY.
WE DON'T SUPPORT.
FOR FOLKS WELL LOOK AT THE FOLKS
WHO FALL BACK INTO MORE
SEGREGATED SETTINGS FROM
COMPETITIVE INTEGRATED
EMPLOYMENT. PRIMARILY BECAUSE OF
ISOLATION LACK OF SOCIAL
OPPORTUNITIES LACK OF SOCIAL
CHOICE BECAUSE. WE DON'T SUPPORT
THOSE OPTIONS ARE FOLKS ANYMORE
SO I THINK THE CRITICAL THING
THAT WE ADD BACK INTO FAMILIES
TO REALLY YOU KNOW IN AND
PROVIDE OUR FOLKS THAT
OPPORTUNITY TO BE. LIKE ALL THE
REST OF US WE ALL WORK WE ALL
LIVE SOMEWHERE AND WE ALL HAVE
RECREATION ACTIVITIES THAT WE
DO.
THEY NEED THAT SUPPORT.
MARTY MOTOR CALIFORNIA
DISABILITY CAMINO ACTION NETWORK
ALSO FAMILY MEMBER MY SISTER
ACTUALLY WHEN SHE WAS ALIVE
VALUED. THESE
PROGRAMS
A IT WAS A QUALITY OF LIFE ISSUE
AND JUST ONE ISSUE OF SEMI
STRONG SUPPORT FOR RESTORATION
THANK YOU.
CAMP IS AWESOME. I DID. EVERY
SINGLE ONE OF MY TEENAGE YEARS.
.
MY AUNT'S
WAS THE DAHLE ONE OF THE
DIRECTORS FOR CAMP SUNSHINE
DREAMS WHICH IS A CANCER CAMP.
DOWN THROUGH VALLEY CHILDREN'S
HOSPITAL. EFFORT AMAZING
STORIES.
I CAN'T.
SPEAK ENOUGH ABOUT HOW AWESOME
CAMP IS AND HOW IT'S A GAME
CHANGER.
.
BUT ALSO WHAT THE RECREATIONAL
THERAPY SIDE.
.
THERE'S A PLACE OUT WHEN I WAS
AT FRESNO STATE THERE'S A PLACE
UP IN.
.
CLOVIS.
THAT IS CALLED HARD A HORSE
THERE PETE RANCH. AND I'VE
LITERALLY SEEN CHILDREN THAT
HAVE BEEN NON VERBAL GET ON THE
BACK OF A HORSE.
AND GET OFF THE HORSE TALKING.
.
SO THE RECREATIONAL SIDE.
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT AS A
COMPLETE GAME CHANGER.
OFFERED GETTING PEOPLE OUT AND
INTO THE COMMUNITY AND DOING
THINGS THAT QUITE FRANKLY MANY
OF THEM. PROBABLY NEVER THOUGHT
THAT THEY WOULD BE ABLE TO DO.
WITH THAT WE WILL HOLD ISSUE
EIGHT OPEN AND MOVE ON TO OUR
FINAL ISSUE ISSUE TEN THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
EUROPE AFTER THE WAR.
YEAH.
ONE.
HELLO.
GOOD AFTERNOON I AM JUST GO
BROKE STATE DIRECTOR FOR BEST
BUDDIES CALIFORNIA A STATE
AFFILIATE OF BASS BUDDIES
INTERNATIONAL.
FOUNDED IN NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE
BEST BUDDIES IS A FIVE OH ONE C.
THREE NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION
WHOSE MISSION IS TO PROVIDE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR ONCE ONE
FRIENDSHIPS. INTEGRATED
EMPLOYMENT AND LEADERSHIP
DEVELOPMENT FOR PEOPLE WITH
INTELLECTUAL AND DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES.
OUR PARTNERSHIP WITH THE STATE
HELP SPOTS BODIES PROVIDE A
UNIQUE MIX OF ESSENTIAL
INCLUSION EMPLOYMENT AND
LEADERSHIP DEVELOPMENT SERVICES
TO NEARLY SIXTY FOUR HUNDRED
CALIFORNIANS.
FOR MANY YEARS BASS BODIES HAS
BEEN FORTUNATE TO PARTICIPATE IN
A PRODUCTIVE WORKING
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE
LEGISLATURE THE ADMINISTRATION
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES ALL
JOINING TOGETHER AND DELIVERING
MUCH NEEDED SERVICES FOR THOSE
CALIFORNIANS WITH INTELLECTUAL
AND DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES.
THIS COMMITTEE AND ITS MEMBERS
HAVE BEEN DILIGENT AND
UNDERSTANDING AND SPEARHEADING
THE INCLUSION OF THOSE WITH IDT
WITH AND SOCIETY AND FOR THAT
WE'RE VERY GRATEFUL TO BE OUR
PARTNER.
WE CURRENTLY DELIVER OUR SOCIAL
INCLUSION SERVICES THROUGH ONE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY SEVEN BEST
BUDDIES CHAPTERS AT ELEMENTARY
SCHOOLS MIDDLE SCHOOLS HIGH
SCHOOLS AND COLLEGES THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. THIS IS A THIRTY
SEVEN PERCENT INCREASE IN THE
CHAPTERS OVER THE PREVIOUS
ACADEMIC SCHOOL YEAR.
THESE PROGRAMS FACILITATE THE
SOCIAL INTEGRATION OF
INDIVIDUALS WITH DISABILITIES
ARE STAFF WORK WITH VOLUNTEERS
STUDENT AND FACULTY LEADERSHIP
TEAMS FROM THESE CHAPTERS TO
CREATE AND MANAGE ONE'S ONE
FRIENDSHIPS BETWEEN PARTICIPANTS
WITH AND WITHOUT DISABILITIES.
ADDITIONALLY CHAPTERS ORGANIZE
SCHOOL AND COMMUNITY BASED
ACTIVITIES FOR THEIR MEMBERS
THESE SCHOOL BASED PROGRAMS
BREAK DOWN LONGSTANDING SOCIAL
AND PHYSICAL BARRIERS THAT
INHIBIT INTERACTIONS BETWEEN
PEOPLE WITH AND WITHOUT
DISABILITIES.
AS A RESULT BEST BUDDIES
PARTICIPANTS ARE LESS LIKELY TO
EXPERIENCE THE NEGATIVE EFFECTS
OF THESE BARRIERS SUCH AS
INCREASED VULNERABILITY TO
BULLYING. AND DAMAGING SOCIAL
ISOLATION THAT CAN IMPACT THEIR
ABILITY TO LIVE HAPPY HEALTHY
LIVES.
ADDITIONALLY PARTICIPATION IN
BASS BUDDIES MAKE STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES BOTH COLLEGE AND
CAREER READY BY SUPPORTING THE
DEVELOPMENT OF ESSENTIAL SOCIAL
SKILLS.
IN ADDITION TO OUR INCLUSION
PROGRAMS BEST BUDDIES ALSO
PLACES ADULTS WITH DISABILITIES
AND JOBS IN THE COMMUNITY.
BEST BUDDIES STAFF MEMBERS
PROVIDE INDIVIDUALIZED
ASSESSMENT JOB DEVELOPMENT JOB
PLACEMENT ON THE JOB TRAINING
AND FOLLOW ALONG SUPPORT FOR
INDIVIDUALS WITH INTELLECTUAL
AND DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
AGED EIGHTEEN AND UP.
ALL SERVICES ARE PERSON CENTERED
AND BASED ON THE INDIVIDUALS
INTERESTS SKILLS AND CAREER
GOALS.
BEST BUDDIES HAS A PROVEN TRACK
RECORD OF HELPING PARTICIPANTS
SECURE NONTRADITIONAL SUPPORTED
EMPLOYMENT IN SETTINGS LIKE LAW
FIRMS FINANCIAL PLANNING FIRMS
THE ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY
HOSPITALS LUXURY HOTELS AND HIGH
PROFILE GOVERNMENT OFFICES.
THE HOURLY WAGE OF A PARTICIPANT
PLACED BYPASS BUDDIES IN
CALIFORNIA IS THIRTEEN SEVENTY
FIVE WHICH IS SIGNIFICANTLY
ABOVE THE AVERAGE WAGE FOR
PEOPLE WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES WHICH AVERAGES SIX
FORTY FOUR TO EIGHT FORTY EIGHT
PER HOUR. AND THE FEDERAL
MINIMUM WAGE OF SEVEN TWENTY
FIVE AND CALIFORNIA'S OWN
MINIMUM WAGE OF TEN FIFTY.
WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST ONE
POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS FROM
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA FOR
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY NINETEEN TO
SUPPORT EIGHT THOUSAND
PARTICIPANTS AT ONE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY SEVEN BEST BUDDIES
CHAPTER STATEWIDE. TWENTY NEW
CHAPTERS IN LOS ANGELES THE
INLAND EMPIRE CENTRAL CALIFORNIA
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA ORANGE
COUNTY AND OR SAN DIEGO. ONE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY TWO ADULTS
WITH DISABILITIES ALREADY PLACED
IN COMPETITIVE INTEGRATED
EMPLOYMENT.
SPANS EMPLOYMENT SERVICES TO
INCLUDE A CLASS OF NINE NEW AND
TURNS OUT THE FRESNO PROJECTS
SEARCH SITE. TWELVE NEW JOB
PLACEMENTS IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA TEN NEW JOB
PLACEMENTS IN LOS ANGELES FIVE
NEW JOB PLACEMENTS IN LONG BEACH
AND AND TAKE A CLASS OF EIGHT ME
AND TURNS AND THE HARBOUR CITY
PROJECTS SEARCH. TWENTY EIGHTEEN
TWENTY NINETEEN CLASS THINK YOU.
THINK YOU.
DEPARTMENT.
BERMAN FINANCE VALLEJO.
M. SONY PARTICULARLY.
NOT WE WE DON'T COME IN ON THE
MERITS OF THE PROPOSAL BUT JUST
WANTED TO PROVIDE A BIT OF
HISTORICAL CONTEXT FOR YOUR
REFERENCE WHICH IS THAT BEST
BUDDIES WAS PROVIDED A STATE
APPROPRIATION FOR IN FROM TWO
THOUSAND ONE TO TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT ABOUT ONE MILLION GENERAL
FUND. ANNUALLY.
FROM TWO THOUSAND NINE TO
TWENTY FIFTEEN THE FUNDING WAS
CUT BAM LIKELY DUE TO THE
RECESSION.
AND THEN IN TWENTY SIXTEEN
SEVENTEEN FUNDING WAS RESTORED
AT THE ONE MILLION DOLLAR LEVEL
AND THEN LAST YEAR ONE POINT SIX
MILLION DOLLARS.
THANK YOU WE WILL NOT TAKE
PUBLIC COMMENT ON ISSUE TEN.
HAVING SUPPORTED BEST BUDDIES
OVER THE YEARS AND BEEN A BEST
BUDDIES CHAPTER THEIR WORK IS
ADMIRABLE.
BUT IT'S AVERELL IT'S THE SAME
AS THE OTHER SIXTEEN THOUSAND
VENDORS TO PROVIDE SERVICE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. I
PROVIDE EVERYONE IN THE SERVICES
THE BEST BUDDIES DOES IN
DIFFERENT WAYS.
WE DO A COMPETITIVE EMPLOYMENT
ON REQUIRED TO CARVE CERTIFIED.
ALL THOSE THINGS ARE OUT THERE.
THAT THEY'RE THE ONLY VENDOR. IN
THE STATE.
THE GETS MONEY FROM THE
LEGISLATURE IS ACTUALLY SOMEWHAT
OFFENSIVE IN MY VIEW.
ALL THE REST OF US HAVE TO PLAY
THROUGH ALL KINDS OF OTHER
RULES.
THEY ARE GREAT PROGRAM NO DOUBT
ABOUT IT BUT THERE ARE THOUSANDS
OF GREAT PROGRAMS THAT DIDN'T
MERIT THAT SAME ISSUE. THE OTHER
ONE IS WE JUST TALKED ABOUT
SOCIAL RIGHT IS PROHIBITED I
CAN'T SUPPORT MY ADULTS DO
SOCIAL RACK. PART OF THEIR
PROGRAM IS ABOUT SOCIAL RACK.
HOW IS THAT?
FAIR FOR OUR FOLKS AGAIN.
HOW COME THE COAL CAN GET THAT
SAME BENEFIT THANK YOU?
THANK YOU SIR.
WITH THAT WILL BRING IT UP TO
THE DYESS FRONT COMMENTS WE MAY
HAVE SEEN NON WE WILL HOLD THIS
ITEM OPEN. BUT BEFORE I CLOSE
TODAY'S HEARING I WANTED TO
COMMENT IF I COULD. ON HOW THE
DEPARTMENT OF DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES DID A TRULY HEROIC JOB
DURING THE WILDFIRE
SPECIFICALLY YOU DIRECTOR NANCY
PART MAN AS WELL AS YOUR TEAM.
JOHN DOYLE TO WHEN THE FOX
BRIAN WINFIELD JIM KNIGHT AND
ERIC HOLDER.
AND WITH THAT I WOULD LIKE TO
CLOSE TODAY'S HEARING THANK YOU
ALL FOR ATTENDING